this course from Harvard University is
an introduction to programming using the
Python programming language you will
learn how to read and write code as well
as how to test and debug it this course
is taught by Dr David Malin and it's
designed for students with or without
prior programming experience who'd like
to Learn Python
[Music]
foreign
world my name is David Malin and this is
cs50's Introduction to programming with
python whereas cs50 itself is an
introduction to the intellectual
Enterprises of computer science and the
Art of programming this course is
specifically focused on programming in
Python itself at the beginning of the
course we'll be focus on a topic in
programming known as functions and
variables mechanisms via which you can
write code that solve smaller problems
but you can compose those smaller
Solutions into solutions to larger
problems still we'll then transition to
a look at conditionals away in code of
expressing yourself logically to maybe
do something if some question has an
answer of true or not do something if
the answer is false we'll transition
thereafter to introducing you to Loops
the ability and code to do something
again and again and again some number of
times we'll then transition to something
a little more technical known as
exceptions unfortunately a lot can go
wrong when you're writing code some of
it your fault some of it perhaps someone
else's fault but you can write code
defensively so to speak and actually
catch those kinds of exceptions those
errors and handle them properly so that
the users you're writing code for don't
actually see the same thereafter we'll
take a look at libraries third-party
code written by other people often or
perhaps yourself in the past that you
can use and reuse in your own project so
as to avoid Reinventing the wheel again
and again we'll look thereafter at
something called Unit tests it turns out
you'll actually write code to test your
own code but you won't have to write
tests for your tests indeed this is a
best practice in Industry writing tests
for your code so that one you can be
sure that your code today is hopefully
if your tests are correct correct itself
but moreover if you or someone else
modifies your code tomorrow or down the
line you can rerun those same tests to
ensure that those new changes have not
broken anything about your own code
we'll then take a look at something
called file Io Io for input and output
the ability to not just store
information inside of a computer's
memory but rather save it persistently
to disk so to speak to files and folders
we'll then take a look at another
technique known as regular expressions
whereby in Python you can Define
patterns and you can validate data to
make sure the human types something in
as you expect you can use regular
Expressions to extract data perhaps from
some data set you're trying to analyze
we'll then take a look ultimately at
object oriented programming a paradigm a
way of writing code whereby you can
represent in code real world entities
and this is an addition to other
paradigms of programming that we'll also
explore among them procedural
programming where you write lots of
those functions procedures really top to
bottom to solve problems step by step
and even something known as functional
programming as well and then at the very
end of the course when we equip you with
all the more tools for your toolkit an
additional building blocks additional
vocabulary via which after the same
course you can go off on your own and
either take other courses or solve
projects of your own using all of these
mechanisms now this course itself
assumes no prior programming background
so you don't have to have written a
single line of code in python or n any
language yet but this is also a course
that you can take before during or even
after cs50 itself if you'd like to get
all the more versed with python each
week via the course's lectures will we
introduce you to any number of Concepts
that will then drill down more deeply
into in the form of problem sets each
week that is programming projects that
will enable you to apply some of those
Lessons Learned to problems of your very
own and by the end of the course you'll
solve to have solved so many problems
that ideally are representative of
problems you'll eventually encounter in
the real world whether you aspire to
solve code in the technical world or
perhaps in the Arts the humanities the
social sciences the Natural Sciences or
Beyond you'll have ultimately the
vocabulary and the technical skills via
which to approach the same this then is
cs50 and this is cs50's Introduction to
programming with python
foreign
[Music]
all right this is cs50's Introduction to
programming with python my name is David
Malin and this is our week on functions
and variables but odds are many of you
most of you have never actually
programmed before so let's start by
doing just that let me go ahead here and
open up my computer and on it a program
called Visual Studio code or vs code
which is just a very popular program
nowadays for actually writing code now
you don't have to write code using this
particular tool in fact all we need at
the end of the day is a so-called text
editor a program for writing text and
Heck if you really want you could even
use something like Google Docs or
Microsoft Word you'd have to save it in
the right format but really at the end
of the day all you need is a program for
writing text because that's what code is
text now within this particular program
I'm going to have the ability to create
one or more files via this top portion
of the screen and I'm going to do so by
diving right in and doing this at the
bottom of my screen at the bottom of my
screen is a so-called terminal window
and this is a command line interface or
CLI enter face to the underlying
computer be it your Mac or your PC or
even some server in the cloud and what
I'm going to do here is literally write
code and then the name of the file that
I want to code for instance Hello dot pi
as we'll soon see any program that you
write in Python generally has a file
name that ends in dot pi to indicate to
the computer that it's indeed a program
written in Python now you'll see here at
the top of my screen I have a blinking
cursor a line one which is where the
very first line of my code is going to
go and then just a tab that reminds me
of the name of this file hello.pi and
without even knowing much python I'm
going to write my very first program
here as follows print open parenthesis
quote hello comma World close quote and
close parenthesis and you'll see that at
my keyboard some of my thoughts were
finished for me I only had to type one
parenthesis and the other one
automatically appeared and that's just a
feature that we'll see of tools like
this tool here now even if you've never
programmed before odds are you can guess
infer what the this simple program is
going to do and it's only one line print
open parenthesis quote Hello World close
quote close parenthesis indeed when I
run this program ultimately it's just
going to say hello to the world and in
fact this is a very famous perhaps the
most canonical program you can write as
your very first program in Python or any
other language and so that's what I've
done here but on my Mac my PC even my
phone I'm generally in the habit like
you of running programs by double
clicking an icon or just tapping on the
screen but I see no such icons here and
in fact that's because my interface to
at least my current Mac or PC or some
server in the cloud is again only a CLI
command line interface which even though
it might feel like it's a step back from
the menus and buttons and icons that you
and I take for granted every day you'll
find we think that it's ultimately a
much more powerful interface and
Incredibly popular to use among
programmers in the real world so to run
this program I'm going to have to use a
command and I'm going to move my cursor
back down to the bottom of the screen
here where previously I already ran one
command the command code which has the
effect of opening vs code in my computer
and then I passed in the name of the
file that I wanted to code up now I have
a chance to type a second command and
you'll see I see a second dollar sign
now the dollar sign here doesn't
indicate any kind of currency or money
it just is the symbol that's generally
used to indicate your prompt where the
command line interface wants you to put
those commands now the command I can run
here is going to be this I'm going to
run python of Hello dot Pi now why is
that well it turns out that when I
actually write code in a language like
python it's of course stored in that
file hello.pi but I need to interpret
the code top to bottom left to right so
that the computer knows what to do
indeed at the end of the day even if you
don't really know much about computers
you've probably heard that computers
only understand zeros in one the
so-called binary system well if that's
the case then something that says prints
and parenthesis and quote unquote hello
world is not surely zeros and ones we
have to somehow translate it into the
zeros and ones that the computer
understands now fortunately so long as
you've installed such a program in
advance there's a program as well as a
language called python so python is not
only a language in which we're going to
write code it's also a program Otherwise
Known As an interpreter that you install
for free on your own Mac or PC or some
server in the cloud and you can then run
that program that interpreter passing to
it as input the name of your file like
mine here hello.pi and then that program
that interpreter will handle the process
of reading it top to bottom left to
right and translating it effectively
into those zeros and ones that the
computer can understand so let's do just
that let me go back to vs code here I
already typed out python of hello.pi but
I didn't yet hit enter and that's what's
now going to kick off this command and
hopefully if I didn't mess any of this
up I should see my very first programs
output to the screen and voila hello
world so if you two have typed exactly
that same code and have executed exactly
that same command you will have written
your very first program in this case in
Python well now let's take a step back
and consider what is it that we actually
just did and what is it we're looking
here on the screen well first and
foremost in most any programming
language you tend to have access to what
are called functions a function is like
an action or a verb that lets you do
something in the program and generally
speaking any language comes with some
predetermined set of functions some very
basic actions or verbs that the computer
will already know how to do for you that
the language really will know how to do
for you and you the programmer the human
can use those functions at will to get
the computer to do those things now the
program in question here hello.pi is
using one function and you can perhaps
guess what it is that function is of
course going to be this function print
and that print function of course
doesn't print some pre-ordained string
of text that is to say it Prince
whatever it is you want it to print and
here too do we have another piece of
terminology in the world of programming
namely arguments an argument is an input
to a function that somehow influences
Its Behavior the people who invented
python of course didn't necessarily know
what it is you and I are going to want
to print to the screen so they designed
this print function using these
parentheses with the ability to take as
input some string of text be it in
English or any other human language that
is what you want this function
ultimately to print onto the screen
and what is it that the program's
ultimately doing on the screen well it's
printing of course it's showing us hello
world on the screen and that's generally
in programming known as a side effect it
can be visual can be audio in this case
it's something that appears on the
screen and functions therefore can
indeed have these side effects one of
the things they can do as this verb or
action is to display on the screen as a
side effect something like those World
words that we wanted hello world so
that's my first program and you know I'm
feeling pretty good everything worked as
planned I didn't make any mistakes but
honestly when you're learning how to
program and even once you've learned how
to program years later you're going to
make mistakes and those mistakes of
course are refer to a term you might
already know which is that of a bug a
bug is a mistake in a program and they
can take so many forms and take comfort
perhaps in knowing that over the coming
weeks you're going to make so many
mistakes you're going to have so many
bugs in your code just like I did and
just as I still do and those bugs
themselves are just mistakes that are
problems for you to solve and over the
weeks to come we're going to give you a
lot of tools both mental and Technical
via which you can solve those problems
but just don't get discouraged if when
writing your program for the first time
it doesn't even work that first time it
will with time with practice and with
experience so let me deliberately now
make a mistake that there was a non-zero
chance I might have done accidentally
already but I got lucky let me go ahead
and just suppose I forgot to include
something like the closing parenthesis
at the end of this line of code you know
the code is almost correct it's like 99
of the way there but now that I've
pointed it out it's pretty obvious that
it's missing that close parenthesis but
even little seemingly Minor Details like
that that you and I as humans wouldn't
really care about and if you're sending
an email or a text message out whatever
it's just a typo it's not that big a
deal it is going to be a big deal to the
computer a computer is going to take you
literally and if you don't finish your
thought in the way the language expects
it's not going to necessarily run at all
so let's do this I'm going to go go
ahead here and clear my screen down at
the bottom just so I can start fresh and
I'm going to go ahead and run this
version of my program after having made
that change by deleting the parenthesis
I'm going to go ahead and type python
again of hello.pi and this time when I
hit enter I'm hoping I'm going to see
hello world but here we have an error on
the screen a so-called syntax error
which refers to my having made a mistake
at my keyboard and if this one
fortunately is pretty straightforward it
indeed says that this open parenthesis
was never closed and so that's probably
pretty intuitive now what I need to do I
need of course to close it unfortunately
sometimes the error messages we'll see
in the coming weeks are not going to be
nearly that user friendly but there too
again with experience with practice will
you get better at debugging such
programs let me now make sure that I
indeed fixed it correctly let me go
ahead run now hello.pi and hit enter and
voila we're back in business well let me
pause here and see if we have any
questions now about python itself
writing or running even the simplest
of these programs
uh could I write code inside a word or
for example Microsoft Excel and what's
the barrier to doing that a really good
question and allow me to very explicitly
say to the entire internet that you
should not write code with Microsoft
Word I mentioned that only because it's
a tool via which you can write text and
code is at the end of the day just text
but it's not the right tool for the job
we don't need bold facing underlining
paragraphs and the like we generally
want something much simpler than
Microsoft Word or Google Docs and so vs
code is an example of just a more
general purpose text editor its purpose
in life is to allow you the human to
edit text nowadays these text editors
come with many more features in fact
you'll notice that even in my code here
even though it's just one line there's a
bit of color to it the word print for me
is appearing in blue the parentheses are
black and we'll see as we might write
more lines of code more and more of the
lines will come to life in various
colors now that's just one feature of a
text editor we'll see too that it has
features like this built-in terminal
window it's going to have a built-in
tool for debugging or finding problems
with code and it's just a very popular
tool nowadays but there are many many
others out there you're welcome to use
them for this course and Beyond we just
happen to use this one in large part two
because you can also use vs code
nowadays for free in the cloud how about
one other question here on programming
with python or hello world or syntax
more generally if
it's not possible to run the computer
using the terminal window I think I
heard is it not if it's possible to run
the program without the terminal window
yes sir okay you froze for me again but
let me infer what the question is so in
this environment as I've configured my
computer I can only run these python
programs via the terminal window now
that's good for me the programmer or the
person who's trying to learn how to
program but it's not very good if you
want to ship this software and have
other people use your actual code you
can absolutely write programs and then
allow other people to use not a command
line interface but a graphical user
interface or GUI GUI this is just one
mechanism and perhaps I think the the
best one with which to start writing
code because eventually it's going to
give us a lot more control allow me to
forge ahead here but please feel free to
continue asking questions along the way
if only via the chat and let's consider
now how we might go about improving this
program let's go about improving this
program to make it a little more
interactive and not just assume that
everyone is going to want to be greeted
more generically as hello world let's
see if I can't get this program to say
something like hello David or hello
Jeremiah or hello Horatio or when
whatever the actual user's name is well
to do this I'm going to go back up to
hello.pi and I'm going to add another
line of code at the very top that simply
says for instance what's your name quote
unquote with an extra space at the end
so I'm printing to the user asking them
a question for some input but now I need
another function to actually get input
from the user and perfectly enough
python comes with a function named input
so here I'm going to go ahead and call a
function input open paren close paren
and that's going to prompt the user with
just a blinking cursor waiting for them
to type something in now it turns out if
I read the documentation for the input
function it actually takes an argument
itself I don't need to use print
separately and then prompt the user for
input so I can actually simplify this
code before we even use it I'm going to
go ahead here and take that same string
from print put it as an argument to the
input function and get rid of the print
altogether and in fact that print would
have added a new line anyway so now I've
just got a prompt where the user's
cursor is going to end up blinking at
the end of the line asking them what's
your name in my terminal window I'm
going to run python of hello.pi enter
okay we're making progress it seems that
this new function input is indeed
prompting me the human for input so I'm
going to type in my name David and hit
enter unfortunately it doesn't really do
anything with my name it just outputs it
immediately all right well I could fix
this right I could go up to line two and
I could change world to David and then
back in my terminal window here I can do
python of hello.pi enter what's your
name David enter and there we go all
right now I'm up and running now my
program is working as intended of course
this isn't really working as intended
here let me go ahead and try pretending
to be my colleague Carter here well
Carter's name is this I'm going to go
ahead and hit enter and I'll see of
course hello Carter well obviously not
because I've hard coded so to speak I've
written literally my name inside of the
string so we need some way now of
actually getting back what the user's
input is and doing something with It
ultimately and for this we're going to
leverage another feature of programming
specifically a feature of some functions
which is that they can have return
values as well if you think of input as
being again this action this verb you
can actually personify it as maybe a
person like a friend of yours that
you've asked a question of and you've
asked your friend to go get input from
someone else go ask that person their
name and if your friend comes back
knowing that person's name well wouldn't
it be nice if they handed that name back
to you that's kind of what we need
metaphorically the function to do is get
the user's input and then hand it back
to me so that I the programmer can do
something with it but if it's going to
be handed back to me I kind of want to
put it somewhere so that I can then
print it back on the screen I need to do
the equivalent of take out like a piece
of paper or Post-It note write down on
this piece of paper what it is the human
has said so that I can then feed it into
as input that print function and to do
that we're going to need one more
feature of programming namely variables
and odds are most everyone's familiar
with variables for math class way back
when X and Y and Z and the like well
programming has that same capability
this ability to create a variable in
this case in the computer's memory not
just on a piece of paper and that
variable can store a value a number some
text even an image or video or more a
variable is just a container for some
variable a variable is just a container
for some value inside of a computer or
inside of your own program so how do I
go about expressing myself in this way
well I think what I'm going to do is
introduce a variable that's a little
more interestingly named than X or Y I
could just say this x equals input but
I'm going to use a better name than a
typical mathematical variable here and
I'm going to literally call my variable
name why well in programming because I
have a whole keyboard in front of me I
can use more descriptive terms to
describe what it is I'm writing and now
though there's an opportunity to
consider a specific piece of syntax
we've seen parentheses we've seen quotes
all of which are necessary when passing
inputs to a function but this equal sign
here that's in between input on the
right and name on the left is actually
important and it's technically not an
equal sign per se it doesn't mean
equality as much as it means assignment
so in Python in many programming
languages a single equal sign is the
assignment operator and what that means
specifically is that you want to assign
from right to left whatever the user's
input is so the equal sign copies from
the right to the left whatever the
return value of the function on the
right is so again the input function
clearly gets input from the user that's
why I was able to type my name or
Carter's but it also sort of behind the
scenes hands that value that return
value back to me the programmer and if I
use an equal sign and a variable no
matter what I call it I can store that
input in that variable so as to reuse it
later so now sitting in the computer's
memory somewhere is a container
containing David quote unquote or Carter
quote unquote or whatever the human has
typed in
but here it's easy to make a mistake
suppose I decide to try to print that
name and so I I kind of on a hunch type
in this hello comma name just kind of
plugging in the name of the variable
well let me go ahead here and run python
of hello.pi and hit enter that's going
to prompt me for my name and let me type
in my name David but I haven't hit enter
yet and perhaps via the chat what's
going to happen here when I now hit
enter I'm hoping it says hello David I'd
be okay if it says hello world but I
don't want it to say what it's actually
going to say and yep what we're seeing
in the chat is well it's probably going
to say literally hello comma name so
that's not quite right so we need
another way of printing out the value
inside of that variable rather than just
this word name well let me try this in a
couple of different ways let me try this
as follows let me go ahead and maybe
undo this because I've gotten pretty
good already at saying hello so let's
let you know let's draw that Line in the
Sand to just say all right let's get at
least get hello comma out the door let's
now print name and just on a hunch I'm
going to try this I'm going to use print
again because you can use these
functions as many times as you need and
I'm going to pass to the name to the
print function the variable called name
but notice I'm being a little clever now
I'm not putting it in double quotes
because we've seen already that double
quotes means literally print out n-a-m-e
I'm getting rid of the quotes this time
in hopes that now by passing the
variable called name to the function
called print it will in fact go about
printing the contents of that variable
that is its so-called value all right
let's go ahead and do this here python
of hello.pi enter what's your name David
and now crossing my finger still I see
hello comma David all right so it's not
the best program I'm I'm kind of cutting
some Corners here so to speak I'm saying
hello David on two separate lines so
it's not as elegant it's not as pretty
it's not as grammatically appropriate it
in English as just saying it all in one
breath on one line but at least I've
solved the problem just not very well
yet but let me take a step back now and
perhaps introduce a couple of other
concepts with which we should be
familiar which is as our programs get
longer and they're no longer just one
line or two or even three eventually our
programs are going to become dozens of
lines maybe even hundreds of lines long
let's set the stage for Success moving
forward it turns out that python and a
lot of programming languages also
support something called comments
comments are notes to yourself in your
code and you include comments by way of
a special symbol in Python it's going to
be the hash symbol typically and that
allows you to write the equivalent of a
note to yourself but in a way that's not
going to break your code the computer
actually ignores your comments it's just
there for you it's just there for your
teacher it's just there for your
colleague with whom you're sharing
ultimately that code so if I go back to
vs code here and I just want to add some
comments to this program to explain to
my teacher to myself to my colleagues
what this program is doing well let's go
ahead and do that I'm going to go at the
very top of my program and on line one
now I'm going to move that original line
of code down a bit I'm going to add a
hash and I'm going to say something like
this ask user for their name now I don't
have to use that language I don't have
to use that that text I could use any
human language whatsoever it doesn't
have to be English but I'm going to now
below that just say something like this
say hello to user and you'll notice that
vs code by default is kind of graying
out my comments they're no longer blue
there's no red there's no color in them
and that's just because they're notes to
myself and the computer ultimately is
going to ignore them but what we have
now is two comments ask user for their
name and then a second comment say hello
to user and I've just kind of commented
each chunk of code like each line or
lines plural of code that are doing
something noteworthy why well tomorrow
morning when I wake up having you know
uh slept for quite some time forgotten
what it is I did the previous this day
it's convenient with comments to just
see in English or your own human
language what it is this program is
doing so that you don't have to read the
code itself and better yet if there's
maybe a mistake down the road you can
read what your intention was and then
you can look at the code and figure out
if your code's now doing what you
intended so this isn't really necessary
for a program this small it's pretty
obvious with just one or two or three
lines what the program's doing it's just
as fast to read the code than the
comments but getting into this habit is
generally a good thing to comment your
code every one or few lines so as to
remind yourself and others what it is
your intent and your code is doing
what's nice about comments too is this
comments can also serve to be sort of a
to-do list for yourself there's this
notion in programming of pseudo code
pseudocode isn't a formal thing it's not
one specific language it's just using
English or your own human language to
express your thoughts succinctly
methodically algorithmically so to speak
but pseudocode therefore because it's
not not Python and it's not necessarily
English it just kind of allows you to
outline your program even in advance so
for instance if I wasn't sure today how
I wanted to go about writing this
program but I didn't know what I want to
do I could have started today by just
writing this in hello.pi no code I could
have written just a couple of comments
to myself step one ask user for their
name step two say hello to user then
once I've outlined my program in
pseudocode then I can go in there and
say all right how do I ask the user for
their name well I can do input quote
unquote what's your name question mark
and then on the left here I can maybe
put a variable and assign it to that
okay how do I say hello to the user well
I know I can use print to say things on
the screen let me say hello comma and
let me okay let me now print the
person's name so again pseudocode is a
nice way of structuring your to-do list
especially if you have no idea how to
write the code because it breaks a
bigger program down into small
bite-sized tasks all right let me call
us here to see if there are now any
questions on comments pseudo code return
values or variables
any questions we can clear up here
yeah my question is uh does the function
input work for any type of information
or only for Words yeah really good
question so according to its
documentation and we'll look more at
formal documentation soon input is going
to expect what's called a string that is
a sequence of text be it in English or
any other human language but it's indeed
going to be expecting text with which to
prompt the user a good question how
about another question from the group if
we could I I wanted to ask how I make a
server line comment
oh how do you do many lines of comments
if I'm hearing it correctly sure uh you
would just keep doing them like this you
just prefix each of the lines with a
hash symbol like I'm doing here there is
another technique for doing multi-line
comments in Python that actually tend to
have special meaning you can do three
double quotes like this and then
anything in between here is a comment
that's another technique or you can use
single quotes as well but more on those
I think another time
all right well if you don't mind let me
Forge ahead here and see how we might
improve this program further and also
introduce a few other features that we
might want to take into account over
time so it turns out that we can
certainly improve on this program
because it's a little disappointing that
I'm cutting this corner and saying hello
comma and then on a new line printing
out name like we can do better and most
programs you use on your phone or your
laptop certainly keep text together when
people want so how can we go about doing
that well there's a few different ways
and in fact the goal here is not so much
to solve this one problem but to
demonstrate and emphasize that in
programming Python and other languages
there's so many ways sometimes to solve
the same problem and here's one way to
solve this problem let me go in here and
let me go ahead now and say hello comma
and let me just add to the end of that
the user's name so I'm using Plus in
kind of an interesting way this is not
addition per se I'm not adding numbers
obviously but I do kind of want to add
add the person's name to the string of
text hello comma well let me go now down
to my terminal window and run python if
hello.pi again enter what's your name
I'm going to type in David enter okay
it's better it's better but there's a
minor bug albeit aesthetic here there's
missing space but let's just use some
intuition here well if I'm missing the
space after the comma why don't I go
ahead and just add it manually here let
me now rerun the program python of
hello.pi enter David enter and there we
go now we have something that looks a
little prettier in terms of English
grammar hello comma space David and now
if we rewind you might have noticed
before or wondered why I had this
seemingly extra space after my question
mark namely here there's a space after
the question mark before the double
quote and that was just for Aesthetics
too I wanted to move the user's cursor
one space to the right so that when I
type their name or they type their name
it's not immediately next to that same
question mark there but there's other
ways we can do this it turns out that
some functions print among them actually
take multiple arguments and it turns out
that if you separate the inputs to a
function the so-called arguments to a
function with a comma you can pass in
not just one but two three four five
onward so let me go ahead and pass in
not just hello comma space but that
followed by name and this is a little
confusing potentially at first glance
because now I've got two commas but it's
important to note that the first comma
is inside of my quotation marks which is
uh simply an English grammatical thing
the second comma here is outside of the
quotes but between what are now two
separate arguments to print the first
argument is hello comma space the second
argument is the name variable itself so
let's see how this looks
python of hello.pi enter what's your
name David enter okay I've kind of over
corrected now I've got two spaces for
some reason well it turns out and this
is subtle when you pass multiple
arguments to print it automatically
inserts a space for you this was not
relevant earlier because I was passing
in one big argument to print all at once
by using that plus operator this time
I'm passing in two because of the comma
so if I don't want that extra space I
don't need to pass in one myself I can
just do this and now notice if I run
this program again pythonoflo.pi type in
my name David now it looks grammatically
like I might want now which of these
approaches is better this approach uses
a function print with two arguments
hello comma and the name variable the
previous version recall technically used
one argument even though it looked a
little curious It's one argument in the
sense that the computer just like
mathematicians are going to do what's
inside of parentheses for first so if
inside of parentheses you have this
string of text hello comma and a space
which I need to add back then you have a
plus which means not addition per se but
concatenation to join the thing on the
left and the thing on the right this
ultimately becomes the English phrase
hello comma space David and then what's
being passed ultimately to the function
is technically something like this but
it's doing it all dynamically it's not
me typing in David as I I secretly as I
discreetly did earlier it's figuring out
dynamically what that value is after
concatenating hello with the value of
name and then passing that ultimately to
print as the sole argument let me pause
here to see if there's any questions on
numbers of arguments now
to functions
can we use a function many times to
solve a certain problem which we can
encounter many times in our code
you can you can use a function many
different times to solve some problem
what we'll soon see though is if you
find yourself as the programmer solving
a problem the same way again and again
and again it turns out you'll be able to
make your own function so that you don't
have to keep reusing the basic ones that
come with the language
I was curious about the comma and the
plus sign so after plus sign can we give
just one variable and after comma can we
give multiple variables like what is the
difference a good question so in the
context of strings and I keep using that
term string is a technical term in a
programming language and again it means
a sequence of text a character a word a
whole paragraph even so the plus
operator is not just used as we'll see
for addition of numbers in Python like
we do on paper pencil but it also is
used for concatenation of strings on the
left and the right if you did want to
combine not just two strings left and
right but a third and a fourth you can
absolutely keep using plus plus plus
plus and chain them together just like
in math eventually that's going to start
to look a little ugly I dare say
especially if your line of code gets
long so there's better ways that we'll
actually soon see and a good question as
well well let me come back to the code
here in question and see if we can't
show you just a couple of other ways to
solve the same problem along the way
emphasizing that what we're technically
talking about here yes are strings but
there's even a technical term for these
strings in Python it's just stir so to
speak Str for short for string as you
may know if you programmed in other
languages people who invent programming
languages like to be very succinct to
the point so we tend to use fairly short
phrases to describe things not
necessarily full words so while you
might say string technically in Python
what we're really talking about these
sequences of text are technically stirs
this is an actual type of data in a
program but we'll soon see that there's
other types of data in programs as well
in fact let's see if we can't improve
this in one other way I like the
progress we've made by keeping
everything on the same line hello comma
David
all on the same line what more though
could we do in terms of solving this
problem well it turns out that we didn't
have to give up entirely with using
print twice let me rewind a little bit
and go back to that earlier version
where I wasn't really sure how to solve
this problem so I was using print once
to print out just the hello and the
space and the comma and then I use print
again to call to print name that
strictly speaking wasn't bad but there
was this visual side effect that I just
didn't like it just looked ugly to have
these two lines of text separate from
one another but there's another way to
fix this clearly it seems to be the case
that the print function is automatically
outputting a blank line it's moving the
cursor automatically for me to the next
line because that's why I'm seeing hello
on one line and David on the next and
then my prompt the dollar sign on the
line below that so print seems to be
presuming automatically that you want it
to move the cursor to the next line
after you pass it some argument but you
can override that Behavior again
functions take arguments which influence
their behavior you just have to know
what those arguments are and it turns
out that if we look at the documentation
for Python's print function we can
actually look up at this URL here
docs.python.org is where all of Python's
official documentation lies if I poke
around I can find my way to more
specifically this URL here where I can
find all of the available functions in
Python
that and the documentation therefore and
if I go a little more precisely I can
even find specific documentation for the
print function itself and rather than
pull that up in a browser I'm going to
go ahead and highlight just one line
from that same URL which is this and
this is easily the most cryptic thing
we've seen yet but this is the official
documentation for the print function and
one of the best things you can do when
learning a programming language is
honestly learn to read the documentation
because truly all of the answers to your
questions will in some way be there even
though admittedly it's not always
obvious and I will say too Python's
documentation isn't necessarily the
easiest thing especially for a first
time or a novice programmer it too just
takes practice so try not to get
overwhelmed if you're not sure what
you're looking at but let me walk you
through this example this again is a
line of text from Python's official
documentation for the print function
what this indicates as follows is this
the name of this function is of course
print then there's a parenthesis over
here and another close parenthesis way
over there everything inside of those
parentheses are the arguments the
potential arguments to the function
however when we're looking at these
arguments in the documentation like this
there's technically a different term
that we would use these are technically
the parameters to the function so when
you're talking about what you can pass
to a function and what those inputs are
called those are parameters when you
actually use the function and pass in
values inside of those parentheses those
inputs those values are arguments so
we're talking about the exact same thing
parameters and arguments are effectively
the same thing but the terms you use
from looking at the problem from
different directions when we're looking
at what the function can take versus
what you're actually passing into the
function so what does this imply well
this syntax is pretty cryptic but at the
moment just know that an asterisk a star
and then the word objects means that the
print function can take any number of
objects you can pass in zero strings of
text one string like I did two strings
like I did or technically infinitely
many if you you really want though that
code's not going to look very good after
that we see a comma then we see another
parameter here called sep short for
separator in English and notice the
equal sign and the single quote space
single quote so quote unquote space I
don't know what that is yet but I I
think we've seen a hint about it let's
focus though for a moment on this the
print function takes another parameter
called end and the default value of that
parameter is apparently based on this
equal sign and these quotes backslash n
and what is backslash n if you'd like to
chime in the chat anyone who's
programmed before has probably seen this
though if you've never programmed before
this might look quite cryptic
backslash n
means new line and it's a way textually
of indicating if and when you want the
computer effectively to move the cursor
to the next line create a new line of
text and so technically if we read into
the documentation we'll see more detail
on this the fact that there's a
parameter called end in the
documentation for the print function
just means that by default this print
function is going to end every line with
backslash n you don't literally see
backslash n you see a new line you see
the cursor moving to the next line now
by that logic let's move backwards sep
for separator the default value of
separator is apparently a single Blank
Space well where have we seen that well
recall in an earlier example when I
passed in not just one but two arguments
to the print function recall that they
magically had a space between them in
fact they had that space plus my own
space and that's why I deleted my space
because at that point it was extra so
this just means that when you pass
multiple arguments to print by by
default they're going to be separated by
a single Space by default when you pass
arguments to print it's the whole thing
is going to be ended with a new line now
just by knowing this and let me
literally wave my hand at the rest of
the documentation for another day
there's more things that print can do
but we're going to focus just on sep and
on end let's see if we can't leverage
this now to solve that original problem
the original problem was this I don't
like how hello comma David is on two
different lines well that's happening
again because print is automatically
printing out a new line so let's tell it
not to do that let's Tell It by passing
a second argument to the first use of
print to say end equals quote unquote
not backslash n which is the default
automatically let's make it quote
unquote nothing else let's override the
default value so there is no new line
there's literally nothing there and
let's see what happens let me now go
down to my terminal window and clear it
and I'm going to run python of hello.pi
enter I'm going to type in my name David
and I think now everything's going to
stay on the same line because and it did
this line here 5 is going to print out
hello comma space but then nothing at
the end of it because I changed it to be
quote unquote the second line is going
to print the name David or whatever the
human's name is and it will move the
cursor to the next line because I didn't
override the value of n there just to
see this more explicitly if you do
something cryptic like well I have no
idea what's going on let me just put in
temporarily three question marks here
we'll see the results of this too let me
go back down to my terminal window run
pythonflo.pi what's your name David and
now you see literally really ugly output
but you see literally what's going on
hello comma space then three question
marks and that print statement and then
you see DAV ID so not a good outcome but
it demonstrates just how much control we
have here too and let me rewind further
recall that in our other version of this
when I passed in hello comma and name
they were separated by a single space so
python of hello.pi
d-a-v-i-d enter that just worked well
what if we override the value of sep for
separator instead of being one space we
could say something like uh question
mark question mark question mark just to
wrap our minds around what's going on
there let me now do python of hello.pi
David enter and you see two these two
inputs hello comma and the name are now
separated in an ugly Way by three
question marks because I've overridden
the default behavior of sep and even
though the documentation uses single
quotes I've been in the habit of using
double quotes in Python you can use
either strictly speaking it doesn't
matter but you should be consistent and
I generally always use double quotes
Python's documentation though always
uses single quotes
questions now on these types of
parameters and allow me to propose that
we give these an official name up until
now when we've been passing values to
print those are called positional
parameters positional in the sense that
the first thing you pass to print gets
printed first the second thing you pass
to print after a comma gets printed
second and so forth but there's also
these things we've now seen called named
parameters named SCP separator or end
end for the line ending those are named
parameters because one they're optional
and you can pass them in at the end of
your print statement but you can also
call use them by name this may be a
weird question but I was wondering uh
what if someone wants to like add
actually quote quotation marks within
the quotation marks yeah I like how you
think this is what we would call a
corner case right just when we've made
right this is this is all sounding great
at least as as programming goes but wait
a minute what if you want to print a
quote that's a really good question well
let's see if we can't figure this out
suppose that I want to print out not
just the user's name let me simplify
this further let me go ahead and get rid
of all out of this and let me just say
something like hello
um
maybe I'm being a little sarcastic here
hello friend you know in that kind of
tone well this is not gonna work
actually because you are trying to use
quotes to be like friend and finger
quotes but you're also trying to end the
sentence and if I try running this let's
do this pythonf hello.pi you'll see that
this is just invalid syntax perhaps you
forgot a comma and this is actually a
bit annoying sometimes the error
messages you see are misleading like the
computer the language doesn't really
know what's going on so it gives its
best guess but it's not necessarily
correct but I can solve this problem in
a couple of ways I can do this I can
change my outermost quotes to single
quotes because recall a moment ago I
said you could use double quotes or
single quotes so long as you're
consistent so that's fine if you use
single quotes on the outside you can
then use double quotes on the inside and
you'll see them literally so for
instance if I run python if hello.pi
there we go hello friend but there's
another way if you insist on using
double quotes as you might want to just
because consistent you can also use that
backslash character again we saw the
backslash n a moment ago and that meant
we don't want a literal n to be in the
output we wanted a new line so the
backslash actually represents what's
called an escape character an escape
character is one that you can't just
type necessarily once on your keyboard
you need to express it with multiple
characters so I can actually put
backslashes in front of these inner
double quotes so that the computer
realizes oh wait a minute those aren't
literal those aren't quotes that finish
or start the thought they're literal
quotes So now let me go back to my
terminal window run python of hello.pi
enter and now it's working as well so
escaping is a general technique that
allows us to do that too
and if I may let me rewind now on these
examples and go back to where we left
off with my code I'm just undoing all of
that because I want to get back to the
point ultimately of specifying now a
final way of solving this problem well
it turns out that we have yet another
way we can solve this problem which is
perhaps the most frequently done now or
at least the most elegant when it comes
to setting us up for longer and longer
uses of strings you can use a relatively
new feature of python that allows you to
do this you can literally put not the
name of the variable like that in your
string because we already saw this is
wrong right if you do this you will
literally see hello comma name but what
if I do this what if I put curly braces
or curly brackets around the variable's
name notice vs code is actually very
subtly changing the color of it so vs
code knows something interesting is
going on here let me run this program
but I'm not done yet python if hello.pi
enter DAV vid enter okay obviously not
what I want but I need to tell python
that this is a special string this is
what we're going to call a format string
or an F string a relatively new feature
of python in the past few years that
tells python to actually format stuff in
the string in a special way and the
symbol via which you do this is a little
weird but this is what the World shows
if you put a f at the beginning of the
string right before the first quote Mark
that's a clue to python that oh this is
a special string let me format this in a
special way for you let me now rerun the
program python hello.pi enter David
enter and now we see the goal this whole
time hello comma David we don't start
with this way because I think if we did
this the first way you'd be like why are
we doing this what are all these magical
symbols but this is just yet another way
to solve the same problem but let me
propose that we consider now yet other
things we can do with strings and it
turns out that even as we've been doing
some relatively simple operations here
we've generally been trusting that the
user is going to cooperate and that is
to say that they're going to actually
type in what we want them to type now
just because they type A String though
doesn't mean it's going to look the way
we want you and I honestly as humans are
actually in the habit on websites and
apps of like accidentally hitting the
space bar a lot either at the beginning
of our input or at the end maybe because
the space bar tends to be so big it's
pretty common to get accidental spaces
before or after some user's input you
and I are definitely in the habit of not
necessarily capitalizing words like we
should if we're sending text messages
we're probably being a little quick and
just sending everything in lower case
for instance if that's your style if
your phone's not fixing it for you maybe
in a formal letter you would capitalize
things properly but you and I as humans
we can't really be trusted to type
things in a nice way necessarily when
using some piece of software be it an
app or a website or something else but
it turns out that strings themselves
come with a lot of built-in
functionality and you can see all of
that in Python's own documentation here
the string data type that we've been
talking about comes with a lot of
functionality built in that means that
we can manipulate the user's input to do
more than just join it with something
else like hello we can actually clean it
up or reformat it in a way that
hopefully looks a little better for us
so let me go back to my code here and
let me just demonstrate what might
happen if a user doesn't cooperate if I
go ahead here and run python of hello.pi
enter let me just sloppily hit the space
bar a few too many times why I just
wasn't paying attention and I'm going to
type in my name David and I don't know I
hit the space bar a couple more times
like it's kind of a mess it's all lower
case that's not going to necessarily
look grammatically right it's got spaces
here and here the program is going to
print exactly that and that looks really
bad at least if we're prioritizing
Aesthetics and grammar like why are
there so many spaces after the comma
this is not a very nice way to greet
your users but we can clean this up it
turns out that built into Strings which
again is this data type so to speak this
type of data in Python is the ability to
actually do things to that string so let
me do this I can actually go ahead and
do something like this uh name equals
name dot strip and what does this do
remove white space from string
and what do I mean by this well on the
right hand side notice I've written the
variable name called name I've then used
a period or a DOT and then I seem to be
doing what's a function right anytime
we've seen a function thus far we see
it's the the function's name print or
input then we see a parenthesis then
another parenthesis and that's exactly
what I see here but I'm using this
function a little differently
technically this function is in this
context called a method and what do I
mean by that well if name is a string
AKA stir well it turns out according to
the documentation there's a lot of
functions that come with strings in
Python and you can access that
functionality by using the name of a
string like literally name here then a
period Then the name of the function and
then an open parenthesis and a closed
parenthesis maybe some arguments inside
of those parentheses but in this case it
doesn't need any arguments I just want
to strip the space from the left and the
space from the right of the user's input
but that's not enough I want to remember
that I've stripped off that white space
on the left and the right so I'm going
to use the equal sign again here and
notice that just as before this doesn't
mean equality this means assignment from
right to left so when this line of code
here name dot strip returns to me AKA a
return value it will return the same
thing that the user typed in but with no
more white space to the left or to the
white to the right so then the equal
sign assignment is going to copy that
value from the right to the left thereby
updating the value inside of my name
variable so you can not only assign
values to variables you can absolutely
change the value of variables by just
using the assignment operator the equal
sign again and again and again and it
will just keep copying from right to
left whatever the new value should be so
now if I rerun this program python of
hello.pi
enter
I have Davi let's do it again space
space space space dab ID in all
lowercase space space enter it's better
it hasn't fixed my capitalization so I'm
still being a little sloppy with the
first D but it has stripped off all of
that extra space super Minor Detail
right like this isn't all that exciting
but it just speaks to the power of what
you can do with just a single line of
code now what else can I do here well I
could capitalize the user's input let me
go ahead and try this it turns out that
I could also
uh do this name dot capitalize so let me
go ahead and capitalize uh user's name
and again I'm making comments and
there's no one right way to write the
comments I'm just using some short
English phrases here to remind myself of
what I'm doing what's now going on here
well let me go ahead and run python if
hello.pi enter uh space space space
d-a-v-i-d space enter
okay now it's looking prettier right no
matter how the user typed in their name
even a little sloppily I'm now fixing
that but let's let's try something I'm
getting a little curious here how about
this uh space space space
David space Malin I'll use my last name
now enter okay so ironically capitalize
is not really capitalizing everything we
want it's clearly capitalizing what just
the very first letter so it turns out
that again there's other functions in
Python that come with strings and if we
poke around the documentation scrolling
through a URL like that I bet we'll find
another solution one of which is
actually this let's actually change this
to title there's yet another function
that come with strings called title that
do title based capitalization just like
a book or a person's name capitalizing
the first letter of each word and this
is just going to do a little more work
for us so let's go ahead and run this
and as an aside I'm kind of tired now at
this point of typing python python
python all the time it turns out that
when using a command line interface like
this you can actually go back through
all of your old commands what I just did
a moment ago is I hit the up arrow that
immediately goes back through my history
of all of the commands I've ever typed
so this is just a faster way now for me
to repeat myself than typing everything
manually let me go ahead and hit enter
space space space
David mail in space space all lowercase
enter now it's it's looking better now
I've capitalized things and cleaned
things up but what about my code I've
got like eight lines of code now four of
which are comments four of which are
actual code do I really need this much
well not necessarily watch what I can
also do in Python let me not bother
capitalizing the user's name separately
let me say this and capital log uh
capitalize user's name I can chain these
functions together I can add title to
the end of this and now what's happening
well again with a line of code like this
you first focus on what's to the right
of the equal sign then we'll get to the
left of the equal sign what's on the
right of the equal sign this line here
well what does this mean get the value
of the name variable like David space
m-a-l-a-n then strip off the white space
on the left and the right that is going
to return a value it's going to return
dab ID space m-a-l-a-n without any white
space to the left or right what do you
want to do with that return value you
want python to title case it that is go
through every word in that resulting
string and fix the first letter of the
first word the first letter of the
second word and so forth and and then
now we can finish our thought copy the
whole thing
from right to left into that same name
variable and you know what I can take
this even one step further why don't we
go ahead and do this if we want let me
get rid of all that and let me just do
strip and title all on that first line
and now we've gone from like eight lines
of code to four it's a lot tighter it's
a lot neater and even though reasonable
people might disagree it's arguably
better because it's just easier to read
fewer lines of code fewer opportunities
for mistakes it just allows me to move
on with my next problem to solve
all right let me pause here and see if
there's any questions on these methods a
method is a function that's built in to
a type of value like these functions are
or on F strings which we saw a moment
ago
yes hi thanks David
um so is there a way to remove the
spaces between the spaces that I might
have added a short answer no if you read
the documentation at that same URL
earlier you'll see that strip removes
from the left and the right but not in
between in fact there's two other
functions that come with strings one's
called L strip the other is called R
strip that allow you to do one or the
other if we want to start getting rid of
space in the middle we're going to have
to do a different trick altogether
how many functions can be combined like
this dot strip dot title you have
combined so how many we can combine yeah
a really good question technically as
many as you want but at some point your
code is going to start to look really
really bad right because the line of
code is going to get really really long
it's eventually going to maybe wrap
around again and again so at some point
you just kind of say like uh-uh that's
too many and you start breaking it up
into multiple lines like I did maybe
reassigning the value to the variable as
needed and this is actually a good
question if I can pivot to video off
your question I mean what do people
think if we could go ahead and put
everyone's hands down for a moment let
me ask this is the way I've done this
now with strip and title and input all
in the same line better than my previous
approach in Zoom you can use the yes
icon or the no icon if you think this
version is better say yes if you think
this previous version was better there
for instance this one here where we had
everything broken out say no and then
we'll see why in just a moment
I proposed earlier that reasonable
people can disagree and that's
absolutely the case
doing it one way or the other isn't
necessarily best at least if you can
justify it let me go back to the most
recent version here
all right so we're seeing a lot of yeses
and a lot of no's why don't we go ahead
and call on one of the yeses if we could
someone who's voting yes why do you
think the current version of this code
is indeed better than the previous
longer version of the code
I think it's more readable so I can say
hey this is the name Fung this is the
name variable it gets some input and
then remove the space and give it a
title and there you go you have a Hello
name yeah I think that's pretty
reasonable it's very readable at least
if you're in the habit as you are in
English of reading left to right it just
kind of flows very naturally as a result
the lines is not really that long it's
certainly fitting nicely onto the screen
so I think that's a good argument how
about a Counterpoint though someone who
voted no if we could call on someone who
thinks this is worse because it's not
available at all it seems like uh
it's a very long uh line so I think it's
better to separate yeah I I think that's
persuasive too right it's getting a
little longer and even though my
sentence here what's your name is
relatively short you could imagine that
this could get even uglier quickly if I
were asking a longer question of the
user that's going to make this line of
code even longer and therefore less
readable it might be less obvious to me
or my colleagues that I am calling strip
or that I am calling title it might be
kind of a unexpected surprise so I think
that's reasonable too in short there is
no right answer here and in fact part of
the process of getting better at
programming is getting your own sense of
style or working for a company where
they might prescribe which way is better
than the other because they just want
everyone doing the same thing even
though reasonable people might disagree
ultimately though so long as you have
what's a pretty good argument in favor
of one way or the other like ultimately
that's what's important if you're just
doing things because you don't really
know which one's better that's not great
but if if and when you start to acquire
require opinions and if your boss if
your teacher if your colleague your
friend can challenge you and say wait
why did you do it like this they might
not agree with you but at least have an
answer and that should be sufficiently
persuasive in general now strings come
with a whole bunch of other methods as
well among which is one called split
which can as the name suggests split a
string into multiple smaller substrings
so to speak for instance if the human
here is in the habit of typing in their
first name then a space and then their
last name and you want to go ahead and
greet them only by first name what we
could actually leverage that single
space between the first name and last
name and split that string into two
smaller substrings how can we do this
well let me go ahead and in between
these lines proactively comment that
we're about to split users name into
first name and last name and then let's
go ahead and take that name variable
which currently contains something like
presumably David space Malin and let me
go ahead and call split and pass in as
the argument to split a single white
space thereby indicating that I indeed
want to split on that character now it
turns out split's going to return a
sequence of values ideally a first name
and then a last name and we can actually
in Python assign both of those values
from that sequence at once to some
variables for instance first comma last
equals and that's going to have the
effect from right to left of putting the
first such value in the first variable
the second such value in the second
variable so now on my last line of code
I can go in and say hello not to the
full name something like David Malin I
can just say hello comma first all right
let's go ahead and clear my terminal
window run python of hello.pi and hit
enter I won't bother with any leading
white space this time but let me go
ahead and type in David space Malin and
crossing my fingers as usual hello David
is what we now see
all right so we've seen so much so many
examples thus far involving strings but
certainly programs uh and programming
languages can manipulate other types of
data as well let's go ahead and
transition them to another very common
type of data in Python in programming
more generally namely integers otherwise
known in Python is int int so just as
stir Str is short for string so is INT
in Python short for integer well what's
an integer well just like in math it's a
number like negative two negative one
zero one two and all the way toward
negative Infinity all the way toward
positive Infinity but there's no decimal
point in an integer it's just a number
like negative two negative one zero one
and two onward that's an INT of course
in the world of mathematics there's lots
of symbols that we use and we've seen
plus before although we used it for a
different purpose but python supports
these symbols and more and python allows
you to add numbers together plus
subtract numbers multiply numbers divide
numbers and the only one here that might
look a little strange to people or
unfamiliar is this percent sign but it
doesn't mean percent in this context if
you use a single percent sign in a
Python program that's actually the
so-called modulo operator the operator
that allows you to take the remainder
after dividing one number by another so
we'll see examples of that before long
but the first four of these are perhaps
quite quite familiar well it turns out
that in Python you cannot necessarily
you don't necessarily have to keep
writing code in a file like hello.pi and
then running it in a terminal window one
of the features that many people like
about python is that it supports this
so-called interactive mode like you can
start writing python code and
immediately execute each of those lines
interactively if especially if you don't
care about saving all of your lines of
code you just want to execute code and
get back some answers so for instance
let me go back to vs code here and let
me close hello.pi and let me click on
the Little Triangle over here and my
terminal a window just to make it much
bigger just temporarily for a moment so
I'm not creating any dot Pi file now I'm
just going to run python by itself at my
prompt and you'll see when I do this I
get some cryptic looking output and the
date and time at which the program was
last updated and so forth but I
ultimately get three triple uh brackets
like this this is the interactive mode
for python so I'm running the python
interpreter and anytime I type a line of
code in The Interpreter it's going to
execute it immediately I don't have to
keep running python again and again it's
as though in the human world if you were
standing next to a human who speaks some
other language and you're just having a
conversation with them back and forth
It's all happening the translation
immediately so what might I do in
interactive mode well I could do
something like one plus one enter that's
actually code right you might not think
of it as code but if you know a bit of
arithmetic and you know numbers and you
know plus that's valid python code and
you can use Python really as a fancy
calculator but I could do other things
too if I want to print to myself hello
comma world I can also print out that
line of code there too hello world so
it's interactive in the sense that the
moment you execute a line of code boom
you see the result we're generally not
going to do that because at least when
teaching the language we tend to want to
do things incrementally and we want you
to be able to see where it is we came
from and we want to be able to try
things again and again especially if we
make mistakes but know that this is
indeed a feature of python this
so-called interactive mode but let's
focus for a moment now not just on that
interactivity but really on the fact
that python apparently supports integers
and Mathematics and some of those basic
operations and let's see if we can't
make maybe our our own little calculator
so let me go ahead and open up vs code
again and I'm going to shrink down my
terminal window and I'm going to create
a new file called calculator dot Pi so
to do that recall I can type code down
here and the name of the file I want to
create dot Pi enter that gives me a new
tab up top so I have already closed
hello.piom now in calculator.pi and
let's just make a simple calculator that
does some addition for me but I'm going
to do it in a file so that we can
iterate on this and make changes for
better for worse over time let me go
ahead and first declare a couple of
variables I'm going to do the
mathematical thing of calling my first
variable X
my second variable Y and then I'm going
to give myself a third variable Z equals
X Plus Y and then I'm going to go ahead
and print out Z now this program
admittedly not very exciting or
interesting in fact it's a little less
interesting than printing stuff on the
screen like before with strings but
we'll build on this and see what other
features exist in Python that we can
leverage so hopefully if python knows
its math as well as I do when I run
python of calculator.pi I should see
hopefully that 1 plus 2 equals indeed 3.
all right so not that surprising and not
that interesting and honestly this isn't
the most useful program because it's
always going to calculate 1 plus 2
equals three let's at least make this
program say a little more interactive
right we already know from previous
examples how we can get input from the
user let's bring back that input
function and let's do this let me go
ahead now and at the top of my code
let's change X to not be the number one
always let's change it to be whatever
the return value you is of asking the
user for x and I can use any English or
human language I want here I'm going to
say what's X just like I asked before
what's your name and I'm going to do the
same thing for y I'm going to use input
again but this time change the question
to be what's y
all right at this point I think I'm
going to leave the rest of the code the
same Z equals X Plus Y and then print Z
but what's nice now is that I think I
have a nice interactive calculator right
now it's not going to do one plus two
all the time it's going to do whatever
the user types plus whatever the user
types so let's try this let me go ahead
and run the program all right let's do
it one is going to be x 2 is going to be
Y and of course everyone in agreement 1
plus 2 equals 3.
huh what's going on there
either your math class misled you or I
have misled you
why don't we call on someone here to see
if you can't help us reason through what
the bug is what's the mistake uh Anjali
if I'm saying it right
I think the issue is is that it's
concatenating strings because you use
the plus operator instead of adding
perfect so perfect intuition we've seen
that plus is used a little differently
in the context of strings because it
concatenates that is it joins the two
strings and that seems to indeed be
what's happening here even though the
user typed a number but the interesting
thing here is that when you get user
input because they're using a keyboard
on their Mac or PC or their phone it is
always going to be text it might look
like a number but by default it's coming
from the keyboard as a string that is as
text and so how do we go about
resolving this if ultimately we don't
want to treat those inputs as strings we
want to treat them as actual numbers
well we need another function and it
turns out in Python that you can convert
sometimes from one type of data to
another type of data for instance from
string to int by doing something like
this let me go back into my code and let
me change X before adding it to y to be
whatever the integer version of X is
plus whatever the integer version of Y
is so it turns out that int is not only
a type of data in Python it's also a
function and it's a function that if you
pass in an input like a string so long
as that string looks like a number like
one or like two it will convert it to an
actual number that you can perform
mathematics on instead so if I now go
back to my terminal window and run
Python and let me show you another trick
calculator is kind of a long word it's a
little tedious to type notice what I can
do in my terminal window in a command
line interface in general if I start
typing C-A-L for calculator I can
actually hit tab to finish my thought so
autocomplete is possible in a terminal
window like this type the first letter
or few letters and then boom with tab
it'll finish your thought for you or you
can go back in your history like I did
with the up and down arrows let me go
ahead and execute this what's X1 what's
X2 and there we go now we have a general
purpose calculator that's going to
support not just
addition of one and two but now any two
integers that the user types and let me
now improve this right we've seen how we
can make improvements to code and I I
don't know if it's going to necessarily
be better but let's try this do I really
need the Z variable
it's worth noting that I'm creating a
variable called c z and then I'm
immediately using it on the next line of
code now that's not that compelling
because if you're creating a variable
and then immediately using it but never
again using it did you really need to
take the time to introduce another
symbol and another variable just to use
it once and only once well maybe not
maybe we don't really need Z in this way
maybe I should go and do something
like this maybe I should get rid of Z
here
maybe I should change this to be int up
here change this to be int up here doing
something that's pretty interesting now
even though it's a bit of new syntax
notice that you can Nest functions so to
speak you can put one function call that
is the use of a function inside of the
use of another function so that the
return value of the inner function
becomes the argument to or the input to
the outer function so just like in math
if you have parentheses parentheses
parentheses your teacher probably taught
you to focus on what's inside the
innermost parentheses first and then
work your way out same thing with
programming that's what Python's going
to do it's going to look at what's
inside of the parentheses first it's
going to get the answer and then it's
going to pass the return value to the
outermost function so what happens on
line one now is that the input function
gets called first then the result of
that quote unquote one becomes the input
to the int function and same online too
the output of what's y becomes the input
to this int function and now there is no
Z I could just do print X Plus Y and
because I've taken the time to convert
each of those strings to an integer I
think we're okay so let me try this
python of calculator.pi enter one and
two and we're still getting 3. not 12 or
not twelve one two we're indeed getting
three and we've additionally gotten rid
of the variable because we didn't
necessarily need it it seems especially
if only using it once well here too let
me put everyone's hands down for just a
moment and let me ask as before this
version now which uses int around the
invocations of input and does not use Z
is this better than the previous version
if you want to vote yes go ahead or if
you prefer the old Way vote no the old
way I'll undo all of this as we vote
instead looked like this
all right and let me go back to now the
newest version let's take a hand of the
yeses someone who thinks this latest
version is better I think this way is
better because it uh allows us to
immediately see what the X and Y
variables are with integers and so we
know what to expect from them and also
the print argument is more inclusive we
avoid too much clutter in the code
the lines of code are not very long I
don't need to know what Z is because it
doesn't exist it just C print X Plus y I
like that but someone who prefers the
older way where we did have Z and we
more explicitly passed individual
variables to the in function yeah hi uh
I think but the earlier version is
better because when uh I mean if user
can put something else other than ink
let's say I mean let's say they type one
right and two like so will be it will be
easier to debug this version or the this
version here or the old version
okay that's fair and in fact I'm I'm
being very careful today as best I can
not to mess up I have thus far only
inputted integers when I'm expecting
integers and Rose actually pointed to
something we'll come back to in the
coming weeks how do we actually handle
errors what if the user doesn't type in
the number one or the number two or a
number at all what if they type in a
word like cat c-a-t that's not a number
and I bet I can't convert it to an
integer but for today I'm not going to
focus on that I'm just going to hope
that the user cooperates but that's not
going to be the case and so perhaps one
way would set us up for more success
when it comes to handling those errors
now for today's purposes which is better
I mean I like both and I think both of
you made very valid arguments in there
too so long as you have a justification
that feels pretty reasonable I mean
that's what ultimately matters but
acquiring again a sense of the
trade-offs here well is this way better
if so why or why not just understanding
what those trade-offs are but generally
speaking prioritizing readability is a
very good thing making your code
readable for someone else is a very good
thing and very good for you too so that
when you wake up the next morning or you
come back the next week or the next year
you too can read your own code without
having to waste time trying to remember
what you did and simplicity tends to be
a good thing too keeping your code
simple so is as you get more comfortable
with programming you might be tempted to
try to like combine an entire program
into one long line for instance let me
do right just that don't technically
speaking we don't really need X in a
variable we don't really need Y in a
variable we could also do this I could
just get rid of X and Y altogether I
could then now eliminate that and make
it just one line of code okay so on some
sense you might be inclined to think wow
that's really nice you made it one
simple line of code I would argue this
actually isn't that simple now I think
I'm starting to Nest too many things I
have to think about print and int and
input I then have to notice that okay
I've opened two parentheses I've closed
two of them there's a plus you're making
me think too much and anytime you make
me think you're wasting time and anytime
you complicate the look of the code like
this you're just going to increase the
probability of mistakes and tactical
mistakes or logical errors in your code
so of all the things we've done this is
the only one that I would argue yes it's
one line and it's nice and compact it's
just not readable enough I would shy
away from doing this especially since
two of those function calls are getting
input from the user but there too
reasonable people might disagree but
that's the kind of like visceral
reaction you should have sometimes when
code starts getting a little too
complicated a little too clever perhaps
for its own good
all right well it's not just integers we
have access to let me propose that we
transition from integers to one more
data type here namely a float so again a
string is a sequence of text an INT is
an integer like negative one zero and
one a flow is a number with a decimal
point properly called a floating point
value and you can think of the floating
Point as being the decimal that might be
over here or over here with some number
of digits to the left or the right
mathematically it's a real number a
number that has a decimal point in it so
that's a third type of data that python
supports right now our calculator is
somewhat naively assuming that the user
is only going to type in integers but if
I want to support floating Point values
too I think I can just make a couple of
tweaks so I'm going to go back to vs
code here and instead of just converting
the user's input X and Y to integers on
line one and two let's just make a
simple change let's actually convert it
to a float on the first line and a float
on the second line here now I think if I
go down to my terminal window and run
python of calculator.pi let's type in a
number like 1.2 with a decimal point and
3.4 with the decimal point and there we
go we have 4.6 as the final answer so
that wouldn't have worked before if I
was only expecting integers from the
user but now that I'm support expecting
floating Point values and accommodating
it I can actually now do floating Point
arithmetic as well but suppose that I
don't really want the final answer to be
a floating point value like 4.6 I would
be happy if we just round to the nearest
integer so I want to support the user
typing in floating Point values with
decimal points but at the end of the day
I just want to round the result to the
nearest possible integer for instance
well it turns out that here too python
comes with some functionality built in
and in fact if we return to this URL
from earlier wherein all of the Python
built-in functions are listed there's
one called round which does exactly as
we would expect it takes as input a
number and then rounds it for us for
instance to the nearest digit to the
nearest integer but if we look a little
closer to that documentation as we can
here I'll provide an excerpt this is
what the function looks like in the
documentation and recall that earlier we
looked at the documentation for print
and this is similar in spirit that this
shows us not just the name of the
function but it's available parameters
that is inputs that we can provide when
using this function but this is a little
cryptic too just like Prince was and it
adds some syntax so let's see the name
of this function here is of course round
and its first argument is a number
notice this times there's no star
there's no star objects like there was
for print the round function takes just
one number as its first argument period
that's its positional parameter but
notice this syntax and this is a
convention in programming or technology
more generally generally speaking when
you see square brackets and
documentation like this this means that
you're about to see something optional
and so what this means is that if you
want to specify more precisely the
number of digits that you want the round
function to round two you can specify it
here by adding a comma and then that
number so if we read the documentation
if you don't specify a number of digits
you just specify the number to Round it
rounds to the nearest integer but
suppose you want to round to the tenths
place or the hundredths place that is
one or two digits after the decimal
point you could additionally pass in
comma 1 or comma 2 to be more precise so
that's what the documentation there is
saying let's see if we can't then
translate this to some actual code for
us so if I go back now to vs code and I
consider that I want to go ahead and
round X and Y I can do this in a couple
of ways phase I could do round X Plus y
but uh you know I'd actually kind of
prefer to break this now out into two
lines I don't have to and reasonable
people here might disagree but I'd like
to revert to a scenario where I'm
printing Z so that I can just a little
more clearly to myself to others say Z
equals the rounded result of X Plus y
it's not necessarily the better way to
do it but I'm a little more comfortable
with breaking out my thoughts one at a
time especially if I want to start
commenting each of these chunks of code
all right let me go down to my terminal
window now and run python of
calculator.pi what's X let's do 1.2
again then let's do 3.4 and now it was
previously 4.6 but now it's been rounded
up to the nearest integer which of
course is going to be 5. all right what
if I wanted to change this a little
further what if I wanted to support
maybe really big numbers big numbers
irrespective of rounding let's just do
something like this let me go ahead and
run python if calculator.pi again and
let me just add 999 plus 1 and notice I
don't have to type decimal points even
though I'm converting to float my
program will just allow me to type
decimal points but I don't need to
oblige the answer of course here should
be and is in fact one thousand whether
or not we round so that's just
arithmetic with integers here but in uh
the us we tend to format long numbers by
putting commas after or before every
triple of digits other countries flip it
and they use periods and commas instead
that's a system setting you can change
that on your own Mac or PC or device for
python or any language but for me I'm
using the US approach here which is
periods for decimal points and commas
for separators what if I wanted this to
be outputted as 1 comma zero zero zero
just to make it a little more clear that
it's 1 000 and not something like 100
that's even more useful when it's like 1
million one comma zero zero zero comma
zero zero zero wouldn't it be nice if we
could automatically output those numbers
as well well it turns out that we can
there is a way using python to actually
specify that we want to include commas
like this and here we have an
opportunity to bring back our old friend
the F string first let me do something
that's not that productive first let me
do this let me print out the value of Z
but wait a minute I can't just say quote
unquote Z because that's literally going
to print Z on the screen so let me wrap
it with those curly braces like I did
before but that too was not enough I
literally needed to add an F at the
beginning of my string to tell python
that this is an F string a format string
that now is going to print out not very
interestingly just the value of Z itself
so that I'm going to Great Lengths just
to print Z when really I could have just
passed Z as the sole argument but just
to ensure that I haven't broken it let's
do this again 999 plus one enter okay
it's still a thousand so I didn't make
anything worse but notice this and this
syntax is unfortunately a bit cryptic
notice that I can actually do this I can
put a colon after the Z and I can put a
comma thereafter this looks very cryptic
admittedly and even I have to constantly
look things like this up in the
documentation to remember the syntax but
here let me run it again python of
calculator.pi 999 1 and now notice that
the number has been automatically
formatted for me if I were in a
different country or Locale I could
absolutely override this to use periods
instead of commas or vice versa but in
this case here it's just happening for
me automatically so there too we see a
hint of what it means to really format a
string there's even more power more
powerful capabilities built into that
all right let me pause here to see if
there's any questions now on floats on
rounding or on this use of f strings
yes so I have a question so when using
floats um is it like a cap you how many
decimal points it can have a really good
question so floats yes and this is a
problem we'll revisit before long floats
cannot represent numbers infinitely
precisely in a nutshell because
computers only have so much memory they
only have a finite amount of memory you
and I only have a finite uh amount of
Hardware inside of the computer so at
some point they're going to have to
Round right now I'm rounding
automatically effectively computers will
eventually have to do that for us but
we'll see that as a fundamental problem
before long allow me to turn back just
for a few final examples on float before
we introduce a few final examples that
allow us not just to use functions but
to make our own let me propose that we
also try our hand at a bit of division
here let me propose that we modify this
calculator now to still take a couple of
floats but let's now just do something a
little simpler than a little different
from this just doing x divided by Y and
let me go ahead and get rid of my format
string and just keep it simple for now
printing out Z instead and what are we
going to see here well just some simple
division so python of calculator dot Pi
let's do something like 2 divided by
three and of course I get .6666 and to
Ethan's question a moment ago it does
seem to be finite it's not rounding in a
weird way here but I only seem to see so
many digits that's a an inevitability of
using a float in this way by contrast
just so you know integers nowadays in
Python can be as big as you want them to
be unlike other languages there is no
upper bound on how big an INT can be now
in Python on but there is a bound on
just how precise a floating point value
can be all right now that I've got some
simple division working here let's go
ahead and round this it would be nice to
round this really long number 0.6666666
and so forth to maybe just two decimal
places we've seen how to do this with
round though at least in its
documentation let's just round this not
to the nearest int by passing in just x
divided by Y which is one argument once
the math is done inside of the
parentheses I don't want to pass in just
one argument I want to pass in two so
that I can specify n digits number of
digits which recall was the second
parameter for round let me go ahead and
run python of calculator.pi I'll do the
same thing 2 and then
3.67 so here too we see a way of
rounding now not just to a nearest
integer but to his nearest number of
digits but there's another way to do
this here and in fact this evokes our
our F F string example again let me go
ahead and change this suppose that you
didn't remember for the round function
or for some reason you didn't want to
use it you instead want to just use a
format string well let's go there let me
do quote unquote Z but let me surround
it with those curly braces let me add
the F at the beginning and again this is
not interesting yet this is just going
to print out Z but I'm adding a lot more
complexity to turn it into an F string
but notice I can do something else after
my variable name after the colon if this
were going to be a big integer I might
want to use a comma like before to
separate each triple of numbers with
commas but I don't I'm going to use a
different sequence of characters I'm
going to say 0.2 F and this 2 is one of
these very cryptic things I have to
constantly look up because I forget if I
don't use it that often so don't be
intimidated if this looks especially
weird but this is according to the
documentation the way you specify using
an F string how many digits you want to
print so let me run this version of the
calculator type in 2 and then three we
get the exact same thing but again this
is just consistent with my claim that in
programming we can so very often solve
the same problem in multiple ways this
is just now the F string approach to
that very same problem
all right which one is better it depends
in this case they're pretty equivalent
you could imagine though it being useful
to use a function sometimes so that you
can pass in an argument like n digits as
that second argument or you can imagine
just deciding in advance that you want
point two and then writing it like this
let's transition now from focusing on
strings and on integers and on floats to
focusing now on functions themselves we
began today by focusing on how you can
use functions that come with python but
wouldn't it be nice if you could invent
your own functions especially if to our
Point earlier you find yourself solving
the same kind of problem again and again
it's nice that python comes with the
print function because it's really
useful to be able to print things on the
screen but wouldn't it be nice if you
could print specific things on the
screen by just calling your own function
well let me propose that we do this let
me go back to vs code here and let me
propose that we go back to hello.pi I'm
going to reopen hello.pi where we left
it before and I'm going to go ahead now
and propose that we consider how we can
start improving this further by making
our own function I have written so many
programs today that just say hello and
each time I'm using print but wouldn't
it have been nice if from the beginning
of today we could just call a function
called hello that just says hello for us
now the authors of python years ago
didn't think that we need a special
function just to say hello but I would
like that to exist I'm saying hello so
many times I just want to be able to
call a function hello so I'm going to
start from scratch here I'm going to
delete all of my code from earlier and
I'm going to pretend for the moment that
a function called hello exists and I'm
going to do just as I did before I'm
going to get the user's name with the
input function asking what's your name
question mark and now I'm going to call
a function hello and then I'm going to
print out the user's name now I will
admit hello doesn't exist so bad things
are about to happen but let's see what
let me go down to my terminal window let
me run python of hello.pi I think the
first line is going to be okay because
that worked before and indeed it's
prompting me for my name so let me type
in David the second line of code is
apparently calling a function that looks
like it's called hello because why is it
a function it has a parenthesis and a
closed parenthesis immediately after it
and that's what every function we've
used has looked like but Python's not
going to recognize this one when I hit
enter now I get a name error name hello
is not defined did you mean help I
didn't although it's opportune that's
what I need at this point is some help
but I am encountering this error because
why the function just doesn't exist so
how do I make this function exist well I
need to create it myself using this
keyword def for Define so here too just
as stir is short for string and into
short for integer def is short for fine
if and when you want to Define create
invent your own functions you can do so
using now this keyword in Python so let
me go back to my code here and let me
propose that we Define this perhaps in
this way at the very top of my file I'm
going to first take a moment to define a
function called hello using def
hello open parenthesis close parenthesis
colon what this means now is that python
is going to treat every line of code
that I indent underneath this one as the
meaning of this new function hello So
Def is important as is the space I get
to choose the name of the function and
I'm choosing to call it hello the
parentheses with nothing inside means
that this function at the moment is not
going to take any inputs no arguments
there too the colon means stay tuned for
some indentation everything that's
indented beneath this line of code is
going to be part of this function it's
going to be a super short function one
line of code it's just going to print
out quote unquote hello but now on lines
one and two I have invented my own
function hello notice these dots that
have now magically appeared here this is
just a setting of my text editor vs code
in this case that's just making super
explicit to me that I've hit the space
bar four times or equivalently the Tab
Key once which is converted
automatically to four space cases
generally speaking I'm going to need to
make sure that all of my indented code
lines up now so that python knows that
it's all part of the same thing but it's
easy in this case because it's just a
single line but now thanks to lines one
and two the function hello will
absolutely exist when I'm ready to use
it on line six so let me go down to my
terminal window and run python of
hello.pi enter here comes my name again
and now when I hit enter I now see hello
David all right we've kind of regressed
though right this is not nearly as
pretty as it once was I think we can
probably do better than this by
improving things further why don't we
consider though how we might say
parameterize this same function that is
to say can we customize hello to maybe
take the user's name as input so that we
can say not only hello but the person's
name all on one line all in one breath
well I think we can do this let me
propose that we do this as follows let
me go ahead in up in my code let me
inside of these parentheses let me come
up with my own parameter name I have
complete Choice here and I'm going to
say that the name of my parameter will
be the word to why because I want my
function to sound like the verb it
represents hello but who do you want to
say hello to well I'm going to call my
parameter for this function 2 just
because in English it kind of sounds
nice to me hello to who do you want to
say hello to that's why I'm calling this
parameter 2 instead of something simpler
like X or Y or Z all right well what do
I want to do with the word two well I
can do a couple of different things
we've seen like so many different ways
to implement hello let me just add a
comma there for grammar's sake and then
let me put the word to after that as the
second argument to the function hello
there's other ways we can do this and
we've seen so many but this one looks a
little clear to me I'll say what's going
to happen next well I don't think I need
this extra print line here I think what
I'm going to do is this I'm going to go
head here and print out not the person's
name manually I'm going to sense instead
say hello parentheses name so what am I
now doing on lines one and two I'm
defining my very own function called
hello but this time that function has
been designed to take a parameter a
single parameter as input and I'm using
the value of that parameter which I
called 2 to plug into print so that I
see not only hello but also that
person's name what am I doing on line
five same as always I'm just getting the
user's name line six I'm not only
calling hello I'm passing as input the
name variable as an argument
so that that's what gets passed into
hello and what's Happening Here is
essentially this even though the
variable is called name here when the
function itself is called the computer
assumes that that same value is now
called two so name is essentially copied
to another variable called 2 so that in
the context of hello I can say hello to
that variable instead and we'll see in a
moment what happens if we don't keep
those straight let me go ahead and run
python if hello.pi enter what's your
name and now I'm crossing my fingers
enter there we go we're back in business
but now I have my own custom function
called hello that's allowing me to say
hello to a specific person and here's
where now things can get really fancy
what if you wanted your hello function
to say hello to someone specific but you
know what if you don't know who you want
to say hello to you want to say hello to
the whole world you can give parameters
default values we've seen that recall
that with print there was a default
value for sep for the separator there
was a default value for end the line
ending we can do that too and here's the
syntax if you want the value of this
parameter by default if not provided by
the programmer to be equal to
quote-unquote world you literally do
that in the same line you're defining
the function and I'll admit it's
starting to look more cryptic but I'm
still just defining a function called
hello it takes a parameter called 2 but
I'm assigning it with the equal sign a
default value of quote unquote world
just in case the programmer doesn't call
hello with an argument and we can see
this here let me change my code to use
hello in two ways on line five I'm going
to very simply call hello no arguments
then on line six I'm going to get the
name line seven I'm going to call hello
with an argument so you'll see hello now
being used in two ways let me go ahead
and run pythonflow.pi
I'll type in my name oh interesting
notice I already see hello world but
that's expected because line five
happens before line six but once I type
my name now the program is going to be a
little more polite and say hello to me
personally
so there too we see with relatively
simple but new syntax how you can
Implement functionality very similar in
spirit to what the print function gave
us automatically now you have control
over doing that yourself but let me now
make this point too one of the whole
points of defining your own functions is
one just to avoid having to repeat
yourself again and again you don't have
to actually keep Reinventing the wheel
and keep using the print function again
and again and again if you just want to
say hello wouldn't it be nice now if I
could kind of move this code that I
wrote for defining the hello function
and just to be dramatic I'm going to hit
enter a whole lot of times 50 lines down
and put my definition of hello way
further down in this file why well just
from the spirit of out of sight out of
mind because if I now rewind to the
start of my program now you can sort of
take for granted that oh hello is a
function y because it's there on line
one and it has an open parenthesis and a
closed parenthesis which up until now
has meant call this function and then on
line two we're getting a variable from
the user by typing in their name and
then we're calling hello passing in that
value well at this point I can just take
for granted that hello exists even if
it's way down further in the file or as
we'll see in future weeks even if it's
in a different file altogether but
there's a problem here and let me go
ahead and run this version of hello.pi
notice that as soon as I run The
Interpreter python of hello.pi I see a
name error name hello is not defined
again did you mean help well again
fitting I do need some help here but I
didn't mean to call the function help
the problem here though is that python
is just taking me literally I have
defined my function hello all the way
down here but I'm trying to use it way
up here and that's not allowed Python's
interpreter is going to take you
literally and if you use a function it
must already exist by the time you are
calling it so how do I fix this well
apparently I can't do that I have to
Define any functions I want at the very
top of my file but that too could get me
into a bit of trouble eventually because
if I constantly have to define a
function above where I want to use it
you're kind of writing code in Reverse
you're constantly writing functions up
here appear up here as opposed to like
writing your code logically top to
bottom so let me fix this in a more
standard way which is to do this
generally speaking you do want to put
the main part of your code at the top of
your file and in fact I'm going to go so
far as to Define my function called main
it's not a requirement but it's indeed a
convention and this just connotes to the
reader that this is the main part of my
program I'm going to get rid of my empty
hello call now and only pass in one
version with hello name and then down
here a couple lines further down I'll
actually Define my hello function
unfortunately now that I've reordered
the functions in this way by putting the
main part of my code at the top and
hello at the bottom so that my logic
kind of flows top to bottom if I go
ahead and run python of hello.pi enter
nothing whatsoever happens if I do it
again nothing whatsoever happens well
why in the world is this well just
because I've defined a function called
Main and I've defined a function called
hello doesn't mean that I've actually
called that is used either of them yes
I'm using hello inside of Main but no
one is telling python to actually use or
call Main so in order to tidy this up
the last thing I need to do in this file
it seems is actually call my main
function and in fact by calling my main
function in this way it gets me out of
trouble because now I'm defining main
first but I'm not calling hello yet I'm
defining hello next but I'm not calling
hello next I only at the very end of
this file call Main which has the effect
of running this code up here which has
the effect of running this code down
here and it allows me therefore to
organize my file and Order My functions
in any way I want including main at the
very top and solving ultimately that
problem of python not knowing what's
going on now it's important to note that
I defined my function hello as taking an
argument to and then I passed into that
function the value of the variable that
I wanted to say hello to that is the
variable called name because suppose I
had done something a little bit
differently suppose that I hadn't
defined hello is taking an argument so I
just remove mention of two and its
default value help world and I go back
up to my main function and I just call
hello itself without passing in any
arguments and now let me go ahead and
make one more change one more mistake
technically let me go ahead and just try
to naively print out the value of name
in the hello function so now to be clear
in my main function on line two I'm
defining my variable called name and
assigning it the return value of the
input function from the user I'm then
just calling hello in my hello function
which now no longer takes any arguments
I am calling print passing in hello
comma and then immediately passing a
name the variable into which I got the
user's input but the catch is that name
exists now only in Main and so watch
what happens when I try to run this
version of the program with python
hello.pi I hit enter I'm prompted for my
name David enter and ah a name error
name name quote unquote is not defined
so it turns out that this is actually an
issue of what's called scope scope
refers to a variable only existing in
the context in which you defined it so
insofar as I Define this variable name
in my main function I can only use that
variable in my name function I can't use
it as I've tried to here in my hello
function it doesn't exist in that
so-called scope and so this is why now
if I rewind and undo all of those
changes you'll see that I'm deliberately
passing main from my main function into
my hello function and now in the hello
function it technically has a different
name it's called 2 in that context but
that's fine it's completely up to each
individual function to name its own
variables or name its own arguments but
this is a way now that I'm handing to
the hello function the value of that
variable so it can be printed by hello
as well and there's one final flourish
we can add here now that we've
implemented hello you'll notice that
hello only has a so-called side effect
it only prints out something to the
screen well what if I also want my
function
to not have a side effect per se but
actually hand me back a value recall
that the input function returns a value
the string that the user typed in recall
that the int function returns a value
the float function returns a value that
was passed into it well you can use one
final keyword here literally return to
return a value explicitly yourself in
fact let me go back to vs code here and
I think we'll return our attention to
calculator dot pi and see if we can't
Implement one other version of calculate
calculator.pi that actually has our own
function that even returns a value so
I'm going to go ahead and open up
calculator.pi and I think this time I'm
going to throw everything away as before
and I'm just going to start practicing
what we're preaching here Define a
function called main which is now going
to be the main part of my function let's
go ahead and now declare a variable
called X and assign it to the converted
version of the user input after asking
them what's X so again a line of code
quite like we've done before and suppose
now that what I want to do is square
this value I want to take the number
that the users typed in and raise it to
the power of 2. so 2 squared would be 4.
3 squared would be 9. 4 squared would be
16 and so forth well how do I go about
implementing a function literally called
Square which actually doesn't come with
python built in well let me assume for
the moment that it does exist and let me
say something like this let me go ahead
and say that printing how about x
squared is
comma square of X so what have I done
I've defined a function called Main and
I've implemented two lines the first of
these lines prompts the user for a value
X and converts it to an INT and stores
it in a variable called X on line three
I then say x squared is and then I pass
a second argument to the print function
whatever the return value is of a square
function but Square doesn't exist and
I'll show you this here if I now call
Main at the bottom and I run python of
calculator dot pi
foreign
I'll see that X is 2 and then I see a
whole bunch of Errors a name error name
square is not defined so this isn't a
typo here it's just the function doesn't
exist but I think I can make it exist
here let me go ahead and Define another
function called Square this one's going
to take in a number and I'm going to
call it generically n as many a
programmer would just to represent any
old number and then what do I want to do
in order to square n well a numbered
squared is really just itself times
itself so I'm going to do this n times n
but it's not enough just to do the math
yourself n times n you're going to have
to return the actual value n times n and
that's our new keyword here when I now
do this Watch What Happens python of
calculator.pi enter X say shall be 2 x
squared is 4. let me go ahead now and
say x is now 3 x squared is now 9. so
I've implemented my very own function
that Returns the square of a value and
because I'm using the return keyword
that ensures that I can pass the return
value of this just like the return value
of input or int or float to another
function like print instead and here too
there's going to be so many ways to
solve the same problem I can actually
raise n to the power of two we've not
seen the syntax before but if you use
two two asterisks like this two stars
that raises the thing on the left so the
power on the right or it turns out there
is in Python a function called pal for
raising something to the power that
takes two arguments the first of which
is the number the second of which is the
exponent so there too there's just so
many ways to actually solve that same
problem as well
so ultimately what we have we done here
we first introduced functions these
actions are verbs many of which come
built into python that you can just use
in your own code we then introduced
variables via which you could store
those return values and then maybe do
something more with it at the end of the
day too you now have the ability to
create to invent your own functions to
solve simple problems like hello or in
the weeks to come much more
sophisticated more challenging more fun
problems as well
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
this is cs50's Introduction to
programming with python my name is David
Malin and this week we focus on
conditionals conditionals or conditional
statements in Python and in other
languages are this ability to ask
questions and answer those questions in
order to decide do you want to execute
this line of code or this line of code
or this other line of code instead they
allow you to take the proverbial Forks
in the road within your own code
logically so how might we go about
making some of these decisions well it
turns out that python comes with a lot
of built-in syntax for instance here are
just some of the symbols you can use in
Python to ask questions admittedly
mathematical questions but we'll start
there if only to keep the example simply
simple simple early on this first symbol
as you might know for math represents
greater than the second symbol might not
look too familiar because we usually
write it all as one thing on a piece of
paper but on a keyboard if you want to
say greater than or equal to you'd use
this symbol Instead This of course means
less than this means less than or equal
to and this one's a bit of a curiosity
we've seen in our look at functions and
variables how we were able to assign
values to variables using a single equal
sign but that equal sign didn't
represent equality it represented
assignment from right to left that's
great because it solved that problem but
it kind of left us in a bit of a bind
because how do we now compare two things
left and right well in Python and in
many languages you actually use two
equal signs so two equal signs
represents equality comparing the thing
on the left and the right one equal sign
as always represents assignment of
copying the thing from the right to the
left lastly this last symbol represents
not equal to so the exclamation point or
bang followed by an equal sign means not
equal to some value next to it well to
ask the questions using these symbols or
any others we're going to need another
keyword in Python and that keyword quite
simply as in English is if you can ask
questions in Python code along the line
of if the answer to this question is
true then go ahead and execute this code
for me so let's go ahead and write some
of these examples here I'm going to go
over to vs code and let's go ahead and
create a program first called compare.pi
the goal of which is simply to write
code that compares values and makes
decisions based on those values let's go
ahead and type code of compare.pi in
order to create a brand new file called
compare in which we'll start to express
some of this logic all right well what
do we want to compare so
jurors but we'd like those integers to
come from the user so that we can make
decisions based on numbers we don't know
the values of in advance well let's go
ahead and do this as we've done in the
past let's declare a variable like X
let's assign it equal to the return
value of the int function and pass to
the int function the return value of the
input function asking the user a
question like what's X question mark As
we've done in the past let's do this one
more time with Y asking the user for the
value of y and again converting that
ultimately to an INT as well so with
this amount of the story we have two
variables X and Y Each of which has
values and ideally we should be able to
now compare these values so suppose I
want to make a decision based on the
values of these variables I'm going to
use the keyword if and I'm going to use
some of those mathematical symbols to
actually ask the question itself so how
about this if x is less than y then
let's go ahead and just print as much
Out quote unquote X is less than y so
this is in a very interesting program
yet I'm literally just stating the
obvious based on the math but it's
allowing me to now introduce some new
syntax and exactly what is this syntax
well it's this not just the keyword if
which I've added here at the start of
line four but then I ask my question
here x less than y x is one variable on
the left Y is one variable on the right
and of course the less than sign is
expressing the mathematical question I
have what I've highlighted here is
technically called a Boolean expression
a Boolean expression named after a
mathematician named bull is simply a
question that has a yes or no answer or
technically a true or false answer and
that's nice because if there's only two
possible answers it's very easy for me
and in turn the computer to make a
decision do this or don't do this thing
now notice if you come from other
languages you might notice that I have
not typed any parentheses they are not
in fact necessary at least in this case
in Python but I have typed a colon at
the end of the line and even more
importantly at the next line I have
begun my line with some indentation
hitting the space bar four times or just
hitting tab once which will
automatically be converted to the same
that indentation is what tells python
that line five should only be executed
if the answer to line Four's question is
in fact true so if x is less than y that
phrase will be printed thereafter well
let's add a few more lines of code how
about another question If X is greater
than y then let's go ahead and print
that X is greater than y and let's do
one final question if x equals y then
wait a minute
what have I done wrong here right a good
eye here I don't want to assign y to x
if x equals equals y is how I express
equality let's go ahead and print out X
is equal to Y so I now have a uh three
conditions if you will one question
asking X less than y one asking X
greater than y One X getting x equals
equals y let's run the code well down
here in my terminal window I'm going to
run python of compare.pi and hit enter
what's X let's go with one what's y
let's go with two this should of course
execute that first line of code and tell
me indeed that X is less than y exactly
as I would expect there well what just
happened though in code well let's take
a look perhaps at this same code
visually particularly if you're a more
visual learner this I dare say is what
just happened so what we're looking at
here is a flow chart it's a diagram of
this program's logic and more
technically it shows the program's
control flow that is the ability of you
and code to control the flow of a
program generally from top to bottom in
fact let me go ahead and zoom in on the
top of this flowchart and you'll see an
oval at the very top that says quite
literally start that is irrespective of
what shape or layout the diagram is is
where your own thinking and logic should
start when trying to wrap your mind
around this program notice that there's
an arrow from start to this diamond
shape and inside of that diamond is a
question a Boolean expression X less
than y and this shape just means based
on the answer to that question go left
or go right specifically go left if the
answer is true or go right if the answer
is false well the inputs I typed were
one and two respectively for X and Y so
of course 1 is less than two so that's
why my program printed out quote unquote
X is less than y but recall the code the
code then proceeded to ask two more
questions is X greater than y is x equal
equal to Y well the flowchart depicts
those questions too notice that no
matter whether the question had an
answer of true or false the arrows both
convert urge back down to this second
diamond shape here and that second
diamond shape asks the second question X
greater than y that too has a true or
false answer so we go one way or the
other but if x is one and Y is two then
no the answer is false one is not
greater than y so logically in the
flowchart you follow the false Arrow
this time and notice along that false
Arrow you don't print anything this time
that's why we only saw one print out on
the screen now there was still a third
question and this flowchart captures
that as well the third Diamond asks x
equals equals y now that too has a false
answer in this case because 1 of course
does not equal equal Y and so we again
follow the third false Branch here and
that leads us of course to stop and stop
just indicates that's it for the program
so I think that's correct and that
particular flow chart does happen to
represent the actual code that I wrote
so it's correct it does what it's
supposed to do it answered the question
correctly by printing on the screen X
less than 1 why but what is perhaps
poorly designed about it let's make this
first distinction it's not enough
necessarily for the code that you write
to be correct and do what you intend
longer term especially as our programs
get longer and more sophisticated more
complicated we're going to want them to
be well designed too
thoughts on in what way this program is
arguably not well designed even though
it's correct
let's see here uh Khalid if I'm saying
that right your thoughts too many ifs I
think is getting repetitive we can make
our code more concise maybe yeah it
seems a little repetitive I'm asking if
this if this if this and yet logically I
should know the answer to some of those
later questions once I figure one out
and in short if you look at this diagram
here notice that no matter whether I go
left or I go right I'm always asking
three questions no matter what all of
those arrows lead to the first the
second and the third Diamond so I'm
asking three questions no matter whether
any of those answers are true or false
well how might I go about improving this
well let me propose that we introduce
another keyword to our python vocabulary
namely L if and this too is kind of a
succinct one it's a conjunction of else
if in English which allows us to ask a
question that takes into account whether
or not a previous question had a true or
false answer well what do I mean by that
well let me go back to my code here and
let me propose that we now improve upon
this year by asking ourselves ultimately
how can we ask fewer questions and let
me go ahead here and propose that
instead of asking if if if let's make
these conditions potentially mutually
exclusive that is to say don't keep
answering questions once we get back a
true answer so I'm going to change my
code up here as follows instead of
asking if if I'm going to say if x less
than y l if x greater than y l if x
equals equals y so I'm going to
implicitly just like in English take
into account that I'm only going to keep
it's asking myself these questions if I
haven't yet gotten a true response think
about the logic here the English if x is
less than y on line four print out X is
less than y well if that's the case
you're done logically because if the
English is saying if x less than y else
if x greater than why those are going to
be mutually exclusive if the answer to
the first question is true you don't
have to keep asking questions to which
you already logically know the answer so
let me go ahead now and run this program
and I think the behavior is going to be
the same python of compare.pi what's X
let's do one what's y let's do two x is
less than y now honestly I didn't really
notice a difference when I ran the
program and honestly my Mac my PC my
phone nowadays are so darn fast these
kinds of improvements aren't going to
necessarily feel any faster until we're
writing bigger faster programs but it's
laying the foundation for writing better
code longer term now what is the
Improvement I've just made well if
previously my diagram looked like this
which was problematic in so far as I was
asking three questions no matter what
even if I already figured out what I
want to print on the screen this new
version of the program that says if L if
L if might look a little something like
this instead now it got a little wider
that's just because we drew the arrow
Rose to be a bit wider here but let's
focus on just how many questions are
getting asked let me zoom in at the top
as before and let me propose that we
note that the start oval is at the very
top and it's asking us to ask one
question first X less than y is one less
than two but notice here let me zoom out
if one is indeed less than two we follow
this longer Arrow the down Mark true we
print out quote unquote X is less than y
but then we immediately follow this next
arrow down to the icon that says stop so
that's what's implied by doing if L if L
if if we get back a true answer right
away to that first if we're going to
print out X is less than y and then stop
we're logically at the end of the
program so this picture is just
representing graphically what the code
is actually doing but suppose I typed in
something else suppose that my code
actually ran and I typed in 2 for x and
one for y that is to say the answer to
the first question is now false but the
answer to the second question is now
true because of course one two is
greater than one well let's go back to
the diagram same as before we start at
the very top where it says start the
very first question up here now X less
than y is an answer of false because no
2 is not less than one so we follow this
arrow to the next question this diamond
is X greater than y well yes 2 is
greater than one so now we follow this
left Arrow which is true we print out
quote unquote X is greater than y and
then stop so what's the Improvement well
in the first case we got lucky and we
only had to ask one question and boom
we're done this time we had asked two
questions but then boom we're done only
if x happens to equal y do we actually
find ourselves logically getting all the
way down to this final L if in my code
and pictorially only if x is equal to Y
we we find ourselves going all the way
down to the third Diamond the third
question asking is it equal to why or
not now hopefully the answer at that
point is not false we've included a
false Arrow just so that the program
itself is well defined but logically we
shouldn't actually be getting there
anyway because it's got to be less than
or greater than or equal to in this case
well let me pause here to see if there's
any questions now either on the code
version thereof here or on this
diagramming of that very same logic
questions here on this control flow
aren't we supposed to put an else at the
end ah a good question and yes so that's
going to be my my third and Final
Approach and if you don't mind let's
pivot there right away identifying a
third keyword that indeed exists in
Python that allows us to be even better
at expressing this logic to design this
program even better and that's going to
solve a particular problem so if I take
us back to our code here notice that
what I've highlighted earlier L if x
equals equals y it's not wrong to ask
that question in fact if you're trying
to be especially thorough it makes
perfect sense to check if x is less than
y greater than y or equal to Y but
why don't I need to ask this third and
final question we don't need to ask if x
is equal to Y anymore because logically
if the two conditionals evaluate to
false there is only one
um conditional that will evaluate to
true and that is X is equal to Y exactly
if we're all pretty comfortable with
math and comparisons here of course X is
either going to be less than y greater
than y or equal to Y but once you rule
out the first two scenarios logically
it's got to be the case that X must
equal y if it wasn't the case that it's
less than or greater than so hope
proposed that we use this other keyword
else and how do we use this well exactly
as we might in English let me go back to
my code here and instead of bothering to
ask the third and final question let's
not ask a question at all let's just
have this catch-all so to speak a final
line of code that says else just assume
that X is equal to Y therefore printing
it as well so what's the upside of that
my code is still going to work exactly
the same and again my computer's so darn
fast I don't even notice that it's
working even faster than it was before
but we would notice these kinds of
things if we were doing a lot more work
a lot bigger programs here but let me
run python of compare.pi let's do for
instance one and two it still works for
that let's do two and one still works
for that let's do one and one and it
indeed now works for that but in these
cases now let's consider the path we
just went down previously our diagram
when we had if L if L if in place looked
a little something like this and notice
that again we might have asked one
question or two or worst case three
whole questions but we can do better
than that using else as hope proposed we
can Whittle this diagram now down to
this and even though it looks like the
diagram is getting bigger notice that
it's having fewer building blocks inside
of it there's fewer arrows and there's
fewer nodes in this picture let's start
at the top now start leads us to the
first first question still X less than y
if the answer is true great we can say
as much X is less than y and we can stop
if it's not true if it's false we can
ask the next question X is greater than
y true or false if it is great we can
print X is greater than y and stop else
if it's not the case that X is greater
than y the answer is false we can just
immediately logically say x is equal to
Y we don't have to add the third
question at all we can just immediately
conclude there so what's the implication
here you can see with these pictures a
relative decrease in the complexity of a
program the first one was very long and
stringy with lots and lots of questions
unnecessarily ultimately the next one
got a little shorter and this one's even
shorter still and again the fewer lines
of code you have the less likely you are
arguably to make any mistakes the easier
it is for other people to read and so
generally this readability this
simplification is indeed a good thing
well let's go ahead and add another
piece of capability it's a python and
that's this one here just like in
English where you can ask this question
or this other question you can say the
same thing in Python using literally
this word or so let me go back to my
python code here and let's propose how
we might ask a couple of questions at
once this time perhaps this time
considering how we might ask not whether
or not it's greater than or equal to in
caring about the precise answer let's
take a a coarser approach here and let's
just try to determine is X greater is x
equal to y or not well let me go ahead
and delete some of this code and change
the question we're asking let me do this
well if I care about whether it's equal
or not let's check the possible
scenarios if x is less than y or X is
greater than y let's go ahead and print
out X is not equal to Y now why is that
no pun intended if x is less than y well
it's obviously not equal if x is greater
than y it's obviously not equal so we
can include X is not equal to y
so if we instead want to make sure that
it is equal to we can just use hopes
else using print quote unquote X is
equal to Y and again Y is this well if x
is less than y or X is greater than y
they're obviously not equal otherwise
logically they must be equal in fact so
let's run this let's go ahead and run
python if compare.pi what's X1 what's Y2
okay X is not equal to Y let's do it
again but 2 for x 1 for Y X is not equal
to Y and one third time how about X is
one and Y is One X is now equal to Y now
if we want to compare that visually to
let me propose that the picture looks a
little something like this and again
this is the exact same thing logically
but it's a pictorial representation
thereof what's the first question well
if x is less than y well then we follow
the true arrow and we say quote unquote
X is not equal to Y and then we stop
but what if X is not less than y what if
it's greater than y what if it's 2 and 1
respectively then the answer to x less
than y's first question is false so we
go here we ask the second question
because of the or and that asks is X
greater than y if so notice this we can
kind of reuse some of the same parts of
this picture and just say X is not equal
to Y we don't need to add arrows and add
boxes unnecessarily we can reuse lines
of code uh picture parts of the picture
just as we have lines of code and then
we stop lastly we have the following if
we know that X is not less than y we
know that X is not greater than y it
must be the case that x equals y we
don't need to ask a third question
another diamond we can just immediately
print as much and then say stop as well
well what could I do here I bet I could
improve this code slightly
and if we really want to be nitpicky I
would argue that this is now really just
a minor refinement but it's a good habit
to get into thinking about could my code
be better could my code be simpler
could I improve this code further it's
subtle but could I improve the design
could I ask fewer questions could I
tighten it up so to speak
what do folks think you can ask if x is
just equal to Y then if we print X is
equal to Y else X is not equal to RX
perfect recall one of the other symbols
we saw in the available list earlier we
can check not just less than or greater
than or equal to we can literally ask
the question is it not equal to why are
we wasting time asking if it's less than
or if it's greater than well if all you
care about is is it not equal I think we
can do exactly that let's just ask the
one simple question we do care about and
so let me go back up here and let me
just say not both of these questions
let's get rid of the or let's just say
if X is not equal to Y then go ahead and
print X is not equal to Y and that too I
think is going to work exactly the same
but the picture now looks a little bit
different notice that this was our
flowchart earlier that represented that
same logic and there's a bit of
complexity you got to go left you got to
go right based on the answer to these
couple of questions if we now take into
account what this version of the program
looks like it's even simpler perhaps the
simplest one we've seen yet when we
start off the program we ask just one
and only one question is X not equal to
Y and if so true we we go ahead and
print out X not equal to Y if the answer
is false then of course it must be equal
to Y so we say that instead and if we
really want we could invert this if I go
back here to my code and if for whatever
reason you just prefer to think in terms
of equal or not equal as opposed to not
equal or equal it's really up to you we
could change this to be equals equals
but I'm going to have to change my print
statements to be in the opposite order
so let me go ahead now and reverse these
two here and move the second one first
and the first one second so now when I
execute this code I'm asking still just
one question so it's still just as good
just as succinct but now the diagram
instead of looking like this is going to
change the not equal to equal equal and
we just need to make sure that we print
out the right thing accordingly and
again here too just as the code is
getting a little more compact a little
more compact with fewer and fewer
characters so are these diagrams these
flow charts capturing the relative
simplification of each of those programs
too all right let me go ahead and pause
here to see if there's any questions now
on any of these versions of code
yeah I have a couple of questions
what if indentation is not used
uh if indentation is not used your
program will not work so python is a
little different from a lot of languages
in that it enforces the indentation
requirement uh some of you who have been
programming for years might not
necessarily be in the best habit of
indenting your code properly and one of
the features arguably of python is that
it makes you indent your code or it will
not just work and I think did you have
one other question
uh yeah uh this is the colon necessary
is the colon necessary yes the colon 2
is necessary so with python what you see
is what you get here and indeed it needs
to be indented and the colon is
necessary python does not use in the
same way by Convention as C and C plus
plus and Java curly braces to connote
blocks instead it relies indeed on this
indentation
well let me propose that we introduce
one other keyword here in Python to see
exactly how we might combine additional
thoughts and that's going to be
literally the word and a conjunction of
one or two or more questions that we
might want to ask at once and let me
propose here that we explore this kind
of logic by way of another program
altogether in vs code whereby I'll go
ahead now and create a new program say
called grade dot Pi let's consider
exactly what grade a student should get
based on their score on an exam or a
test or a quiz or some other assignment
like that I'm going to go ahead and run
code of grade.pi to give myself a new
file and I'm going to go ahead and start
by just getting the user's score again
on some assignment or tester or the like
and I'm going to store it in a variable
called score equal the return value of
the int function which is going to
convert whatever the user's input is
when prompted for this score so again
the user should just Oblige by giving me
a number like zero or one or two or
hopefully much higher than that like 97
98 99 100 assuming the test or assess is
out of 100 percentage points now how
could I go about assigning a grade to
the student score well in the U.S it's
very commonly the case that if you get
between a 90 and 100 that's an A and if
it's between an 80 and an 89 it's a b if
it's 70 and 79 it's a c and so forth all
the way down to F which should be e but
we'll see that there's a bit of a jump
so how might I express this well I can
use conditionals and I can ask a few
questions and then print out the
student's grade accordingly so let me
express it like this if the student
score is greater than or equal to 90 and
the student's score is less than or
equal to 100 so it's in that range let's
go ahead and print out that their grade
shall be an a because they're in the 90s
above grades range
L if the score is greater than or equal
to 80 and the score is less than or
equal to say 89 but here I have some
options logically I can actually express
myself in any number of ways and maybe
just to be a little cleaner I'm going to
say and score is less than 90. so I'm
using less than instead of less than or
equal to so I'm making sure that they're
boundaries between these grades are
correct then I'm going to go ahead and
give the student a b
if it's in the 80s L if score is greater
than or equal to 70 and the score is
less than 80. I'm going to go ahead and
give them a c l if the score is greater
than or equal to 60 and the score is
less than 70. I'm going to go ahead and
give them a d and here's where it's a
little anomalous at least in some
schools here else I'm going to go ahead
and give them uh an F so we're skipping
e all together and we're going to give
an f instead for the grade so that's the
catch-all and I think logically I've
gotten this correct at least based on
where I went to school growing up such
that it's going to give an A or a b or c
or a d else it's going to assume that
you got an F well let's try just a few
of these here let's run python of
grade.pi my score is let's let's start
strong 100. all right I got an A didn't
do as well the next time maybe it's a 95
still an a starting to slip further so I
got an 89 the next time that's now say a
b and let's say I really had a bad week
and it's now like a 71 that's now A C or
I didn't even submit it at all that's a
an F all together all right so it seems
to work that's not really an exhaustive
test but at least based on some sampling
there my code seems to work as I expect
but let's see if we can't tighten this
up it's not wrong it's correct and
indeed according to my own
specifications I dare say this code is
correct but can we tighten it up can we
reduce the probability of bugs now we're
down the line can we increase the
readability of it and can we increase
the efficiency of it can we get the
computer to have to answer fewer
questions and still get the same result
well let's see what we might do let me
just kind of switch things up if only to
demonstrate that we can use these
symbols in different ways I could say as
I've done if score is greater than or
equal to 90 but I can actually do this I
can flip it around instead of saying
greater than or equal to let's say 90 is
less than or equal to score and here
let's say if 80 is less than or equal to
score and here 70
is less than or equal to score and then
lastly 60 is less than or equal to score
so it's the same thing logically I'm
just kind of switching things around
just like you could do on paper pencil
if you really wanted but now notice this
trick and this is not possible for those
of you who have programmed in C or C
plus or Java or other languages notice
what I can do here is actually combine
these ranges notice that I'm asking two
questions two Boolean Expressions is 90
less than or equal to score and is score
less than or equal to 100 well python
allows you to Nest these things like
this and chain them together and just
like you would on paper pencil in the
real world you can encode in Python do
this which is just a little cleaner
right it's tightening up the code a
little bit it's fewer keystrokes it's
faster to type it's easier to read
moving forward so that's arguably better
as well so that's one Improvement it's
largely aesthetic in this case it's
still asking the same number of
questions but it's doing it a little
more succinctly still well what what
more could I do here next well you know
what each time I'm deciding these grades
I don't think I have to ask two
questions I don't have to ask is it
greater than 90 and less than 100 is it
greater than 80 and less than 90 if I
kind of rethink my logic I can maybe do
this better still let me propose that we
simplify this further and just do this
if we know the input for the moment is
going to be within 0 and 100 we can make
some assumptions we could say something
like if the score is greater than or
equal to 90 well the student gets an A L
if the score is greater than or equal to
80 the student gets a b l if score is
greater than or equal to 70 they get a c
l if
the score is greater than or equal to 60
they get a d else they get an F so what
have I done here well instead of asking
two questions every time checking the
lower bound and the upper bound of that
range I'm kind of being a little more
clever here by asking if the score is
greater than 90 well they've obviously
gotten an A or better if your score is
greater than 80 well you either deserve
an a if it's really strong or a B if
it's just above 80 but because of the if
L if logic we've already checked as the
student score greater than 90 and if
it's not then we're asking the question
well is it greater than 80 so you
implicitly know it's somewhere in the 80
to 89 range else you know it's in the 70
to 79 reach else it's in the next range
down so it's a minor optimization that
allows us to ask fewer questions but
again it's making the code arguably a
little more readable certainly more
succinct and then hopefully more
maintainable longer term any questions
then on these types
of changes and this type of logic with
our code
uh what if we don't use alif at all what
if we uh write the code in F yeah so
that's a good question because it's
actually going to have an unintended
effect here let me get rid of the F
temporarily and just focus on a through
D if we revert to where we began today's
story with conditional saying if if if
if now our cleverness here of using
broader strokes and not using an upper
and lower bound ranges is going to come
back to be a downside let me go ahead
and run python of grade.pi and suppose
my score is uh 95 I am so darn excited I
want my a but nope I just got an A a b a
c and a d so logically that's broken
things because if you don't make these
conditions mutually exclusive every one
of those questions is going to get asked
and therefore answered and even if your
grade is above a 90 it's also logically
above an 80 above a 70 above a 60 and if
I'd kept it in there I would have failed
as well with an F really good question
other questions here
on this form of logic like would there
be any I guess better way to kind of
clean up even just this simple statement
like we had before the previous one that
you had with the Elton oh I I like your
enthusiasm for simplifying things
further
I'm gonna go out on a limb here and say
this is about as good as it gets at
least using only conditional statements
I can if my mind wanders think of a
slightly more clever way to do this
maybe with something called a loop or
another programming construct we don't
have that yet in our vocabulary but yes
there's absolutely other ways to do it
but I think not yet if we want to
restrict ourselves to just words like if
and or and else uh and elif and and the
like well let me propose that we pivot
now to use another approach here that
uses one other symbol that up until now
we've not really had occasion to use let
me propose that we Implement a program
that we'll call parity and Mathematics
parity can refer to whether a number is
even or odd and that's kind of an
interesting question and it turns out it
can be useful in other applications too
to just ask the question is a given
number even or odd maybe that the user
typed in and let me go ahead and write a
new program called parity dot Pi via
code parody.pi in my terminal and let me
propose that we use this as an
opportunity to introduce the last of
those arithmetic symbols at least most
of which we're familiar with addition
subtraction multiplication division but
there's been on this list before this
last one here a percent sign and it
doesn't mean percentage in this case
when used as an operator in programming
in Python rather it represents the
so-called modulo operator for modular
arithmetic or at least in our case we're
going to use it to calculate the
remainder when dividing one number by
another well what do I mean by that well
if you take a number like 1 divided by
three three does not go into one eat
cleanly so you have a remainder of one
two divided by three has a remainder of
two three divided by three has a
remainder of zero because it divides
cleanly 4 divided by three has a
remainder of one because you can divide
it in once but then that leaves one so
it has a remainder of one and then
lastly something like 5 divided by 3 has
a remainder of course of two so that's
all we mean by remainder how much is
left over after divide dividing one
number by another well if I go back now
to my code and I consider how I might
implement the question is this number
even or odd let's consider how we might
Implement that since it's perhaps not
necessarily obvious how we can use this
additional building block but it turns
out it's going to be very useful longer
term well let's first just get a number
from the user in a variable called X and
I'm going to set that equal to the
conversion to int of whatever the user
inputs after asking them what's X
question mark and we've done that before
many times how do I now determine if x
is even or odd well it turns out if I
have access to a programmatic operator
that tells me the remainder I think I
can do this in fact let me just ask the
group and this is just from grade school
math perhaps what does it mean for a
number to be even
to be clear a number like zero two four
six eight ten twelve fourteen sixteen
those are all even numbers but what does
that really mean Elena if I'm saying
that right uh even numbers that can
divide it exactly by two for example two
four six eight and ten and perfect and
we could go on all day long literally
since there's an infinite number of
those even numbers but it's nice that
you formulated it in terms of a question
that we can ask very clearly is this
number cleanly divided by two that is
can we divide it by two with no
remainder a remainder of zero well
that's perfect because if we have this
operator this percentage sign that
allows us to answer just that what is
the remainder we can presumably check is
the remainder is zero or is it one do we
have nothing left over or do we have one
left over well let's ask that if x
divided by
two has a remainder of zero as Elena
proposes let's go ahead and print out
something like quote unquote even and
just say as much to the user else I
think we can assume that if a number is
not even it's going to be odd if it's
indeed an integer so I'm going to go
ahead and print out quote unquote odd
instead and let's go ahead and now run
pythonofparity.pi in my prompt what's X
let's start with two two is in fact even
let's start with four four is in fact
even let's get thing let's get
interesting with three three is now odd
and I think we could do that all day
long and hopefully get back indeed
exactly that answer but what more could
we do here how could we improve upon
this well recall that we have the
ability to invent our own functions and
let me just propose for the sake of
discussion that we're going to
eventually find that it's useful to be
able to determine if a number is even or
odd and so we'd like to have that
functionality built in and I don't think
python has a function for telling me
just that but I can invent it using Code
like just this so so let me go into my
earlier version here and let me propose
that we do this let me go ahead and
write a main function I'm going to get
back into that habit of defining a main
function to represent the main part of
my program and I'm going to do what I
did before I'm going to get an integer
from the user's input asking them what's
X question mark and then I'm going to
ask this question for the moment I'm
going to naively assume that the
function already exists but that's a
useful problem solving technique even if
I have no idea yet where I'm going with
this how I'm going to invent and
function that determines if a number is
even I'm just going to assume that
there's a function called is even and
I'm going to call it blindly like this
if is even passing in x
and then go ahead and print quote
unquote even so if this magical function
called is even returns true as its
return value I am going to print out
that it's even else otherwise I'm going
to assume that it's of course odd now
the one problem with this program even
if I call Main over here is that is even
does not exist and this program would
break if I ran it right now but that's
okay I have the ability to recall to
invent my own function so let me Define
with def a function called is even I
want this function to take an argument
and I'm going to call it n just a number
generically I could call it X but again
I don't want to confuse myself as to
which X is which so I'm going to give it
a different name and that's fine I'm
just going to call it more generically n
for number and then I'm going to do this
I'm going to say if n percent two equals
equals 0 just like before then and
here's the magic you the programmer can
actually return what are called Boolean
values we've seen in Python that python
has stirs or strings ins or integers
Floats or floating Point values all of
which are different types of data in
python python also has a fourth data
type called Bool for a Boolean value and
even though this is just adding to our
list the nice thing about bulls is that
they can only be true or false an INT
can be any number of an infinite
possible values a bull can only be true
or false and it must be capital T and
capital F if you're writing itself so if
I go back now to my code and I consider
exactly what I want to return here well
if x if n percent two equals equals zero
that is if n divided by 2 has a
remainder of 0 well I think it's even to
Elena your definition so let's return
true capital T else if it doesn't have a
remainder of zero I'm pretty sure
mathematically it's got to have a
remainder of one but it doesn't matter I
know it's not even so I'm going to
return false and we've returned false
instead capital F and now that we've
defined both Main and is even and I'm
calling main at the bottom I think I've
got this right python of parity.pi enter
what's X let's try something simple like
two and it's even let's do it again
what's X how about four even once more
what's X how about 3 and it's odd now
what have I done here I've just made the
point that if I want to create my own
function called is even that answers
this question for me that I can now use
in this program and heck maybe future
programs that I write I now have a
function that no one gave me I gave
myself that I can use and reuse and I
can even perhaps share it with others
I'm using that function now on line
three just to make a decision I'm using
a conditional up there and my Boolean
expression something that's true or
false is going to be not something
explicit like X less than y or y greater
than x or the like it's going to be a
function call I'm using a function as my
Boolean expression but that's okay
because I know because I wrote it that
that function is even returns true or it
returns false and that's all I need in a
conditional to make a decision to print
even or print odd
so let me pause here to see if there's
any questions now on how I've
implemented is even
using this bull hello hi David first of
all thank you for this wonderful class
uh name for yesterday and create stuff
uh I have just one query like basis on
the background of java uh there when we
used to pass the arguments we can also
pass the address of the variables so is
there any sort of this concept in Python
uh short answer no those who are
unfamiliar with Java or other languages
or C or C plus plus there's generally
ways to pass values in different
mechanisms that allow you or disallow
you to change them in Python no
everything we're going to see is
actually in fact an object but more on
that down the line how about time for
one more question here
on these bulls and these is evens
so I actually had a question about
um defining a function okay if that's
okay sure so if you define one are you
like within your code like you made it
up are you allowed to use the dot
operator like we did name dot strip and
use it like that good question if you've
created your own function can you use
other functions like dot strip or dot
title or dot capitalize that we've seen
in the past
um you can use those on strings those
functions come with strings you can't
necessarily use them on your own
functions unless your function returns a
string for the examples you gave I'm
returning a bull bulls have no notion of
white space to the left or the right you
can't call strip you can't call
capitalize but if you were writing a
different function that returns a string
absolutely you could use those functions
as well well let me turn our attention
if I may back to this example here and
consider as we now frequently do can we
improve on the design of this code can I
make this particular program better and
I can there's a couple of ways here and
I'll show you something that's now
generally known as something pythonic
there's actually this term of Art in the
python world where something is pythonic
if it's just the way you do things in
Python which is to say we've seen
already there's so many different ways
to solve certain problems and in the
python community of programmers there
tend to be some ways that are smiled
upon more than others and they tend to
relate to features that maybe only
python has but not other languages and
here's some syntax that you might not
have seen in languages like Java or C or
C plus if you've programmed before and
if you've never programmed before this
too is going to be new
instead of asking a question like this
if else using four lines in Python you
can actually collapse this into just one
more elegant line if you will instead of
asking if n divided by 2 has a remainder
of 0 return true else returned false let
me delete all of that and just say this
return true if n divided by 2 has a
remainder of 0 else return false now
those of you who do have prior
programming experience might actually
think this is kind of cool you can
condense from four lines into one line
that very same thought and one of the
reasons why python is popular is that it
does tend to read rather like English
it's not quite as user friendly as most
English or most human languages but
notice now the line does rather say what
you mean return true if n divided by 2
has a remainder of 0 else false I mean
that's pretty darn close to something
you might say logically in English be it
about even an odd or really anything
else so that program is going to work
exactly the same python of parody.pi let
me type in two it's still even let me
type in three it's still odd but I can
refine this even further and again
consistent with this idea of not just
writing correct code but writing better
and better code but still keeping it
readable I can do one even better than
this notice this value here is my
Boolean expression and it is going to
evaluate to true or false is n divided
by 2 having a remainder of 0 or not like
that is by definition a Boolean
expression it has a yes no answer a true
false answer well if you're Boolean
expression itself has a true or false
answer why are you asking a question in
the first place why ask if why say else
just return the value of your own
Boolean expression and perhaps the
tightest version the most succinct and
still readable version of this code
would be to delete this whole line
pythonic though it is and just return n
modulo 2 equals equals zero if it helps
let me add parentheses temporarily
because what's going to happen in
parentheses will happen first n divided
by 2 either does or does not have a a
remainder of zero if it does the answer
is true if it doesn't the answer is
false so just return the question if you
will you don't need to wrap it
explicitly with an if and an else and in
fact because of order of operations you
don't even need the parentheses so now
this is perhaps the most elegant way to
implement this same idea now which is
better this is pretty darn good and it's
hard to take fault with this because
it's so very succinct but it's perfectly
okay and just as correct to have an if
and then an else even though it might be
four Total Lines if that helps you think
about your code more clearly and it
helps other people reason about it as
well so it turns out there's another
syntax that you can use to implement the
same idea of a conditional whereby you
do something optionally based on the
answer to some Boolean expression and
the keyword that you can now use in
recent versions of python is called this
match match is a mechanism that if
you've programmed before is similar in
spirit to something called switch in
other languages for instance let me go
ahead here and close out parity.pi and
let me go ahead and create a new file
called house.pi and in house.pi I think
what we're going to do is try to
implement a program that prompts the
user for their name and it just outputs
what house they're known to be in in the
World of Harry Potter so for instance
let me go ahead and do this let me give
myself a variable called name set it
equal to the return value of the input
function and I'll say something like
what's your name question mark and then
after that I'm just going to use a
traditional if L if else construct to
decide what house this person is in so
let me say if name equals equals say
Harry as in Harry Potter well let's go
ahead and print out Harry's house which
is Gryffindor in the World of Harry
Potter L if the name is instead Hermione
then go ahead and print out also quote
unquote Gryffindor as she's in the same
house too L if name equals equals Ron
let's go ahead and similarly print out
Gryffindor quote unquote and let's make
this a little more interesting now L if
name equals quote unquote about Draco
Draco Malfoy in the books Let's go ahead
and print out quote unquote Slytherin
and just in case someone else's name
gets inputted for now let's just suppose
that we don't recognize them and say by
default else print out quote unquote who
question mark just to convey that we
don't actually have a hard-coded
response to that particular name let me
go ahead now and run this as python of
house.pi enter and I'll go ahead and
type in something like Harry and voila
we see that Harry is indeed in
Gryffindor let's run it one more time
python of house.pi let's type in Draco
this time Slytherin and now let's type
in an unrecognized name let's go ahead
and rerun python of house.pi and let's
go ahead and type in Padma enter and who
because we haven't actually hard-coded
with an L if condition in this case uh
what house Padma is meant to be in all
right well it turns out there's other
ways to implement this indeed there's
some redundancy here in that we're check
checking if Harry or Hermione or Ron are
all in Gryffindor I feel like we can at
least tighten this code up a little bit
using techniques we've seen already so
let me go ahead and do this let me go up
here and instead do something like this
let's get rid of these two blocks of L
ifs leaving just Harry's for a moment
and let's use that or keyword again and
say or name equals equals quote unquote
Hermione or name equals quote unquote
Ron thereby consolidating all three
cases if you will into just one if
statement then we still have a separate
L if for Draco because he's not in fact
in Gryffindor and then the final else to
catch anyone else all right let me go
ahead now and run this version of the
program python of house.pi I'll type in
Hermione this time she too is still in
Gryffindor let me try it with Ron and
that too still seems to be correct well
it turns out there's another approach
altogether that can perhaps make your
code a little less verbose you could
imagine how complicated this code might
get if we had not just Harry and
Hermione and Ron but a whole bunch of
other names as well for Gryffindor for
Slytherin and for all of the other
Hogwarts houses so you can imagine that
code just getting pretty unwieldy pretty
fast well it turns out another technique
you can use is indeed this keyword
called match which is very similar in
spirit but the syntax is different and
allows you to express the same ideas a
little more compactly so let me go back
to house.pi and let me propose that I
get rid of my current if L if else
approach and instead do this literally
use the keyword match and type the name
of the variable or value that we want to
match on and then I'm going to go ahead
and include a colon and then underneath
that I'm going to include literally a
keyword called case and the first case I
want to consider is going to be Harry
and I'm going to put Harry in quotes
because it's a string or a stir and I'm
going to have another colon at the end
of this line and indent it under that
one I'm going to go ahead and for now
print out Gryffindor which of course is
Harry's house otherwise I'm going to
have another case for quote unquote
Hermione and similarly I'm going to have
under that indented print quote unquote
Gryffindor or close quote now I'm going
to have another case for Ron also in
quotes with a colon now print quote
unquote Gryffindor and now I'm going to
have a other case for let's say Draco
this one gets a little more interesting
because Draco of course now is in
Slytherin and then I'm gonna go ahead
and leave it as that for now so let me
go ahead and save this file and go back
down to my terminal window running
python of house.pi enter and let's go
ahead and try Harry and he seems still
to be in Gryffindor let's run it again
for Hermione enter Gryffindor let's skip
ahead to Draco and type in draco's name
he's indeed in Slytherin now let's try
another name that we haven't handled a
case for like Padma again enter and
we're just ignored there's no output
whatsoever because there wasn't a case
for Padma now we could of course go back
in and explicitly add one for Padma but
what if we similarly to the else
construct just want kind of a catch-all
that handles anyone whose name is not
explicitly specified Well turns out the
Syntax for that using this new match
statement is to still have another case
but then to use this single underscore
character which is used in other
contexts in Python but for here it's
meant to say whatever case has not yet
been handled go ahead and print out as
we did before for instance quote unquote
who with a question mark at the end now
let's go ahead and rerun this python of
house.pi I'll type padma's name again
and this time I think we're at least
going to get an explicit response
indicating who whereas previously we did
not have the equivalent of that now I
think we've regressed a little bit we
went from tightening things up by
putting Harry and Hermione and Ron all
on the same line in the same if
statement but here we have now three
case statements again for all three of
those well we can tighten these this
code up as well but the syntax is going
to be a little bit different I'm going
to go ahead and delete these two middle
cases for Hermione and Ron and then up
here next to Harry's name before the
colon I'm going to go ahead and use a
single vertical bar and then a
quote-unquote Hermione then another
single bar and do quote on unquote Ron
and this is how using this relatively
new match statement you can say the
equivalent of Harry or Hermione or Ron
but more concisely than you could using
an if statement alone as we implemented
it previously so now one final run of
the program with python of house.pi
let's make sure that Harry is still in
Gryffindor let's make sure that Hermione
is still in Gryffindor let's make sure
that Ron is still in Gryffindor and
indeed all three of them are now as
always with python and programming more
generally there's going to be different
ways you can solve these problems this
is just another tool in your toolkit
arguably it has tightened things up
arguably it's perhaps a little more
readable because there's a little less
syntax going on a little less
duplication of equal signs and elephant
elephant eleph all over the place but
ultimately this would be an equally
correct approach to that same problem
but it turns out with the match
statement you can do even more powerful
forms of matching as well here we've
used it simply to implement the same
idea as that if L if else construct and
it's worth noting if you've programmed
in some other language the syntax here
is indeed correct you do not need for
instance a break statement as has been
peppered throughout and you don't need
something like default or something
explicit you indeed just use this
underscore as your catch-all at the end
of the match
so just by adding in some of these new
keywords here like if and L if and else
we have now the ability to ask questions
about values we have the ability to
analyze input from users and ultimately
make decisions about it and these then
were our conditionals lying ahead is
going to be the ability for us to not
only use functions and variables and
also these conditionals but also next
Loops the ability to do something now
again and again
[Music]
thank you
all right this is cs50's Introduction to
programming with python my name is David
Malin and this week we focus on Loops
disability in python and a lot of other
programming languages to do something
again and again a cycle of sorts and
let's see if we can't begin by
motivating exactly why we have this
ability to do things cyclically using
these loops I'm going to go ahead here
and open up vs code and in my terminal
window let's go ahead and create uh via
code cat.pi a Python program that meows
like a cat and I'm going to go ahead
here in this code tab very simply
perhaps I'm going to start by
implementing this cat just by using
print we're going to have this cat not
make audible sounds but just print meow
meow meow on the screen three times well
I think the simplest way I can do this
is just to print meow once and to print
meow again and to print meow One Last
Time on the screen and now let me go
down to my terminal window let me run
python of cat.pi enter and meow meow
meow all right so this program works
this program indeed works if my goal is
to get the cat to meow three times and
let me propose just to help us wrap our
minds around what's going on inside of
the computer let me propose that we
consider this flowchart so as before we
have this flowchart that starts with a
this oval which just means start reading
here and then notice it goes via arrows
to a meow meow meow and then it stops
it's perfectly correct and honestly it's
wonderfully simple but I dare say we can
find fault with my code nonetheless
why is my code arguably poorly designed
now the answer is going to be Loops in
some way but let's see if we can
identify in what way the code is
actually poorly designed in some sense
let's see any thoughts Alex
okay so I mean repeating the same action
like three times so even more
um it's not a good habit yeah I'm just
repeating myself and honestly it's not
that big a deal if we go back to my code
here am I really doing such a bad thing
by just printing meow meow meow three
times not really but let's consider The
Logical extension of this suppose I
wanted me out four times or five times
or 50 times or 500 times do you really
think even if you've never programmed
before is the solution to this problem
really going to be to hit copy paste 50
times like probably not we can probably
do better than that and Beyond it just
being ugly at that point having so many
lines of identical code just imagine if
you wanted to change the code maybe I
changed my mind and I don't want to make
a cat I want to make a dog so now it has
to say woof woof woof multiple times now
I have to change that in like 50
different places and yes sure I could do
find and replace but come on like we're
programmers now there's got to be a
better way than just repeating ourselves
so I bet that we can do better than that
if we think about a little harder what
we how we go about structuring this
program and we can do that if we augment
our vocabulary just a little bit it
turns out in Python and in other
languages too there's a keyword called
while and while is one way that we can
express what's called a loop a block of
code that's going to do something again
and again and again zero times one time
two times fifty times as many times as
we want
but while rather leaves to us the the
particulars of how we express ourselves
to do something again and again so let
me go back over to vs code here and let
me propose that I do this while is a
construct that allows me to ask a
question again and again and anytime
we've seen a question it's been in the
form of a Boolean expression a question
to which the answer is true or false
well how could I do this how could I
print out meow three times and ask three
times a question to which the answer is
true or false well what if I did some
counting right like literally on my
fingers and if I'm trying to count maybe
down from three I want to meow three
times I can put three fingers up and I
can meow and then I can put like one of
the fingers down and then meow and I can
put one of the fingers down and I can
meow put one of the fingers down and
maybe the question I can ask every time
I meow is do I have any fingers up still
do I have any fingers up still do I have
any fingers up still don't the answer is
true keep going if the answer is false
stop
so how can I translate that to code well
once we've added this wild keyword I
think we have all the building blocks
already let me propose that I do this
let me propose that I give myself a
variable and I'll call it I for integer
but I could call it anything I want and
I'm going to initialize it to 3. then
I'm going to use this new feature of
python while and I'm going to ask a
question the answer to which must be
true or false and I'm going to say while
I does not equal zero so I'm going to
ask the question while I does not equal
0 do the following notice the colon at
the end of the line notice my
indentation and just like with functions
just like with conditionals you indent
the lines that you only want to execute
as part of this other thing what do I
want to do while I does not equal zero
well I think I just want to meow but
it's not enough just to write this code
if I were to very dangerously run python
of cat.pi and hit enter right now
what might happen on the screen
whether you've programmed before or not
why is this a very bad thing potentially
it's not going to break things but it
might it might lose control of my
computer somehow
any thoughts uh yeah Teemo hi uh I think
it's going to continue uh to print out
mail since I is always equal to 3 and
the wow is always true yeah exactly if
I'm initializing I to three that is
setting it equal to three on line one
then I'm asking the question while I
does not equal zero and that's going to
be true it does not equal zero it
obviously equals three print meow and
the way a while loop works is that the
python interpreter just keeps going back
and forth it goes from line one to line
two then to line three and then it goes
back to line two to ask the question
again if the answer is still true it
goes to line three it then goes back to
line two if the answer is still true it
goes back to line three and to timu's
point if you're never actually changing
the value of I it's always three you're
just going to be looping literally
forever and this is an accidental
infinite Loop so we've got to be smarter
than that I'm not going to hit enter
because I don't want to lose control
over my computer here such that it's
printing out meow forever fortunately if
you ever do do that and you find
yourself in an accidental infinite Loop
control C for cancel or interrupt is
going to be your friend if you ever seem
to lose control you don't need to like
reboot or turn off the computer you can
just hit Ctrl C in your terminal window
and that will likely fix it all right
well what do I want to do then after
meowing each time I think what I'd like
to do here is maybe something like this
let me update I to equal whatever the
current value is
minus one here whoops sorry minus one so
if I on each iteration am updating I to
be one less one less one less it should
eventually hit zero at which point the
answer to 9 2's question will now be
false so let's see if this works I'm
going to go down to my terminal window
and run python of cat.pi and I indeed
get three meows why why because I've
kind of wired this up kind of like a
machine in software if you will I've set
I equal to three then I keep asking this
question but I keep turning the gears I
keep changing the value of the variable
to make sure that ultimately it is
actually being decremented that is
decreased by one until we eventually hit
zero now for those of you who think a
little more graphically let me pull up
one of our usual flow charts this is
just a representation graphically of the
exact same thing notice what's happening
I first start the program and then I
initialize I to three and then I ask the
first of my questions again the diamonds
always represent questions and the
answer is going to be true or false does
I not equal zero well it doesn't equals
three so if I follow the true line I
meow and then I follow this arrow and I
update I to equal I minus 1 at this
point in the story I presumably equals
two mathematically I Follow the arrow
and there's the loop this is why it's
nice to see this graphically perhaps
because you can literally see the loop
back and forth now I ask the question
again does two not equal zero well it
does not equal zero it's two so we meow
again we change I from two to one well
does one not equal zero well obviously
if one is not zero so we meow again we
decrement I again I is now zero does
zero not equal zero no it equals zero so
the answer is false and we stop
so there perhaps more so than any of our
flow charts before do you really see the
structure of what's Happening inside of
the program and you don't have to get
into the habit of making these charts or
creating these charts but just as a
first pass at what's going on inside of
the computer that's indeed one way to
visualize it instead well let me propose
that like always there's many different
ways to solve this problem and suppose
you just like to think a little
differently maybe you don't like
starting at three and then counting down
to zero y maybe your just brain doesn't
work that way and you prefer to count up
instead of down totally fine let me go
ahead and change my code here to set I
equal to one instead of three and here
let me just change my logic rather than
checking for not equal to zero like
maybe you don't like thinking in terms
of not because it's a little confusing
and it might be let's just check that I
is less than or equal to three so we'll
be a little more explicit we'll count
from one up through three each time
printing meow but I'm going to need to
change this line here let me see if we
can't call on someone to change line
four for me how do I want to change line
four
to be consistent
with counting from one up to and through
three
I would be plus one every time you meow
yeah exactly in this case we want to add
one not subtract one and in fact if you
think about this this two could end very
poorly right if you start counting at
one and you keep subtracting one
subtracting one subtracting one I think
we're going to find ourselves with the
same problem which is that we're never
going to stop because we're going to
keep getting more and more negative as
opposed to ever getting up to the number
three so I think you're right I need to
change this to be I equals I plus one
and now notice just for clarity two the
equal sign is again our assignment
operator from right to left logically
this might otherwise strike you as
strange like how can I equal itself plus
one well it doesn't until you execute
this code from right to left you add one
to I or You Subtract one from I and then
you update the value of I on the left
the assignment copies the value from the
right to the left well how else might I
do this well I will say that most
programmers computer scientists more
generally tend to start counting from
zero it's a convention and it actually
has upsides even in Python and other
languages where generally speaking it's
a good thing to start counting from zero
instead of counting like we might in the
real world from one let's go ahead and
adopt that convention now let me set I
equal to zero and I need to make a
change now notice if I don't change my
logic this program just became buggy the
cat has a bug it's now meowing four
times if I run it as is but the easiest
fix here would be to change my
inequality to be this less than instead
of less than or equal to now I'm
starting at zero but I'm going up two
but not through three and even though
this might of all the things we've seen
thus far see maybe the least familiar
most of us might start at one two then
three it's a good habit to get into now
start at zero and go up two but not
through the value that you care about
ultimate at least three in this case
here well let me tighten things up a bit
here not only will this now fix my
counting problem it now meows three
times as expected there's a more
succinct way to express I equals I plus
one and this is because it's such a
popular thing to do in code you can
instead just say I plus equals one and
that's it you don't need to put
everything on the right hand side this
is a special syntax that says the exact
same thing increment I but it does it
with a few fewer keystrokes it's just a
little more pleasant to type it's a
little faster to read it's just a
convention those of you who have
programmed in C C plus plus python not
python C C plus plus Java JavaScript
might have seen plus plus before or
minus minus
sorry python doesn't have it so you
cannot use that this is a succinct as
your line of code might get
all right let me pause here to see then
if there's any questions about these
implementations of while loops
um can we use stuff like for Loops which
um have a certain I value initialized to
it at the start and it runs from the
particular condition you put into the
um into the thing and increment it as as
you go along short answer no you cannot
do what you're describing but there is
another type of for Loop that we will
soon see but let's compare to that in
just a moment other questions
on Loops using while here
so I had a question about the flow
charts okay uh there were certainly yeah
there were certain symbols for the
certain kind of the statements uh sir
the artists certainly used for that kind
of statement that they are protected
they are so I deliberate use anyone I
deliberately use certain types of
symbols certain shapes here uh whereby
an oval is conventional for start and
stop I used rectangles for any statement
of code like an assignment or a printing
and so forth and I use diamonds to
represent uh questions that you might
ask conditions as we've seen
um if you're doing this for yourself if
you're just trying to make sense of your
code and writing it down you certainly
don't need to use these formal symbols
but I tried to be consistent with some
best practices and in fact let me come
back to the same picture because this
was the first version of our picture but
we've since modified our code a couple
of times this recall was the version
where the question we were asking was I
not equal to zero let me go ahead and
just change this code now to represent
the next version we did which recall
changed our logic to start counting from
one it changed our question to check is
I less than or equal to three but then
everything else was the same except for
the counting which is now Plus instead
of minus and then we refined it little
bit further by counting now from zero up
two but not through three and we
tightened up this code here by just
incrementing one by using the slightly
more succinct syntax so at this point
these flow charts might become less and
less useful for us because once you've
wrapped your mind around the concept and
hopefully the picture helps bring that
concept to life it's certainly fine to
focus entirely on the code and only
think about or even draw something like
this if you need to wrap your mind
around something more complicated than
you're used to well let me go ahead if I
may and propose that we transition to
another approach of types of Loops using
another keyword here namely a for Loop
and this is a word that does exist in
other languages but doesn't necessarily
have as many features as other languages
might use it for but there is a
different type of loop not a while loop
but a for Loop and a for Loop is going
to explore allow us to express ourselves
a little differently but to do so I'd
propose that the easiest way is if we
introduce one other idea in Python we
which is that of a list and here too no
pun intended we're adding to the list of
data types that python supports we've
seen stirs or strings ins or integers
Floats or floating Point values bulls or
Boolean Expressions python also has
lists which is another type of data but
wonderfully this one's probably pretty
familiar a list of things in the real
world is a list of things in Python it's
a way of containing multiple values all
in the same place all in the same
variable so what do I mean by this well
let me propose that we go back to our vs
code here and let me kind of start fresh
with my code here and not use a while
loop at all but let me use this new
keyword for the way the for Loop works
is that it allows you to iterate over a
list of items so what does this look
like it might look like this 4 I in the
following list of items 0 1 2. this is
my starting point and on each iteration
of this Loop that is on each execution
of this loop again and again I want to
print out meow
now I'll admit I kind of like the look
of this code already even though there's
some new syntax here because it's just
shorter than the while loop right the
while loop had multiple lines a moment
ago and it was entirely up to me to
decide what i is I have to check a
condition I have to increment or
decrement I like I was doing a lot of
work relatively speaking to make that
thing turn to make that Loop go and go
it was very mechanical in a sense you
could kind of in your mind's eye maybe
see the gears turning as all of these
variables are changing and these
questions are being asked a for Loop
kind of simplifies all of that and it
just says if you want a variable like I
a number and you know in advance how
many times you want this Loop to execute
three times we'll just kind of specify
what it is you want I to take on as
values explicitly in this loop I will be
automatically initialized by python to
be zero then meow will be printed then
python would automatically update I to
equal one then meow will be printed then
python will automatically update I to B2
and meow will be printed and because
that's it for the values in that list
python will stop and it will only map
now a total of three times what is the
list the list in this program is exactly
that zero comma one comma two and notice
the square brackets those aren't
parentheses those are square brackets
that represent a list that's how you
know visually as the programmer that's
how python knows as the language that
you intend for that to be a list
so let me go ahead and run this python
of cat dot pi and it works just the same
but it's only two lines it's pretty
readable once you have familiarity with
that construct but
to my constant point about correctness
not necessarily being the same as design
in what sense is this program perhaps
poorly designed it seems to work it
meows three times
but why might this not be the best way
to solve this problem even if you've
never programmed before again think
about Corner cases things that may or
may not happen think about extreme cases
that really test the quality of this
code okay I think that because like
again we are saying 0 1 2
please subscribed and then like if you
want to print a million you say one two
three
yeah exactly and that's what I mean
about thinking about the extreme cases
if you're trying to decide for yourself
if your own code is good or someone
else's code is good it might look so at
first glance but think about the extreme
well what if it's not three things it's
a million things I mean are you really
gonna write out one zero through a
million or zero through nine uh you know
999 thousand uh 999 999 like no you're
not gonna write that many numbers on the
screen there's got to be a better way so
let's do the better way from the get-go
rather than set the stage for doing
something poorly and the one way we can
solve this problem to improve the design
is don't just manually specify the list
of values use a function someone else's
function that comes with python that
gives you the list you want and the
easiest way to do that in Python is to
use a function called range that returns
to a range of values it expects his
input at least one argument and that
number is going to be the number of
values you want back those values are
going to start at zero and go to one to
two and so forth but they will go up two
but not through the number you specify
so by specifying range three you're
essentially being handed back one two
three values and by default those values
are 0 1 and 2 and that's it but what's
brilliant about this is that now to
Hope's point if I do want to meow a
million times I mean that is an angry
cat I can now do a million by just
typing a million I don't have to
literally type zero comma one comma two
comma three comma four all the way up to
999 999 I just do this so that's got to
be a better way long term so that's
indeed one Improvement we can indeed
make here still using a for Loop but now
using this range function and just to
show you something else that's pythonic
this is not strictly necessary but it's
commonly done there's a minor
Improvement we can make here even if
we're just meowing three times and
notice that even though I'm defining a
variable I
I'm not ever using it and it's kind of
necessary logically because python
presumably has to use something for
counting right it has to know what it's
iterating over but there's this
convention in Python where if you need a
variable just because the programming
feature requires it to do some kind of
counting or automatic updating but you
the human don't care about its value a
pythonic Improvement here would be to
name that variable a single underscore
just because it's not required it
doesn't change the correctness of the
program but it signals to yourself later
it signals to colleagues or teachers
that are looking at your code too that
yes it's a variable but you don't care
about its name because you're not using
it later it's just necessary in order to
use this feature this Loop in this case
here so just a minor Improvement or
change there
but to really get you intrigued by
what's possible in Python let's take
this one step further so if we really
want to be pythonic this one if you've
programmed before is kind of going to
blow your mind so to speak whereby if I
want the cat to meow three times what if
I actually do this
print open parenthesis quote unquote
meow times three
all right you have to be kind of a geek
to think this is cool but this is kind
of cool so you can literally just print
what you want multiply it by the number
of times that you wanted and you will
get back exactly that result now I've
kind of made a mistake here so let's see
what this does it's not quite as
beautiful as this code might look to to
you to some of you to me let me run
python of cat.pi enter okay it's a
really like Hungry Cat or something it's
meowing really fast but I can fix this I
bet
let's think about now some of the basic
building blocks we've discussed the
problem is clearly that literally meow
meow meow is being repeated three times
but it's not as pretty as I want it I
want it to be meow meow meow on separate
lines what might be a possible solution
here while still using this
multiplication operator and think back
we've used plus to concatenate strings
you can apparently use multiplication to
concatenate strings but more than once
again and again and again how could I
clean this up without reverting to my
for Loop or my while loop and still use
multiplication in this way we can use an
escape sequence we should do backslash
and amazing yes think back to backslash
n which is the way you as the programmer
can express a new line in code and I
think if I take your advice I put a
backslash in there inside of my quotes
So that at the end of every meow there's
a new line let's see how this looks Let
Me Clear My screen and run python of
cat.pi okay so close I like this let me
call on someone else the only thing I
don't like and I know I'm being really
nitpicky now is that it's meow meow meow
on separate lines but there's kind of
this extra blank line which I'm just not
loving aesthetically I think we can uh
make Endeavor
yeah so here too like all of these
things we've seen in past weeks are kind
of coming together right recall that the
print function lets you control what the
line ending is by default it's backslash
and itself which is why at the very end
of this print the cursor is being moved
again to the next line well we need to
just override that so let me go into my
code here and let me change this to
comma end equals quote unquote so that
it's no longer the default backslash n
it's instead now going to be uh nothing
whatsoever that should eliminate then
hopefully that additional uh blank line
so let me run this one last time here
python of cat.i I enter and there we
have it so now you know at least as
programming goes it's kind of cool that
I can distill this into a short line and
express myself all at once now to be
fair it's a little less readable like
now I've got backslash n I've got times
three I've got and equals quote unquote
so you don't have to do things this way
my previous approach with a for Loop
totally fine my previous approach with a
while loop totally fine and in some
sense perfectly well designed but this
is just yet another way to do it but
it's not a good thing if you or your
teacher your colleague your friend are
going to struggle to read your own code
but this is a feature of python that
some languages do not in fact have
all right well let me propose that
things get more interesting still if
we're not just smelling three times only
but we're meowing some variable number
of times let's ask the user how many
times this cat should meow so let me
clear the screen here and let me figure
out well how do I get a number from the
user the catch here is that if I want
the user to give me a number I'm not
doing math per se I'm meowing and
therefore the user has to give me a
positive value the user has to give me a
positive value so how can I insist on
this well if I just do this n equals int
of input what's n question mark
well I want to check like I could say if
n is less than zero like if it's
negative well I could do this well then
ask again int input what's and question
mark okay well what if the user still
doesn't give me a positive number what
if they're being really difficult
they're not paying attention and they
typed in two negative numbers well if n
is less than zero well let's do it again
n equals right this does not end well
you can't infinitely many times keep
checking is it negative is it negative
is it negative right the program would
never be done written so we can do this
I think better maybe with a loop so let
me propose this a very common Paradigm
in Python when you want to get user
input that matches a certain expectation
you have that it's all positive that
it's all negative or just something like
that you just immediately say while true
you deliberately and a little
dangerously but a very conventionally
induce an infinite it Loop now what is
an infinite loop it's just one that goes
forever and we've seen how that can
happen accidentally mathematically it's
absolutely going to happen when you say
while true why well the answer to the
true question is always true so this is
a way of deliberately inducing a loop
that by default is going to go forever
so we're going to need a way of breaking
out of this Loop when we have the number
we want the convention though inside of
this otherwise an infinite Loop is to
ask the question you care about like
give me an INT by prompting the user for
input like what's n question mark and
then just ask your question so if n is
less than zero then I think we want
python to just continue to prompt the
user again that is we want the code to
stay in the loop recall the input
function and hope that the user gives us
a better answer if this time around it's
less than zero so let's just literally
use Python's keyword continue which says
just that continue to stay within this
Loop else if it's not less than zero
let's go ahead and just break out of the
loop altogether using another keyword in
Python break break will break you out of
the most recently begun Loop in this
case if it's not the case that n is less
than zero so this will work and it will
allow us to get a value that's zero or
greater from the user but I think we can
tighten it up further so as to not
bother having an if and an else why
don't we instead just say if n is
greater than zero go ahead and break in
fact it's not that interesting a program
if we even allow the user to type in
zero so let's wait until they give us an
integer that is greater than zero and
then break out of this Loop and what can
I now do down here for I in range of
whatever that value n is print meow and
honestly I don't need I here so let me
come back to that principle before and
let me just change it to an underscore
just to be pythonic if you will so
what's going on lines one through four
deliberately Implement an infinite Loop
that otherwise by default is going to go
forever but I'm asking a question inside
of that loop after getting an INT from
the user on line two I'm then checking
is it greater than zero or is it zero is
it negative none of which makes sense
for a meowing cat like I want the cat to
meow at least one time so if it is
greater than zero break and this break
statement even though it's indented
indented twice has the effect of
breaking out of the most recently begun
while loop so once the user gives you a
positive value then we get to line six
at which point we meow that many times
because of lines six and seven so if I
run this now python of cat.pi enter well
what's n let's start with 3 where we
began meow meow meow well this time let
me go ahead and increase the size of my
terminal window just temporarily let me
run python of cat.pi let me do it 10
times meow 10 times now appears on the
screen and the takeaways here are not
just that we can meow 10 times or do
something again and again but this is a
very common Paradigm in Python when you
want to do something again and again and
again but only until the user actually
gives you a value that you care about
here
and let me propose actually now that we
practice a little more what we've been
preaching especially when it comes to
say
especially when it comes to say writing
your own functions you know now that I'm
doing all this mailing it might be nice
to actually have a meow function that
the inventors of python didn't Envision
so let me do this let me actually get
rid of all this code and let me go ahead
and do this let me go ahead and say
Define a main function as I've done
before and let me just blindly call meow
three meow doesn't exist yet but when it
does that'll be great so let me go ahead
now and Define meow so my meow function
should take as input a parameter called
n or anything I want and this part's
pretty easy now how do you meow in times
well for underscore in the range of n Go
ahead and just print meow so same code
as before nothing new here I'm just
putting that logic inside of a meow
function that's going to have this side
effect of printing meow and now as
before let me go down here and let me
make sure I call Main and if I now run
this code python of cat.pai meow meow
meow it's always going to do three be
because I've hard-coded the three well
let's make one Improvement here let me
go ahead now and maybe do this let me
ask the user for a number so let's say
something like this number equals get
number all right unfortunately there is
no function in Python called get number
that gets a positive number from the
user but I can invent that so Define get
number open paren close paren and then
inside of this function let me do this
while true go ahead and get a number
from the user converting it to an INT
asking them what's in question mark and
then if n is what I want it's a greater
than zero value a positive number I
don't want to break this time
necessarily
although I could I instead want to
return the value so I can actually do
this instead and this too is a feature
of python this ability not to just break
out of a block of code but also to
return a value in code to actually
return a value gives you the ability
ultimately to return explicitly a value
so that your function has not just a
side effect necessarily but it actually
hands back just like input does just
like int does just like float does and
actual value to the user now to be clear
I don't have to return n here I can
still break out of the loop as I've done
in the past with code like this but then
after the loop I still have to return n
and so what's happening here is that if
you use break to get out of the loop but
you need to hand back a value from a
function you still have to use the
return keyword now explicitly either in
the loop as I did or now outside of the
loop but still inside of
the function the last thing I'm going to
do here now is change that 3 which we
hard coded earlier to actually be the
value of the variable we've gotten from
the user so that now down here if I run
python of cat.pi enter what's N I can
type in three I get my three meows or if
I only want one I now get one meow
instead
all right so if we now have this ability
to do things again and again in these
Loops let's see if we can't solve some
other problems via which to express
ourselves cyclically but get back some
interesting answers as well let me
propose for instance that we look a
little more closely at these lists it
turns out that in Python and really in
programs in general it's useful to have
a list of values because we're going to
be able to work with more and more data
larger and larger data sets so let me
propose that we come back to vs code
here and let's do something that's
perhaps a little familiar to some folks
the world of Hogwarts and let me go
ahead and code up a file called Hogwarts
and let's see if we can't have a list of
students at Hogwarts here so I have a
new tab called hogwarts.pi and let me go
ahead and propose that I just Define in
this program a list of students whose
names I know in advance so I'm not going
to get user input for now I'm just going
to know from the get-go that the three
students I want to consider are these a
variable is going to be called students
it's going to equal as I've stun in the
past a square bracket which means hey
here comes a list and those values are
going to be Hermione in quotes because
it's a string Harry in quotes because
it's a string and then Ron in quotes
because it's a string as well so this is
a list of length three it's similar in
spirit to my list of length 3 earlier
but that had three ins zero one two now
I have a list of three strings instead
and this isn't very useful at the moment
but let me just do something as a check
for myself let me print out each of
these students well wait a minute how do
I
print the contents of a list well in the
past when we've printed a variable we've
just printed out the name of the
variable but I don't want to print out
all of Hermione and Harry and Ron all at
once maybe I want to print out Hermione
first then Harry then Ron so I need a
way to express more precisely which
value do I want from this list and the
way you do this in Python is you use
square brackets in another way if you
have a variable in this case called
students and you want to go inside of
that variable and get a specific value
that is to say you want to index into
the list you use square brackets this
way using numbers inside of the square
brackets and here's where we see that it
is useful to think and count in terms of
zero on up instead of one on up these
lists in python or shall we say zero
indexed the first item in a list is at
location zero the second item in a
python list is at location one and the
third is that location 2 too so you're
always kind of off by one mentally but
you get used to it if you've never
programmed before over time so let me
print out all three students so let me
print out students bracket zero then
students bracket one then lastly let me
print students bracket two and this is
my third and final line and of course if
I run this code it probably does what
you would guess if I run python of
hogwarts.pi there's Hermione Harry and
Rob each on their own lines there but
there's got to be a better way right
especially if I don't know in advance
who's going to be in this list if next
year there's some new students at
Hogwarts we can use a loop to do
something automatically without having
to manually type out zero and then one
and two well here's another feature of
python you can use a for Loop not just
to count from zero to one to two you can
use Python to just iterate over anything
not just numbers but strings so I could
actually do this
4. student in students colon and then
indented underneath that I can say print
student now it doesn't matter if I have
three students or four or four hundred
this two lines of code this Loop will
print all of those students for me one
at a time so if I now run python of
hogwarts.pi there's the same list but I
don't need to know in advance how long
that actual list is now notice I made a
conscious decision here I didn't call
this variable underscore because this
time I'm using the variable and while I
could do this now no no no no your code
is getting way too cryptic if you're
naming the variable underscore and
you're using the variable underscore now
you're helping no one now you're
confusing the reader yourself down in
the down the line you should call your
variables what they are so in very
appropriate name though I'm sure you
could come up with others would be
student and here you could say you would
say student as well if you'd prefer to
be more succinct it's not unreal
reasonable to do something succinct in a
loop like this for s in students using
maybe the same letter that the list
itself begins with but again why bother
python is meant to be more readable if
you have a list of students iterate over
them one student at a time let me pause
here to see if there's now questions
about lists as I've now defined them a
list of strings in this case or using a
for Loop now to iterate over and print
each of those names yeah uh so is it not
necessary to initiate student in this
case or we can just declare a variable
in the loop good question you do not
need to manually initialize it python
takes care of initializing the student
variable to Hermione first then Harry
second then Ron third unlike other
languages you don't need to initialize
it to something yourself it just exists
and it will work other questions on
loops and lists in this way since you
describe break so is there any concept
of continue so that we can skip a
particular case in Loops yes you can
continue using another syntax as well we
haven't shown that for now we focused
only on break
uh okay so uh can this follow work with
either hash tables or different kind of
fight tables or arrays uh indeed so
we're getting ahead of ourselves there
but there are yet other types of data in
Python and indeed you can use a for Loop
to iterate over those as well anything
that is iterable so to speak is a piece
of data that can be used with a loop
like this but more on those more on
those soon in fact let me transition
here to show just another way of solving
the same problem because up until now
when we've used Loops we really have
relied on numbers and that's fine if you
prefer to sort of stay in that space
suppose I did want to iterate using
numbers like I and 0 1 2 and so forth
let me propose that we could change this
code as follows if you would prefer to
think about or if the program you're
trying to implement requires that you
use numbers like this you might do this
for I in well I don't want to just say
students because then I is not going to
be a number I is going to be literally
Hermione then Harry then Rob I need to
iterate from zero to one to two right if
I know a list with three elements has
these locations zero one two I need to
create a loop somehow that starts at
zero and ends at two previously when I
wanted to do that I needed range but
this 2 is not going to work I can't just
say in the range of students because
students is not a number it's not an
integer so you can't pass it to range
range expects an integer but there is a
solution here it turns out that there is
a function in Python called length or
Len Len that will tell you the length of
a list and other things down the line
too and now I think I can assemble these
building blocks in a way that can allow
me to use numbers in this way so range
doesn't take a list of strings it takes
a number and ideally that number is
going to be three so I get a range of
values 0 1 and 2. so I think I can Nest
my functions like this this if I first
get the length of the students list
that's going to be 3 then I pass that
return value as the argument to range
that's going to give me back a range of
value 0 then 1 then 2. and what that's
going to allow me to do then in code if
I want is not just this I could do print
now students bracket I and this is now
where the syntax we're seeing is getting
very expressive new and perhaps
unfamiliar but if I can do Open Bracket
zero close bracket or Open Bracket one
close bracket or Open Bracket two close
bracket turns out I can actually put a
variable in there and I can express any
number inside of those brackets so as to
print these all out dynamically in a
loop let me do this python of
hogwarts.pi enter there's Hermione Harry
and Ron and now if I'm just curious I
just want to poke around or maybe I want
to do a ranking like who are the top
three students in the school or in
Gryffindor well I can print multiple
things at a time we've seen let me print
out not just the students at location I
but rather let's print I first and then
the student at location I so two things
to print and we know that print can take
two arguments we've seen that before
they'll be separated by a space let me
go ahead and rerun this now I see that
okay Hermione is the top student but
she's in zeroth place that's a little
weird like we don't need to show the
human using my program that we started
counting at zero I can clean this up I
can just add one to the I up here and
now we see sort of a top three list of
students Hermione is number one Harry's
number two and of course Ron is number
three so we can get access to all of
those same values as well or any
questions now on on these lists
any questions now on these lists
this length these ranges or otherwise my
question is
4i in range can you explain this once
more uh
so let me rewind in time we started off
doing this for I in 0 1 2 and then we
printed out meow three times in that way
the way that the for Loop works is that
it creates for you a variable that I've
called I but I could call it anything I
want it then assigns I initially to the
first thing in the list it then
automatically assigns I to the next
thing in the list and then it assigns I
to the third thing in the list and each
time it does all of the indented code
underneath
we realize though that this is not going
to scale well if I want to do something
like a million times so we introduced
range instead that has the effect of
doing the same thing it returns to me a
range of values a list of three things
really so the behavior is exactly the
same if we now fast forward to this
Hogwarts example now though what I'm
doing is just combining these smaller
ideas I'm still creating a for Loop I'm
still creating a variable called I I
want to do it over a range of values but
how many values well if I use the length
function and pass to the length function
the list of values lengths purpose in
life is to tell me how long is this list
and it's three so that's almost as
though before I had just done something
like this but I don't want to hard code
three I want to dynamically figure out
how many students are at Hogwarts so I'm
just composing composing composing or
nesting all of these various ideas
all right if I may let me transition now
to hog in Hogwarts still to introduce
one final type of data before we combine
everything with a few final programs it
turns out in Python there's not just
strings not just ins not just floating
Point values not just bulls not just
lists there are also what are called
dictionaries or dicks which are a data
structure that allows you to associate
one value with another literally a
dictionary like in the human world if
you were to open in a dictionary be it
in English or any other human language
what's inside of a dictionary well it's
a bunch of words and definitions a
computer scientist though and a
programmer would describe those more
generically as keys and values something
associated with something else that's
all a dictionary is it allows you to
associate something with something else
and notice this is already more powerful
more interesting than a list a list is
just a set of multiple values but a
dictionary is sort of two-dimensional if
you well just like a human dictionary a
book it Associates something with
something else like words with their
definitions now what does this actually
mean in practice well suppose that we
wanted to keep track of who is in what
house at Hogwarts well I could do it
using lists alone let me go back to vs
code here and let me just temporarily
but in a way that I'm not going to like
ultimately let me create another
variable called houses set it equal to
Gryffindor corresponding to Hermione's
house Gryffindor corresponding to
Harry's house and Gryffindor
corresponding to Ron's house and let's
add Draco in there so we now have four
instead of three students just so we
have a little variety and he was in uh
Slytherin so now we have two lists and
we could just agree amongst ourselves
that whoever is first in the students
variable lives in the first value in
houses whoever is second in students
lives in the second house there's our
third Institute students lives in the
third house we could do that but
honestly that is going to break down
quickly when we have a lot of students
when we have a lot of houses and what if
we want to keep track of more things
than that what if we want to keep track
of every student's house and the
Patronus this uh this image that they
conjure up magically well then we need a
third list like this is just going to
get messy quickly if we're just on the
honor System using multiple lists where
everything lines up logically it doesn't
end up well when your code gets more
complicated but I do want to implement
this idea I want to associate something
with something a student with a house a
student with a house a student with a
house and so forth so how can I go about
doing this well let me go back to my
code here and let me propose that we do
this using a python dictionary and this
is the last of the new syntax really
that we'll see here's the new syntax
instead of using square brackets we're
going to use curly braces for
dictionaries as well we've seen curly
braces in the context of f strings
completely unrelated sometimes you run
out of keys on the keyboard and the
authors of a language need to start
reusing symbols in different ways that's
what's about to happen we're using curly
braces in a different way now so let me
create a variable called students and
let me go ahead and set it equal to open
curly brace and close curly brace this
is an empty dictionary at the moment and
here's how a dictionary works it allows
you to associate something with
something else and you do that like this
Hermione quote unquote
colon and then the value thereof what do
you want to associate with Hermione well
Gryffindor what do I want to associate
Harry with well I want to associate him
with Gryffindor what do I want to
associate Ron with well I want to
associate him with Gryffindor well this
is actually not gonna this is gonna get
very ugly quickly once we add in Draco
and Slytherin my code is going to get
too long it's going to start wrapping so
this is purely aesthetic it is perfectly
acceptable in Python and other languages
to format your code a little more
readily and just add new lines if it
makes it more readable and one way of
doing this might be as follows I still
have my curly brace up here I still have
my curly brace down here but notice it's
a little more readable now in that I
have my keys on the left my somethings
and my values on the right my other
somethings it's just a little easier to
skim top to bottom you could format it
differently as well but I'm going to go
ahead and add in now uh Draco who lives
of course in in Slytherin so now I have
each of these keys on the left and
values on the right which is really
again just a code implementation of this
idea a little chart that you might write
up with paper pencil when associating
something with something else so how do
I now use this code in an interesting
way the syntax is almost the same if I
want to print out the very first student
Hermione's house I could do this print
out the name of the variable but I need
to go inside of the variable I need to
index into it and what's neat about
dictionaries is that whereas lists
have locations that are numeric zero one
two Hermione Harry Ron respectively
dictionaries allow you to use actual
words as your indices so to speak your
indexes to get inside of them so if you
want to print out Hermione's house the
key you care about is quote unquote
Hermione and what this syntax here will
do notice it's not a number zero or one
or two it's literally Hermione's name
this is like going to the Chart earlier
and saying all right give me uh Hermione
is my key Gryffindor is the value that's
what we're doing here syntactically
we're looking up Hermione and getting
the value thereof so if I go back to my
code that should print out Gryffindor
and if I do this a few times students
bracket quote unquote Harry should give
me Harry's house print students Open
Bracket Ron that should give me Ron's
house and then lastly if I do this with
students bracket Draco that should give
me draco's house now it's a little
manual still I bet we can improve this
but let me run python on hogwarts.pi and
we should see Gryffindor Gryffindor
Gryffindor Slytherin which is exactly
what we'd expect now all we've done
again is we've just now moved from
having just a simple list of names to
again sort of two Dimensions associating
like we would on paper pencil something
with something else keys with values
respectively allow me if you will even
though I realize this is getting a
little fancy allow me to escalate things
slightly here and transition from
looking at just for instance
uh that pattern there just hard coding
those values there to actually printing
these out more dynamically let me go
ahead and use our Loop and this question
came up earlier as well let me go ahead
and say for each student
in students go ahead and print out for
instance the students variable at well
let's just say student first let's keep
it simple so this is not going to be
that interesting yet but when I run
python of hogwarts.pi and hit enter
notice
what should I say let me take a question
here to see what am I going to see when
I hit enter now when I'm doing for
student in students yeah I think we we
will only see Keys perfect so good
intuition it could have gone both ways
could have been values the houses but
when you use a for Loop in Python to
iterate over a dictionary by design it
iterates over all of the keys so we
should see I think Hermione Harry Ron
and Draco let me hit enter now enter and
indeed you're exactly right we see just
the keys but that's not really that
useful if what I really care about is
who lives where can I print out both
well I think I can let me go ahead and
do this let me print out not just the
student's name the key but let me use
the key their name to index into the
dictionary right if I know the word in
the dictionary let me look up its
definition if I know the student's name
let me look up their house and the
Syntax for this just like a list is
students bracket and just like in the
past we used I when I was a number we
can also with a dictionary use a string
so if the student's name is the key then
this syntax students Open Bracket
student close bracket will go to
Hermione's location and get back her
house we'll go to Harry's location and
get back his house and so forth so if I
do python up hogwarts.pi enter now I see
Hermione Gryffindor Harry Griffin or Ron
Gryffindor Draco Slytherin now it looks
like I've given them all new last names
but I can clean that up this is just a
print thing let's go ahead and change
our separator from the default space to
maybe a space comma and just using print
features now let me run the same program
again enter now I've just got some nice
pretty commas in there to make clear
that Hermione's last name is not in fact
Gryffindor but that's just a print
detail any questions then on these
dictionaries and what I've just done
questions on these dictionaries and this
looping
over them here
um I just can't get my head around the
uh four student in students does uh if
I'm just correct me if I'm right does
that mean it Imports the list of
students and uses the indexes or in
other words Hermione Harry and Ron as
the indexes in the actual um the list of
students correct so this is just a
feature of python when you use a for
loop with a dictionary what happens is
this if this is the dictionary here with
the keys on top and the values on bottom
you get to choose what the variable is
called I called my variable student just
because it makes sense because I want
one student at a time and what the for
Loop does just like it did with numbers
before the zero the one and the two it
allows me to for instance set student
equal initially to Hermione's name and
then the next iteration of the loop the
next cycle sets student equal to Harry's
name then Ron then Draco it just kind of
happens automatically like that is what
the python interpreter does for you when
it sees a for Loop like that so it's
very similar in spirit to iterating with
a for Loop over a list but rather than
indurate over the numeric location 0 1 2
it iterates over the bold-faced keys in
this representation here graphically
and allow me to give us one other
example on Hogwarts before we look at
one other familiar uh domain at the risk
of things escalating a little bit let me
propose that we continue the story with
one final Hogwarts example like this
what if we have more information about
each of our students and this is kind of
inevitable right if you're implementing
a program that's a database with people
or customers or employees or anything
else you can imagine having a lot of
data about anything you're representing
in your program here for the sake of
discussion suppose that every student at
Hogwarts of course has a name they have
already a house but they also have a
Patronus for those unfamiliar this is
the animal or entity that comes out of
the end of their wand when they make a
Certain Magical spell the point here
being is that we want to associate not
just one thing with the student but
multiple things as well their name their
house and their Patronus in this case
well what might code like this look like
well let me go back to hogwarts.pi and
let me start fresh for just a moment and
let me propose that I enhance this with
a bit more data and this data is going
to look as follows my students variable
now
I'm going to propose we think of it as a
list what if we have a list of
dictionaries as follows indeed I want to
literally implement this picture here so
notice that my previous picture just
represented a single dictionary but
suppose I wanted to compose a list of
dictionaries that is for students so a
list of four students and suppose that
each of those students is itself a
dictionary a collection of key value
pairs keys and values something and
something else well here's one other way
we can do this in code let me go back to
vs code here
and let me Define a variable called
students that is equal to a list and I'm
going to preemptively move my cursor
onto separate lines because I know this
is going to be long and I want to fit
all of the elements of this list inside
of it I'm now going to create a
dictionary one dictionary per student
and how do I create a dictionary I just
use those curly braces but it's up to me
to Define what those keys are and let me
propose that 1K this time won't be the
student's name explicitly it will
literally be the word name and they're
going to have the name Hermione this
same student is going to have another
key called house and the value is going
to be Gryffindor and this same student
is going to have a third key called
Patronus and the value of that is going
to be I had to look it up in otter
according to the book now I'm going to
create a second dictionary inside of
this list and again a dictionary it's
like literally like the human dictionary
of words it's a book that contains keys
and values words and definitions what
are the three words I'm storing in each
of my dictionaries name house and
Patronus what are the definitions of
those words for Hermione Hermione
Gryffindor and Otter respectively for
Harry the definitions are going to be
different in this new dictionary let me
give myself another pair of curly braces
and say this name quote unquote colon
Harry a house here is again going to be
Gryffindor and this one I I knew his
Patronus is going to be in this case a
stag
all right next a third dictionary the
name here will be Ron and I'm going to
go ahead and do that just like this next
I have the house and he too was
Gryffindor lastly how to look this one
up Ron's Patronus was a Jack Russell
Terrier lastly
is Draco in a third in a fourth
dictionary now so another pair of curly
braces the name of the student is of
course Draco the house of this student
is Slytherin and Draco interestingly
enough at least according to the
internet has no Patronus was never
revealed in the books or the movies so
it turns out this is actually a
wonderful teachable moment there is a
special key word in Python that is
literally none
n-o-n-e with the first letter
capitalized this represents officially
the absence of a value so I could a
little sloppily do something like quote
unquote but does that mean I didn't get
around to typing it or not it's a little
clear semantically to say literally none
a special keyword in Python to make
clear that I know uh Draco has no
Patronus it's not just an oversight on
my part
now that I have this what do I have in
the computer's memory I have a list how
do I know it's a list because I see a
square bracket at the beginning and
another square bracket at the end that's
just my visual clue okay I don't know
necessarily what else is going on here
but there's a list of something what is
in that list well here too the syntax is
our clue because this line 2 starts with
a curly brace and ends with a curly
brace I just know that is a dictionary a
collection of key value pairs now this
all fit on my screen perfectly so I
didn't bother moving all of the key
value pairs onto new lines it would have
made it really tall so I kept it all
together here this time but how many
keys does this first dictionary have put
another way in Hermione's physical
dictionary how many words are in that
dictionary three the words are name
house and Patronus what are the three
definitions or values of those words in
Hermione's dictionary Hermione
Gryffindor and Otter respectively and
the same story goes for Harry
then for Ron then for Draco I have by
Design chosen to give them dictionaries
that have all the same Keys all the same
names but they all have unique values
and that's my design That's My
Prerogative as a programmer so why is
this useful at the end of the day now I
have access to a whole collection of
interesting data about all of these
students and I can still do a loop I can
say for student and students
that's going to allow me to iterate over
this list of students and let me go
ahead and print out just one thing at a
time let me print out the current
Student's name so as complicated as the
dictionary is this should be pretty
comfortable for student and students is
just going to iterate over every student
in the list one two three four total the
next line is just going to print out the
value of the name key it's like opening
a physical dictionary looking up the
word name and giving us Hermione Harry
Ron and Draco respectively from each
dictionary so if I run this version of
Hogwarts and hit enter there I get all
three of their names but what if I want
more information than that I want both
their names and their houses well just
add to Prince arguments student Open
Bracket House close bracket all right
let's go ahead and run this python of
hogwarts.pi and hit enter so I now see
Hermione Gryffindor Harry Gryffindor and
so forth well we can aesthetically clean
this up a little bit by adding a
separator with print like a comma and a
space just so that when I run this again
I now see some commas separating these
values but recall that students have not
just a name not just a house but also
that Patronus so if we want to print out
that too we now have the syntax via
which to go into that same dictionary
for each student and output their
Patronus as well as their house and
their name so if I run this program one
final time now I see all of the data in
this here dictionary so this is a lot to
absorb all at once I'm sure it's the
last of our new data types on top of
lists we have these dictionaries but
again a dictionary at the end of the day
is just a collection of values similar
to these values here that allow you to
associate keys with values and the first
version of this program Associated
literally the students names with their
houses but then I realized in my next
version wait a minute what if every
student has not just a name and a house
but a Patronus let's actually
standardize the names of our keys to be
name house and Patronus and then the
values of those keys can actually be the
data like Hermione Gryffindor otter and
so forth questions now on these
dictionaries and iteration thereof
I just was wondering if the suppose the
dictionary is very huge and if I want to
look up for a specific student so how do
I know uh where to look that student
from like can we sort it out in
alphabetical order or numeric order or
anything like that in short answer yes
one of the features of python is that it
makes these dictionaries very highly
performant for you that is even if
they're very large as they will be in
future weeks when we manipulate more
data python will find the data you care
about quickly for you and in fact that
is a feature of the language that is a
feature of a dictionary to get you the
data quickly and there are functions
that you can use you can sort the data
you can sift through it you can do very
performant operations as we eventually
will
allow me then to propose as we wrap up
these Loops that we solve just a few
final problems that will perhaps evoke
fond memories of yesteryear at least for
me wherein one of my favorite games
growing up was this one here on the
original Nintendo and this is a
two-dimensional world where the
characters move up down and right not so
much to the left in jumping over
pyramids and obstructions like these and
allow me to propose that we use this
just for inspiration not to do something
that's quite as colorful or graphical as
this but just to focus on for instance
this barrier in the middle of the world
here that Mario or Luigi had to jump
over and so this here seems to be like
three bricks stepped on top of one
another and we won't do things quite
graphically but let's just Implement a
very simple python-based version of this
textually using maybe just hashes for
bricks because there's a pattern here
one on top of the other and I bet we can
solve this in any number of ways well
let me switch back over to vs code here
and let me propose that we create a
program called Mario o.pi using code in
the terminal window and then up here let
me start by implementing that same
picture as simply as I can printing out
just literally the hash and then the
hash and then a third final hash this is
going to be a very textual approximation
of it but I think if I run python
mario.pi I've got a very simple version
of that same column of bricks so to
speak but you can imagine that certainly
in a game where maybe these columns get
higher or lower it would be nice to
write code that's actually a little more
Dynamic than that and doesn't just use
print print which is literally copy and
paste it would seem so let me at least
adopt some of today's Lessons Learned
and instead do something like this for
underscore in range of three let's now
print out just one of these at a time
but the fact that I've now used a three
to range means if I want to change it to
something bigger or smaller I change it
in one place not in three or more places
and this code two of course if I got it
right is is just going to print out the
exact same thing so we're iterating here
but let's see if we can't now integrate
our discussion of writing functions of
our own to begin writing something a
little more Dynamic and solving more
complicated problems ultimately one of
the nice things about functions is that
they allow us to not just write code
that we can use and reuse they allow us
to create abstractions if you will an
abstraction is a simplification of a
potentially more complicated idea and
we've seen this a few times over the
course of the weeks for instance we had
a function called hello which granted
didn't do all that much you just printed
hello but it allowed me to think about
the function as exactly what it does not
generically printing something but
literally saying hello I've been able to
get a number using something similar by
defining my own function like get number
well let me go ahead and for instance
assume for the moment that I've had the
forethought to in my function main use a
function called print column that seems
as good a name as any to use a function
that prints a column of bricks well how
can I go about now implementing this
abstraction this simple idea print
column with actual code well we've seen
before with def we can do just that let
me Define a function called print column
let me accept as its input generically
speaking a parameter called height I
could call it n or H but I'll be a
little more explicit now with Heights
just so I remind myself what it's doing
and now I think I can just borrow some
of that same code from before for
underscore in range of height go ahead
and print out a single hash and then at
the end of this whole program let's just
call Main so I've kind of complicated
the code it doesn't do anything more
just yet but it's setting me up for
solving what I think are going to be
more sophisticated problems if I run
python of mario.pi we're back where we
began but I now have a function an
abstraction print column that's going to
allow me to think about printing some
chunk of the world of Mario at a time
and I can do this in different ways too
notice that if I really want I could do
something like this I could re-implement
now print column in different ways
especially if I'm using print column all
over my code or maybe still a colleague
of mine a friend someone else on the
Internet is using my print column
function what's also nice about
functions you've written is you can
change the underlying implementation
details of them but so long as you don't
change the name of the function or its
parameters or what it returns if
anything no one else knows the
difference you can change the internal
implementation as much as you want if
you want to improve it or make fixes
over time so for instance another way we
could Implement print column recall
would be something like this a bit
clever with one hash and then a new line
and then maybe we could do
multiplication of strings and then end
this line with quote unquote again it's
okay if you're not comfortable with this
syntax this was a more clever approach
we saw in the past but if I run python
of miro.pi here I'll still see a column
of three but what's important here is
that Main does not need to know that the
underlying implementation of print
column has changed well let's transition
to a different dimension if you will and
rather than print out just these
vertical bricks let's fast forward in
the game to this part of the world here
at some part Mario encounters these
bricks in the sky that if he jumps up
underneath they become coins and so he
he gains to his score but let's go ahead
and focus only on those coins and let me
propose that we print out oh just these
four question marks here and let me go
back to vs code here and let me propose
that within vs code here just like
before we try to abstract this away so
let me go ahead and get rid of this
version because we're now going
horizontal instead of vertical with our
output and let me just say well print
row four times let me just abstract away
the problem at hand I don't know yet how
I'm going to print those four question
marks but let's call it print row four
and I'll assume I'll now solve this
problem let's now go down that rabbit
hole of solving the problem Define a
function called print row it's going to
take a width instead of a height because
it's horizontal instead of vertical and
how can I do this well now we have an
opportunity to do string multiplication
even more elegantly I can say quote
unquote question mark times with and
this is a very pretty pythonic way of
printing what could otherwise be a loop
and that's fine but this is going to go
ahead and print those question marks for
me let's do python of mario.pi enter and
now I've got four question marks it's
not nearly as pretty as the more
graphical version but it is at least a
building block toward having now a
reusable function like print row
am I doing all this like why are we over
engineering the solution to these
problems by having print column and
print row well it's a useful problem
solving technique as soon as your world
does not look one-dimensional like this
or with the column version but what
about this later in Super Mario Brothers
does Mario have to jump down into this
world where there's a lot of these
underworld barriers and this one here
for instance looks like a square it's
two-dimensional there's a height and a
width to it and that is to say there's a
bunch of different ways we could
implement this thing if maybe for
discussion it's like a three by three
grid a three by three square of sorts
well how can we go about solving this
here problem well let me propose we come
back to vs code and let me propose that
we think about this in a couple of
different ways I could do this hmm like
this if I if I know where I'm going you
know maybe I'm a seasoned programmer let
me go ahead and do this let me print out
a square the width and the height of
which is three that's an abstraction I'm
just taking for granted for a moment
that there is already a function called
print Square that's going to be with 3
and height 3 as well
someone's got to implement this and at
the moment there's only me at the
keyboard so let's go ahead and Implement
that square let me go ahead and Define a
function called print square that takes
in a specific size both for height and
for width and here's where we have an
opportunity to use some of those loops
and we can use those Loops in a way we
haven't yet if I want to print out all
of these rows but also all of these
columns I now have to think not just
cyclically like a loop allows but I need
to think two-dimensionally and if you're
familiar with like an old school
typewriter or even a printer nowadays It
generally prints from top to bottom so
even if you have multiple columns you
print out one line at a time and while
you're on that line the printer or the
typewriter prints from left to right and
that's kind of the mental model to have
with your black and white terminal
window all of the output for every
example thus far starts at the top and
goes down to the bottom from top to
bottom left to right so we have to
generate our output our Square in that
same way so let me propose that we do
this let me propose that we know we need
to iterate this many times three or more
generally size so let me do this for I
in the range of size
what do I need to do three times Well I
want to print out what one two three
rows of bricks but within each row of
bricks what do I want to print one two
three bricks specifically so if we go
back to our diagram here and I stipulate
that it's indeed meant to be a three by
three Square
three wide and three tall what do I want
to do to print the first row I want to
print brick brick brick brick brick what
do I want to print on the second row
brick brick brick and the third row
brick brick brick so I'm doing three
things three times there's a lot of
printing that must happen so let me go
back to my code here and let me propose
now that we think of this outer loop
that I've just started as representing
each of our rows for I in range of size
is going to ensure no matter what I do
next that I can print out one two three
rows or more generally size where size
could be three but it could be smaller
or larger
what do I want to do on each of the rows
well just like an old school typewriter
or printer on each row I want to print
out brick brick brick brick brick brick
brick brick brick well that sounds like
a cycle some kind of loop so maybe I can
have inside of one Loop another loop I
don't want to use I again because I
don't want to use the same variable and
mess up my counting so I'm going to by
convention use J very common to use I
and then J maybe K but after that you
shouldn't keep nesting inside of each
other let me go ahead and say for J in
range of size 2 because it's a square
and then each of these rows let me print
out a single hash but no new line
but after each row let me print only a
new line
so there's a lot going on here
especially if you've never touched
python let alone Loops but notice what
I've done here too and I'll add some
comments for clarity for each row in
square
for each
brick in row
print brick and here is where comments
and more generally pseudocode can really
help explain to yourself and to others
what your lines of code are doing on
line eight I'm iterating from I equals
zero on up to size so zero one two on
line 11 I'm doing the exact same thing
but using J from 0 1 2 but that's good
because I represents now each of my rows
and while I'm on each of those rows
inside of this outer loop I'm going to
do brick brick brick one two three one
two three one two three but I don't want
my cursor to keep moving to the next
line while I'm on a row so I'm just
overriding that line ending but let me
ask a question of the group now why on
line 16 do I have a print here all by
itself
why do I have a print all by itself
notice that it's below the inner loop
but inside of the outer loop so to speak
what is that loop on line 16 doing
ultimately
every time you finish a line you have to
add a new line and at the end of it so
print it prints a new line perfect I
don't want a new line after every brick
I only want to do that at the end of the
row and that's why my comments now are
perhaps enlightening notice that this
Loop here is just iterating for each
brick in the row once I'm done with that
inner loop so to speak once I'm done
with these highlighted lines here to
Evelyn's point I need to print out one
blank new line and we've not done this
before but when you call print with no
arguments all you get is that automatic
line ending the backslash n where the
cursor moves to the next line so if I
now roll go back to my terminal window
and run mario.pi I think I should get a
three by three square and it doesn't
quite look like a square on my screen
because these hashes are a little taller
than they are wide but it is in fact
three by three but let me propose as
we've always done here how we might
tighten up this code further just for
clarity's sake let me get rid of my
comments for a moment just so we can see
how many lines of code we have total and
let me propose that we maybe do this let
me propose that you know what this inner
loop especially if you're having trouble
wrapping your mind around one Loop
inside of another loop you don't
strictly need it what if we do this
trick again what if we print out inside
of the outer and only Loop each of those
hashes times the number of times we want
them right we draw inspiration from an
earlier approach and we run python now
of mario.pi same result but now print
square is really nice and compact it has
one explicit Loop and it's still
printing out using string multiplication
all of the hashes at once on that row if
you like abstraction and you'd like to
wrap your mind more around what the code
is doing well let's do this if you're
not quite clear on what's going on let's
propose that you implement a function
called print row oh passing in size and
let me propose that this print row
function it simply taken that width and
print out the individual hash times that
many times in other words here's an
opportunity for abstraction whereby well
what does it mean to print a row well
when you're implementing print Square I
don't really care what it means to print
a row I just need to know that someone's
taking care of printing the row you can
kind of pass the buck to another
function altogether and how does print
row work well it could use a for Loop it
could use this string multiplication
trick this is a way to take a larger
program and this is probably the most
complicated one we've looked at thus far
and to decompose it into these smaller
components that once assembled achieve
your final idea
seeing no questions that's the end of
our look at Loops in Python this ability
to do things cyclically again and again
and when we combine those with
conditionals this ability to ask and
answer questions and combine them with
our functions and variables we really
now have most of the building blocks we
need to solve much larger much more
interesting much more personal questions
so in the weeks to come we'll start to
see exactly what could go wrong though
when we do so but we'll introduce you to
all the more tools by which you can
troubleshoot those same problems
[Music]
thank you
all right this is cs50's Introduction to
programming with python my name is David
Malin and this is our week on exceptions
exceptions in python as well as in other
programming languages refer to problems
in your code indeed when something is
exceptional in your program it actually
doesn't mean it's a good thing it means
something has gone wrong that ideally
you will somehow solve so what are some
of the things that can go wrong so I'm
going to go ahead and open up vs code on
my computer here and in the terminal
window I'm going to go ahead and run
code of hello.pi that's going to of
course open up a brand new tab for me
hello.pi in which I can write my code
and let me go ahead and write some very
simple code just to say hello to the
world let's go ahead and say print quote
hello comma world and then let me go
ahead and I'm forgetting to close that
quote so a mistake that you yourself
might have already made or might surely
in the future make and it's a little
subtle because you might not necessarily
notice that you've just missed that one
character well let me go ahead and
somewhat optimistically go down to my my
terminal window now and run python of
hello.pi and hit enter and that's the
first of my errors my gosh I've only
written one line of code and I seem to
have more lines of errors on the screen
but the Salient point is this bottom
most thing here notice where it says
syntax error syntax error is a problem
with the code that you have typed your
syntax just like English and other human
languages have syntax associated with
them so does my code and it's not quite
correct something is awry I didn't
follow the instructions properly and it
does elaborate for me unterminated
string literal now that's a bit Arcane
that is a bit of a confusing error
message but unterminated would generally
mean that I started something but didn't
stop it I didn't terminate it string of
course is a sequence of text like we
discussed before or stir in Python and
literal generally refers to something
that you literally typed it's not a
variable it's something like quote
unquote or just quote hello world so the
fix here of course is going to be to go
ahead and terminate that string and
actually close close the quote and if I
now go back down into my terminal window
and rerun python of hello.pi now I'm
saying hello to the world so the catch
with syntax errors here is that syntax
errors are entirely on you to solve a
syntax error is a problem that you've
got to go back into your code and fix
from the get-go you can't just kind of
hope that it's going to resolve itself
or expect that other parts of your code
will catch it for you syntax errors just
must be fixed but there's a lot of other
types of errors in Python that might be
described as runtime errors that happen
while your code is running and it's
really up to you to write some
additional code defensively to detect
when those errors happen because you
don't necessarily know for instance what
input humans are going to type into your
program and so you better be ready
defensively to accommodate things that
they type or even mistype so for
instance let's go back over here to vs
code and let me propose that we take a
look at a new file altogether I'm going
to close hello.pi and I'm going to write
code of say number dot Pi so let's play
around with some numbers in Python and
the first thing I'm going to go ahead
here and do with number.pi after opening
this new tab is I think I'm going to go
ahead and print type up a relatively
simple program that maybe prompts the
user for an integer like X and then just
prints out what x is so we're going to
start super simple but again in starting
simple we'll be able to really see where
I've done something wrong well here we
go I'm going to go ahead and say a
variable called X is going to get
assigned the value of the return value
of input quote unquote what's X question
mark and I'm going to include a space to
move the cursor over a little bit and
then ultimately I'm going to go ahead
and oh wait a minute if I'm wanting to
get an INT from the user recall that I
need to do something proactively I need
to actually convert that input to an
integer using the int function in Python
so now I'm passing the return value of
input as the argument to int and that
will store in X ultimately an integer
not a string that looks like an integer
all right let me go ahead now and just
quite simply print out what this is I'm
going to go ahead and print out uh quote
unquote X is X but I don't want to
literally say x is X I want to plug in
the value of x so maybe the easiest way
to do that is to surround it with curly
braces and then if I'm using these curly
braces and I want python to interpolate
the value of that variable that is
substitute what x actually is in between
those curly braces recall that I need to
use a format string or an F string by
prefixing this whole thing with an F now
that I've done that let's go ahead and
see what happens I'm going to go ahead
in my terminal window and run python of
number dot Pi I hit enter and so far so
good all is well I'm being prompted for
X let me go ahead and type in a number
like 50. all right that seems to work
program seems to be correct
or is it
what could go wrong in this program even
though nothing did just go wrong but if
I run it and run it and run it again
during the running of my program what
could still go wrong especially if I'm
not the human interacting with it but
some other Human Instead and he
volunteers here for this one
what could go wrong and in what way is
this program not really correct
even though at first glance it seems so
but uh what is an interface
we got in a in a integrated IDE
we can't code in an interpreter so I'm
not calling an integer I'm still having
trouble hearing you but what I think I
heard is that if the what the user types
in is not in fact an integer I can't
just blindly convert it to an INT if I'm
not putting too many words into your
mouth I think what I should perhaps do
here is be a little defensive and let me
see if I can't simulate exactly the
problem that could go wrong here let me
go ahead and run again python of number
dot Pi let me try another number and in
fact when testing your code generally
it's a good idea to test Corner cases
maybe numbers that aren't quite as plain
as 50 or 49 or 51 let's choose some
numbers that might be a little more
interesting if only mathematically like
zero all right zero seems to work my
code still prints out that X is zero
what might be another Corner case to
consider well let me go ahead and try a
negative number that 2 is pretty
different in spirit from 50 negative one
okay that works too well let me try it
one more time I've tried positive
numbers negative numbers zero let me try
something like a cat so literally cat
typing in a string that doesn't even
look like a number and yet let's see now
what happens when I hit enter
all right we'll see now we've got
another kind of error it's not a syntax
error because I didn't make a
typographical mistake I didn't forget
some piece of syntax I actually now have
a error with one of my values and it's
in a value I didn't even anticipate the
human me in this case typed it in long
after I wrote the code so what does this
refer to a value error well let's see
what the explanation is invalid literal
for INT with base 10 quote unquote cat
now this two is a bit of a mouthful and
unfortunately in Python in a lot of
programming languages the error messages
are written for pretty comfortable
programmers and of course when you're
learning programming for the first time
you might not be so comfortable with the
programming language let alone the error
messages but let's see if we can't glean
some insight so invalid literal well
again a literal is just something that's
been typed in it would seem for INT what
is int exactly well int is the function
I'm using to convert the user's input to
a corresponding integer base 10 that
refers to the decimal system which is
this the default that that Python's
using and it looks like at the end of
the day what python really doesn't like
is that I passed Cat quote unquote to
the int function so how do I go about
actually fixing this problem well I
could just add instructions in my
program maybe I could add a line of
print telling the user more explicitly
be sure to type in integer or please
don't type cat please don't type strings
of course the user might still not
oblige they might not be reading the
instructions so that too is probably not
an effective strategy what we really
want to do is write our code with error
handling in mind we want to write lines
of code that not only accomplish the
problems we care about but that also
handle errors that might unexpectedly
happen and in general when programming
programming defensively assume that the
users aren't going to be paying
attention or Worse they're malicious
they're trying to crash your program so
we want to handle as many errors as we
can now how do we go about doing that in
Python well it turns out whether you
want to catch a value error or other
types of errors as well though not
syntax error python actually has this
keyword called try and it's sort of
aptly named if you want to try to do
something in Python you can literally
use this keyword and you can check
whether or not something exceptional
something erroneous has happened so
using both try and this other keyword
except can I go and try to do something
except if something goes wrong I can do
something else instead so let's consider
how can I go about trying to convert the
user's input to an INT except if
something goes wrong well let me go back
to my code here and let me propose that
I now modify this example as follows let
me go ahead and above my first line of
code I literally write try and a colon
telling python try to do the following
I'm going to go ahead and indent my
existing lines of codes here by the same
number of spaces four in this case and
then I'm going to add one more new line
down here that's literally says accept
value error and notice it's important
that I've capitalized the V and I've
capitalized the E these symbols are case
sensitive and this is now an opportunity
after this colon to tell python what I
want to do in exceptional cases when the
number or the input from the user is not
in fact a number and I'm going to say
something plain like print quote unquote
X is not an integer I'm at least going
to tell the user roughly what the
problem actually is so notice another
detail the indentation is important
because I have try on line one and I've
been dented lines two and three those
are the two lines of code that I'm
trying except if I see a value error
line five because it's indented is what
is going to get executed in cases of
those errors let me go ahead now back to
my terminal window and run python of
hello of python of number dot Pi enter
and let's go ahead and type in 50 again
still seems to work and of course I'm
trying and succeeding let me go ahead
and try once more this time though with
the word cat or really anything that's
not a decimal number and now you'll see
much more cleanly at X is not an integer
I'm not seeing some scary error message
that I have a user and I'm going to have
no idea how to handle now you the
programmer have anticipated that
something exceptional can happen and
you've gone about actually handling the
error for the user giving them an
appropriate error message instead let me
pause here and see are there any
questions now on what we've just done by
introducing try and accept to handle
this value error
is value ever the only type of ever you
can get or the other types is value
error the only thing you can catch there
are other errors as well and we'll see a
few of them today and there's many many
more honestly that if you continue
programming and programming in Python
you're going to see a lot of them over
the the weeks the months the years to
come but the technique for handling them
is going to be largely the same other
questions on try accept or these
exceptions more generally uh yes sir
actually do use the accept block you
need to know the type of error right
like here you knew it was a value Adder
40 what if you can't anticipate this
particular type of theater a really good
question so I'm being very good about
catching so to speak the very error that
I know might happen I don't know when it
might happen because it's going to
depend on the user but I know what kind
of error will happen from the int
function there is a way in Python where
you can say except if anything goes
wrong and you can literally omit value
error and just catch everything the
problem with that is that it's sometimes
times hides other bugs in your code
because you don't necessarily know
what's going wrong and if you don't
necessarily know what's going wrong how
can you possibly handle it correctly so
bad practice and it put another way it's
lazy to do that to just say catch
everything and I'll deal with it here so
a much better practice would be to
figure out what kind of Errors could
happen and include mention of them
explicitly as I've done now with that
said if you read Python's official
documentation is you'll eventually
invariably do it is not great about
telling you proactively what kinds of
Errors can be raised in this way so it's
a bit of contradictory advice you should
do it this way but it's not always
obvious what you should be checking for
but you get better at it with practice
and some of the times the documentation
does spell out what could go wrong let
me turn our attention now back to this
and point out that even though this is
better code it is more correct in the
sense that I'm not just leaving it to
the user to see some really ugly default
python error message that most people
are going to have no idea what to do
with I'm at least handling it more
elegantly and I'm printing out X is not
an integer so it's at least more
instructive but this isn't necessarily
the best way to implement this code y
well here too I'm actually still being a
little lazy so notice that I'm trying to
do not one line of code but two lines of
code and this isn't a huge deal because
we're only talking about two lines of
code but in the interest of preaching
best practices you should really only be
trying to do the one or very few lines
of code that can actually raise an
exception that can actually fail in some
way I am pretty sure that calling print
here is not going to raise a value error
whether X is an INT or a string or a
float or anything else the format string
feature of python is going to handle
printing it just fine so really what I'm
going to do is this I'm going to move
this line three down to the bottom of my
code I no longer need to indent it I'm
just going to execute it at the bottom
of my file L here
unfortunately by doing this I've done a
good thing by now only trying to do the
minimal amount of work necessary that
might raise the exception of value error
but I fear I've introduced a new mistake
well let's see what is now incorrect let
me go ahead and again run python of
number.pi enter let me go ahead and do
it correctly with 50 and all seems to be
well but again let's try those Corner
cases the zeros the negative numbers or
in this case the cat let me go ahead and
type in cat again enter now I have a
name error so now it's yet another type
of error in my code that I've introduced
here and what is this name error mean
well just as a value error refers to
that the value of some variable the
value that someone has typed in is
incorrect name error tends to refer to
your code like you're doing something
with the name of a variable that you
shouldn't and why might that be well let
me turn our attention back to the code
here and consider what is it complaining
about well the name error is what I see
down here and it's telling me name quote
unquote X is not defined and notice if I
look further here it is mentioning line
six so I know the problem is with my
code on line six and that worked a
moment ago and I'm defining X on line
two but let me ask the group here why
does X not in fact exist on line six why
is it not defined even though I'm pretty
sure I was intending to Define it on
line two
maybe the scope of the variable is
between the try block so good
terminology scope refers to the portion
of code in which a variable exists that
too though isn't quite right in Python
that would be true in CC plus plus and
Java where indentation or curly braces
tend to define the scope of a variable
but again here in general and this
worked a moment ago X exists once it's
defined on line two because remember I
printed out X is 50 a little bit ago
let's try one more
hypothesis here one more hand Y is X
somehow still not defined
um yeah so is it because it's local
variable meaning that like it doesn't
Define outside of scope is like what
people have mentioned it's it's asked it
prompts the input in try right but
outside of it is undefined so still good
instincts and good terminology too
there's this notion of local variables
which tend to exist inside of functions
for instance Global variables which can
tend to exist in entire files in this
case too though that's not quite the
case What's Happening Here boils down to
order of operations let me come back to
the code here and recall that anytime
we've discussed the assignment operator
the single equal sign that copies a
value from the right to the left but
consider for a moment at what point
something is going wrong well the input
function is probably working just fine
because we've used that a lot now to get
users input it always returns a string
or a stir in Python but what could be
going wrong well if I'm passing that
string to the int function as its
argument it's probably the int function
that's airing and indeed if you think
back earlier when we had the value error
it was in fact the int function that did
not lie quote unquote cat as input so
this is all to say that this portion of
my code highlighted now to the right of
the equal sign that's the code that's
creating a problem that's the code that
was creating a value error and in this
case we're catching the value error but
because the value error is happening on
the right of the equal sign there's no
value being copied to the left the error
is interrupting that whole process so
even though we see x equals dot dot on
line two the portion of that line to the
left of the equal sign isn't getting
evaluated ultimately because the value
error is happening too soon and so when
we finally get down to line six even
though it looked like I was defining on
line two and I would have defined X
online 2 if all had gone well we didn't
get to the part where the value is
copied from right to left because the
value error happened first so this code
is just incorrect now so how do I go
about solving something like this well
it turns out that there's another
feature of the try and accept syntax
that python supports which is that it
also supports the keyword else now we've
seen else before if you think back to
our discussion of conditionals we saw if
we saw L if we saw else which was kind
of this catch-all what you should do in
the event that nothing else is relevant
that's kind of the same intuition here
for the try accept feature of python
what you can do is this you can try to
do the following as I've done except if
this goes wrong but if nothing goes
wrong else go ahead and do this so this
is one way I can solve this same problem
now no matter what now python is going
to try to execute line two if something
goes wrong it's going to execute slides
three and four to handle that value
error however if you try and this code
succeeds then there is no exception to
handle so you're then going to execute
this line here so it's a little
confusing perhaps in that we're now
using else both for conditionals if L if
L if L if else and we're also using else
with these try accept blocks but that's
okay that's part of the language that's
one of the features so now if I rerun
this code in my terminal window python
of number dot Pi let's do something
correct like 50 I see that X is 50. so
line one is executed we're trying to do
the following line two is executed
because the conversion happened and
successfully and the number 50 gets
copied from right to left the exception
does not happen so we ignore lines three
and four we jump immediately to line
five and six which prints out the result
by contrast though let's do this one
last time python of number dot Pi let's
type in cat or again any other word and
hit enter now we don't see what x is
rather we see quote unquote X is not an
integer which is what's being handled in
my accept Clause all right let me pause
here because that's a lot of new syntax
and see here if there's any questions on
try on accept on else name error or
value error can you please repeat try
function repeat the name error what's
the problem with the name error yes yes
yeah so let's let's just rewind a couple
of lines here before I fix this problem
by now getting rid of the else a moment
ago we had code that looks like this
whereby I was getting a name error
python of number dot Pi enter typing in
cat at that looked like this where name
X is not defined and the problem was on
line six according to this output in
Python well let's think about this now
deductively let's try a different
approach on line six I'm seeing an error
that name X is not defined okay Python's
already telling me X does not exist at
that point so how could that possibly be
well where should X be defined well
presumably X is defined on line two up
here so what could go wrong well if the
user has inputted something that doesn't
look like a number like the word cat
passing cat the return value of input as
the argument to int to convert the word
to an INT makes no sense you can't
convert a cat c-a-t to an integer at all
so the int function is raising a value
error at that point and the error is
being handled with this code here but
notice this line 6 is not indented it's
left aligned with the rest of my code
which means no matter what line six is
going to execute it's going to execute
whether I typed in 50 or I typed in cat
but if I typed in cat again X never gets
a value so it's not defined here on line
six so when I introduce finally the else
statement that makes sure that these
things are mutually exclusive I only
execute the else if I tried and
succeeded up above
well let me propose that we refine this
just a little bit further as well and
consider how we might improve this
example a little bit more it's a little
it's a little unfriendly of me to be
rejecting the user's input after they
fail to provide an integer and just
quitting the program really right it'd
be more user friendly if I just prompt
or reprompt the user again and again and
in the chat if you could what's the
feature of python that you can use if
you want to do something again and again
and again until such time as the user
cooperates and gives you what you're
looking for like a number so yeah loop
loop loop so a loop is something that
happens again and again and again and
maybe we can use that same mechanism a
loop in order to prompt the user for x
and if they don't give us a number
prompt them again and if they don't
prompt them again and again and again we
don't need to just quit out of the
program so quickly so let me propose
this let me propose here that I improve
this code by deliberately doing this let
me induce a infinite loop at the very
top of my code with while true recall
that the while keyword induces a loop a
cycle that behaves like this and it asks
a question a Boolean expression that
needs to evaluate either to true or
false well if I want this thing to Loop
Forever at least initially we'll just
say while true because true is true so
this has the effect of doing something
no matter what forever unless we break
out of it early now I'm going to go
ahead and do this I'm going to go ahead
and move my try accept code indented
underneath this Loop so that I'm trying
to get an X if I have a value error
instead I print that X is not an integer
but this time what do I want to do if
the user does try and succeed in giving
me a number well I can do this I can
just break out of my code here and down
here now I can use that same line of
code from before an F string that says X
is and then in curly braces X again
so what's going on here I think this
code now because I've added the loop is
going to have the effect of trying at
least once maybe a second time maybe a
third time maybe 500 times until the
user finally gives me what I want which
is an integer and once they do once
there's no value error happening then I
break out of the loop and line 9
executes as I would hope so let me go
ahead and try executing this version
python of number dot Pi enter what's X
let me go ahead and type in the easy
thing first 50. X is 50. what just
happened in terms of the control flow of
this program the flow of my logic well I
first found myself on line one inside of
a loop hopefully I'll get out of this
Loop what did I then do on lines two and
three I tried to get input from the user
and convert it to an INT well I was a
nice guy this time and I typed in 50
which looks like and is a number so the
int function converted it just fine and
stored it from right to left in X except
value error there is no value error
because if I typed in a number there's
nothing exceptional happening this is a
boring good execution of my program so
what happens I break out of the loop so
again the else Clause is associated with
the try not with the accept and once I'm
out of the loop of course I'm just
printing out what x is well let's try
the other scenario that might happen
python of number.pi enter what's X let's
try cat or any other word enter
ah this is now a new feature I'm being
informed what I did wrong X is not an
integer so I'm getting some useful user
feedback but notice again I'm prompted
what's X well let me try typing in dog X
is not an integer what's X let me try
bird enter X is not an integer what's X
and suffice it to say this will happen
now forever if I'm in an infinite Loop
until I try and succeed at which point I
break out so let's try again 50 enter
now I'm out of the loop and I'm printing
out what x actually is
all right let me pause here and see if
there are any questions the logic is
almost the same but what is different
now is I'm in a loop and I'm using the
keyword break in Python to deliberately
break out of the loop when I'm ready to
once the user has cooperated we really
need to break can't we just print
or what keeps us from just printing a
good question so let me try that
well let's see what happens if I do that
let me move this print line at the end
into my Loop here thereby shortening the
program and in general that's been a
good thing python of number dot Pi enter
let me go ahead and type in 50. okay X
is 50. what's x uh okay maybe it's 49 x
is 49. uh okay maybe 48. unfortunately I
think you're you're laughing you see it
I never break out of the loop which
maybe that's a feature maybe you want
this to be your program but I didn't I'd
eventually like this game to stop so I
need to break out in that way but I can
do it a little differently and let me
propose that we modify this a little bit
but first any other questions on this
syntax here let me rewind to
the prior version
hi uh can I use break our except
else for example in another uh print
print in the else you can use prints
together with break or something like
this you so you can use break inside of
Loops to break out of loops and you can
use it inside of a conditional like an
if an L if or an else you can do it
inside of a try except else statement
two anytime you're in a loop that you
want to break out of you can use this
keyword break I'm using it in the
context of exceptions but it's not
restricted to that and let me show you
too it doesn't even have to be in the
else if I wanted to I could actually do
this I could get rid of my else
and I could go back to line three add
another line that's indented line four
and break out here now why is this
logically okay well consider what I'm
now trying to do I'm trying to execute
line three and converting the user's
input to an INT and I'm trying to store
the result from right to left in X if
something goes wrong the code we've
already seen is immediately gonna jump
to line five and then six to handle the
exception but if nothing goes wrong my
code presumably should just keep on
executing line by line so I could
technically logically put the break here
and watch what happens when I run this
version python of number dot Pi 50 enter
it worked I broke out of the loop now
which way is better honestly I think it
could go either way at this point this
program's so relatively short that even
though I'm trying to do two things now
one of which the break is not going to
fail like you either break or you don't
there's no p piece of data from the user
that's going to influence that we don't
strictly need to have those two lines of
code there but it's only two lines so I
think it's okay and if you recall our
discussion in the past not just of
correctness does the code work as it
should but design I think you could
argue it either way if you prefer the
readability of this and the fact that
you don't have an else that's fine if
though you prefer to minimize just how
many lines of code you're trying to
execute in case something goes wrong the
else is a reasonable approach too well
allow me to propose too now that we
refine this further I think we're at the
point where it's pretty darn correct but
suppose now that I find myself today and
tomorrow trying to get numbers from the
user quite a bit it would be nice as
we've seen to maybe just invent my own
function get int to get an integer from
the user both today and tomorrow and
Beyond and heck maybe I can even share
that function with other people if they
want to write programs they get integers
from users so how might I go about doing
this well let me go ahead and propose
that we do this let me get rid of the
print line but keep most of my Loop here
let me Define a function called get int
that takes no arguments for now and I'm
going to go ahead and indent all of the
code I already wrote underneath get int
so now I have a function called get int
that tries to do the following try to
get an in from the user if something
goes wrong and there's a value error
yell at them with X is not an integer
else break but it's not just breaking
that I want to do here now that I'm in a
function recall our discussion of return
values if you're inventing your own
function whose purpose in life isn't
just to print something on the screen
like a side effect but is to hand back a
value to hand you back a value like on
that same Post-It note from our
discussion of functions well you need to
return X explicitly how do I now use
this function well as soon as we start
making our own functions it tends to be
convenient to Define our own main
function as well that's the main part of
our program and I'm going to keep this
simple I'm now going to say x equals get
int and then on the next line I'm going
to do that print from before quote
unquote X is in curly braces X and at
the very bottom of my program recall I'm
going to call Main so that no matter
what I'm invoking my main function after
everything's been defined well let's see
how this works let me go ahead and run
python
of number.pi enter let's type in 50 and
it seems to work as before let's go
ahead and run it again typing in cat c a
t this time X is not an integer and I'm
being prompted dog and I'm being
prompted bird and I'm being prompted
fine fine 50 that's an INT and so it is
printed so what's worth noting here well
I'm manifesting a couple of good
properties here one I've kind of
abstracted away this notion of getting
an integer and even though I just
artificially hit enter a whole bunch of
times just to hide that function for now
it needs to be there but we don't need
to see it at this point notice that now
this entire program really boils down to
just these three lines of code now why
because I've abstracted away that whole
process of getting an INT from the user
into this new function of my own called
get int but can I improve upon this well
let me go ahead and undo all of those
blank lines and pull this up just so we
can see more on the screen at once can I
tighten up my implementation of get int
it is correct I claim this is correct
it's handling errors and it's returning
X but I don't strictly speaking need to
write the code as long what else could I
do well let me propose that if all
you're doing on this line 13 is breaking
and then immediately after that per the
indentation you're executing return X on
line 14. why are you wasting everyone's
time once you know you're ready to
return the value you could just return X
and so in my else I could break out and
return a value so here too return is
used to return values from functions
break is used to break out of Loops but
it turns out that return is sort of
stronger than break it will not only
break you out of a loop it will also
return a value for you so it's doing two
things for once if you will
but can I make this even more compact if
if my goal is to just tighten the code
up even though it's already correct can
anyone think of a further refinement
whether you've programmed in Python
before or not can I shorten this
implementation further just a little bit
if only to decrease the probability that
I've made a mistake by having fewer
lines and just make it a little easier
to read because it's shorter
any suggestions for tightening up my
implementation of get int you can just
return the value on the drive function
uh when you're trying uh you take the
input X and then return X good we can
just return x a little higher up and let
me correct folks as we go it's not a try
function it would be a try statement
technically a function typically has a
parenthesis and another one in this case
it's just a statement so but we can do
exactly that I don't technically need
the else if I really want I could do
this right after line nine I could
return X here or recall our discussion
of defining variables unnecessarily
sometimes like why Define a variable
here if you're immediately going to use
it here and then never again so we could
avoid a new line here and I could avoid
even defining X explicitly I could just
say something like this I could return
int input quote unquote what's X I can
do it all at once now which is better I
don't know I mean again this is where
reasonable people might disagree I'd
argue that on the one hand we're
tightening up the code we're using fewer
lines it's easier to read lower
probability that I've made a mistake on
the other hand it's a little more
complicated to understand perhaps it's a
little less obvious where I'm returning
from so I think arguments can be made
either way at the end of the day what's
important is that you've done this
consciously you've made a decision to do
it this way or this way and you can
justify it in your mind not that your
answer is it worked so I left it alone
like have a good reason come up with a
good reason and that will come with
experience and practice well let me
propose to you that we make one other
refinement here suppose that you're
finding your programs to be a little
noisy and it's a little obnoxious that
you keep telling the user X is not an
integer X is not an integer X is not an
integer what if you want to make things
a little gentler and just prompt the
user again with the same words what's x
what is X what's X again and again well
you can do that as well and it turns out
that if you want to handle an exception
in Python but you want to pass on doing
anything with it so you want to catch it
but you essentially want to ignore it
you don't want to print anything you
don't want to quit the program you just
want to silently ignore it like if
you're talking in a room full of people
and you're it's your turn to talk and
you're just like pass they're still
calling on you but you're not doing or
saying anything more well we can add
this keyword to our code here let me go
back to my program here and instead of
printing out again and again X is not an
integer I could just do this I could
pass on handling the error further I'm
still catching it so the user is not
going to see a scary message even
mentioning value error my code is
catching it but I'm passing on saying
anything about it I'm going to stay in
the loop I'm going to stay in the loop
and keep prompting and reprompting the
user so now the effect looks a little
something like this python of number dot
Pi let's type in cat
what's X again let's type in dog what's
X again type in bird so it's just a
little maybe more user friendly and that
you're just reminding the user what you
want maybe it's worse maybe it would be
helpful to tell the user why you're
prompting them again and again it's not
obvious so it could go both ways but
again it's just another mechanism now
for handling these errors we use the
accept keyword to catch a specific error
but we don't have to handle it more than
that we can just pass on doing something
further let me pause here and see if
there's any questions now on try except
else or pass
okay yeah no I was just kind of curious
I guess about uh the idea of when you
were indenting with uh the get in
function for example
um because I'm noticing you know
obviously going through it with the
whole logic and breakdown of the entire
uh the entire function you know while
true do this but I'm just kind of
curious on the library with the
indentations for the uh code more yeah
so the indentation is deliberate
logically some languages don't require
as rigorous indentation you can use
curly braces or other symbology to make
clear what is associated with what in
general anytime you indent something in
Python on this line so rather anytime
you write a code a line of code in
Python that's here and the lines below
it are somehow indented that means that
those lines are somehow associated with
that first line and presumably those
indented lines should only be executed
if the first line told the uh told the
computer to do so so concretely what
does this mean on line six here we're
defining a function called get in that
takes no arguments colon everything
that's indented by at least four spaces
Hereafter is part of that function why
that's just the design of the Python
language frankly I think the designers
got tired of seeing really ugly code in
languages like C and C plus and Java
that don't necessarily enforce
indentation to this extent so now it's
baked into the language and my
chronology might be a little off there
but there's been many languages that are
looser than python when it comes to
indentation the indentation is
Meaningful on line seven two notice that
because the while true is indented by
four spaces that just means it's part of
the get-in function but notice below the
while true statement there's eight
there's twelve there's eight there's 12
spaces here and I'm just quickly
counting the dots that means that all of
the lines I've just highlighted are
inside of that while loop while true
means to execute lines 8 through 11
potentially again and again and again
and now lastly on line eight
because we have tried and indented below
it is line nine that just means that
what you should try is what's on my nine
and similarly on line 10 below it we
have indented line 11 you should only
pass when there is an exception of a
value error so the indentation just
means what is associated with what and
once you get comfortable with that
you'll see that it helps the indentation
alone helps explain the logic of your
program and it has a wonderful side
effect that for yourself the next
morning for your colleagues your family
your friends your teachers your code is
much more readable as a result it's not
one big mess of a blob of text other
questions now on try except else or pass
yeah thanks
um two question uh question one
um uh once you say pass can the caller
still
um learn anything about this error
um through a system variable or whatever
and question two problem set zero
referenced some string Methods including
is numeric is it any different to
um go via istomeric here a good question
so on the first question if I'm handling
the error in this way the caller is not
going to know anything about it that's
the point of my handling it so that main
or other callers don't know that
anything technically went wrong on the
second question is numeric is another
function that you can call that can look
at a string and determine is this in
fact a number I could use a mechanism
like that I could use a conditional if
this looks like a number then pass it to
the int function and go ahead and
convert it to an integer that's totally
fine I would generally say that the
pythonic way of doing things is often
for better for worse to try things hope
they work but if they don't handle the
exception so other languages are more in
favor of checking if if if if L if else
in all of these conditionals python
tends to be a little more of the mindset
eh try it but just make sure you're
handling the error so this would be the
pythonic way of doing it your way though
checking with the conditional is it a
number first is totally reasonable too
if you want to go that way well let me
propose some final refinements to this
program that really just kind of tighten
things up one additional step to improve
the implementation of this get in
function let me propose that we not hard
code so to speak that is type manually X
all over the place let's make this
function get into a little more reusable
right now notice that I'm just kind of
using the honor System that well main is
defining a variable called X and get int
is asking for a variable called X but it
would be nice if the caller main doesn't
have to know what the call Lee is naming
its variables and vice versa so caller
to call a function means to use it the
caller is the function that's using it
the call E is just the function being
called it would be nice if I'm not just
hoping that X is the same in both places
so let me propose this let me propose
that we actually add
a parameter to get int like this what's
X that is to say if Maine wants to use
the get in function well then main
should probably tell the get in function
what prompt to show the user just like
the input function recall that comes
with python it's up to you to pass in a
prompt that the user then sees when the
human is asked for input so how do I
make this work here I can go down to my
definition of get int and I can say all
right get into is going to take a
parameter now called prompt I could call
it anything I want but prompt in English
is pretty self-explanatory it means what
do you want the message the user will
see and now down here when I actually
use input I don't have to presumptuously
say what's X because what if the program
the caller wants to ask for y or Z or
some other variable I can just pass to
input whatever prompt the caller has
provided so now I'm making more reusable
code it still works just the same I
haven't changed the functionality per se
but now it's a little more dynamic
because now get int doesn't have to know
or care what variables being asked for
what's being asked for it just needs to
know what prompt it should show to the
user so if I now run this program down
here again prompt number dot Pi enter
what's x 50 still seems to work let's
run it again let's type in cat it still
seems to work and if I type in cat dog
bird or anything else it will keep
prompting me with that same prompt
making this code therefore all the more
usable now it turns out too you can even
raise exceptions yourself using Python's
raise keyword but more on that another
time so in the coming days the coming
weeks the coming months as you write
more code in Python you'll see that
errors are inevitable sometimes there's
syntax errors which you gotta just fix
if you even want to run your program at
all but they could be name errors for
instance variables that you meant to
Define but somehow didn't value errors
where maybe the user didn't cooperate
and provided you with something that you
weren't expecting or a whole list of
other possible errors or except options
but now hopefully you know how you can
handle these errors and respond to them
in any way you like this then was our
look at exceptions and we'll see you
next time
[Music]
foreign
this is cs50's Introduction to
programming with python my name is David
Malin and this is our week on libraries
so libraries are generally files of code
that other people have written that you
can use in your own programs or a
libraries code that you've written that
you can use in your own program but
maybe not just this program but another
and another as well so python supports
exactly this idea this ability to share
code with others share code across your
own projects and it does so by way of
what it calls module a module in Python
is just a library that typically has one
or more functions or other features
built into it generally the purpose of a
library or a module specifically is to
encourage reusability of code if you
find yourself using the same types of
functions again and again the same
functionality if you find yourself
copying and pasting from an old project
into your new project odds are there's
an opportunity there to factor out that
code that you keep copying and pasting
that you keep reusing and put it in into
a library that you can then load into
your programs moving forward so as to
not just copy and paste it and have all
these different copies all over so what
are some of the modules or libraries
that python comes with well python comes
with a random Library literally which is
to say that when you install the python
interpreter on your Mac or PC or
somewhere in the cloud not only do you
get python you get a whole bunch of
modules as well now these modules
provide you with functions that you
don't have access to just by default
like you do print and input print and
input and other such functions just work
in Python but sometimes functions are
tucked away in these modules so you have
to be more deliberate about loading them
into the computer's memory so somewhere
on the computer's hard drive once you've
installed python there is also it turns
out a file probably called random dot Pi
that someone else wrote probably long
ago but that you have access to and in
that random dot Pi file there's probably
one or more functions that you yourself
can use in order to do things things
randomly that is to say how could you
flip a coin in a program in Python how
could you pick a a random number between
1 and 10 in Python well you need a bit
of Randomness and while you could figure
out mathematically how to write
functions like that yourself it's a lot
easier to stand on the shoulders of
others who've already solved that
problem for you so you can focus on the
problem that you yourself want to solve
so for documentation on most any python
module you go to the official python
docs and you go to a URL like this where
the documentation for that specific
module lives and within the
documentation you'll see a list of the
functions or other functionality that
some module provides but how do you go
about loading a module into your own
program so that you can use the
functions in that module well we need a
new keyword in Python and namely it's
import the import keyword in Python
allows you to import the contents of the
functions from some module in Python
well how might I go about using this in
practice well let me propose that there
exists in that random module this
function among others so I have copied
and pasted from the documentation this
summary of a function called choice now
the function exists in the random module
so to speak not a random module the
random module and so generally the
documentation describes it fully like
this random.choice is how you would
technically call this function though
we'll see alternatives to that in
parentheses there is a parameter called
seq for sequence and sequence generally
means a list or something that is list
like if you have a list of numbers or
strings or anything else and the
documentation elaborates well how can I
go about using this function to solve
perhaps a familiar problem well let me
go ahead and open up vs code here and
let me propose that we Implement a
program that simulates flipping a coin a
coin that in the US heads heads or tails
the idea of which is to pick a decision
with 50 50 probability 50 probability of
heads 50 probability of Tails or you can
use some other mechanism like that well
let me go ahead and open a program with
code called generate dot Pi because I
want to start generating a whole bunch
of random information the first of which
is just going to be a coin toss now how
do I go about using that function well I
first have to import the random Library
so literally the first or among the
first lines of my file should be import
random and that just gives me access to
all of the functions in that specific
module now suppose I want to flip a coin
well I can do random dot Choice per the
documentation a moment ago and that
again takes a sequence what's a sequence
it's a list or something that's list
like and we know about lists we've used
lists to iterate over numbers we've used
lists to iterate over students at
Hogwarts let's go ahead now and let's
iterate over just a list of two sides of
a coin heads quote unquote or tails now
I could call these anything I want these
are my strings I just just want to
simulate a tossing a coin so I'm just
going to say in all lower case heads and
tails but notice the syntax I have heads
and tails and double quotes that's
because they're strings I could also use
single quotes so long as I'm consistent
there's a comma between them which means
the list has two elements there's square
brackets to the right and the left which
indicates that this is indeed a list
that's the syntax recall for defining a
list in Python and then lastly there's
something more familiar there's the
parentheses outside of those square
brackets but those are just the
parentheses that belong to the choice
function and specify where its parameter
gets passed in but again unlike past
functions I have to specify what module
this function is in at least for now and
so I do random dot choice to call the
specific function all right well it's
one thing to flip a coin picking between
those with 50 probability and that's
what random.choice does it takes in a
list and it returns to one of those
values randomly with equal probability
because I've passed in two items I've
got a 50 50 chance if I passed in three
items it'd be a 33 chance for each of
those items and so forth python does the
math for you but I want to store the
value of this in a variable so let's
Define a variable called coin equals
whatever the return value is so this is
indeed like flipping a coin I'm going to
store in a variable called coin whatever
that value is heads or tails and now
just so I can see what's going on let's
go ahead and print out the value of that
string coin all right let me go ahead
now and run this program in my terminal
window python of generate dot Pi enter
and it looks like the first coin toss
was the heads let's go ahead and run it
again
and it looks like it was heads again
maybe you want to chime into the chat
here if I run it a third time what's it
going to be this time if you want to
type your thoughts in the chat
you might think there's a bug here but
this is probability in action if I go
ahead and hit enter a third time there
it's actually now tails and again tails
and again tails and again tails and
again tails and again heads now if we
did this an infinite number of times it
would indeed work out to be 50 50. if we
only do it a few times it might not work
out as cleanly but that's how
probabilities indeed work all right so
I've got that now working could I have
implemented this in a different way well
let me show you an alternative to
actually using the import keyword alone
and let me introduce the keyword from in
Python so from is a keyword in Python
that you can use when importing
functions from a module but it allows
you to be a little more specific than
import alone so if I go back to my code
here it's worth noting that what
technically I'm doing here by importing
random is I'm technically importing
everything that's in that module so not
just the function called random.choice
but a few other functions as well help
so instead of using this line of code at
the top of my file import random which
will technically give me access to all
of the contents they're in a downside of
that is that I have to type in
random.choice random.this random.that
because all of the functions I'm calling
have to be associated with the scope of
that module well suppose that I just
want to call the function as its name
choice I can do that as well let me
replace this first line here with from
random import choice and what this does
effectively is it loads the function's
name Choice into my current namespace
into the scope of the file I'm working
in what that means is that I now no
longer have to specify Which choice
function I mean I can just say choice
and so it loads it into the local
namespace that is into my local
vocabulary if you will so I can just now
say choice this might be advantageous in
what cases do you think when might you
want to import the name of the function
explicitly like this this as opposed to
just saying random.choice random.choice
throughout your code when calling a
function
any instincts here for this alternative
import using from
um hello I'm Muhammad from Egypt and
maybe if we have a variable that its
name is basically like choice if I have
a variable called the choice so I need
to differentiate which trays I choose so
I'm gonna choose random dotted Choice
yeah really good instincts by using the
first approach by just importing random
you're making sure that all of its
contents are associated with are scoped
to the random module so that you can
have your own choice function you can
have your own choice variable you can
use the same names as all of the
functions or variables that are stored
inside of that file without them
colliding so to speak and this is a good
thing in older languages it was the case
that if you imported someone's Library
you better hope that you're not using
the same functions or variables as they
are because you might in fact have some
kind of conflict Python and certain
other languages allow you to scope the
names of those functions and variables
to the file or the module that they come
from so that's a good thing but honestly
this is such a short program or
equivalently maybe I'm using the choice
function in so many places calling
random.choice random.choice
random.choice it's just making my code
longer and longer and longer marginally
so but it's just getting ugly and
annoying I can simply import choice and
now tighten up my code a little bit so
as with so many decisions in the past
there's not necessarily one right
approach or another it depends but I
think for those very reasons sometimes
it's better to do what we did the first
time which is only import the module so
as to retain the scope they're in well
let me propose that we transition to
another function that comes with
Python's random module and that's this
here from the documentation Rand int
it's a bit hard to say but it implies
get back a random int and if you read
the documentation it's a random end
that's between A and B inclusive so if
you were to pass in one for a and ten
for B you would get back a number
between 1 and 10 inclusive include
including the one and including the 10
potentially each with a ten percent
probability so how might I go about
using a program like this well let me
come back to my generate.pi file and why
don't we go ahead and try generating a
random number between one and ten you
might do this frequently in the real
world when you just want someone to pick
a random number you tell them as much in
the human response let's get the
computer to do the same here let me go
ahead and delete my two lines of code at
the bottom but keep my import random and
let's go ahead and Define a variable
this time called number set it equal to
the return value of
random.randint and now pass in a a value
of 1 and B a value of 10 and now let's
go ahead and print the number I'm going
to go ahead in my terminal window and
run python of generate.pi and hit enter
four
a python of generate.pi and hit enter
eight again nine again seven again ten
again two again and we can do this all
day long and if we add all of those up
they should end up being with ten
percent probability each now how might
you use this information well maybe
we're playing a guessing game or maybe
we're trying to randomize the behavior
of some character in the game you can
imagine using very simple building
blocks like this just kind of spicing up
your program by getting it to do things
a little less predictably because you're
choosing these values seemingly randomly
and you're deferring to python to
actually do the generation of these
numbers uh using its own algorithms and
its own math well what more could we do
here let me propose that we introduce
another function that comes from this
random Library yet another that you
yourself have don't don't have to
implement Shuffle if you read the
documentation for Shuffle in the same
random module you'll see that it takes
in a list for instance of values and
just shuffles them up it randomizes them
like a a deck of cards here you might
shuffle them so as to put them into
seemingly random order well how do I use
this based on this function's name well
let me propose that we go back to vs
code here and let me go ahead and this
time do the following because I need to
shuffle something like a deck of cards
let me go ahead and not just import
random but let me give myself a variable
called cards that's going to be of type
list and just so I have something to
shuffle I don't need all 52 cards in a
typical deck I'm just going to shuffle
three cards a jack a queen and a king I
could call those strings anything I want
but I just wanted a list of some values
so as to shuffle them up that is
randomize the order they're in well how
does this now work if you read the
documentation for random.shuffle you'll
see that it shuffles the argument in
place that is unlike many of the
functions we've seen it doesn't return
to a value that contains the shuffled
cards in this case it actually shuffles
the list it's given itself so what this
means for my code is that I need to do
something like this random dot Shuffle
and pass in the variable containing
those cards and then on a final line
here how might I go about printing the
cards well I could do this and I could
say print cards but if I do that I'm
actually going to see python Syntax for
lists and it's just going to format in
its own way using commas and the like I
want to print these cards out one at a
time just because I think it'll look a
little better so we can use some of our
syntax from loops and say something like
this for card in cards go ahead and
print out the current card so what's now
Happening Here line three I'm defining a
list of three cards in this order Jack
queen king I'm then shuffling those same
cards on line four and then on line five
I'm using a for Loop for each of the
cards in that list printed out one at a
time and because I'm using print one
line at a time well let's see the
results down here in my terminal window
I'm going to run python of generate.pi
and hit enter queen king Jack seemingly
shot because that's not the order I
defined earlier let's do it again
queen king Jack okay that happens to be
the same but let's see this could just
be bad chance there we go Jack queen
king doesn't look like it's shuffled but
at least we're getting back different
orderings now again jack queen king hmm
not so good Jack queen king not so good
this is someone you probably want to
play against with cards Queen Jack King
there we go but of course we only have
three cards here so there's not that
many permutations we might see and if we
do this over time we will see all of
them but if we had of course 13 or 52
cards we'd see a lot more permutations
instead so we have now these three ways
to Generate random information one is
simple coin toss if you want to start
some kind of athletic event one pick a
number between one and ten if you want
to decide something based on that and
now using Shuffle we can even take in a
list of things and shuffle them about so
that we get some kind of random Behavior
let me pause here and see if there's any
questions yet on random on modules or
any of these three functions yeah uh can
we increase or decrease the probability
uh of course
if you want to for example there is
three there is a 33 percent chance of
probability so is there any chance to
increase or decrease the probability can
you set these probabilities not using
these same functions uh can you set the
probabilities but you can absolutely
Implement some of your own functions or
use more sophisticated functions that do
exist in this library and others to
exercise more control these are meant to
be very user-friendly and simple
functions certainly the ones we looked
at that give you equal probability for
all of those but absolutely you could
skew things though hopefully if you're
implementing a gambling game or the like
you're not actually making some cards
more probable than others allow me to
turn back now to our implementation here
of this Randomness and consider how we
might leverage other types of
functionality that aren't necessarily in
this specific Library here well it turns
out that python also comes with a
statistics library and this contains all
sorts of functions for doing things more
statistical in nature namely calculating
means or medians or modes or other
aspects of a data set that you might
want to analyze so how might we use the
statistics module in Python well we
might first just take a look at its
documentation like any other module in
Python and we'll see within that library
that there's a whole bunch of functions
and one of those functions is one that's
quite simple it's average a function
that allows you to calculate the average
of some numbers that you've passed in
let me go ahead and envious code in my
terminal window open up a new file
called average dot pi and at the top of
this file I'm going to import a
different Library this time namely the
statistics module in Python and now I'm
going to go ahead and call a function
that I know comes in that module namely
mean for the average of some values and
I'm going to call statistics dot mean
and I'm going to pass into this function
mean a list of some values and let's
suppose that I'm quickly trying to
calculate what my current grade average
is in school and I did really well on my
first test and I got a hundred percent
and on my second I did well but not as
well and I got a 90. and ironically I'm
not very good with math so I'd like to
figure out what my average now is
between those two tests so let me go
ahead now and in this list type in the
number 100 comma 90 thereby passing in a
list of two values two ants 190 and ins
outside of those are the parentheses
because of course this is now the
argument I'm passing to the function
called mean and this function mean is in
the module called statistics well it's
not that interesting to just calculate
the mean if I don't actually see what it
is so let me additionally pass the
return value of that mean function to
the print function as usual let me now
in my terminal window in vs code Type in
Python of average dot pi and hit enter
and voila as you might expect my average
is 95 percent so the difference here is
that I'm just using a different module
that still comes with python but I need
to import it instead of for instance the
random module instead and this time I
know from the documentation that there
exists a function called mean well it
turns out there's even more
functionality that comes with python and
that comes with other modules and Python
and there's this feature generally known
as command line arguments this is a
feature not just of python but of
languages more generally that allow you
to provide input not when prompted
inside of a program as happens whenever
we call the python function input but
rather there's this feature command line
arguments of programs that allows you to
provide arguments that is input to the
program of just when you're executing it
at the command line so up until now for
instance recall that we've generally run
python of something.pi for instance
pythonofhello.pi and I've never once
really executed any words or phrases
after the name of the file but I could
in fact when you're running programs in
a command-like environment like we are
you can provide any number of words or
numbers or phrases after the command
that you're typing and all of those will
somehow be passed in as inputs to the
program itself you don't have to prompt
the user for one thing at a time by
manually calling that input function so
what does this mean in real terms well
let me go ahead back into vs code here
and let me propose that we consider how
we might leverage a certain module I'm
going to go ahead and create a file
called
name.pi and I'd like to use a new module
this time that's going to give me access
to
values that have been typed at that
command line but what's this module
going to be well this one's going to be
called CIS and CIS short for system
contains a whole lot of functionality
that's specific to the system itself and
the commands that you and I are typing
the documentation for this module is
that this URL here and it lists all of
the various functions and variables and
the like that come with that module but
we're going to focus on something a
little more specific namely this thing
here it turns out in the sys module in
Python there is a variable that just
magically exists for you called ARG V it
stands for argument Vector which is a
fancy way of describing the list of all
of the words that the human typed in at
their prompt before they hit enter all
of those are seemingly magically
provided to you via python in a variable
called sys.org V this variable is a list
which means that the first element is
going to be the first word that you type
the second element is going to be the
second word that you typed in so forth
and by way of this list then can you
figure out what words did the human
actually type at the prompt and maybe
use that to influence the behavior of
your own program so what does this mean
now in real terms well in this new tab
called name.pi let me go ahead and
import CIS within that sys module is
going to give me access to sys.org V but
how might I want to use it well let's do
this instead of writing a hello world
program that all of these times has just
looked for the return value of input to
figure out what the user wants me to
print let's go ahead and just expect the
user to tell us when they run the Python
program itself what their name is and
suppose this time I'd like to generate a
whole bunch of name tags initially just
one and in the US here it's very common
to wear a sticker on your lapel that
says hello my name is David so I want to
print out some text that resembles that
the idea being maybe I could enhance
this program someday to even send that
text straight to the printer and
dynamically generate those name tags
well let me go ahead now and do this let
me go ahead and print out as always
hello but I'll say a little something
more this time to make things more
interesting hello my name is quote
unquote and then after that I normally
have been in the habit of calling input
storing the return value in a variable
and passing in the name of that variable
here but I'm going to instead jump right
to this
sys.rv bracket one and that's it I'm
going to have a program here that says
hello my name is followed by whatever is
in sys.rv bracket one and notice cis.org
V again is a list and recall from our
discussion of loops and in turn lists we
use this square bracket notation to get
at the various elements inside of a list
all right let me go down now into my
terminal window and run python of name
dot Pi but this time rather than just
hit enter and wait for the program to
prompt me for my name let me proactively
just tell this program what my name is
at the so-called command line here we go
David separated with a space from the
name of the file so that now when I
execute python name.pi David I see on
the screen voila hello my name is David
So based on this demonstration alone I
think we can infer exactly what's going
on in sys.rv even though it sounds
certainly at first glance uh rather
complicated here let's look up at
sis.orgby I'm going to bracket one here
so clearly
sys.orgv bracket one is storing
d-a-v-i-d but it's one in the past when
we looked at Loops recall that we said
that they were zero indexed that is the
first element is zero the next element
is one this next element is two and so
forth and yet here I am treating it as
though my name is at the start of the
list one well let me ask this question
what is probably
insist.org V of zero
what is probably insist.org V of zero
the very first element actually in that
list oh yeah I think uh it's like in C
uh the name of program indeed it's
indeed like in C in other languages the
name of the program well if we consider
what it was I typed I certainly typed
python because that's the name of my
interpreter and we don't really need to
know that because we're using python
itself but after that I did type two
things I typed name dot pi as I've done
so many times anytime I want python to
interpret a program I've written and it
turns out by convention what python does
is it stores in sys.orgv the name of the
file that you're executing or
interpreting followed by any number of
other words that you type so all this
time we could have been accessing the
name of the program which frankly isn't
all that interesting but we can also now
access words that are typed after that
prompt as well but of course if I don't
type anything in what might happen here
this might be naive of me to assume that
there's always going to be something at
location one in sys.org V let me go
ahead and try this python name dot pi
and no I'm not giving you my name
because at this point I might not even
know that you want my name to be typed
so let me hit enter now and uh oh we see
now an error a so-called exception in
Python this one's a new one this one's
an index error that elaborates list
index out of range and turns out this is
actually one of the most common mistakes
in programming whether using a list in
python or arrays or vectors in other
languages is to try to access some
element that does not exist you try to
go too far to the left or you try to go
too far to the right in this in this
object that is just a list of some
values so of course the mistake here is
that I'm assuming there's going to be
something at location one when really
it's location zero that's the only one
that has a value but fixing this is not
going to amount to doing bracket zero
because now if I go ahead and rerun this
program with no other words after name
dot Pi it says hello my name is name.pi
which is fine if we're making a name tag
for the program but that's not of course
what my goal here is instead so if the
fix is not just to change the one to a
zero how else might I handle this error
how else might I handle this error this
index error that happens if the user
just doesn't remember to or doesn't know
to type their actual name at the prompt
we could always put an exception into
the program saying if there is
um if there's nothing at location one
we just come out to say okay we haven't
got a parameter or something but if
there is you continue along with the
program
perfect so if I might simplify we can
try to execute this line of code except
if there's an error we'll deal with it
in some other way now ideally and once
I'm a strong enough programmer I would
have anticipated this and written the
following code from the get-go but when
you're learning it's certainly
reasonable to see an error oh I didn't
realize I should detect that and then go
back and improve your code but of course
if you read the documentation you
ingrain some of the Lessons Learned From
the Past you'll get into the habit of
trying and checking for some of these
exceptions yourself so let me solve this
in one possible way as you proposed here
let's try to handle this exception as
follows let me go ahead now and instead
of just blindly calling this print line
let me try to print out hello my name is
such and such except if there is an
issue specifically an index error then
what do I want to go ahead and do I'm
going to say something like too few
arguments I could be more explanatory
than that but for now I'm just going to
explain to the user that they gave me
too few arguments too few words at the
prompt so now it's still not going to
work in quite the way I want I'm still
not going to be able to generate their
name tag but at least they're not going
to see some cryptic error message and
think that they themselves broke the
program let me go ahead now and run
python of name.pi enter and too few
arguments okay let me go ahead now and
do python of name.pi and type in my name
David and now we're back in business and
I see that my name is on the screen too
but strictly speaking I don't have to
try to do this I could actually be a
little more defensive in writing this
code and maybe I could check whether or
not the user has indeed provided a name
or multiple names at the prompt so as to
give them more refined error messages as
well so how might I do this well let me
go and undo the exception handling I've
added and why do I instead more modestly
try to do this let me go ahead and
introduce a conditional here if the
length of cis.org V is less than 2 or
equivalently equal to just 1 value but
I'll just stick with less than two for
now then go ahead and print out two few
arguments so I want ultimately two
arguments I want the name of the program
at location zero and I want the name of
the human at location one so that's a
total of two arguments so if I have
fewer than two arguments let's tell the
user with this print line L if the
length of sys dot ARG V is say greater
than two like they typed in too many
words at the prompt well let's tell them
print quote unquote too many arguments
else if they did get it right and they
gave me exactly two arguments else let's
go ahead and print what I actually care
about all right let me go down to my
terminal window here and run python of
name.pi and voila
a completely different type of error
this one a syntax error which we've seen
in the past now a syntax error recall is
mayakopa like I messed up here and I
wrote invalid syntax and so no amount of
conditionals or exception handling is
really going to catch this one I need to
go back and just get my program to work
because it's not running at all well let
me go up here and see line four is the
issue and it indeed it looks like I have
an unterminated string here I need to go
ahead and now add this double quote so
let me go ahead now when with that red
herring gone let me rerun python of
name.pi and hit enter and now we see too
few arguments okay maybe it wants my
full name let me go ahead now and run
python of name.pi David Malin typing in
both words after the name of the file
and hit enter and now of course it's too
many arguments fine now I'll oblige and
do python of name.pi and just David and
there we have it my name tag printed on
the screen so strictly speaking we don't
have to handle exceptions if we can be a
little smarter about it and just check
for the things that we're worried about
especially if we want to give the user
more refined advice we don't want to
just tell them no something went wrong
or we don't want to pass we want to tell
them no that's too few or no that's too
many we have conditionals in our
vocabulary already via which we can now
Express that well let me pause here and
see if there's any questions now on how
we handled the error before with the
index error or how now we're just
proactively avoiding all index errors
all together by just checking first is
it too few is it too many or is it
exactly what we want oh yeah thank you
um so I was wondering you you touched
upon kind of using your full name
um could we could we then
um is there a way going forwards that
perhaps we uh have people that want
their full names and want their just
their first name that we separate that
into like oh this person has full name
this person has just the one name
absolutely and allow me to uh allow me
to propose we come back to that support
for multiple names but indeed we could
do that and I should know too though we
can support full names right now if I do
this instead of typing in David space
Malin which is problematic because again
by definition of how ARG V Works each
word ends up in a specific location in
the list but if I add quotes single
quotes or double quotes at the command
line now python will view this as two
total things the name of the file and
this full name and now when I hit enter
I don't see the quotes the whole thing
is passed in as my full name and if I
want to adapt this further for multiple
people we'll be able to do that as well
other questions now on this version with
if elif else or on accept before
I want to ask you uh can we use multiple
else in statement can you use multiple
else's statements no else is the last
catch-all statement that you can have
you can have multiple l if statements in
the middle but not multiple else's
all right all right well let's turn our
attention back now to this code and see
if we can't refine it a bit more by
adding in some additional functionality
that we get with modules like the sys
module one of the things I don't love
about this version of the code even
though arguably it is now correct is
that the essence of my program which is
just to print out the name tag is kind
of relegated to this else clause and
that's fine logically it's correct but
generally speaking there's something
nice about keeping all of your error
handling separate from the code that you
really care about having all of these
ifs El lifts perhaps at the top of your
code that are checking to make sure that
all of the data is as expected but then
it would be nice if only for design sake
not to sort of hide in this else
statement the actual code that you care
about I would prefer for instance to do
something logically like this I could
check for errors up top and then down
here print the name tags it would be
nice if there those are sort of distinct
blocks of code all of which are here
left aligned but there's a problem with
what I've just done here logically what
bug did I just introduce by getting rid
of the else
and introducing line 10 on its own with
no indentation outside of the
conditional
what bug have I just introduced what
mistake to be clear
um name error ironically it's a name
error but not a name error exception
it's an error with my name but
I think you're Frozen for me it's going
to raise an exception because even
though I'm checking the length of
sys.org V up top and even though I'm
checking it again for being greater than
two not just less than two but greater
I'm still then blindly and incorrectly
assuming it's now going to exist so just
to be clear if I run python of name.pi
and I don't type any arguments I've got
too few I think I'm going to see that I
have too few but I'm also going to see
that same exception at the very top of
my terminal Windows output there's my
error message too few arguments but
again on line 10 I blindly proceed to
still index into my list at location one
which does not exist so it turns out
there's a better way to handle errors
like this especially if you're writing a
program in Python that's just meant to
run briefly and then exit anyway but
maybe we could start to exit prematurely
if the program itself just can't proceed
if the user has not given us the data we
want perhaps we should just exit the
program earlier than we might otherwise
so let me go ahead and do this let me go
ahead and remove my comments so as to
focus only on the code here and let me
propose that instead of just printing
quote unquote too few arguments I'm
going to use one other function that
comes with the sys module I'm going to
go ahead and call Sis dot exit and as
the name suggests it's going to do
exactly that with the system's help it's
going to exit my program then and there
on line four why is that okay well if
you gave me too few arguments I have
nothing more to say to you the user I
might as well exit a bit prematurely and
I can do this as well on line six let's
go ahead and not just print that but
sys.exit quote unquote too many
arguments print out that message and
just exit right there now I can trust
that by the time I get to line eight
every error condition has been checked
for and so it's safe for me to assume
that there is in fact an item at
location one in sys.org V so let me go
ahead now and run this python of name.pi
enter too few arguments but I'm back at
my prompt nothing more has happened let
me run it again python of name.pi David
Malin with no quotes enter too many
arguments is now printed here finally
python of name dot Pi just David enter
hello my name is David so we have then
insists two forms of functionality now
we have access to this variable sys.orgv
this argument Vector that gives me all
of the words that were typed at the
prompt including the program's own file
name and it turns out if we read further
in the documentation there's an exit
function that can take different types
of inputs but if I pass out a string
like this it will indeed print that
string for me and then exit from my
program then and there questions now on
exiting from programs like this
to be clear all of this time once python
gets to the bottom of your file it's
going to exit anyway so I'm using
sys.exit now just to make sure that I
exit earlier than otherwise
um my question is about the CIS that are
are V so is that capable of accepting or
taking multiple elements at once let's
say for example uh python name that by
David Malin I'm a male uh 20 years old
and if let's say I only want to access
your name which is at the first index
and then you're you're your age is
brought say at the sixth index can I say
sys dot RV one
and another one for six to access what I
just want is that possible for assist RB
uh short answer yes I think if I
understand your question correctly
whereby you're proposing to have many
words at the end of the command and you
want to access those individual words
absolutely at some point it gets a
little fragile I would say if you're
typing so many words at the prompt that
the order really matters and so it turns
out there's a lot of programs and
there's functionality in Python that can
allow you to provide those values like
name or age or any number of other
fields in any order you want but pass in
a bit more information textually that
tells the program how you want to use it
so in short what you're describing is
possible and let me do a small
incarnation of it as follows let me
propose that we go back to my code here
and let's propose that we actually now
want to support multiple values at the
prompt so there's going to be no such
thing as too many arguments suppose that
I want to generate name tag tags not
just for David but for David for Carter
for wrong Shin for others in the group
who all want their name tags as well so
I'm going to go ahead and do this I'm
going to get rid of my L if condition
because I don't want to limit the
maximum number of words that are typed
at the prompt anymore I instead want to
iterate over every
name at the prompt so I'm going to say
this for ARG in sis.org V go ahead and
print out this time ARG so what am I
doing here well even though the syntax
is a little different the idea is the
same as before when we've had Loops I'm
using a for Loop to iterate over a list
the list in question here is sys.org V
ARG is a variable that I'm creating on
the Fly the for Loop is going to make
sure that the first time through this
Loop ARG is set to the first word on the
command line the second time through the
loop Python's going to make sure that
ARG is now set to the second thing on
the command line and so forth that's
just how a for Loop works it updates the
variable for us I don't have to call it
Arc I could call it name so long as I
change it to name in both places but ARG
is reasonable if I'm iterating over
arguments more generally if I now run
this program though unfortunately
there's a little bit of a bug even if I
type in David and Carter and wrong shin
I'm not going to get just three name
tags
in your mind does anyone see the bug I'm
about to trip over it's not a huge deal
if I've got enough name tags to go
around but I'm going to be wasting one
because this is going to print not three
but four name tags whereby the first
contains the name of the program itself
maybe not a big deal maybe that's the
sticker we don't bother handing out but
it's wasteful and it does look wrong so
how could we get access to not all four
elements of argv but just a slice of ARG
V and this is actually a technical term
in Python in some other languages to
take a slice of a list means to take a
subset of it maybe from the beginning
maybe the middle maybe the end but a
slice is a subset of a data structure
like a list well how do I actually do
this in code well in Python it's
actually very easy to take a slice of a
list that is a subset thereof you can
simply do this at the end of the list
name sys.org V in this case you can use
square brackets and then in those square
brackets you can specify the start and
the end of the list that you want to
retain I want to start at element one
not zero I want to start at element one
and I want to just go to the end so I'm
actually going to Omit a second number
altogether it's not necessary to have a
second number but I do need that colon
because this is going to give me a slice
of the list it's going to give me a
slice of the list that starts at
location one not zero and the colon and
then a blank just means it's going to
give me everything else so this is
equivalently going to slice off the
first element of the list and give me a
new list that contains just those three
human names not the name of the file
itself let me try running this again I'm
going to run python of name.pi David
Carter wrong Shin this time hopefully
I'm going to get three and only three
name tags hitting enter and indeed I've
done now just this so again using some
relatively simple syntax in Python we
can use square brackets not just to go
to specific elements like bracket zero
or bracket one we can also get subsets
of the slices of the list by doing
bracket something colon Something where
each of those some things is a number
the beginning or the end and they're
optional depending on whether you want
all of them or just some
any questions now on this version which
adds the loop and these slices with that
new syntax
can we slice starting from the end of
the argument argument Vector you can you
can slice something from the end of the
argument vector and this might uh this
might blow one's mind a little bit let
me go ahead and do this uh let's see let
me go ahead and do negative one at the
end using a negative number here and
running the same command we've just
uninvited wrong Shin from receiving a
name tag here so if you use a negative
number it has the effect of counting to
the uh in the other direction from the
end of the list a good question there
other questions now on slices on looping
over sys.org V
hype so I remember very early on uh when
we were talking about only having two
decimal places in uh in an float value
um
does this is is that in the same vein
like um because we use the the colon
point to f
uh so that's is that the same thing then
uh why would the F be included then in
the point 2 f as opposed to here when
you just have the numbers
a really good question and it's just the
short answer is that context matters so
there's only so many keyboard keys on
our keyboard and so we sometimes use the
same symbols for different things so
what you're alluding to is the format
code in in fstring for actually
formatting a number using a colon using
a period using a number using the letter
F and so forth and that is very specific
to the F string feature of python this
case has nothing to do with any of that
syntax per se this is just using a colon
in a different context to solve this
problem to implement a slice the authors
of python could have chosen another
symbol but honestly looking down at my
keyboard here we don't have that many to
choose from that are easy to type so
sometimes they have different meanings a
good question as well allow me to
propose now that we take things further
and move away from using only those
modules those libraries that python
comes with to talk about more generally
packages that exist one of the reasons
that python is so popular and Powerful
these days is that there's a lot of
third-party libraries out there as well
otherwise known as packages strictly
speaking python itself has a term of art
called a package which is a module
essentially that's implemented in a
folder not just a file but a folder but
more generally a package is a
third-party library that you that I can
install on our own Mac or PC or our
Cloud Server and gain access to even
more functionality that other people
have implemented for us now one of the
locations you can get all of these
packages is called the Pi Pi websites
the python package index which lives at
this URL here and this is a website that
is searchable via the command line as
well as via the web that allows you to
download and install all sorts of
packages even cs50 has some of its own
packages in services like these now
there's a fun one out there that's a
throwback to a command that's been
around for years in command line
environments called cow set cow say is a
package in Python on that allows you to
have a cow say something on your screen
if curious to read up on it its own
documentation is on pipi.org
specifically at this URL here but how do
you actually get the package into your
system well technically you could figure
out how to download the file and maybe
unzip it and put it into the right
location on your Mac or PC but nowadays
a lot of languages python among them has
what's called its own package manager
this one here called pip which is just
one so pip is a program that generally
comes with python itself nowadays that
allows you to install packages onto your
own Macs or PCS or Cloud environment by
just running a command and then voila
you have access to a whole new library
in Python that didn't come with python
itself but now it's available on your
system for you let's go back to vs code
here and in my terminal window I'm going
to go ahead and type pip install cow say
now what's going on here pip is the
command the package manager and I want
you to install what package the package
called cow say I'm going to go ahead and
hit enter here and after a little bit of
output it has successfully installed cow
say now what does that mean that means I
can now go about importing this into my
own code well let's go ahead and see
what this means let me go ahead and
create a new file with code called say
dot Pi because I want something to be
said on the screen and in my new tab
here I'm going to go ahead and import
cow say which presumably is now
installed I'm now going to import sys as
well because I'd like to use some
command line arguments in this program
just so that I can run it quickly and
without using the input function I can
get the user's name immediately from The
Prompt and let me go ahead and do this
I'm going to do a bit of error checking
proactively this time and rather than
use less than or greater than I'm this
time going to say if the length of
sys.org V does equal to so if the human
is provided just the name of the program
and their own first name we're good to
go I'm going to do the following I'm
going to call a function called cow in
the package called Cow Say and I'm going
to pass in a string hello comma and then
as in the past I'm going to pass in just
one string because according to its
documentation it's not like print I
can't pass in comma this comma that I
can only pass in one string so I'm going
to concatenate the contents of CIS dot
ARG V bracket one so long as then I type
in my name David after the name of this
program it should end up in sys.org V1
in which case this line five of codes
should concatenate hello with my name
with a space in between and apparently a
cow is going to say it so let's see what
happens here let me go ahead and clear
my screen and increase the size of my
terminal window let me go ahead and run
python of say dot pi and type my name
David and enter there is the program
called cow say it literally has a cow
say something on the screen and this is
a throwback to a program from yesteryear
that tended to come with a lot of
systems this is otherwise known as ASCII
art it's a textual way using just keys
on your keyboard to print pictures of
sorts on the screen now we can really go
down the rabbit hole here and there's
questionable academic value of doing so
so I'll do so just once turns out the
cow say package comes with other
functions as well one of those functions
for instance is T-Rex and if I now
increase the size of my terminal window
we'll perhaps see where we're going with
this let me now run again python of
say.pi this time let me not provide my
name just to see if it's broken it's
still okay because we have that if
condition if the length of sys.org V
equals equals two and only if it equals
equals two do we do anything that's why
we're not seeing anything here let me go
ahead and cooperate now say dot Pi space
David and it's no longer a cow but
if I zoom out on my screen a T-Rex why
just because these are the things you
can do once you know how to program you
can even package them up and make them
freely available to others as open
source software for us it's
demonstrative of a feature more
generally here namely being able to
install these third-party packages and
how you might do so in Python now I'll
leave this up on the screen for a moment
and see if there's any questions about
cows or Tyrannosaurus Rexes or packages
more generally
I'm really qualified to speak to just
one of those
hi um I've got two questions it's a bit
earlier than what it's supposed to be um
so my first question is
the packages that you're calling
um to uh use in the program are they the
same as
um let's say because if I'm doing Java
um the same as calling a class or Java
file in order to use its functions
and my second question is what's the
actual purpose of using command line
arguments as you've used because it's
not really the best way to
as you say be user friendly where as in
let's say the person who's
using the program doesn't know what it
what they want what the program's asking
them really good questions the first
question about the comparison with Java
python packages are similar to Java
packages where you have something dot
something dot something at the top of
your program that gives you access to a
class or something else python itself
supports classes more on those down the
road and you can do very similar things
in python as you can do with Java but
the analog really is python packages to
Java packages here as for command line
arguments you ask a good question why do
we use them especially if they're a
little yes user friendly they're a
little less user friendly to people who
aren't in this Zoom to be honest you and
I as we learn more and more about
programming and more about command line
arguments I dare say will become more
comfortable with and tend to prefer the
ability to customize commands using
these command line arguments why
productivity it tends to make you faster
because you get into the habit of
knowing exactly how you can configure
your software without having to manually
answer questions and case in point all
of this time have we been running python
of something dot Pi you could imagine
not doing that you can imagine typing
only python hitting enter and then
you're prompted for the name of the file
you want to run so you type in
something.pi and then it runs not a big
deal but I I would argue that over time
you're going to get a little tired of
that tedium and you would much prefer to
just automate the command again and
again and again especially with little
conveniences like being able to hit up
and down in your keyboard history so as
to rerun those same commands automation
is Big too if you emerge from a class
like this and start using python to
automate processes at work or for
personal projects or the like the
ability to specify all of your inputs on
the one line just means you can get work
done more quickly so hands down
absolutely using command line arguments
is a more Arcane feature of systems that
most of us are no longer as familiar
with because of Windows and Mac OS and
other operating systems that have
buttons and gui's and menus but the more
comfortable yet you get with programming
I dare say the more you will tend to
prefer these capabilities because they
allow you to do things more quickly
with that said allow me to propose that
we take a turn toward yet another
package that's particularly popular and
just as easy to install all toward an
end of using apis now apis are not
something that's python specific more
generally an API is an application
programming interface and it can refer
to python files and functions but often
apis really refer to third-party
services that you and I can write code
that talk to many apis but not all live
on the internet these days so that so
long as you have a browser or so long as
you have some experience with Python
Programming or programming in any
language you can write code that in
effect pretends to be a browser connects
to that third-party API on a server and
download some data that you can then
incorporate into your own program now
how do you do this well python has a
very popular package that you can
install via pip called requests the
requests Library allows you to make make
web requests internet requests using
python code essentially as though you
were a browser yourself you can automate
therefore the retrieval of URLs that
start with HTTP or https the
documentation for this library is a URL
like this but it too can be installed at
the command line and even though it's
third party it's one of the most popular
and commonly used packages out there in
Python and this too is one of the
reasons again that python is so popular
there's just so many solutions to
problems that you and I have or are
invariably going to have when we write
projects of our own there's just a
really vibrant ecosystem a really
Vibrant Community of Open Source
software that's that easy for us to
install let me go back to my terminal
window now and run pip install requests
in order to install this package on my
own system and after some lines of
output I'll see that it's successfully
installed now let's go ahead and create
a new file here for instance
itunes.pi it turns out that Apple has
its own API for their tune service the
software that provides you with the
ability to download and search for music
and songs and other information as well
and it turns out that let me go back
over to my computer here and open up a
browser like Chrome and let me go ahead
and visit this URL here https colon
slash
itunes.apple.com search question mark
entity equal song Ampersand limit equals
one Ampersand term equals Weezer now I
constructed this URL manually by reading
the documentation for Apple's API
application programming interface for
iTunes and what they told me is that if
I want to search for information about
songs in their database I should specify
entity equals song so that it's songs
and not albums or artists or something
like that if I just want to get back
information on one song I'm going to
provide limit equals one and if the band
I want to search for the artist is
Weezer I should specify term equals
Weezer so with this if I go ahead and
hit enter and visit this URL I actually
end up with a text file and my downloads
folder on my Mac if I go ahead and open
that text file that my browser just
downloaded we'll see all of this text
here which at first glance might look a
bit cryptic but it actually follows a
pattern notice this curly brace at the
start and notice this closed curly brace
at the end notice this open square
bracket here and notice this closed
square bracket here and in between those
pieces of syntax are a whole bunch of
strings and values in fact a whole bunch
of key value pairs what we're looking at
here is a standard text format known as
Json JavaScript object notation which
yes is technically related to yet
another programming language called
JavaScript but Json itself is typically
used nowadays as a language agnostic
format for exchanging data between
computers by language agnostic I mean
you don't have to use JavaScript you can
use python or any other language to read
Json or write it as well and it's a
completely text based format which means
that if I visit that URL with my browser
what gets downloaded is just a bunch of
text but that text is formatted in a
standard way using curly braces and
square brackets using quotes and some
colons that ultimately contains all of
the information in Apple's database on
Weezer's song at least the first one
because I limited it to one in their
database and that's an API an
application programming interface a
mechanism whereby I can access data on
someone else's server and somehow
integrate it into my own program now of
course my browser Chrome is not
something I wrote I should actually
write some python code that perhaps
pretends to be a browser to grab the
same data so let's do that let me go
back to vs code here and let me write a
program with code itunes.pi and we're
going to write some code via which I can
then use the iTunes API and in turn
python to get information about any band
that I might want I'm going to go here
and import first the requests Library
which I installed earlier in order to
make those HTTP requests I'm going to go
ahead and import the sys Library via
which I'll have the ability to use
command line arguments like
specification of the band that I want to
search for if not Weezer and then down
here I'm going to go ahead and insert
some error checking to say if the length
of cis.orgv does not equal 2 so if the
user does not provide me with the name
of the file they want to run and the
name of a band and that's it you know
what let's just go ahead and exit for
now I could provide a more explanatory
message but for now I'm going to keep
things simple and just exit the program
prematurely so that I can trust
Hereafter that sys.rv has what I want
and now I have the opportunity to use
the requests library to write some
python code that effectively is
pretending to be a web browser so as to
connect to that same https URL on
Apple's own server so now that I've
guaranteed that the user has typed in
not just the name of the file but also
the name of a band at the prompt giving
me a length of two for sys.rv let's go
ahead and execute requests.get which is
a function inside of the requests
package that will literally get some
response from a server and the URL that
I want to get is exactly the same as
before https colon slash
itunes.apple.com search question mark
entity equals song Ampersand limit
equals one Ampersand term equals
previously Weezer but let's make this
program a little interactive and
actually allow the human to specify at
the command line what artist they'd like
to search for so I'm going to go ahead
and close my quote early and just append
using the concatenation operator as in
the past
sis.orgv bracket one and now it'd
actually be nice to store the response
from the server in a variable so I'm
going to go ahead and say response
equals and to store all of the response
that comes back from the server in a
variable called response down here now
I'd like to just understand what the
server is returning to me to make sure I
know how next to proceed so this isn't
going to be very pretty yet but I'm
going to go ahead and print out
response.json which ensures that the
data I'm getting back is formatted on my
screen as exactly that Json the same
text format as we saw on my screen it's
not a useful program yet I'm really just
learning along the way but let me go
ahead now and increase the size of my
terminal window and run python of
itunes.pi and type in the name of a band
like Weezer and hit enter
and what we see on the screen formatted
almost the same as before is exactly
that same text but what you'll see here
is that this has been standardized now
as a python dictionary what indeed
Apple's returning is technically a Json
response JavaScript object notation but
python the requests library is
converting it to a python dictionary
which happens to use wonderfully
coincidentally almost the same syntax it
uses curly braces to represent the
dictionary here and a closed curly brace
to represent the end of it here for any
lists therein it uses a square bracket
here and a closed square bracket down
here it uses quotes single quotes in
this case or equivalently double quotes
to represent the keys in that dictionary
and after a colon it stores the value of
that key and so you'll see that indeed
we have a result count key whose value
is one but then a more interesting
results key called results whose value
is this entire list of data now honestly
this is such a big blob of text that
it's going to take me forever to wrap my
mind around what I'm seeing so let me
propose temporarily we use another
library in Python that will allow me to
format my data a little more cleanly it
turns out that python also comes with a
special Library uh called Json that
allows you to manipulate Json data and
even just printy print it that is
formatted in a way that's going to be
way easier for you and I to understand
so let me go back to my code here let me
shrink my terminal window and let me
propose that just temporarily again we
do this let me import this additional
Library Json which comes with python so
I don't need to install it manually with
Pip and let me go ahead now and not just
print out response.json which was that
Big Blob of hard to understand text let
me go ahead and use one other function
here called Json dot dump s for dump
string and pass to that function that
response.json return value so again I'm
just introducing an another function who
I claim it has a purpose in life of
pretty printing nicely formatting on the
screen the exact same information and I
know this from the documentation having
done this before but I'd like things to
be nicely indented and according to the
documentation if I pass in a named
parameter of indent equals 2 that's
going to indent everything at least two
spaces I could do four or something else
but it's going to be enough to help me
wrap my mind around what the data is I'm
getting back because again I'm just
learning along with you so let me
increase the size of my terminal window
again let me run python of itunes.pi and
again let's search for Weezer and hit
enter and now notice it's still a little
bit cryptic because there's a lot going
on here but my gosh I can totally read
this more easily now notice now that I
still see the first curly brace which
means hey this is a dictionary in Python
a collection of keys and values the
first key is called result count it
happens to be displayed in double quotes
now but that's just an issue of
formatting it could be double or single
so as long as we're consistent the value
of that key is one why well I told the
URL to only limit the responses to one
Weezer song so I've gotten a result set
of one if I increase that limit I could
probably get more then the interesting
part of this response is really the data
itself notice in the results key here
there's a really big value the value is
a python list as implied
by this square bracket what does this
list contain well I know from skimming
it earlier that this contains one
dictionary and that's why we see another
curly brace here
so again if this gets a little more
complicated keep in mind that a
dictionary is just a collection of key
value Pairs and python uses curly braces
to indicate as much it is perfectly
reasonable for a dictionary to be inside
of another dictionary if the value of
some key itself is another dictionary so
this is a common Paradigm and even
though it might seem a bit cryptic it's
just something that allows us to
associate more keys with more values now
most of this information I probably
don't care about for instance according
to Apple the unique identifier for
Weezer is apparently 115
234. that might be useful if I'm making
my own database and I want this to be
searchable but for today's purposes all
I care about is the name of the track
otherwise called track name as key and
the first song and only song because we
limited it to one that we got back from
iTunes here is the song that you might
know by Weezer called say it ain't so
so now I have a bit of a clue if my goal
here is to implement a program called
itunes.pi that doesn't just dump the
response from the server which is
admittedly very cryptic but to print out
all of the songs that iTunes has for the
band called Weezer maybe I can iterate
over this somehow so let me backtrack
here's the key called track name it is
inside of a dictionary that is the value
of results here
so how can I go about getting this well
let me go ahead and try this let me go
ahead and Shrink my terminal window back
down and let me propose now for one
final flourish we don't just lazily
print out the contents of that response
because that's not interesting or pretty
for anyone let's do this let me go ahead
and create a new variable just for the
sake of discussion called o for object
and I'm going to go ahead and call O
equals response dot Json just a store
that Json response specifically in a
variable called o but I could name it
anything I want and now I'm going to do
this
for each result in that object's key
called results go ahead and print out
that result track name and notice I have
used exactly the same capitalization
track name has a capital N results is
all lower case and let me rewind before
we run the actual program in line eight
we are making an HTTP request using
python to the server just like you and I
as humans type URLs into a browser and
hit enter this is the python equivalent
thereof I am then on line 10 just
grabbing from that variable that
contains the server's response the Json
object that I care about the thing
between those curly braces at the very
top and the bottom but because we've
poked around and because I read the
documentation earlier I know that that
object has a key called results and that
results key again is a list now at the
moment that list contains only one song
Say It Ain't So because I limited my
response to one but even so my Loop will
work it's just going to iterate once and
each time through that loop it's going
to print the current results track name
if I want to make this even more
interesting let me change this limit now
from 1 to 50 so I'll at least get back
50 track names instead let me go ahead
now and increase the size of my terminal
once more and go ahead now and run
python of itunes.pi searching again for
a band like Weezer and here we go
and voila there are 50 songs that iTunes
has for Weezer and if we scroll back up
to the top here we'll see that the very
first one there is indeed Say It Ain't
So but now we got undone The Sweater
Song Buddy Holly apparently another
rendition of Say It Ain't So perhaps
from another album another Buddy Holly
undone my name is Jonas and so forth
questions now on this program which
integrates python with a real world
third-party API
yeah hi uh can we use break instead of
system.exist exit good question but no
break again is used to break out of
things like Loops like we saw earlier
sys.exit is used to break out of the
whole program itself use break for Loops
for now and use sys.exit to terminate
the whole program good question
other questions now on this program are
others from where we bring the name of
the key results
from where do we get the name of the key
uh results itself can we change the
results name you cannot you so we could
in our program so the keys that come
back in that Json response to be clear
come from itunes.apple.com some engineer
some team of Engineers decided for us
what all of those keys would be called
including track name results result
count and everything else you and I can
absolutely store those same values in
variables just like I'm doing here with
o just like I'm doing here with result
you can rename those keys anything you
want using python variables but the Json
response is coming from that third-party
server
other questions uh yes sir I have a
question related to to Cow Say package
so like uh yes so sort of what sort of
uh ASCII Graphics uh is it capable of
outputting the cow say package um I
would refer you to the URL in the slides
earlier uh if only because it's more
thorough they have not just cows but
Tyrannosaurus Rexes and several other
animals as well I should emphasize that
this is not a package I suspect you will
use much in the real world it's really
just meant to be representative of the
types of packages you can install but
allow me to refer to the documentation
for what more is there but ASCII art uh
is the all we had before there were
emojis let alone gifs and jpegs and
pings but it's what is immortalized in
cow say well allow me to transition us
back now to one final capability of
python which is that you yourselves have
the ability to make your own libraries
up until now we've been writing all of
our functions in our one file hello pi
and everything since and now that we've
introduced modules in Python like like
random and statistics we can import
those that come with python but that's
other people's code as well and we've
now used Pip this package manager to
install third-party packages as well in
the system and using other people's code
still but to come full circle what if
you yourself find yourself implementing
the same kinds of functions again and
again or you find yourself opening up
old programs copying and pasting code
you wrote into new programs because you
have the same problem yet again a good
practice would be to somehow bundle up
that code you keep reusing and make your
own python module or package you can
keep it local on your own Mac or PC or
Cloud Server or you can go through the
steps of actually bundling it up making
it free and open source and putting it
on something like Pi Pi for others to
use as well okay I'm going to go ahead
and run code of sayings.pi to create a
brand new file called sayings.pi which
is going to be my own sayings module I'm
going to define a couple of simple
functions in there I'm going to define a
hello function that's going to take a
name parameter is input and that
function is simply going to print out an
F string that contains hello comma and
then in curly braces whatever that
person's name actually is then I'm going
to go ahead and Define one other
function a goodbye function that has def
goodbye also takes a name as its input
and then that prints out by contrast an
F string that says goodbye comma and
then in curly braces name and now just
for good measure just so I can be sure
that these functions are working as
expected I'm going to go ahead and
Define a main function in here too just
for the purposes of testing and I'm
going to go ahead and Define a main
function that simply does a couple of
tests for instance it calls uh hello of
quote unquote worlds shall we say and
then it's going to call goodbye of quote
unquote world as well and hopefully what
I'll see on the screen then is hello
world and goodbye world when I run this
program of course as always I need to
explicitly tell python to call that
function so I'm going to call Main at
the very bottom of this file all right
let's try it out python of sayings.pi
enter and indeed I see Hello World and
goodbye world and so I think it's
reasonable for me to assume that these
functions albeit simple are pretty
correct at this point but now suppose
that I want to use these functions as
though I've indeed created my own
Library my own python module that makes
available a hello function for me or
anyone else who wants to use it or a
goodbye function as well well let me go
ahead and open up again say dot Pi but
start fresh and rather than have the cow
say anything let me go ahead and have my
own Library do the talking so I'm going
to go ahead and as before import CIS so
that I have access to command line
arguments and from my own module called
sayings I'm going to import hello so
because I created a file called
sayings.pi I can say from sayings and
it's inferred by python that I mean
sayings.pi at least in this current
directory but I specifically am going to
import just one of the functions for now
namely hello and now I can do something
like this if if the user obliges by
giving me two command line arguments
which I can check by just checking the
length of sys.r V I'm going to then go
ahead and call this new hello function
passing is its input assist.org V
bracket 1 which should hopefully be the
person's name which I'm going to expect
them to type at the prompt so here we go
I'm going to go down to my terminal
window run python of say dot pi and my
own name because I want my own name to
end up in the command line arguments and
therefore be part of the hello so when I
hit enter in just a moment I should
hopefully see hello comma David so here
we go enter
and huh I see Hello World Goodbye World
and then I see hello David so why is
this happening well it turns out even
though I've done everything according to
our own past practice it's not really
the right way to go about calling Maine
after all if I'm blindly calling Maine
here at the bottom of my file that means
whenever this file is loaded by python
Maine is going to get called and
unfortunately that's true even if I'm
importing this file or just a function
from this file as I am here in my say
dot Pi program this is to say on line
three here when I say from sayings
import hello this effectively tells
python to go find that module sayings.pi
read it from top to bottom left to right
and then import specifically the hello
function unfortunately by the time
python has read the file from top to
bottom left to right that last line of
code recall is to call main main gets
called No Matter What so really the
right way to go about using a main
function which does solve that problem
of ensuring that we can order our
functions however we want and all the
functions will be defined at the time
they're invoked I shouldn't be
unconditionally calling main at the
bottom of this or really any of my
programs I should instead use this
technique I should say if underscore
underscore name underscore underscore
equals equals quote unquote underscore
underscore main underscore underscore
close quote then and only then should
you actually call Main well it turns out
that this variable is a special symbol
in Python underscore underscore name
underscore underscore and notice that vs
code because of its font isn't quite
showing those two underscores but
they're indeed there to the left and the
right this is a special variable whose
value is automatically set by python to
be quote unquote main when you run a
file from the command line as by running
python of sayings.pi so Watch What
Happens now with this additional
conditional in sayings.pi if I run
python of sayings.pi it's still works as
before because name will be
automatically set to underscore
underscore main underscore underscore
when I run this file using python of
sayings.pi but notice this name is not
going to be set to quote unquote main
it's going to be set to something else
technically the name of the module when
I instead import the file like I do here
so this highlighted line of code even
though it will cause python to go find
sayings.pi read it from top to bottom
left to right it's going to ignore the
call to main this time because it's
wrapped in that conditional in this case
when I'm importing a file and not
running it directly at the command line
main will not get called by definition
of that name's value so let me go ahead
and try this instead of running python
of sayings.pi which is the module which
contains that conditional main let me go
ahead here on run python of say dot Pi
which is the program here before me that
Imports hello from sayings but because
of that conditional it's not going to
say it hello to anyone else except
me in this case all right we're here at
the end of our week it's only
appropriate I think to import something
other than hello why don't I go ahead
and import not hello but goodbye from
here let me go ahead and call goodbye
instead of hello and this time when I
run python of say.pi I'm not going to
type my own name allow me if I may to
type in the whole world so that our
final sentiment today is goodbye World
indeed that's it for this week we will
see you next time
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
this is cs50's Introduction to
programming with python my name is David
Malin and this is our week on unit tests
up until now we've been writing a lot of
code and you might have been testing
your code by running your program and
passing in some sample inputs and
running it again and passing in some
sample inputs or you might have been
waiting for us to test your code instead
but it's actually much better practice
to get into the habits sooner rather
than later of testing your own code
using Code of your own in fact whether
you're writing a personal project or
working in industry it's very common
nowadays to not only write code to solve
the problems that you want to solve but
also to write a little extra code to
test the code that you wrote and that's
what we're going to focus on today
writing our own tests so as to be all
the more confident all the more certain
that the problems we have been trying to
solve are in fact solved correctly so
let's rewind a few weeks now to a
program we wrote a while back namely to
to calculate uh numbers and specifically
we left off with this calculator on
trying to compute the power of a number
like x squared or where X might be two
or three or some other number as well
well let me go ahead and resurrect that
file by going into my terminal window
here and running again code of
calculator dot pi and let me go ahead
and pick up where we left off way back
when by defining a main function here
and then in my main function I did
something like this I said x equals int
of input and I asked the user what's X
question mark and then I immediately
went ahead and printed out something
like x squared is and then I passed in
as a second argument to print the result
of calling a function called Square
passing in that value X now of course I
haven't yet implemented the square
function so let's define that as well
let me go down a couple of lines and
Define square and it takes an argument
recall a parameter that at the time I
called n for number so I'll do that
again so I could technically choose any
name for this variable and I recall did
this I returned n times n and there were
multiple ways to do this the squaring a
number is multiplying it by itself so I
could also use other syntax here but
this is what we ultimately settled on
and then recall that I ultimately called
Main in order to kick off the process of
running this program so just as a test
manually let me go ahead and run python
of calculator.pi and hit enter what's X
let's start with two all right x squared
is four I think that's correct so let's
run it again just for good measure
python of calculator.pi let's type in 3
for X this time x squared is nine and I
think that's correct and I might be
feeling pretty good at this point and I
go off and submit my code to a course or
I post it on the internet for others to
use but I haven't really methodically
tested this code and it's not
necessarily the case that it works
entirely in fact I haven't really
considered a number of corner cases I
went with some pretty obvious numbers
like two and three but what about zero
what about negative numbers what about
any number of other infinite numbers
well we're not going to test an infinite
number of inputs to this because the
program would never halt but we should
test some representative inputs
ultimately but before we do that let's
get into the habit of making sure that
Maine isn't always called let's adopt
this habit again of doing if underscore
underscore name underscore underscore
equals equals quote unquote underscore
underscore main underscore underscore
only then should we execute Main and I'm
doing this now proactively because I
want to make sure that when I import my
Square function perhaps from another
library from another file treating it as
though it's a library I want to make
sure that main is not just automatically
called itself now what do I want to do
from here now that I've modified this
program as follows well let's go ahead
and write a completely different program
whose sole purpose in life is to now
test this program so I've got my actual
calculator and calculator.pi I've
readied myself to call Main
conditionally so that I can safely
import one or more things from this file
in another file well what should I that
other file being well by convention I'm
going to create a file that's called
test underscore and then because the
thing I'm testing is this calculator
itself let's call this file test
calculator dot Pi that's going to give
me a new tab in which I can write a
brand new program whose purpose in life
is now specifically to test that program
but really that program specific
functionality built into that program is
the square function let's focus on
testing that function all right so how
do I access that function in this
program well recall that I can import a
function from another file as though
it's a library of my own a so-called
module so I'm going to do this from
calculator import Square
I could go ahead and just import Square
itself but then I would have to prefix
my use of square recall by saying
calculator dot everywhere and it's just
a little cleaner to just import the one
function and now let me go ahead and do
this let me go ahead and Define a
function called test Square this two is
a convention if you want to test a
function called Square your function for
testing should be called test underscore
square or alternatively you could do
Square underscore test but I'll adopt
this convention here now what kind of
tests can we do well I don't dislike the
test I ran earlier testing x equals 2
and x equals 3 but every time I want to
test my program previously I would have
to do that manually and that's going to
get tedious it's not going to be easy
for someone else to test it and if I'm
actually working in the real world it
would be nice if I could automatically
have my program tested again and again
by having some automated process run mic
own code so let's do that and take the
human ultimately out of the equation so
how might I go about testing the square
function that I've now imported per line
one well in my test Square function why
do I do this if the result of calling
square of 2 does not equal 4 why don't
we go ahead and print an error message
because I know that in the real world 2
squared should equal 4 so if square of 2
does not equal 4 there's a bug in my
program there's a bug in my function
I've made a mistake so let me go ahead
and print something like that so I or
someone else knows 2 squared was not 4
for instance so I could print out
anything here what should I maybe next
test well let's do more than one test
let's say if the square of 3 does not
equal 3 squared 9 then let's go ahead
and print out that 3 squared was not 9.
so I haven't done any more testing than
I did earlier but I've baked those two
tests x equals two and x equals 3 into
my own code here so I can now run those
tests automatically if you will now it's
not enough to just Define a function
called test Square I actually if I want
to run this function need to call it
somehow in our convention for doing that
is the same as always in this function
here in this file too let me Define Main
and Main sole purpose in life is going
to be to test square and now at the
bottom of this file as before let me go
ahead and adopt my Convention of if
underscore underscore name underscore
underscore equals equals quote unquote
underscore underscore main underscore
underscore then go ahead and call Main
so a lot of this is just boilerplate
like we've seen this before defining a
main function and calling a function to
kick off some process now adding the
conditional at the bottom of the file to
make sure I'm only conditionally calling
main just in case I import anything from
this file elsewhere so let's see let's
go ahead and test my code now let me go
ahead and run test calculator with
python and hit enter and nothing outputs
nothing outputs but I think it's okay I
think no output is good because look at
my test Square function I'm not printing
anything if all seems well so let's
let's demonstrate as much by going back
to my calculator and let me break it let
me introduce a bug maybe I didn't even
get it right the first time maybe my
code originally looked like this I
wasn't thinking I forgot my squares and
so I thought that the square of a number
is n plus n instead of n times n so a
reasonable mistake to make perhaps
arithmetically let me now go back to my
test calculator which I'm not going to
change but I am going to rerun it python
of testcalculator.pi I'm going to cross
my fingers here but for naught I'm going
to see immediately that 3 squared was
not 9. now what is it well let's see
when your tests fail how can we put our
finger on what's wrong well it's a
little interesting that I completely
broke my Square function and yet only
one of these tests is failing it looks
like this test lines nine and ten is
fine because I'm not seeing that output
but of course these two lines this test
is failing because 3 squared is not 9
when I'm using plus so just to be clear
here why is my function only partially
broken
just to be clear why am I seeing only
one error instead of two even though the
square function is now mathematically
broken because two plus two is four yeah
I mean it's as simple as that I just got
lucky that two plus two is the same
thing as two times two so this is one of
those Corner cases and this is why it's
good to be in the habit of not just
testing one thing but test several and
make sure you're covering your bases so
to speak so I got lucky here and that
explains why I'm seeing only one error
even though the function itself is
flawed but let me propose that there's
another way we could do this because
honestly if I extrapolate from this
simple example running not just two
tests but three or four or ten or Twenty
tests you can imagine that my God the
code is going to get so much more
complicated than the function itself I
mean already look in calculator.pi the
function in question is two lines long
and yet in test calculator the fun code
in question is five lines long like I've
written more code to test my code than I
actually wrote original code so the
fewer lines of code code we can write
when testing code I think the more
likely you and I are to do it because
it's going to be literally a little less
work and just fewer opportunities for
mistakes so what's another approach I
can take here well it turns out in
Python there is another keyword that we
haven't yet used which is this here
assert assert is a keyword in Python and
some other languages as well that allow
you to do exactly that as in English to
assert that something is true to sort of
boldly claim that something is true and
if it is nothing's going to happen no
errors are going to appear on the screen
but if you assert something in Python
and it is not true that is the thing
you're insert asserting a Boolean
expression is false you're actually
going to see some kind of error on the
screen so let's go ahead and try this
new keyword as follows let me go back to
my code here and just to make it a
little simpler let me propose that I I
use this new keyword as follows let me
simply assert that the square of 2
should equal 4. or so I've changed my
logic instead of checking for not equals
I'm now asserting very loudly that it
should equal four and then on one
additional line let me do the other test
assert that the square of 3 equals
equals nine and that's it no if no
indented print I'm just going to assert
more simply these two things that I want
to be true well let me go ahead now with
calculator.pi still broken I'm still
using plus accidentally instead of
multiplication let me go ahead now and
run python of test calculator dot Pi
crossing my fingers is always but it's
not going to go well this time a whole
lot of Errors seem to appear on the
screen and if I scroll up here for this
traceback we'll see that the thing that
failed was this line here assert square
of 3 equals equals nine now
unfortunately when you're using the
assert keyword it's not terribly user
friendly it shows you the files and the
line numbers involved but it does show
you the specific line of code that
failed the assertion that fail so to
speak it's now kind of up to you and me
to infer from this well wait a minute
why is the square of 3 not equal to nine
so it's not super user friendly but
honestly it was like half as much code
for me to write it's just two lines
instead of those previous four but
notice this little Remnant down here
this was an assertion error and we have
seen errors before we've seen errors
before when we've made other mistakes in
our code and in the past what was our
solution
for catching those errors
how do we catch errors that seem to
resemble this even though we've not seen
this one before
um
yeah in Python we can use the try and
accept keywords to try to do something
optimistically except if something goes
wrong do something else instead so this
is a step forward in that I can at least
catch this error but it's going to be
perhaps a step backward in that I'm
going to end up writing I'll admit in
advance a little more code uh instead so
let me go ahead and try this let me go
back into my code here and instead of
just asserting blindly let me go ahead
as cholo proposed and try to do this
first assertion except if there is an
assertion error like we saw a moment ago
then go ahead and print out something
more user-friendly that explains what
actually failed 2 squared is uh was not
four and let me go ahead similarly and
try to assert that the square of 3
equals nine except if there's an
assertion error there in which case I'm
going to print out more user are
friendly 3 squared was not 9. so I've
taken a step forward but also a step
back because now I have more code but I
have at least introduced assertions and
exceptions in a manner consistent with
how we've seen in the past when
something goes wrong you actually see an
exception raised well let me go ahead
and run this version of the program now
instead python of testcalculator.pi
crossing my fingers all right it still
failed because I'm seeing output but
we're back to at least user friendly
output so that's at least progress in
some way here but it's again more code
than might have been ideal and in fact
if we continue this further what if we
actually want to add additional test
cases here as well well it seems like we
might end up writing way more code than
would be ideal for instance where I'm
testing two and three now I should
probably test some negative numbers as
well so why don't I go ahead and add in
for instance let me go ahead and copy
and paste this let me try to assert that
the square of negative 2 equals equals 4
which should be the case mathematically
and if not let me go ahead and change
this to say negative 2 squared was not 4
and you know what let me go ahead and
copy paste this again test another
negative number just for good measure
Let's test the square of negative 3
which should equal 9 but if it doesn't
let's go ahead and say that negative 3
squared was not 9 and just to think
aloud here what might be another good
value to test I've tried two I've tried
three I've tried negative two I've tried
negative three I can't try in infinite
numbers but there's at least something
that's a little different in between
those values let's try zero zero is an
interest in case two just in case
something might be wrong and Y zero I'm
just going with instincts here right
odds are positive numbers are generally
going to behave the same negative
numbers might generally behave the same
zero might be a little anomalous there's
no uh science to it necessarily but
rather considering for yourself based on
your own experience like what are the
potential Corner cases based on the
function you're trying to test I'm
trying to test something mathematical so
I want to test representative values so
let me go ahead and paste in one more
try except block let's assert that the
square of zero should equal zero and if
not I'll say something explanatory like
zero squared was not zero now if I go
ahead and run this python of test
calculator dot pi and hit enter now I
see multiple errors and this is
interesting it's a bit of a clue because
notice that sum but not all of these
assertions are failing the one for two
squared is apparently okay as we noted
earlier recall that 2 squared happens to
be 2 plus 2 so that bug doesn't really
throw off our test but it's a good thing
we tested for three it's a good thing we
tested for negative two and negative
three because all of those tests caught
this error the zero test did not notice
because 0 squared is of course zero but
zero plus zero is zero so we're getting
lucky or unlucky there depending on how
you you view the glass is half full or
half empty here we at least by way of
having multiple tests caught this
mistake somehow so it would be nice
though if we weren't writing so much
darn code here right because notice what
I've done I have try accept try except I
have all of these assertions I have a
main function I have this if conditional
at the bottom of my file I mean honestly
who's going to want to write 31 lines of
code now just to test a two-line
function right no one's going to write
test code like this if we're all writing
so much more code to do the actual
testing so people have solved this
problem if you are in the habit of
testing your code a lot or wanting to if
I'm in the habit of wanting to test my
code a lot if everyone else in the real
world is in this habit of wanting to
test their code why don't we create
tools that make it a little easier to do
so and in fact there is a mechanism for
doing this whereby we can use a tool
that's popularly called Pi test so Pi
test is a third party program that you
can download and install that will
automate the testing of your code so
long as you write the tests but what's
nice about this library and others like
it is that it adopts some conventions so
that you don't have to write as many
lines of code code yourself manually
they do some of that automatically for
you now this is a third party Library
there's other libraries for unit tests
so to speak that is testing units of
your code some of them come with python
itself we're proposing that we look at
Pi test today because it's actually a
little simpler than the unit testing
Frameworks they come with python itself
and what do we mean by unit testing unit
testing is just a formal way of
describing testing individual units of
your program what are those individual
units they're typically functions so
unit tests are typically tests for
functions that you have written now what
does this mean in practice here well let
me go back to my vs code here and let me
propose that we simplify my test
calculator significantly I'm going to go
ahead and delete all of these tests
which were
which were accumulating to like 31 lines
of code and let's see if we can distill
the tests to their Essence using pi test
from my same calculator program let me
still import Square so I do still need
that line of code so that I can test
that specific function now I'm going to
go ahead and Define a function just like
I did before as follows I'm going to
define a function called test Square
Again by convention test underscore and
the name of the function you want to
test though it doesn't have to be that
way and now I'm going to go ahead and
make a few assertions I'm going to
assert that the square of 2 should equal
4. I'm going to assert that the square
of 3 should equal 9. I'm going to assert
that the square of negative 2 should
equal 4 and I'm going to insert that the
square of negative 3 should equal 9 and
lastly for now I'm going to assert that
the square of 0 should equal 0. so I'm
still using the assert keyword as I
introduced earlier and even though it
was a little tedious to type those I
mean it's only eight lines of code now
and they're so easy to type it's not try
and accept in all of this wouldn't it be
nice if something else someone else
handled the try the accept the printing
all of the standardization of actually
running these tests and that that's
where indeed Pi test comes into play per
the documentation for pi test which can
itself be installed with Pip install Pi
test which we've used to install other
libraries in the past you can look at
the documentation here for all of its
formal usage but fortunately Pi test is
pretty user friendly as testing
Frameworks go and it actually allows us
to Dive Right In by just running Pi test
on the code that we've written so if I
go back to vs code here and look at my
test calculator.pi which notice has no
main function anymore it has no
conditional it has no tries it has no
accepts it has no prints it just has my
few assertions Pi test and other
libraries like it are going to automate
the process of running these tests for
me and informing me on the screen
whether or not any of those tests failed
so let me go ahead and do this I'm going
to go ahead and increase the size of my
terminal window for a moment just so we
can see more on the screen and I'm going
to run not python as I've been doing I'm
going to run Pi test which again is this
third party tool for running tests in
your code I'm going to run Pi test of
test underscore calculator so that same
file I'm going to cross my fingers as
always and hit enter and we'll see that
ah something has failed now admittedly
even though I do think you'll find that
Pi test is relatively simple to use its
output at least at first glance is not
necessarily super user friendly so what
are we seeing here well notice at the
very top of my window is the command
that I ran after my prompt right below
that is a single F in red which means
fail so not very encouraging I tried
really hard here but fail is my grade on
this program but let's see exactly what
happened well if I look at this excerpt
here under failures you'll see that test
square is the function that failed all
right that makes sense because that's
the only one I wrote and you'll see here
somewhat uh Arcane output describing
what the error was so what you're seeing
here is the first line of output equals
equals four which is fine there's no red
error message below that so that one's
okay but this line of code here insert
that square of 3 equals equals nine Pi
test did not like that assertion because
it didn't end up being true in fact per
the red e at the start of this line
You'll see that I'm effectively trying
to assert that 6 equals equals nine now
where did the six come from okay wait a
minute if my test involves this notice
that where 6 equals square of three this
is saying that because I've called
Square passing in a value of 3 it turns
out its return value is 6 and of course
mathematically 6 does not equal equal
nine so that's why this is failing now
Pi test is not as user friendly as
telling you exactly why the bug is there
or how to fix it this is really just a
clue to you what must be wrong what
you're seeing here is a clue that the
first test passed because there's no red
error below that line of code but this
test failed somehow or other your Square
function is returning six when passed in
three instead of nine so at this point
you sort of put your detective hat on
you go back to your actual code and you
think about in calculator.pi how in the
world is line seven of my square
function returning 6 instead of nine and
at this point odds are the light bulb
would go off above your head proverbly
and you would see oh I'm using addition
instead of multiplication but what pi
test has done for us is automate the
process of at least pointing out that
error for us and if I now go in and fix
this let me go ahead and the light bulb
has gone off I change the plus to a uh
to a multiply now I'm going to go ahead
and after clearing my screen I'm going
to run not python but Pi test of test
calculator dot Pi crossing my fingers
again and now it's green and I see just
a DOT which indicates that my one and
only test passed I'm good a hundred
percent success with my test now after
fixing that bug all right let me pause
here and see if there's any questions so
my question is what if a user instead of
because we are taking input from the
user what if the user is somewhat
malicious and types in a string instead
of an integer or maybe he types in a
float or some other data type yeah so
what if the user like we've seen in past
examples types in cat instead of a
number when we're expecting an integer
how do we test for something like that
at the moment I'm admittedly not testing
user input if I go back to my code here
notice that my calculator function of
course has the square function that we
keep testing and retesting but notice
that all of the user input is currently
relegated to my main function and
admittedly as of now I am not testing my
main function so there could be one of
those bugs and in fact there would be
because if the user types in a string
like cap instead of an integer like two
or three then line two recall would
actually raise a value error exception
so we've seen that before so when it
comes to testing your code this is
actually a good reason for having
multiple functions in your program
rather than putting all of your logic in
just the file itself rather than putting
all of the logic in just main it's
actually really good really helpful
practice to break your ideas up into
smaller bite-sized functions that
themselves are testable and what do I
mean here square is perfectly testable
why because it takes as input a
parameter called n and it returns as
output in integer which is going to be
the square thereof hopefully it has a
well-defined input and a well-defined
output it is therefore completely within
your control in your test program to
pass in those values now I will say if
you want to test whether
Square behaves properly when passed
something like a string like quote
unquote cat we could absolutely do
something like this assert that the
square of uh quote unquote cat it's not
going to equal something you can
actually using different syntax assert
that a specific exception will be raised
so if we were actually going to go back
into our Square function improve it and
deliberately raise an exception we could
test for that too but for now I'm
deliberately only testing the square
function I'm not testing for specific
user input but that's another problem to
be solved other questions now
on unit tests
to test uh code for
the seats cs50 check so check 50 is
similar in spirit check 50 is a tool
that we cs50 wrote that is essentially
doing something like Pi test for the
evaluation of students code it is
similar in spirit but think of check 50
as being an alternative to Pi test if
you will but it works a little bit
differently but same idea Pi test and
unit testing more generally is a
technique that is independent of cs50
and is something that you can and should
be doing on your own code both in or
outside of this class how about one
other question here on
on um on our uh unit tests my question
is instead of writing four times like s
square of 2 is equal to 4 instead of
that can be read if is it I is equals to
in square brackets the numbers we want
instead of writing four lines a really
good question absolutely right now if I
go back to test calculator.pi it's
indeed pretty manual I mean it took me a
while to say and to type out those
several lines and you can imagine
writing some kind of loop to just assert
in a loop that this equals that that
this equals that and so forth using a
list or using maybe a list or a
dictionary or some structure like that
so yes you can absolutely automate some
of these tests by not just doing the
same thing again and again you can still
use all of the syntax of python to do
loops but generally speaking your tests
should be pretty simple and in fact let
me propose that we improve upon even
this design further because at the
moment what's not really ideal when I
run all of this uh when I run all of
these tests when my function is buggy is
notice the output that I got let me
reintroduce that same bug by changing my
multiplication back to addition let me
increase the size of my terminal window
again and let me run Pi test again of
test calculator.pi so this is the
version of my code now that has the bug
again so I'm going to see that big
massive failure where this failure has
been displayed to me but this is not as
helpful as it could be right because I
have all of those other tests in my code
recall that I had what one two three
four five separate tests and I'm only
seeing the output of the first now why
is that well if we go back to my code
here you'll see that the first assertion
that's failing namely this one here that
assert of square of 3 equals equals nine
the other tests aren't even getting run
and that's not a big deal in the sense
that my code is buggy so one or more of
them are probably going to fail anyway
but wouldn't it be nice to know which of
them are going to fail and and in fact
it's ideal to run as many tests all at
once as possible to give you as many
Clues as possible to finding your bug so
let me propose that we improve the
design of my testing code now still
using pi test as follows instead of
having one big function called test
square that tests the entire function
itself with so many different inputs
let's break down my tests into different
categories and here too there's no one
right way to do this but my mind is
thinking that I should maybe test
positive numbers separately test
negative numbers separately and test
zero separately I could think of other
ways I could test even numbers I could
test odd numbers or maybe some other
pattern altogether but separating this
big test into multiple tests is probably
going to yield more clues for me when
something goes wrong so let me do this
let me go ahead and rename this function
to test positive initially and let me
include in that function only those
first two tests let me then create
another function here called test
negative and in this function and let me
test only negative 2 and negative 3.
then down here let me do one more depth
of test zero and I'll just run one test
in there so I have the same assertions
the same five but I've now divided them
up among three separate functions what's
nice about Pi test and other unit
testing Frameworks is that all three of
these test functions will be run
automatically even if one of them fails
the others will be attempted that means
that if one or two or three of them fail
I'll have one or two or three Clues now
for helping me find that mistake so let
me go ahead and again increase the size
of my terminal window just so we can see
more on the screen my calculator still
has the bug using addition instead of
multiplication let me go ahead and run
not python but again Pi test of
testcalculator.pi crossing my fingers as
always and now oh my God there's even
more errors on the screen but this in
itself is more helpful let's work
through them from top to bottom so under
failures here in all caps which I know
is not very encouraging to see failure
or when you're just trying to solve a
problem but that's what these Frameworks
do under failures the first function
that failed is test positive but here
too we see the same clue as before the
first one two the square of two equals
equals four that one's fine it's not
erring with any red errors but the next
one is failing so I know that square is
broken when I pass in three all right
what about down here it looks like
unfortunately my test negative function
is failing too why well when I pass in
oh this is interesting here now negative
2 doesn't even work so I got lucky with
positive two but negative 2 isn't
working so that's a bit of a clue but in
total only two tests failed so notice at
the very bottom this summary two failed
and one passed what's the other one what
was the third one test zero so test zero
is passing these two are failing and so
that kind of leads me logically
mathematically if you will to the source
of the bug and just to be clear too if
you have a lot of tests this little one
line output is helpful even though also
a bit discouraging fail fail and Dot
means pass so there are the three tests
just depicted graphically a little bit
differently well let me rewind now and
go back into
calculator.pi let's fix that bug because
let's suppose that I've deduced okay I'm
using addition I should have been using
multiplication all this time let me now
after fixing the bug yet again let me go
back to my big terminal let me run Pi
test of test calculator.pi hitting enter
crossing my fingers now and dot dot dot
means all is well a hundred percent of
my tests passed all three of them
so now I'm good it doesn't necessarily
mean that my code is 100 correct but it
does mean that it has passed 100 of my
current tests and so it would probably
behoove us to think a little harder
about maybe we should test bigger
numbers maybe we should test even
smaller numbers maybe we should test
strings or something else the onus is
ultimately on you to decide what you're
going to test but in the real world
you're going to be very unhappy with
yourself or someone else maybe your boss
is going to be very unhappy with you if
you did not catch a bug in your code
which you could have caught had you just
written a test to try that kind of input
all right let me pause again and see if
there's any questions now on unit
testings with pi test
um so if you wanted to test like someone
suggested before user input as well as
testing your function do you do that
within the same file or do you make
separate files for different types of
tests really good question you could
absolutely make separate files to test
different types of things or if you
don't have that many you you can keep
them all in the same file at the moment
I've been storing all of my tests in one
file for convenience and there's not
terribly many of them but we'll take a
look in a bit an example that allows me
to put them into a folder and even run
Pi test on a whole folder of tests as
well so that's possible other questions
on unit testing so I've got two
questions
um so a couple while ago you just used
an exception called Assassin
um I'm not sure what was oh yeah
assertion error
um what exactly does that particular
error catch and my second question is
does the assert keyword
um stand out to the compiler and exactly
tell them to set this particular
um line of code indeed the assert
keyword we're seeing and the assertion
error we saw earlier are intertwined so
when you use assert and the assertion
fails because whatever Boolean
expression you're using is not true it's
false an assertion error by definition
of python will be raised so those two
work in conjunction those errors those
assertion errors are still being raised
by my code here when any of these lines
of code fail however Pi test this
third-party library is handling the
process of catching those exceptions
automatically for me so as to give me
this standard output so we started
today's Story by really implementing
unit testing myself I wrote all of the
code myself I wrote main I did my
conditional I did try and accept
honestly it's going to get incredibly
painful to write tests long term if you
and I have to write that much code every
time especially when our function is
this small so Pi test and you unit
testing Frameworks like it just automate
so much of that essentially Pi test ads
the try the accept the if the prints for
you so you can just focus on the essence
of the tests which really are these
inputs and outputs how about time for
one other question here on unit testing
as well
so uh when we enter
-6 or minus five uh the square or square
square root of that number comes up but
when we put a 6.6 or 5.6 something like
that integer then uh
yeah
light shows the error so what's
happening there so uh if I'm
deliberately testing integers right now
in large part because I only want pow to
operate on integers and that might be
conveyed in Python's documentation or my
own documentation for that function if
you were to pass in something else like
a float it turns out that floating Point
values in Python and other languages are
actually very hard if not impossible to
represent 100 precisely and so if you
are trying to compare it against some
other value they might be slight
rounding errors as a result I'm just
inferring from what you've described but
I'm very deliberately now testing this
function with only the inputs that I
would expect it might indeed throw other
errors if other inputs are passed all
right allow me to propose that we
consider what should happen if Square
isn't actually past a number for
instance if I go back to calculator.pi
and suppose that I or perhaps someone
else using my Square function simply
forgets to convert the return value of
input from a stir to an INT as by
modifying line two here well now
something's definitely going to go wrong
if I type in a stir instead of what
appears to be an INT for instance if I
clear my terminal here run python of
calculator.pi and hit enter let's type
in cat as our value for x and of course
this raises Now a type error why can't
multiply sequence by non-int of type
stir what does that mean well you can't
do cat times cat because indeed square
is expecting that n will be some number
but that doesn't necessarily mean that
square itself is buggy but this does
mean that if I expect a type error to be
raised let's test for that too so that I
know the behavior indeed works as
expected so let me go back to
testcalculator.pi and let me go and add
a fourth test down here how about Define
test underscore and I'll call this test
stir because I'm going to specifically
and deliberately pass in a stir for
testing and I want to in spirit assert
that passing in something like cat to
square will raise a type error but we
don't use the assert keyword word for
that rather we need this let me go to
the top of this file and let me
additionally import the pi test Library
itself because it turns out there's a
function in that Library called raises
that allows me to express that I expect
an exception to be raised and I can
express that as follows with pi test dot
raises and then in parentheses I can
pass in the type of exception I expect
which is going to be a type error in
this case and now when do I expect that
type error to be raised whenever I do
something like calling square and
passing in not a number but something
like cat so now if I go back to my
terminal window run Pi test of test
calculator dot Pi this time having four
tests I should see that all four now are
successful
all right let's now consider how we
could test code that doesn't just expect
numbers as input but actually strings
and let me rewind Us in time here in vs
code to that very first program we wrote
a few different versions of in hello.pi
that ultimately looked a little
something like this I had a main
function that prompted the user for the
value of a variable by asking them
what's your name question mark and then
we went ahead and did something like
hello open paren name passing that
user's name into a function called hello
now that function hello recall
ultimately looked like this we defined
hello as taking a parameter called two
the default value of which was world and
that function very simply printed hello
followed by a comma and then whatever
the name that had been passed in and
then we ultimately called main but for
now onward I'm going to always add this
if conditional if name equals equals
underscore underscore main then and only
then do I want to call Main so that's
essential actually what this program
looked like in its last Incarnation how
do we go about testing it well here
again too I'm not going to test the
user's input per se in Maine I'm going
to focus really on the module the module
of code here that's of Interest which is
the hello function itself how can I go
about testing the hello function well
unfortunately even if I start by doing
something like code of test Hello dot Pi
let me go about and start writing a test
program I could import from my hello
program a function called hello so a bit
strange to see from Hello import hello
but notice that on this line here I'm
importing from the module that is the
file called hello.pi the function Call
To Low and how do I go about testing
this well if I have a function like
Define
test argument like this well let me see
this
so if I were to find a function like
Define test hello what could I do well I
could call hello with quote-unquote say
uh
uh David and then check if it equals
what hello comma David
so with this work this approach here if
I've written a test called test hello
that calls hello with an argument of
David and then tests its return value
just like we've done for our calculator
would this work as written
and let me go back to in just a moment
the version of hello that we're testing
so you can see that function hello
here's the test
here is the actual code
would this test now work
any thoughts uh I think the problem is
that in the first version in Hello dot
Pi you're using the toe argument that
you first declared when you declare the
function instead of using the name
okay I that is actually uh not a bug
here so let me stipulate that in
hello.pi this code actually does work as
intended and let me go ahead and test it
manually just to demonstrate as much let
me run python of hello.pi typing in as
my name d-a-v-i-d and I see in fact that
it says hello David if though I were to
change this program and get rid of the
name argument get rid of the name
variable and just call hello again
running python of hello.pi this time I'm
not even prompted because I got rid of
my input call but it does pre-behave as
I expect it does say hello world so let
me stipulate that this code in its
current form is actually correct but my
test is not going to work as I'd hoped
and there's a subtle difference between
hello versus My Pal function that
explain versus my there's a subtle
difference between my hello function and
my Square function that explains why
might this test not work as intended
because it's not returning a value yeah
exactly recall our discussion early on
about functions functions can either
return a value like my Square function
hands you back the square of some value
or they can have side effects sort of
visual artifacts that might happen on
the screen like printing something out
on the screen and by definition that's
how Print Works notice that hello it is
short but it's implemented ultimately
using the print function which does not
return a value as I'm using it here it
instead has this side effect of printing
something onto the screen so it is not
correct in my test function to check if
the return value of hello equals equals
hello David because again hello is not
returning anything it's printing
something with that side effect but
notice literally it has no return
keyword unlike my Square function which
did so here's an opportunity too to
perhaps change how I go about
implementing my actual functions it
turns out that as your programs get more
and more sophisticated more and more
complicated it tends to be best practice
not not to have side effects if you can
avoid it especially if you want your
code to be testable and in fact I'm
going to propose that we change my hello
program to now work as follows let me go
ahead and change this function to not
print hello and then that name let me go
ahead and literally return maybe an F
string which will clean this up a little
bit hello comma 2 close quote at the end
so my syntax here is just the familiar F
string or format string it's going to
return hello world or hello David or
hello whoever's name is passed in is
that argument but I'm returning it now
I'm not printing it out so what needs to
change up here well I could do something
like this I could say something like
output equals hello and then print
output in my main function or I can
simplify that because I don't really
need that variable I could instead just
do this I could still call hello but I
could immediately print out the result
and this version of my hello program now
is actually more testable why because
these assert statements that we're using
and we've seen thus far for our tests
are really designed to test
arguments into functions and return
values there from not testing side
effects so if you're doing equals equals
you're looking for a return value
something that's handed back from the
function so that's fine if I modify the
design of my program now not to just
print hello but to return the string the
sentence the phrase that I want to
construct I can leave it to the caller
that is the function who's using this
hello function to handle the actual
printing now what does this mean in my
code well it means now if my hello.pi
looks like this and hello is indeed
returning a value in my test to low
function I can test it exactly like this
so let me go ahead and run Pi test of
test hello.pi crossing my fingers as
always and voila one passed so I passed
this test because apparently the return
value of hello does indeed equal hello
comma David well let's test the other
scenario what if I Pat call hello
without any arguments let's assert that
calling hello with nothing in those
parentheses similarly equals hello comma
but world the default value let me now
go ahead and run Pi test of test Hello
dot pi and that too passes entirely but
there too suppose that I had made some
mistakes suppose that there were a bug
in my code it might not be best practice
to combine multiple tests in this one
function so let's make it more clear
what might pass or fail let's call the
first function test the default to this
function and let's only include this
first line of code and then let's go
ahead and Define another function like
test argument to test this other line of
code here so now I have two different
tests Each of which is testing something
a little fundamentally different so now
when I run my code it's still not broken
if I run Pi test of test hello.pi enter
I've now passed two tests and that's
just as good as before but if I did have
a bug having two tests instead of one
would indeed give me perhaps a bit more
of a hint as to what's wrong
questions now on this testing of return
values when these return values are now
strings instead of integers and why
we've done this so my question is about
function inside the function
can we test that too
or recursion we we haven't seen
if you have if you have a recursive
function which we've not discussed in
this class yes you can absolutely test
those two uh by simply calling them
exactly in this way recursion does not
affect this process all right how about
one more question here on unit test
before we look at one final example when
testing our uh arguments like uh can we
use something like a Loops or inside of
assets or for the values absolutely you
can absolutely use a loop to test
multiple values in this case for in I
could do something like this I could say
for name in The Following list of
Hermione
uh say Harry
and Ron
I could then within this Loop assert
that hello of that given name equals
equals say the format string of hello
comma name and then run all of these
here at once by running again Pi test of
test hello.pi it's still going to be
just one test within that function but
if there's something interesting about
those several strings that makes it
compelling to test all of them you can
absolutely automate the tests in that
way with that said each of your tests
should ideally be pretty simple and
pretty small why because you don't want
to write so much code so much
complicated code that your tests might
be flawed what we don't want to have to
do is write tests for our tests and test
for our tests for our test because it
would never end so keeping tests nice
and simple is really the goal so that a
reasonable human yourself included can
eyeball them and just claim yeah that is
correct we don't need tests for our
tests all right how about one other
feature suppose that we don't have just
one test but many different tests
instead and we want to start to organize
those tests into multiple files and even
a folder well Pi test and other
Frameworks support that Paradigm as well
in fact let me go ahead and test
hello.pi using a folder of tests with
technically just one test but it'll be
representative of having even more in
that folder I'm going to go ahead and
create a new folder called test using
make dir at my command line and then
within that file I'm within that and
then within that folder I'm going to go
ahead and create a file called test
Hello dot Pi within this file meanwhile
I'm going to test the same things I'm
going to go ahead and from Hello import
hello
and I'm going to go ahead and Define a
function like test default that simply
tests the scenario where hello with no
arguments returns hello comma world and
I'm going to have that other function
where I test that an argument is passed
and in this case I'll choose an argument
like asserting that hello quote unquote
David equals indeed hello comma not
world but David So in this case I've
just recreated the same test as earlier
but they're in a file now in a folder
called test well Pi test allows me to
run these here too but to do so I
actually need to create one other file
within my test directory I need to
create a file called underscore
underscore init underscore underscore
dot Pi which has the effect even if this
file is empty of telling python to treat
that folder as not just a module but a
package so to speak a package is a
python module or multiple modules that
are organized inside of a folder and
this file under underscore underscore in
it underscore underscore Pi is just a
visual indicator to python that indeed
it should treat that folder as a package
if I had more code in this folder I
could do even more things with this file
but for now it's just a clue that it's
indeed meant to be a package and not
just a module or file alone what I can
now do in closing is run Pi test not
even on that specific file but on a
whole folder of tests so if I run Pi
test of test where the test is the name
of that folder Pi test will
automatically search through that folder
looking for all possible tests granted
there's just those two in this one file
but when I run it now with enter I'll
still pass those tests I'll still get a
hundred percent and I now have a
mechanism ultimately for testing my own
code so whether you're writing functions
that return integers or something else
functions that have side effects that
could be Rewritten as functions that
return values you now have a mechanism
to not just wait for one someone like us
to test your code and not just test your
code manually again and again which
might get tedious and you might make
Mistakes by not including some possible
inputs we now have an automated
mechanism for testing one's own code
that's going to be even more powerful
when you start collaborating with others
so that you can write tests that ensure
that if they make a change to the same
code they haven't broken the code that
you've written alright that's it for
this week we'll see you next time
[Music]
thank you
all right this is cs50's Introduction to
programming with python my name is David
Malin and this is our week on file IO
input and output of files so up until
now most every program we've written
just stores all the information that it
collects in memory that is in variables
or inside of the program itself a
downside of which is that as soon as the
program exits anything you typed in
anything that you did with that program
is lost now with files of course on your
Mac or PC you can hang on to information
long term and file i o within the
context of programming is all about
writing code that can read from that is
load information from or write to that
is save information to files themselves
so let's see if we can't transition them
from only using memory and variables and
the like to actually writing code that
saves some files for us and therefore
data persistently well to do this let me
propose that we first consider a
familiar data structure a familiar type
of variable that we've seen before that
of a list and using lists we've been
able to store more than one piece of
information in the past using one
variable we typically store one value
but if that variable is a list we can
store multiple values unfortunately
lists are stored in the computer's
memory and so once your program exits
even the contents of those disappear but
let's at least give ourselves a starting
point so I'm over here in vs code and
I'm going to go ahead and create a
simple program using Code of names dot
Pi a program that just collects people's
names students names if you will and I'm
going to do it super simply initially in
a manner consistent with what we've done
in the past to get user input and print
it back out I'm going to say something
like this name equals input quote
unquote what's your name thereby storing
in a variable called name the return
value of input as always and as always
I'm going to go ahead and very simply
print out a nice F string that says
hello comma and then in curly brace's
name to print out hello David hello
world however it happens to be using the
program let me go ahead and run this
just to remind myself what I should
expect and if I run python of names.pi
and hit enter type in my name like David
of course I now see hello comma David so
suppose though that we wanted to add
support not just for one name but
multiple names maybe three names for the
sake of discussion so that we can begin
to accumulate some amount of information
in the program such that it's really
going to be a downside if we keep
throwing it away once the program exits
well let me go back into names.pi up
here at top let me proactively give
myself a variable this time called names
plural and set it equal to an empty list
recall that the square bracket notation
especially if nothing's inside of it
just means give me an empty list that we
can add things to over time well what do
we want to add to it well let's add
three names each from the user and let
me say something like this for
underscore in range of three let me go
ahead and prompt the user with the input
function and getting their name in this
variable and then using list syntax I
can say names dot append name to that
list and now I have in that list that
given name one two three of them other
points to note is I could use a variable
here like I which is conventional but if
I'm not actually using I explicitly on
any subsequent lines I might as well
just use underscore which is a pythonic
convention and actually if I want to
clean this up a little bit right now
notice that my name variable doesn't
really need to exist because I'm
assigning it a value and then
immediately appending it well I could
tighten this up further by just getting
rid of that variable altogether and just
appending immediately the return value
of input I think we could go both ways
in terms of design here on the one hand
it's a pretty short line and it's
readable on the other hand if I were to
eventually change this phrase to be not
what's your name but something longer we
might want to break it out again into
two lines but for now I think it's
pretty readable now later in the program
let's just go ahead and print out those
same names but let's sort them
alphabetically so that it makes sense to
be gathering them all together then
sorting them and printing them so how
can I do that well in Python the
simplest way to sort a list in a loop is
probably to do something like this for
name in names but wait let's sort the
names first recall that there's a
function called sorted which will return
a sorted version of that list now let's
go ahead and print out an F string that
says again hello bracket name close
quotes all right let me go ahead and run
this so python of names dot pi and let
me go ahead and type in a few names this
time how about Hermione
how about Harry how about Ron and notice
that they're not quite in alphabetical
order but when I hit enter and that Loop
kicks in it's going to print out hello
Harry hello Hermione hello Ron in sorted
order
but of course now if I run this program
again all of the names are lost and if
this is a bigger program than this that
might actually be pretty painful to have
to re-input the same information again
and again and again wouldn't it be nice
like most any program today on a phone
or a laptop or desktop or Cloud to be
able to save this information somehow
instead and that's where file i o comes
in and that's where Files come in they
are a way of storing information
persistently on your own phone or Mac or
PC or some Cloud servers disk so that
they're there when you come back and run
the program again so how can we go about
saving all three of these names on in a
file as opposed to having to type them
again and again let me go ahead and
simplify this file and again give myself
just a single variable called name and
set the return value of input equal to
that variable so what's your name as
before quote unquote and now let me go
ahead and let me do something more with
this value instead of just adding it to
a list or printing it immediately out
let's save the value of the person's
name that's just been typed in to a file
well how do we go about doing that well
in Python there's this function called
open whose purpose in life is to do just
that to open a file but to open it up
programmatically so that you the
programmer can actually read information
from it or write information to it so
open is like the programmer's equivalent
of like double clicking on an icon on
your Mac or PC but it's a programmer's
technique because it's going to allow
you to specify exactly what you want to
read from or write to that file formally
its documentation is here and you'll see
that its usage is relatively
straightforward it minimally just
requires the name of the file that we
want to open and optionally how we want
to open it so let me go back to vs code
here and let me propose now that I do
this I'm going to go ahead and call this
function called open passing in an
argument for names.txt which is the name
of the file I would like to store all of
these names in I could call it anything
I want but because it's going to be just
text it's conventional to call it
something.txt but I'm also going to tell
the open function that I plan to write
to this file so as a second argument to
open I'm going to put literally quote
unquote W for right and that's going to
tell open to open the file in a way
that's going to allow me to change the
contents and better yet if it doesn't
even exist yet it's going to create the
file for me now open returns what's
called a file handle a special value
that allows me to access that file
subsequently so I'm going to go ahead
and sign it equal to a variable like
file and now I'm going to go ahead and
quite simply write this person's name to
that file so I'm going to literally type
file which is the variable a linking to
that file dot write which is a function
otherwise known as a method that comes
with open files that allows me to write
that name to the file and then lastly
I'm going to quite simply going to go
ahead and say file Dot close which will
close and effectively save the file so
these three lines of code here are
essentially the programmers equivalent
to like double clicking an icon on your
Mac or PC making some changes in
Microsoft's word or some other program
and going to file save we're doing that
all in code with just these three lines
here well let's see now how this works
let me go ahead now and run python of
names.pi
and enter let's type in a name I'll type
in Hermione
enter all right where did she end up
well let me go ahead now and type code
of names.txt which is a file that
happens now to exist because I opened it
in right mode and if I open this in a
tab we'll see there's Hermione well
let's go ahead and run names.pi once
more I'm going to go ahead and run
python of names.pi enter and this time
I'll type in Harry let me go ahead and
run it one more time and this time I'll
type in Ron and now let me go up to
names.text where hopefully I'll see all
three of them here
but no I've just actually seen Ron
What might explain what happened to
Hermione and Harry even though I'm
pretty sure I ran the program three
times and I definitely wrote the code
that writes their name to that file
what's going on here do you think I
think because we're not appending them
we should append the names since we are
writing directly it is erasing the old
content and it is replacing with the
last uh
set of characters that we mentioned
exactly unfortunately quote-unquote W is
a little dangerous not only will it
create the file for you it will also
recreate the file for you every time you
open the file in that mode so if you
open the file once and write Hermione
that worked just fine as we saw but if
you do it again for Harry if you do it
again for Ron the code is working but
each time it's opening the file and
recreating it with brand new contents so
we had one version with Hermione one
version with Harry and one final version
with Ron but ideally I think we probably
want to be appending as Vishal says each
of those names to the file not just
clobbering that is overwriting the file
each time so how can I do this it's
actually a relatively easy fix let me go
ahead and do this as follows I'm going
to first remove the old version of
names.txt and now I'm going to change my
code to do this I'm going to change the
W quote unquote to just a quote unquote
a for append which means to add to the
bottom to the bottom to the bottom again
and again now let me go ahead and rerun
python of names.pi and enter I'll again
start from scratch with Hermione because
I'm creating the file new notice that if
I now do code of names.txt enter we do
see that Hermione is back so we've after
removing the file it did get recreated
even though I'm using append which is
good but now let's see what happens when
I go back to my terminal and this time I
run python of names.pi again this time
typing in Harry and let me run it one
more time this time typing in Ron so
hopefully this time in that second tab
names.text I should now see all three of
them but but but
this doesn't look ideal what have I
clearly done wrong
something tells me even though all three
names are there it's not going to be
easy to read those back unless you know
where each name ends and begins
[Music]
the English format is not correctly it's
concatenating then it is it's it can
it's well it appears to be concatenating
but technically speaking it's just
appending to the file first Hermione
then Harry then Ron it has the effect of
combining them back to back but it's not
concatenating per se it really is just
appending let's go to another hand here
what really have I done wrong or
equivalently how might I fix
it would be nice if there were some kind
of gaps between each of the names so we
could read them more cleanly Hello uh we
should add a new line before we write
your name good we want to add a new line
ourselves so whereas print by default
recall always outputs automatically a
line ending of backslash n unless we
override it with the named parameter
called end write does not do that right
takes you literally and if you say right
Hermione that's it you're getting the H
through the E if you say right Harry you
get the H through the uh y you don't get
any extra new lines automatically so if
you want to have a new line at the end
of each of these names we've got to do
that manually so let me again close
names.txt and let me remove the current
file and let me go back up to my code
here and I can fix this in any number of
ways but I'm just going to go ahead and
do this I'm going to write out an F
string that contains name and backslash
n at the end we could do this in
different ways we could manually print
just the new line or some other
technique week but I'm going to go ahead
and use my f strings as I'm in the habit
of doing and just print to the name and
the new line all at once I'm going to go
ahead now and down to my terminal window
run python of names dot Pi again enter
we'll type in Hermione I'm going to run
it again type in Harry I'm going to type
it again and this time Ron now I'm going
to run code of names.txt and open that
file and now it looks like the file is a
bit cleaner indeed I have each of the
name on its own line as well as a line
ending which ensures that we can
separate one from the other now if I
were you know writing code I bet I could
parse that is read the previous file by
looking at differences between lowercase
and uppercase letters but that's going
to get messy quickly generally speaking
when storing data long term in a file
you should probably do it somehow
cleanly like doing one name at a time
well let's now go back and I'll propose
that this code is now working correctly
but we can design it a little bit better
it turns out that it's all too easy when
writing code to sometimes forget to
close files and sometimes this isn't
necessarily a big deal but sometimes it
can create problems files could get
corrupted or accidentally deleted or the
liked depending on what happens in your
code so it turns out that you don't
strictly need to call close on the file
yourself if you take another approach
instead more pythonic when manipulating
files is to do this to introduce this
other keyword called quite simply with
that allows you to specify that in this
context I want you to open and
automatically close some file so how do
we use with it simply looks like this
let me go back to my code here I've
gotten rid of the close line and I'm now
just going to say this instead instead
of saying file equals open I'm going to
say with open then the same arguments as
before and somewhat curiously I'm going
to put the variable at the end of the
line why that's just the way this is
done you say with you call the function
in question and then you say as and
specify the name of the variable that
should be assigned find the return value
of open then I'm going to go ahead and
indent the line underneath so that the
line of code that's writing the name is
now in the context of this with
statement which just ensures that
automatically if I had more code in this
file down below no longer indented the
file would be automatically closed as
soon as line 4 is done executing so it
doesn't change what has just happened
but it does automate the process of at
least closing things for us just to
ensure I don't forget and so that
something doesn't go wrong
but suppose now that I wanted to read
these names from the file all I've done
thus far is write code that writes names
to the file but let's assume now that we
have all of these names in the file and
heck let's go ahead and add one more let
me go ahead and run this one more time
python of names.pi and let's add in
Draco to the mix so now that we have all
four of these names here how might we
want to read them back well let me
propose that we go into names.pi now or
we could create another program
altogether but I'm going to keep reusing
the same name just to keep us focused on
this and now I'm going to write code
that reads an existing file with
Hermione Harry Ron and Draco together
and how do I do this well it's similar
in spirit I'm going to start this time
with with open and then the first
argument is going to be the name of the
file that I want to open as before and
I'm going to open it this time in read
mode quote on quote R and to read a file
just means to load it not to save it and
I'm going to name the return value file
and now I'm going to do this yes and
there's a number of ways I can do this
but one way to read all of the lines
from the file at once would be this let
me declare a variable called lines let
me access that file and call a function
or a method that comes with it called
read lines so if you read the
documentation on file i o and python
you'll see that open files come with a
special method whose purpose in life is
to read all the lines from the file and
return them to me as a list so what this
line 2 is doing is it's reading all of
the lines from that file storing them in
a variable called lines now suppose I
want to iterate over all of those lines
and print out each of those names for
line in lines this is just a standard
for Loop in Python lines as a list line
is the variable that will be
automatically be set to each of those
lines let me go ahead and print out
something like oh hello
comma and then I'll print out the line
itself
alright so let me go to my terminal
window run python of names.pi now I have
not deleted names.txt so it still
contains all four of those names and hit
enter and okay it's not bad but it's a
little ugly here
what's going on when I ran names.pi it's
saying hello to Hermione to Harry to Ron
to Draco but there's these gaps now
between the lines
what's explains that symptom if if
nothing else it just looks ugly it
happens because in the text file we have
new line symbols uh in between those
names and the print always adds another
new line at the end so you you use the
same symbol twice perfect and here's a
good example of a bug a mistake in a
program but if you just think about
those first principles like how do each
of the lines of code work that I'm using
you should be able to reason exactly as
we're fall did there to say that all
right well one of those new lines is
coming from the file after each name and
then of course print all of these Weeks
Later is still giving us for free that
extra new line so there's a couple of
possible solutions I could certainly do
this which we've done in the past and
pass in a named argument to print like
end equals quote unquote and that's fine
I would argue a little better than that
might actually be to do this to strip
off of the end of the line the actual
new line itself so that print is
handling the printing of everything the
person's name game as well as the new
line but you're just stripping off what
is really just an implementation detail
in the file we chose to use new lines in
my text file to separate one name from
another so arguably it should be a
little cleaner in terms of design to
strip that off and then let print print
out what is really just now a name but
that's ultimately a design decision the
effect is going to be exactly the same
well if I'm going to open this file and
read all the lines and then iterate over
all of those lines and print them each
out I could actually combine this into
one thing because right now I'm doing
twice as much work I'm reading all of
the lines then I'm iterating over all of
the lines just to print out each of them
well in Python with files you can
actually do this I'm going to erase
almost all of these lines now keeping
only the with statement at top and
inside of this with statement I'm going
to say this for line in file go ahead
and print out quote unquote hello comma
and then line Dot R strip so I'm going
to take the approach of stripping off
the end of the line but notice how
elegant this is so to speak I've opened
the file in line one and if I want to
iterate over every line in the file I
don't have to very explicitly load all
read all the lines then iterate over all
of the lines I can combine this into one
thought it in Python you can simply say
for line and file and that's going to
have the effect of giving you a for Loop
that iterates over every line in the
file one at a time and on each iteration
updating the value of this variable line
to be Hermione then Harry then Ron then
Draco so this again is one of the
appealing aspects of python is that it
reads rather like English for line and
file print this it's a little more
compact when written this way well what
if though
I don't want quite this Behavior because
notice now if I run python of names.pi
it's correct I'm seeing each of the
names and each of the hellos and there's
no Extra Spaces in between but just to
be difficult I'd really like us to be
sorting these hellos really I'd like to
see Draco first then Harry then Hermione
then Ron no matter what order they
appear in the file so I could go in of
course to the file and manually change
the file but if that file is changing
over time based on who is typing their
name into the program that's not really
a good solution in code I should be able
to load the file no matter what it looks
like and just sort it all at once now
here is a reason to not do what I've
just done I can't iterate over each line
in the file and print it out but sort
everything in advance right logically if
I'm looking at each line one at a time
and printing it out it's too late to
sort I really need to read all of the
lines first without printing them sort
them then print them so we have to take
a step back in order to add now now this
new feature so how can I do this well
let me combine some ideas from before
let me go ahead and start fresh with
this let me give myself a list called
names and assign it an empty list just
so I have a variable in which to
accumulate all of these lines and now
let me open the file with open quote
unquote names.txt and it turns out I can
tighten this up a little bit it turns
out if you're opening a file to read it
you don't need to specify quote unquote
r that is the implicit default so you
can tighten things up by just saying
open names.text and you'll be able to
read the file but not write it I'm going
to give myself a variable called file as
before I am going to iterate over the
file in the same way for line in file
but instead of printing each line I'm
going to do this I'm going to take my
names list and append to it and this is
appending to a list in memory not
appending to the file itself I'm going
to go ahead and append the current line
but I'm going to strip off the new line
at the end so that all I'm adding to
this list is each of the students names
now I can use that familiar technique
from before let me go outside of this
with statement because now I've read the
entire file presumably so by the time
I'm done with lines four and five again
and again and again for each line in the
file I'm done with the file it can close
I now have all of the students names in
this list variable let me do this for
name in not just names but the sorted
names using our python function sorted
which does just that and do print quote
unquote with an F string hello comma and
now I'll plug in bracket name
so now what have I done I'm creating a
list at the beginning just so I have a
place to gather my data I then on lines
three through five iterate over the file
from top to bottom reading in each line
one at a time stripping off the new line
and adding just the student's name to
this list and the reason I'm doing that
is so that on line seven I can sort all
of those names now that they're all in
memory and print them in order I need to
load them all into memory before I can
sort them otherwise I'd be printing them
out prematurely and Draco would end up
last instead of first so let me go ahead
in my terminal window and run python of
names.pi now and hit enter and there we
go the same list of four hellos but now
they're sorted and this is a very common
technique when dealing with files and
information more generally if you want
to change that data in some way like
sorting it creating some kind of
variable at the top of your program like
a list adding or appending information
to it just to collect it in one place
and then do something interesting with
that collection that list is exactly
what I've done here now I should note
that if we just want to sort the file we
can actually do this even more simply in
Python particularly by not bothering
with this names list nor the second for
Loop and let me go ahead and instead
just do more simply this let me go ahead
and tell python that we want the file
itself to be sorted using that same
sorted function but this time on the
file itself and then inside of that for
Loop let's just go ahead and print right
away our hello comma followed by the
line itself but still stripping off of
the end of it any white space therein if
we go ahead and run this same program
now with pythonupnames.pi and hit enter
we get the same result but of course
it's a lot more compact but for the sake
of discussion let's assume that we do
actually want to potentially make some
changes to the data as we iterate over
it so let me undo those changes leave
things as is where by now we'll continue
to accumulate all of the names first
into a list maybe do something to them
maybe forcing them to uppercase or
lowercase or the like and then sort and
print out each item
let me pause and see if there's any
questions now on file IO reading or
writing or now accumulating all of these
values in some list hi is there a way to
sort the files but instead if you want
it from alphabetically from A to Z is
there a way to reverse it from Zeta air
is there like a little extension that
you can add to the end to do that or
would you have to create a new function
if you wanted to reverse the contents of
the file yeah so if you instead of
sorting them from a to z in ascending
order if you're one of them in
descending order
is there an extension for the there is
indeed and as always the documentation
is your friend so if the goal is to sort
them not in alphabetical order which is
the default but maybe reverse
alphabetical order you can take a look
for instance at the formal python
documentation there and what you'll see
is this summary you'll see that the
sorted function takes a first argument
generally known as an iterable and
something that's iterable means that you
can iterate over it that is you can Loop
over it one thing at a time what the
rest of this line here means is that you
can specify a key like how you want to
sort it but more on that later but this
last named parameter here is reverse and
by default per the documentation it's
false it will not be reversed by default
but if we change that to true I bet we
can do that so let me go back to vs code
here and do just that let me go ahead
and pass in a second argument to sorted
in addition to this iterable which is my
names list iterable again in the sense
that it can be looped over and let me
pass in Reverse equals true thereby
overriding the default of false let me
now run python of names Dot pie and now
Ron's at the top and draco's at the
bottom so there too whenever you have a
question like that moving forward
consider what does the documentation say
and see if there's a germ of an idea
there because odds are if you have some
problem odds are some programmer before
you have had the same question other
thoughts
uh can we limit
um
and the second question can we find
specific claim at least really good
question can we limit the number of the
names in the file and can we find a
specific one we absolutely could if we
were to write code we could for instance
open the file first count how many lines
are already there and then if there's
too many already we could just exit with
sys.exit or some other message to
indicate to the user that sorry the
class is full as for finding someone
specifically absolutely you could
imagine opening the file iterating over
it with a for loop again and again and
then adding a conditional like if the
current line equals equals Harry then we
found the chosen run and you can print
something like that so you can
absolutely combine these ideas with
previous ideas like conditionals to ask
those same questions how about one other
question on file IO uh so I just thought
about
this function like uh read all lines and
it looks like it's uh like separate all
the lines by this special character a
backslash n but it looks like we don't
need it a character and we we always
trip it and it looks like some bad
design of function why why wouldn't we
just strip it inside this function a
really good question so we are in my
examples thus far using R strip to
reverse uh to strip from the end of the
line all of this white space you might
not want to do that in this case I am
stripping it away because I know that
each of those lines isn't some generic
line of text each line really represents
a name that I have put there myself I'm
using the new line just to separate one
value from another in other scenarios
you might very well want to keep that
line ending because it's a very long
series of text or a paragraph or
something like that where you want to
keep it distinct from the others but
it's just a convention we have to use
something presumably probably to
separate one chunk of text from another
there are other functions in Python that
will in fact handle the removal of that
white space for you read lines though
does literally that though it reads all
of the lines as is well allow me to turn
our attention back to where we left off
here which is just names to propose that
with names.text we have an ability it
seems to store each of these names
pretty straightforwardly but what if we
wanted to keep track of other
information as well suppose that we
wanted to store information including a
student's uh name and their house at
Hogwarts be it Gryffindor or Slytherin
or something else well where do we go
about putting that you know Hermione
lives in Gryffindor so we could do
something like this in our text file
Harry lives in Gryffindor so we could do
that Ron lives in Gryffindor so we could
do that and Draco lives in Slytherin so
we could do that but I worry here
but I worry now that we're mixing apples
and oranges so to speak like some lines
or names some lines are houses so this
probably isn't the best design if only
because it's confusing or it's ambiguous
so maybe what we could do is Adopt A
convention and indeed this is in fact
what a lot of programmers do they change
this file not to be names.text but
instead let me create a new file called
names.csv CSV stands for comma separated
values and it's a very common convention
to store multiple pieces of information
that are related in the same file and so
to do this I'm going to separate each of
these types of data not with another new
line but simply with a comma I'm going
to keep each student on their own line
but I'm going to separate the
information about each student using a
comma instead and so now we sort of have
a two-dimensional file if you will row
by row we have our students but if you
think of these commas as representing a
column even though it's not perfectly
straight because of the lengths of these
names it's a little it's a little Jagged
you can think of these commas as
representing a column and it turns out
these CSV files are very commonly used
when you use something like Microsoft
Excel Apple numbers or Google
spreadsheets and you want to export the
data to share with someone else as a CSV
file or conversely if you want to import
a CSV file into your preferred
spreadsheet software like Excel or
numbers or Google spreadsheets you can
do that as well so CSV is a very common
very simple text format that just
separates values with commas and
different types of values ultimately
with new lines as well let me go ahead
and run code of students.csv to create a
brand new file that's initially empty
and we'll add to it those same names but
also some other information as well so
if I now have this new file students.csv
inside of which is one column of name so
to speak and one column of houses how do
I go about changing my code to read not
just those names but also those names
and houses so that they're not all on
one line we somehow have access to both
type of value separate lay well let me
go ahead and create a new program here
called
students.pi and in this program let's go
about reading not a text file per se but
a specific type of text file a CSV a
comma separated values file and to do
this I'm going to use similar code as
before I'm going to say with open quote
unquote
students.csv I'm not going to bother
specifying quote unquote R because again
that's the default but I'm going to give
myself a variable name of file and then
in this file I'm going to go ahead and
do this for line in file as before and
now I have to be a bit clever here let
me go back to students.csv looking at
this file and it seems that on my loop
on each iteration I'm going to get
access to the whole line of text I'm not
going to automatically get access to
just Hermione or just Gryffindor recall
that the loop is going to give me each
full line of text so logically what
would you propose that we do inside of a
for Loop that's reading a whole line of
text at once but we now want to get
access to the individual values like
Hermione and Gryffindor Harry and
Gryffindor how do we go about taking one
line of text and gaining access to those
individual values do you think just
instinctively even if you're not sure
what the name of the functions would be
you can access access it as you would
and if you were using a dictionary like
using a key and value
so ideally we would access it using it a
key in value but at this point in the
story all we have is this
loose Loop is giving me one line of text
that is the time I'm the programmer now
I have to solve this there is no
dictionary yet in question how about
another suggestion here
um so you can somehow split the two
words based on the comma yeah even if
you're not quite sure what function is
going to do this intuitively you want to
take this whole line of text Hermione
comma Gryffindor Harry comma Gryffindor
and so forth and split that line into
two pieces if you will and it turns out
wonderfully the function we'll use is
actually called split that can split on
any characters but you can tell it what
character to use so I'm going to go back
into students.pi and inside of this Loop
I'm going to go ahead and do this I'm
going to take the current line I'm going
to remove the white space at the end as
always using R strip here and then
whatever the result of that is I'm going
to now call split and quote unquote
comma so the split function or method
comes with strings stirs in Python any
stir has this method built in and if you
pass in an argument like a comma what
this strip split function will do is
split that current string into one two
three maybe more pieces by looking for
that character again and again
ultimately strip uh ultimately split is
going to return to us a list of all of
the individual parts to the left and to
the right of those commas so I can give
myself a variable called row here and
this is a common Paradigm when you know
you're iterating over a file
specifically a CSV it's common to think
of each line of it as being a row and
each of the values they're in separated
by commas as columns so to speak so I'm
going to deliberately name my variable
row just to be consistent with that
convention and now what do I want to
print well I'm going to go ahead and say
this print how about the following in F
string that starts with curly braces
well how do I get access to the first
thing in that row well the row is going
to have how many parts two because if
I'm splitting on commas and there's one
comma per line that's going to give me a
left part and a right part like Hermione
and Gryffindor Harry and Gryffindor
when I have a list like row how do I get
access to individual values well I can
do this I can say Row Bracket zero and
that's going to go to the first element
of the list which should hopefully be
the student's name then after that I'm
going to say is in and I'm going to have
another curly brace here for Row Bracket
one and then I'm going to close my whole
quote so it looks a little cryptic at
first glance but most of this is just F
string syntax with curly braces to plug
in values and what values am I plugging
in well row again is a list and it has
two elements presumably Hermione in one
and Gryffindor and the other and so
forth so bracket zero is the first
element because remember we start
indexing at zero in Python and one is
going to be the second element so let me
go ahead and run this now and see what
happens python of uh
students.pi enter and we see Hermione is
in Gryffindor Harry's and Gryffindor Ron
is in Gryffindor and Draco is in
Slytherin so we have now implemented our
own code from scratch that actually
parses that is reads and interprets a
CSV file ultimately here
now let me pause to see if there's any
questions but we'll make this even
easier to read in just a moment
any questions on what we've just done
here by splitting by comma so my
question is uh can we edit any line of
code anytime we want or uh the only
option that we have is to append uh the
lines or let's say if we want to let's
say change headies uh house to let's say
Slytherin or some other house yeah a
really good question what if you want to
in Python change a line in the file and
not just a pen to the end you would have
to implement that logic yourself so for
instance you could imagine now opening
the file and reading all of the contents
in then maybe iterating over each of
those lines and as soon as you see that
the current name equals equals Harry you
could maybe change his house to
Slytherin and then it would be up to you
though to write all of those changes
back to the file so in that case you
might want to in simplest form read the
file once and let it close then open it
again but open for writing and change
the whole file it's not really possible
or easy to go in and change just part of
the file though you can do it it's
easier to actually read the whole file
make your changes in memory then write
the whole file out but for larger files
where that might be quite slow you can
be more clever than that well let me
propose now that we clean this up a
little bit because I actually think this
is a little cryptic to read Row Bracket
zero Row Bracket one it's it's not that
well written at the moment I would say
but it turns out that when you have a
variable that's a list like row you
don't have to throw all of those
variables into a list you can actually
unpack that whole sequence at once that
is to say if you know that a function
like split returns a list but you know
in advance that it's going to return two
values in a list the first and the
second you don't have to throw them all
into a variable that itself is a list
you can actually unpack them
simultaneously into two variables doing
name comma house so this is a nice
python technique to not only create but
assign
automatically in parallel two variables
at once rather than just one so this
will have the effect of putting the name
in the left Hermione and it will have
the effect of putting Gryffindor the
house in the right variable and we now
no longer have a row we can now make our
code a little more readable by now
literally just saying name down here and
for instance house down here so just a
little more readable even though
functionally the code now is exactly the
same
all right so this now works and I'll
confirm as much by just running it once
more python of students.pi enter and we
see that the text is as intended but
suppose for the sake of discussion that
I'd like to sort this list of output I'd
like to say hello again to Draco first
then hello to Harry then Hermione then
Ron how can I go about doing this well
let's take some inspiration from the
previous example where we're only
dealing with names and instead do it
with these full phrases so and so is
in-house well let me go ahead and do
this I'm going to go ahead and start
scratch and give myself a list called
students equal to an empty list
initially and then with open
students.csv as file I'm going to go
ahead and say this for line in file and
then below this I'm going to do exactly
as before name comma house equals the
current line stripping off the white
space at the end splitting it on a comma
so that's exact same as before but this
time before I go about uh printing the
sentence I'm going to store it
temporarily in a list so that I can
accumulate all of these sentences and
then sort them later so let me go ahead
and do this students which is my list
dot append let me append the actual
sentence I want to show on the screen so
another F string so name is in house
just as before but notice I'm not
printing that sentence I'm appending it
to my list not a file but to my list why
am I doing this well just because as
before I want to do this for student in
the sorted students I want to go ahead
and print out students like this well
let me go ahead and run python of
students.pi and hit enter now and I
think we'll see indeed Draco is now
first Harry a second Hermione is third
and Ron is fourth but this is arguably a
little sloppy right it seems a little
hackish that I'm constructing these
sentences and even though I'm
technically want to sort by name I'm
technically sorting by these whole
English sentences so it's not wrong it's
achieving the intended result but it's
not really well designed because I'm
just kind of getting lucky that English
is reading from left to right and
therefore when I print this out it's
sorting properly it would be better
really to come up with a technique for
sorting by the students names not by
some English sentence that I've
constructed here on line six
so to achieve this I'm going to need to
make my life more complicated for a
moment and I'm going to need to collect
information about each student before I
bother assembling that sentence so let
me propose that we do this let me go
ahead and undo these last few lines of
code so that we currently have two
variables name and house Each of which
has name in the student's house
respectively and we still have our
Global variable students but let me do
this recall that python supports
dictionaries and dictionaries are just
collections of keys and values so you
can associate something with something
else like a name with Hermione like a
house with Gryffindor that really is a
dictionary so let me do this let me
temporarily create a dictionary that
stores this Association of name with
house let me go ahead and do this let me
say that the student here is going to be
represented initially by an empty
dictionary and just like you could
create an empty list with square
brackets you can create an empty
dictionary with curly braces so give me
an empty diction that will soon have two
keys name and house how do I do that
well I could do it this way student Open
Bracket name
equals the student's name that we got
from the line student bracket house
equals the house that we got from the
line and now I'm going to append to the
students list plural
that particular student now why have I
done this I've admittedly made my code
more complicated it's more lines of code
but I've now collected all of the
information I have about students while
still keeping track what's a name what's
a house the list meanwhile has all of
the students names and houses together
now why have I done this well let me for
the moment just do something simple let
me do for students in students and let
me very Simply Now say print the
following fstring the current student
with this name
uh is in
this current students house and now
notice one detail inside of this F
string I'm using my curly braces as
always
I'm using inside of those curly braces
the name of a variable as always but
then I'm using not bracket zero or one
because these are dictionaries now not
list but why am I using single quotes to
surround house and to surround name
why single quotes inside of this
F string
to access those
Keys yes uh because you have double
quotes
in that in that line 12 and so you have
to tell python to differentiate exactly
because I'm already using double quotes
outside of the F string if I want to put
quotes around any strings on the inside
which I do need to do for dictionaries
because recall when you index into a
dictionary you don't use numbers like
lists 0 1 2 onward you instead use
strings which need to be quoted but if
you're already using double quotes it's
easiest to then use single quotes on the
inside so python doesn't get confused
about what lines up with what so at the
moment when I run this program it's
going to print out those hellos but
they're not yet sorted in fact what I
now have is a list of dictionaries and
nothing is yet sorted but let me tighten
up the code too to point out that it
doesn't need to be quite as verbose if
you're in the habit of creating an empty
dictionary like this on line six and
then immediately putting in two keys
name and house each with two values name
and house respectively you can actually
do this all at once so let me show you a
slightly different syntax I can do this
give me a variable called student and
let me use curly braces on the right
hand side here but instead of leaving
them empty let's just Define those keys
and those values now quote unquote name
will be name and quote unquote house
will be house this achieves the exact
same effect in one line instead of three
it creates a new non-empty dictionary
containing a name key the value of which
is the student's name and a house key
the value of which is the student's
house nothing else needs to change that
will still just work so that if I again
run python of students.pi I'm still
seeing those greetings but they're still
not quite actually sorted well what
might I go about doing here in order to
what could I do to improve upon this
further
well we need some mechanism now of
sorting those students but unfortunately
you can't do this we can't sort all of
the students now because those students
are not names like they were before they
aren't sentences like they were before
each of the students is a dictionary and
it's not obvious how you would sort a
dictionary inside of a list so ideally
what do we want to do if at the moment
we hit line 9 we have a list of all of
these students and inside of that list
is one dictionary per student and each
of those dictionaries has two keys name
and house wouldn't it be nice if there
were ran code to tell python sort this
list by looking at this key in each
dictionary because that would give this
the ability to sort either by name or
even by house or even by any other field
that we add to that file so it turns out
we can do this we can tell the sorted
function not just to reverse things or
not it takes another position National
it takes another named parameter called
key where you can specify what key
should be used in order to sort some
list of dictionaries and I'm going to
propose that we do this I'm going to
first Define a function temporarily for
now called get name and this functions
purpose in life given a student is to
quite simply return the student's name
from that particular dictionary so if
student is a dictionary this is going to
return literally the student's name and
that's it that's the sole purpose of
this function in life what do I now want
to do well now that I have a function
that given a student will return to me
the student's name I can do this I can
change sorted to say use a key that's
equal to whatever the return value of
get name is and this now is a feature of
python python allows you to pass
functions as arguments in two other
functions so get name is a function
sorted is a function and I'm passing in
get name to sort it as the value of that
key parameter now why am I doing that
well if you think of the get name
function as just a bunch a block of code
that will get the name of a student
that's handy because that's the
capability that sorted needs when given
a list of students Each of which is a
dictionary sorted needs to know how do I
get the name of the student in order to
do alphabetical sorting for you the
authors of python didn't know that we
were going to be creating students here
in this class so they couldn't have
anticipated writing code in advance that
specifically sorts on a field called
student let alone called name let alone
house so what did they do they instead
built into the sorted function this
named parameter key that allows us all
these years later to tell their function
sorted how to sort this list of
dictionaries so now watch what happens
if I run python of students.pi and hit
enter I now have a sorted list of output
why because because now that list of
dictionaries has all been sorted by the
student's name I can further do this if
as before we want to reverse the whole
thing by saying reverse equals true we
can do that too let me rerun python of
students.pi and hit enter now it's
reverse now it's Ron then Hermione Harry
and Draco but we can do something
different as well what if I want to sort
for instance by house name reversed I
could do this I could change this
function from get name to get house I
could change the implementation up here
to be get house and I can return not the
student's name but the student's house
and so now notice if I run python of
students.pi enter notice now it is
sorted by house in reverse order
Slytherin is first and then Gryffindor
if I get rid of the reverse but keep the
get house and rerun this program now
it's sorted by house gryffindor's first
and Slytherin is last and the upside now
of this is because I'm using this list
of dictionaries and keeping the students
data together until the last minute when
I'm finally do doing the printing I now
have full control over the information
itself and I can sort by this or that I
don't have to construct construct those
sentences in advance like I rather
hackishly did the first time
all right that was a lot let me pause
here to see if there are questions so
when when we're starting the files do we
every time should we use the loops or
like uh like a dictionary or or any kind
of list can be sort by just sorting not
uh looping or
any kind of stuff a good question and
the short answer with python alone
you're the programmer you need to do the
Sorting with libraries and other
techniques absolutely you can do more of
this automatically because someone else
has written that code what we're doing
at the moment is doing everything from
scratch ourselves but absolutely with
other functions or libraries some of
this could be made uh more uh easily
done some of this could be made uh
easier other questions
on this technique here it's equal to the
return value of the function uh can it
be equal to uh just uh a variable or a
value it well yes it should equal a
value so I'm speci and I should clarify
actually since this was not obvious
so when you pass in a function like get
name or get house to the sorted function
as the value of key that function is
automatically called by the get by the
sorted function for you on each of the
dictionaries in the list and it uses the
return value of get name or get house to
decide what strings to actually use to
compare in order to decide which is
alphabetically correct so this function
which you pass just by name you do not
pass in parentheses at the end is called
by the sorted function in order to
figure out for you how to compare these
same values how can we use nested
dictionaries I have read about the
nested dictionaries what is the
difference between nested dictionaries
and the dictionary inside a list I think
it is sure
um uh so we are using a list of
dictionaries why because each of those
dictionaries represents a student and a
student has a name and a house and we
want to I claim maintain that
Association and it's a list of students
because we've got multiple students four
in this case you could create us a
structure that is a dictionary of
dictionaries but I would argue it just
doesn't solve a problem I don't need a
dictionary of dictionary I need a list
of key value pairs right now that's all
so let me propose if we go back to
students.pi here and we revert back to
the approach where we have get name as
the function both used and defined here
and that function Returns the student's
name what happens to be clear is that
the sorted function will use the value
of key get name in this case calling
that function on every dictionary in the
list that it's supposed to sort and that
function get name Returns the string
that sorted will actually use to decide
whether things go in this order left
right or in this order right left it
alphabetizes things based on that return
value so notice that I'm not calling the
function get name here with parentheses
I'm passing in an only by its name so
that the sorted function can call that
get name function for me now it turns
out as always if you're defining
something be it a variable or in this
case a function and then immediately
using it but never once again needing
the name of that function like get name
we can actually tighten this code up
further I can actually do this I can get
rid of the get name function altogether
just like I could get rid of a variable
that isn't strictly necessary and
instead of passing key the name of a
function I can actually Pass Key what's
called an a Lambda function which is an
anonymous function a function that just
has no name why because you don't need
to give it a name if you're only going
to call it in one place and the syntax
for this in Python is a little weird but
if I do key equals literally the word
Lambda then something like student which
is the name of the parameter I expect
this function to take and then I don't
even type the return key i instead just
say student bracket name so what am I
doing here with my code this code here
that I've highlighted is equivalent to
the get name function I implemented a
moment ago the syntax is admittedly a
little different I don't use def I
didn't even give it a name like get name
i instead I'm using this other keyword
in pi python called Lambda which says
Hey python here comes a function but it
has no name it's Anonymous that function
takes a parameter I could call it
anything I want I'm calling it student
why because this function that's passed
in as key is called on every one of the
students in that list every one of the
dictionaries in that list what do I want
this Anonymous function to return well
given a student I want to index into
that dictionary and access their name so
that the string Hermione and Harry and
Ron and Draco is ultimately returned and
that's what the sorted function uses to
decide how to sort these bigger
dictionaries that have other Keys like
house as well so if I now go back to my
terminal window and run python of
students.pi it still seems to work the
same but it's arguably a little better
design because I didn't waste lines of
Code by defining some other function
calling it in one and only one place
I've done it all sort of in one breath
if you will
all right let me pause here to see if
there's any questions specifically about
Lambda or Anonymous functions and this
tightening up of the code
and I have a question like whether we
could Define Lambda twice
can you you can use Lambda twice you can
create as many Anonymous functions as
you'd like and you generally use them in
context like this where you want to pass
to some other function a function that
itself does not need a name so you can
absolutely use it in more than one place
I just have only one use case for it how
about one other question on Lambda or
Anonymous functions specifically what
what if our Lambda would take more than
one line for example if sure if your
Lambda function takes multiple
parameters that is fine you can simply
specify commas followed by the names of
those parameters maybe X and Y or so
forth after the name student so here too
Lambda looks a little different from
Death in that you don't have parentheses
you don't have the keyword def you don't
have a function name but ultimately they
achieve that same effect they create a
function anonymously and allow you to
pass it in for instance as some value
here so let's now change students.csv to
contain not students houses at Hogwarts
but their homes where they grew up so
Draco for instance grew up in Malfoy
Manor Ron grew up in the borough Harry
grew up in number four
privet drive and according to the
internet no one knows where Hermione
grew up the movies apparently took
certain liberties with where she grew up
so for this purpose we're actually going
to remove Hermione because it is unknown
exactly where she was born so we still
have some three students but if anyone
can spot the potential problem now
how might this be a bad thing well let's
go and try and run our own code here let
me go back to students.pi here and let
me propose that I just changed my
semantics because I'm now not thinking
about Hogwarts houses but the students
own home so I'm just going to change
some variables I'm going to change this
house to a home this house to a home as
well as this one here I'm still going to
sort the students by name but I'm going
to say that they're not in a house but
rather from a home so I've just changed
the names of my variables in my grammar
in English here ultimately to print out
that for instance Harry is from number
four privet drive and so forth but let's
see what happens here when I run python
of this version of students.pi having
changed students.csv to contain those
homes and not houses enter
huh our first value error like the
program just doesn't work What might
explain this value error the explanation
of which rather cryptically is too many
values to unpack and the line in
question is this one involving split how
did all of a sudden after all of these
successful runs of this program did line
five suddenly now break in the line
instruments.csv you have three values
there's a line that you have three
valleys and incidents yeah I spent a lot
of time trying to figure out where every
student should be from so that we could
create this problem for us and
wonderfully like the first sentence of
the book is number four privet drive and
so the fact that that address has a
comma in it is problematic why because
you and I decided some time ago to just
standardize on commas CSV comma
separated values to denote the uh
we standardized on commas in order to
delineate one value from another and if
we have commas grammatically in the
student's home we're clearly confusing
it as this special symbol and the split
function is now for just Harry trying to
split it into three values not just two
and that's why there's too many values
to unpack because we're only trying to
assign two variables name and house now
what could we do here well we could just
change our approach for instance like
one Paradigm that is not uncommon is to
use something a little more
a little less common like a vertical bar
so I could go in and change all of my
commas to Vertical bars that too could
eventually come back to bite Us in that
if my file eventually has vertical bar
somewhere it might still break so maybe
that's not the best approach I could
maybe do something like this I could
escape the data as I've done in the past
and maybe I could put quotes around any
English string that itself contains a
comma and that's fine I could do that
but then my code students.pi is going to
have to change too because I can't just
naively split on a comma Now I'm going
to have to be smarter about it I'm going
to have to take into account split only
on the commas that are not inside of
quotes and oh it's getting complicated
fast and at this point you need to take
a step back and consider you know what
if we're having this problem odds are
many other people before us have had the
same problem it is incredibly common to
store data in files it is incredibly
common to use CSV files specifically and
so you know what why don't we see if
there's a library in Python that exists
to read and or write CSV files rather
than reinvent a wheel so to speak let's
see if we can write better code by
standing on the shoulders of others who
have come before us programmers passed
and actually use their code to do the
reading and writing of csvs so we can
focus on the part of our problem that
you and I care about so let's propose
that we go back to our code here and see
how we might use the CSV Library indeed
within python there is a module called
CSV the documentation for it is at this
URL here in Python's official
documentation but there's a few
functions that are pretty readily
accessible if we just Dive Right In and
let me propose that we do this let me go
back to my code here and instead of
Reinventing this wheel and reading the
file line by line and splitting on
commas and dealing now with quotes and
privet drives and so forth let's do this
instead at the start of my program
let me go up and import the CSV module
let's use this library that someone else
has written that's dealing with all of
these Corner cases if you will I'm still
going to give myself a list initially
empty in which to store all these
students but I'm going to change my
Approach here now just a little bit when
I open this file with with let me go in
here and change this a little bit I'm
going to go in here now and say this
uh reader equals CSV dot reader passing
in file as input so it turns out if you
read the documentation for the CSV
module it comes with a function called
reader whose purpose in life is to read
a CSV file for you and figure out where
are the commas where are the quotes
where are all the the potential Corner
cases and just deal with them for you
you can override certain defaults or
assumptions in case you're using not a
comma but a pipe or something else but
by default I think it's just going to
work now how do I iterate over a reader
and not the raw file itself it's almost
the same the library allows you still to
do this for each row in the reader so
you're not iterating over the file
directly now you're iterating over the
reader which is again going to handle
all of the parsing of commas and new
lines and more for each row in the
reader what am I going to do well at the
moment I'm going to do this I'm going to
append to my students list the following
dictionary a dictionary that has a name
whose value is the current Row's First
Column and whose house or rather home
now is the Rose second column now it's
worth noting that the reader for each
line in the file indeed returns to me a
row but it returns to me a row that's a
list which is to say that the first
element of that list is going to be the
student's name as before the second
student's home as now before but if I
want to access each of those elements
remember that lists are zero indexed we
start counting at zero and then one
rather than one and then two so if I
want to get at the student's name I use
Row Bracket zero and if I want to get at
the student's home I use Row Bracket one
but in my for Loop we can do that same
unpacking as before if I know this CSV
is only going to have two columns I
could even do this for name home in
reader and now I don't need to use list
notation I can unpack things all at once
and say name here and home here the rest
of my code can stay exactly the same
because what am I doing now on line 8
I'm still constructing the same
dictionary as before albeit for homes
instead of houses and I'm grabbing those
values now not from the file itself and
my use of split but the reader and again
what the reader is going to do is figure
out where are those commas where are the
quotes and just solve that problem for
you so let me go now down to my terminal
window and run python of students.pi and
hit enter and now we see successfully
sorted no less that Draco is from
malform Manor Harry is from number four
comma privet drive and Ron is from the
borough
questions now on this technique of using
CSV reader from that CSV module which
again is just getting us out of the
business of reading each line ourself
and reading each of those commas and
splitting so my questions related to
Something in the past
um I recognize that you are reading a
file every time you well you we're we're
assuming that we have the CSV file to
hand already in this case
um is it possible to make a file
readable and writable so in in case if
you want you could you could write some
stuff to the file but then at the same
time you could have another function
that reads through the phone that's
changes to it as you go along a really
good question and the short answer is
yes however historically the mental
model for a file is that of a cassette
tape years ago not really in use anymore
but cassette tapes are sequential
whereby they start at the beginning and
if you want to get to the end you kind
of have to unwind the tape to get to
that point the closest analog nowadays
would be something like Netflix or any
streaming service where there's a
scrubber that you have to go left to
right you can't just jump there or jump
there you don't have Random Access so
the problem with files if you want to
read and write them you or some Library
needs to keep track of where you are in
the file so that if you're reading from
the top and then you write at the bottom
and you want to start reading again you
seek back to the beginning so it's not
something we'll do here in class it's
more involved but it's absolutely doable
for our purposes we'll generally
recommend read the file and then if you
want to change it write it back out
rather than trying to make more
piecemeal changes which is good if
though the file is massive and it would
just be very expensive time wise to
change the whole thing other questions
on this CSV reader
is possible to write a paragraph in that
file
absolutely right now I'm writing very
small strings just names or houses as I
did before but you can absolutely write
as much text as you want
indeed
other questions on CSV reader
choose
himself IP like input key will be a name
or home so short answer yes we could
absolutely write a program that prompts
the user for a name and a home a name
and a home and we could write out those
values and in a moment we'll see how you
can write to a CSV file for now I'm
assuming as the programmer who created
students.csv that I know what the
columns are going to be and therefore
I'm naming my variables accordingly
however this is a good segue to one
final feature of reading csvs which is
that you don't have to rely on either
getting a row as a list and using
bracket zero or bracket one and you
don't have to unpack things manually in
this way we could actually be smarter
and start storing the names of these
columns in the CSV file itself and in
fact if any of you have ever opened a
spreadsheet file before be it in Excel
Apple Numbers Google spreadsheets or the
like all odds are you've noticed that
the first row very frequently is a
little different it actually is bold
face sometimes or it actually contains
the names of those columns the names of
those attributes below and we can do
this here and students.csv I don't have
to just keep assuming that the student's
name is first and that the student's
home is second I can explicitly bake
that information into the file just to
reduce the probability of mistakes down
the road I can literally use the first
row of this file and say name comma home
so notice that
name is not literally someone's name and
home is not literally someone's home it
is literally the words name and home
separated by a comma and if I now go
back into students.pi and don't use CSV
reader but instead I use a dictionary
reader I can actually treat my CSV file
even more flexibly not just for this but
for other examples too let me do this
instead of using a CSV reader let me use
a CSV dict reader which will now iterate
over the file top to bottom loading in
each line of text not as a list of
columns but as a dictionary of columns
what's nice about this is that it's
going to give me automatic access now to
those columns names I'm going to revert
to just saying for Row in reader and now
I'm going to append a name and a home
but how am I going to get access to the
current rows name and the current rows
home well earlier I used bracket zero
for the first and bracket one for the
second when I was using a reader a
reader returns lists addict reader or
dictionary reader returns dictionaries
one at a time and so if I want to access
the current Row's name I can say row
quote unquote name I can say here for
home row quote unquote home and I now
have access to those same values the
only change I had to make to be clear
was in my CSV file I had to include on
the very first row little hints as to
what these columns are and if I now run
this code I think it should behave
pretty much the same python of
students.pi and indeed we get the same
sentences but now my code is more robust
against changes in this data if I were
to open the CSV file in Excel or Google
spreadsheets or apple numbers and for
whatever reason change the columns
around maybe this is a file that you're
sharing with someone else and just
because they decide to sort things
differently left to right by moving the
columns around
previously my code would have broken
because I was assuming that name is
always first and home is always second
but if I did this be it manually in one
of those programs or here home comma
name and suppose I reversed all of this
the home comes first followed by Harry
the borough then by Ron and then lastly
Malfoy Manor then Draco notice that my
file is now completely flipped the First
Column is now the second and the
second's the first but I took care to
update the header of that file the first
row notice my python code I'm not going
to touch it at all I'm going to rerun
python of students.pi and hit enter and
it still just works and this too is an
example of like coding defensively like
what if someone changes your CSV file
your data file ideally that won't happen
but even if it does now because I'm
using a dictionary reader that's going
to infer from that first row for me what
the columns are called my code just
keeps working and so it keeps getting if
you will better and better
any questions now on this approach yeah
what is the importance of new line CSV
file what's the importance of the new
line in the CSV file it's partly a
convention in the world of text files we
humans have just been for decades in the
habit of storing
um data line by line it's visually
convenient it's just easy to extract
from the file because you just look for
the new lines so the new line just
separates some data from some other data
we could use any other symbol on the
keyboard but it's just common to hit
enter to just move the data to the next
line just a convention
other questions it seems to be working
fine if you just have name and home I'm
wondering what will happen if you want
to put in more data
um
say you wanted to add a house to both
the name and the home
sure if you wanted to add the house back
so if I go in here and add house last
and I go here and say Gryffindor for
Harry Gryffindor for Ron and Slytherin
for Draco now I have three columns
effectively if you will home on the left
name in the middle house on the right
each separated by commas with weird
things like number four comma privet
Drive still quoted notice if I go back
to students.pi and I don't change the
code at all and runs python of
students.pi it still just works and this
is what's so powerful about a dictionary
reader it can change over time it can
have more and more columns your existing
code is not going to break your code
would break would be much more fragile
so to speak if you were making
assumptions like the first column's
always going to be named the second
column is always going to be house
things will break fast if those
assumptions break down
so not a problem in this case
well let me propose that besides reading
csvs let's at least take a peek at how
we might write a csv2 if you're writing
a program in which you want to store not
just students names but maybe their
homes as well in a file how can we keep
adding to this file let me go ahead and
delete the contents of students.csv and
just re-add a single simple row name
comma home so as to anticipate inserting
more names and homes into this file and
then let me go to students.pi and let me
just start fresh so as to write out data
this time I'm still going to go ahead
and import CSV I'm going to go ahead now
and prompt the user for their name so
input quote unquote what's your name
question mark and I'm going to go ahead
and prompt the user for their home so
home equals input quote unquote where's
your home question mark now I'm going to
go ahead and open the file but this time
for writing instead of reading as
follows with open quote unquote
students.csv I'm going to open it in
append mode so that I keep adding more
and more students and homes to the file
rather than just overwriting the entire
file itself and I'm going to use a
variable name of file I'm then going to
go ahead and give myself a variable
called writer and I'm going to set it
equal to the return value of another
function in the CSV module called CSV
dot writer and that writer function
takes as its sole argument the file
variable there now I'm going to go ahead
and just do this I'm going to say writer
dot right row and I'm going to pass into
right Row the line that I want to write
to the file specifically as a list so
I'm going to give this a list of name
comma home which of course are the
contents of those variables now I'm
going to go ahead and save the file I'm
going to go ahead and rerun python of
students.pi hit enter and what's your
name well let me go ahead and type in
Harry as my name and number four
comma privet Drive enter now notice that
input itself did have a comma and so if
I go to my CSV file now notice that it's
automatically been quoted for me so that
subsequent reads from this file don't
confuse that comma with the actual comma
between Harry and his home well let me
go ahead and run it a couple of more
times let me go ahead and rerun python
of students.pi let me go ahead and input
this time Ron and his home as the
borough let's go back to students.csv to
see what it looks like now we see Ron
comma the burrow has been added
automatically to the file and let's do
one more python of students.pi enter
let's go ahead and give draco's name and
his home which would be Malfoy Manor
enter and if we go back to students.csv
now we see that Draco is in the file
itself and the library took care of not
only writing each of those rows per the
function's name it also handled the
escaping so to speak of any strings that
themselves contain a comma like Harry's
own home well it turns out there's yet
another way we we could implement this
same program without having to worry
about precisely that order again and
again and just passing in a list it
turns out if we're keeping track of
what's the name and what's the home we
could use something like a dictionary to
associate those keys with those values
so let me go ahead and back up and
remove these students from the file
leaving only the header row again name
comma home and let me go over to
students.pi and this time instead of
using CSV writer I'm going to go ahead
and use
csv.dictriter which is a dictionary
writer that's going to open the file in
much the same way but rather than write
a row as this list of name comma home
what I'm now going to do is follows I'm
going to first output an actual
dictionary the first key of which is
Name colon and then the value thereof is
going to be the name that was typed in
and I'm going to pass in a key of Home
quote unquote the value of which of
course is the home that was typed in but
with dict writer I do need to give it a
hint as to the order in which those
columns are when writing it out so that
subsequently they could be red even if
those orderings change let me go ahead
and pass in field names which is a
second argument to dictwriter equals and
then a list of the actual columns that I
know are in this file which of course
are name comma home those times in
quotes because that's indeed the string
names of the columns so to speak that I
intend to write to in that file all
right now let me go ahead and go to my
terminal window run python of
students.pi this time I'll type in
Harry's name again I'll again type in
number four comma privet Drive
enter let's now go back to students.csv
and voila parries back in the file and
it's properly escaped or quoted I'm sure
then if we do this again with Ron and
the burrow and let's go ahead and run it
one third time with Draco and Malfoy
Manor enter let's go back to
students.csv and Via this dictionary
writer we now have all three of those
students as well so whereas with CSV
writer the onus is on us to pass in a
list of all of the values we want to put
from left to right with a dictionary
writer technically they could be in any
order in the dictionary in fact I could
just have correctly done this passing in
home followed by name but it's a
dictionary and so the ordering in this
case does not matter so long as the key
is there and the value is there and
because I have passed in field names as
the second argument to dict writer it
ensures that the library knows exactly
which column contains name or home
respectively
are there any questions now on
dictionary reading dictionary writing or
csvs more generally
India and your specifics suppressive
fake situation for me to use a single
quotation or double quotation because
after the print we use a single
quotation to represent the key of the
dictionary but after the
reading or writing we use the double
quotation
it's a good question in Python you can
generally use double quotes or you can
use single quotes and it doesn't matter
you should just be self-consistent so
that stylistically your code looks the
same all throughout sometimes though it
is necessary to alternate if you're
already using double quotes as I was
earlier for a long F string but inside
that F string I was interpolating the
values of some variables using curly
braces and those variables were
dictionaries and in order to index into
a dictionary you use square brackets and
then quotes but if you're already using
double quotes out here you should
generally use single quotes here or vice
versa but otherwise I'm in the habit of
using double quotes everywhere others
are in the habit of using single quotes
everywhere it only matters sometimes if
one might be confused for the other
other questions on dictionary writing or
reading uh yeah my question is can we
use multiple CSV files in any program
absolutely you can use as many CSV files
as you want and it's just one of the
formats that you can use to save data
other questions on csvs or file IO
thanks for taking my question uh so when
you're reading from the file the um you
had the um uh as a as a dictionary you
had the fields called
um couldn't you just call it when you're
reading could couldn't you just call the
row in the previous version of the of
the students uh dot Pi file
um when you're reading the uh when
you're reading each row you are
splitting out the um the fields by name
yeah so when you're appending to the uh
to the students list can you just call
the uh for row and reader
students.append row rather than
uh rather than naming each of the fields
oh very clever uh short answer yes in so
far as dict reader returns one
dictionary at a time when you Loop over
it row is already going to be a
dictionary so yes you could actually get
away with doing this and the effect
would really be the same in this case
good observation how about one more
question on csvs
yeah when reading in csvs from my past
work with data a lot of things can go
wrong I don't know if it's a fair
question that you can answer in a few
sentences but are there any best
practices to double check that sort of
no mistakes occurred
it's a really good question and I would
say in general if you're using code to
generate the csvs and to read the csvs
and you're using a good Library
theoretically nothing should go wrong it
should be 100 correct if the libraries
are 100 correct uh you and I tend to be
the problem like when you let a human
touch the CSV or when Excel or apple
numbers or some other tools involved
that might not be aligned with your
code's expectations things then yes can
break the goal really sometimes honestly
the solution is manual fixes you go in
and fix the CSV or you have a lot of
error checking or you have a lot of try
except just to tolerate mistakes in the
data but generally I would say if you're
using CSV or any file format internally
to a program to both read and write it
you shouldn't have concerns there you
and I the humans are the problem uh
generally speaking and not the
programmers the users of those files
instead all right allow me to propose
that we leave csvs behind but to note
that they're not the only file format
you you can use in order to read or
write data in fact they're a popular
format as is just raw text files.txt
files but you can store data really any
way that you want we've just picked csvs
because it's representative of how you
might read and write from a file and do
so in a structured way where you can
somehow have multiple Keys multiple
values all in the same file without
having to resort to what would be
otherwise known as a binary file so a
binary file is a file that's really just
zeros and ones and they can be laid out
in any pattern you might want
particularly if you want to store not
textual information but maybe graphical
or audio or video information as well so
it turns out that python is really good
when it comes to having libraries for
really everything and in fact there's a
popular Library called pillow that
allows you to navigate image files as
well and to perform operations on image
files you can apply filters a lot
Instagram you can animate them as well
and so what I thought we'd do is leave
behind behind text files for now and
Tackle one more demonstration this time
focusing on this particular library and
image files instead so let me propose
that we go over here to vs code and
create a program ultimately that creates
an animated gif these things are
everywhere nowadays in the form of memes
and animations and stickers and the like
in an animated gif is really just an
image file that has multiple images
inside of it and your computer or your
phone shows you those images one after
another sometimes on an endless loop
again and again and so long as there's
enough images it creates the illusion of
Animation because your mind and mind
kind of fills in the gaps visually and
just assumes that if something is moving
even though you're only seeing one frame
per second or some sequence thereof it
looks like an animation so it's like a
simplistic version of a video file well
let me propose that we start with maybe
a couple of uh costumes from another
popular programming language and let me
go ahead and open up my first cost team
here number one so suppose here that
this is a costume or really just a
static image here
costume1.jif and it's just a static
picture of a cat no movement at all let
me go ahead now and open up a second one
costume2.jif that looks a little bit
different notice and I'll go back and
forth this cat's legs are a little bit
aligned differently so that this was
version one and this was version two now
these cats come from a programming
language from MIT called scratch that
allows you very graphically to animate
all this and more but we'll use just
these two static images costume one and
costume two to create our own animated
gif that after this you could text to a
friend or message them much like any
meme online well let me propose that we
create this animated gif not by just
using some off-the-shelf program that we
downloaded but by writing our own code
let me go ahead and run code of
costumes.pi and create our very own
program that's going to take as input to
or even more image file files and then
generate an animated gif from them by
essentially creating this animated gif
by toggling back and forth endlessly
between those two images well how am I
going to do this well let's assume that
this will be a program called
costumes.pi that expects uh two command
line arguments the names of the files
the individual costumes that we want to
animate back and forth so to do that I'm
going to import sys so that we
ultimately have access to sys.org V I'm
then from this pillow Library going to
import support for images specifically
so from pil import image capital i as
per the library's documentation now I'm
going to give myself an empty list
called images just so I have a list in
which to store one or two or or more of
these images and now let me do this
for each argument in sis.org V I'm going
to go ahead and create a new image
variable set it equal to this image
dot open function passing in ARG now
what is this doing I proposing that
eventually I want to be able to run
python of costumes.pi and then as
command line arguments specify
costume1.jif space costume two dot shift
so I want to take in those file names
from the command line as my arguments so
what am I doing here well I'm iterating
over sys.org V all of the words in my
command line arguments I'm creating a
variable called image and I'm passing to
this function image.open from the pillow
library that specific argument and that
library is essentially going to open
that image in a way that gives me a lot
of functionality for manipulating it
like animating now I'm going to go ahead
and
append to my images list
that particular image and that's it so
this Loop's purpose in life is just to
iterate over the command line arguments
and open those images using this Library
the last line is pretty straightforward
I'm going to say this I'm going to grab
the first of those images which is going
to be in my list at location zero and
I'm going to save it to disk that is I'm
going to save this file now in the past
when we use csvs or text files I had to
do the file opening I had to do the file
writing maybe even the closing I don't
need to do that with this Library the
pillow library takes care of the opening
the closing and the saving for me by
just calling save I'm going to call this
save function and just to leave space
because I have a number of arguments to
pass I'm going to move to another line
so it fits I'm going to pass in the name
of the file that I want to create
costume.jif that will be the name of my
animated gif I'm going to tell this
library to save all of the frames that I
passed to it so the First costume the
second costume and even more if I gave
them I'm I'm going to then append to
this first image the image is zero the
following images
equals this list of images and this is a
bit clever but I'm going to do this I
want to append the next image there
images one and now I want to specify a
duration of 200 milliseconds for each of
these frames and I want this to Loop
forever and if you specify Loop equals
zero that is time 0 it means it's just
not going to Loop a finite number of
times but an infinite number of times
instead and I need to do one other thing
recall that sys.org V contains not just
the words I typed after my program's
name but what else does sys.org v
contain if you think back to our
discussion of command line arguments
what else is insist.org V besides the
words I'm about to type like costume
1.jif and costume two yeah so we'll
actually get in that their original name
of the program we want to run the
costume set python indeed we'll get the
original name of the program costumes.pi
in this case which is not a gif
obviously so remember that using slices
in Python we can do this if sys.orgby is
a list and we want to get a slice of
that list everything after the first
element we can do one colon which says
start it location one not zero and take
a slice all the way to the end so give
me everything except the first thing in
that list which to McKenzie's point is
the name of the program
now if I haven't made any mistakes let's
see what happens I'm going to run python
of costumes.pi and now I'm going to
specify the two images that I want to
animate so costume one dot GIF and
costume2.gif
what is the code now going to do well to
recap we're using the sys library to
access those command line arguments
we're using the pillow library to treat
those files as images and with all the
functionality that comes with that
Library I'm using this images list just
to accumulate all of these images one at
a time from the command line and in line
seven through nine I'm just using a loop
to iterate over all of them and just add
them to this list after opening them
with the library and the last step which
is really just one line of code broken
onto three so that it all fits I'm going
to save the first image but I'm asking
the library to append this other image
to it as well not bracket zero but
bracket one and if I had more I could
express those as well I want to save all
of these files together I want to pause
200 milliseconds a fifth of a second in
between each frame and I want it to Loop
infinitely many times so now if I cross
my fingers as always hit enter
nothing bad happened and that's almost
always a good thing let me now run code
of costumes dot Jif to open up in vs
code the final image and what I think I
should see is a very happy cat and
indeed so now we've seen not only that
we can read and write files be it
textually we can read and now write
files that are binary zeros and ones
we've just scratched the surface this is
using the library called pillow But
ultimately this is going to give us the
ability to read and write files however
we want so we've now seen that via file
i o we can manipulate not just textual
files be it txt files or csvs but even
binary files as well in this case they
happen to be images but if we dived in
deeper we could find explore audio and
video and so much more all by way of
these simple Primitives this ability
somehow to read and write files that's
it for now we'll see you next time
[Music]
thank you
all right this is cs50's Introduction to
programming with python my name is David
Malin and this is our week on regular
Expressions so a regular expression
otherwise known as a regex is really
just a pattern and indeed it's quite
common in programming to want to use
patterns to match on some kind of data
often user input for instance if the
user types in an email address whether
to your program or a website or an app
on your phone you might ideally want to
be able to validate that they did indeed
type in an email address and not
something completely different so using
regular Expressions we're going to have
the Newfound capability to Define
patterns in our code to compare them
against data that we're receiving from
someone else whether it's just a
validated or heck even if we want to
clean up a whole lot of data that itself
might be messy because it too came from
us humans before though we use these
regular Expressions let me propose that
we solve a few problems using just some
simpler syntax and see what kind of
limitations we run up against let me
propose that I open up VSCO code here
and let me create a file called
validate.pi the goal at hand being to
validate how about just that a user's
email address they've come to your app
they've come to your website they type
in their email address and we want to
say yes or no this email address looks
valid all right let me go ahead and type
code of validate.pi to create a new tab
here and then within this tab let me go
ahead and start writing some code how
about that keeps things simple initially
first let me go ahead and prompt the
user for their email address and I'll
store the return value of input in a
variable called email asking them what's
your email question mark I'm going to go
ahead and preemptively at least clean up
the user's input a little bit by
minimally just calling strip at the end
of my call to input because recall that
input returns a string or a stir stirs
come with some built-in methods or
functions one of which is strip which
has the effect of stripping off any
leading white space to the left or any
trailing white space to the right so
that's just going to go ahead and at
least least avoid the human having
accidentally typed in a space character
we're going to throw it away just in
case now I'm going to do something
simple
for a user's input to be an email
address I think we can all agree that
it's got to minimally have an at sign
somewhere in it so let's start simple if
the user has typed in something with an
at sign let's very generously just say
Okay valid it looks like an email
address and if we're missing that at
sign let's say invalid because clearly
it's not an email address it's not going
to be the best version of my code yet
but we'll start simple so I'm going to
ask the question if there is an at
symbol in the user's email address go
ahead and print out for instance quote
unquote valid else if there's not now
I'm pretty confident that the email
address is in fact invalid now what is
this code doing well if at sign in email
is a pythonic way of asking is this
string quote unquote at in this other
string email no matter where it is at
the beginning the middle of the end it's
going to automatically search through
the entire string for you automatically
I could do this more verbosely and I
could use a for Loop or a while loop and
look get every character in The user's
email address looking to see if it's an
at sign but this is one of the things
that's nice about python you can do more
with less so just by saying if at quote
unquote in email we're achieving that
same result we're going to get back true
if it's somewhere in there thus valid or
false if it is not well let me go ahead
now and run this program in my terminal
window with python of validate.pi and
I'm going to go ahead and give it my
email address mailon harvard.edu enter
and indeed it's valid looks valid is
valid but of course this program's
technically broken it's buggy what would
be an example input if someone might
like to volunteer and answer here that
would be considered valid but you and I
know it really isn't valid yeah thank
you well please just you can type just
to science science and visit and still
be able to still be violated according
to your program but the same exactly
we've set a very low bar here in fact if
I go ahead and rerun Python and
validate.pi and I'll just type been one
at sign that's it no username no domain
name this doesn't really look like an
email address but unfortunately my code
thinks it in fact is because it's
obviously just looking for an at sign
alone well how could we improve this
well minimally an email address I I
think tends to have though this is not
actually a requirement tends to have an
at sign and a single dot at least maybe
somewhere in the domain name so mailing
at harvard.edu so let's check for that
dot as well again strictly speaking
doesn't even have to be that case but
I'm going for my own email address at
least for now as our test case so let me
go ahead and change my code now and say
not only if at is an email but also uh
dot is in email as well so I'm asking
now two questions I have two Boolean
Expressions if at an email and I'm
ending them together logically this is a
logical and so to speak so if it's the
case that at is an email and Dot is an
email okay now I'm going to go ahead and
say valid all right this would still
seem to work for my email address let me
go ahead and run python validate.pi
Malin harvard.edu enter and that of
course is valid as expected but here too
we can be a little adversarial and type
in something nonsensical like at Dot and
unfortunately that too is going to be
mistaken as valid even though there's
still no username domain name or
anything like that so I think we need to
be a little more methodical here in fact
notice that if I do this like this the
at sign can be anywhere and the dot can
be anywhere but if I'm assuming the user
is going to have a traditional domain
name like harvard.edu or gmail.com I
really want to look for the dot in the
domain name only not necessarily just
the username so let me go ahead and do
this let me go ahead and introduce a bit
more logic here and instead do this let
me go ahead and do email dot split of
quote unquote at sign so email again is
a string or a stir stirs come with
methods not just strip but also another
one called split that is the name
implies we'll split one stir into
multiple ones if you give it a character
or more to split on so this oh is
hopefully going to return to me two
parts from a traditional email address
the username and the domain name and it
turns out I can unpack that sequence of
responses by doing this username comma
domain equals this I could store it in a
list or some other structure but if I
already know in advance what kinds of
values I'm expecting a username and
hopefully a domain I'm going to go ahead
and do it like this instead and just
Define two variables at once on one line
of code and now I'm going to be a little
more precise if username uh uh if
username then I'm going to go ahead and
say print valid else I'm going to go
ahead and say print invalid now this
isn't good enough but I'm at least
checking for the presence of a username
now and you might not have seen this
before but if you simply ask a question
like if username and username is a
string well username if username is
going to give me a true answer if
username is anything except none or
quote unquote nothing so there's a
truthy value here whereby if username
has at least one character that's going
to be considered true but if username
has no characters it's going to be
considered a false value effectively but
this isn't good enough I don't want to
just check for username I want to also
check that it's the case that dot is in
the domain name as well so notice here
there's a bid of potential confusion
with the English language here I seem to
be saying if username and Dot in domain
as though I'm asking the question if the
username and the dot are in the domain
but that's not what this means these are
two separate Boolean Expressions if
username and separately
if dot in domain and if I parenthesize
this we could make that even more clear
by putting parentheses there parentheses
here so just to be clear it's really two
Boolean Expressions that we're ending
together not one longer english-like
sentence now if I go ahead and run this
python of uh validate.pi enter I'll do
my own email address again mailing
harbor.edu and that's valid and it looks
like I could tolerate something like
this if I do mail-in at just say Harvard
I think at the moment this is going to
be invalid now maybe the top level
domain Harvard exists but at the moment
it looks like we're looking for
something more we're looking for a top
level domain too like dot edu so for now
we'll just consider this to be invalid
but it's not just that we want to do
it's not just that we want to check for
the presence of a username and the
presence of a dot let's be more specific
let's start to now narrow the scope of
this program not just to be about
generic emails more generally but about
edu addresses so specifically for
someone in a U.S University for instance
whose email address tends to end with
DOT edu I can be a little more precise
and you might recall this function
already instead of just saying is there
a dots somewhere in domain let me
instead say and the domain ends with
quote
unquote.edu so now we're being even more
precise we want there to be minimally a
username that's not empty it's not just
quote unquote nothing and we want the
domain name to actually end with DOT edu
let me go ahead and run Python and
validate.pi and just to make sure I
haven't made things even worse let me at
least test my own email address which
does seem to be valid now it seems that
I minimally need to provide a username
because we definitely do have that check
in place so I'm going to go ahead and
say Malin and now I'm going to go ahead
and say at and it looks like I could be
a little malicious here just say
mailen.edu as though minimally meeting
the requirements of this of this pattern
and that of course is considered valid
but I'm pretty sure there's no one at
mailen.edu we need to have some domain
name in there so we're still not being
quite as generous now we could
absolutely continue to iterate on this
program and we could add some more
Boolean Expressions we could maybe use
some other python methods for checking
more precisely is there something to the
left of the dot to the right of the dot
we could use split multiple times but
honestly this just escalates quickly
like you end up having to write a lot of
code just to express something that's
relatively simple in spirit just format
this like an email address so how can we
go about improving this well it turns
out in Python there's a library for
regular Expressions it's called
succinctly re and in the re Library you
have a lot of capabilities to Define and
check for and even replace patterns
again a regular expression is a pattern
and this Library the re library in
Python is going to let us to Define some
of these patterns like a pattern for an
email address and then use some built-in
functions to actually validate a user's
input against that pattern or even use
these patterns to change the user's
input or extract partial information
there from we'll see examples of all
this and more so what can and should I
do with this Library well first and
foremost it comes with a lot of
functionality here is the URL for
instance to the official documentation
and let me propose that we focus on
using one of the most versatile
functions in the library library namely
this search
re.search is the name of the function in
the re module that allows you to pass in
a few arguments the first is going to be
a pattern that you want to search for in
for instance a string that came from a
user the string argument here is going
to be the actual string that you want to
search for that pattern and then there's
a third argument optionally that's a
whole bunch of flags a flag in general
is like a a parameter you can pass in to
modify the behavior of the function but
initially we're not even going to use
this we're just going to pass in a cup
couple of arguments instead so let me go
ahead and employ this re Library this
regular expression library and just
improve on this design incrementally so
we're not going to solve this problem
all at once but we'll take some
incremental steps I'm going to go back
to vs code here and I'm going to go
ahead now and get rid of most of this
code but I'm going to go into the top of
my file in first and fall import this re
Library so import re gives me access to
that function and more now after I've
gotten the user's input in the same way
as before stripping off any leading or
trailing white space I'm just going to
use this function super trivially for
now even though this isn't really a big
step forward I'm going to say if re dot
search
contains quote-unquote at in the email
address then let's go ahead and print
valid else let's go ahead and print
invalid at the moment this is really no
better than my very first version where
I was just asking python if at sign in
the email address but now I'm at least
beginning to use this Library by using
its own re.search function which for now
you can assume returns a True Value
effectively if indeed the at sign is an
email just to make sure that this
version does work as I expect let me go
ahead and run Python A validate.pi and
enter I'll type in my actual email
address and we're back in business but
of course this is not great because if I
similarly run this version of the
program and just type in an at sign not
an email address and yet my code of
course thinks it is valid so how can I
do better than this well we need a bit
more vocabulary in the realm of regular
expressions in order to be able to
express ourselves a little more
precisely really the pattern I want to
ultimately Define is going to be
something like I want there to be
something to the left then an at sign
then something to the right and that
something to the right should end with
DOT edu but should also have something
before the dot edu like Harvard or Yale
or any other school in the U.S as well
well how can I go about doing this well
it turns out that in the world of
regular Expressions whether in python or
a lot of other languages as well there
are certain symbols that you can use to
define patterns at the moment I've just
used literal raw text if I go back to my
code here this technically qualifies as
a regular expression I've passed in a
quoted string inside of which is an at
sign now that's not a very interesting
pattern it's just an at sign but it
turns out that once you have access to
regular expressions or a library that
offers that feature you can more
powerfully express yourself as follows
let me reveal that the pattern that you
passed re.search can take a whole bunch
of special symbols and here's just some
of them in the examples we're about to
see in the patterns we're about to
Define here are the special symbols you
can use a single period a DOT to just
represent any character except a new
line a blank line so that is to say if I
don't really care what letters of the
alphabet are in the user's username I
just want there to be one or more
characters uh in the user's name dot
allows me to express a through z
uppercase and lowercase and a bunch of
other letters as well star is going to
mean in single asterisk zero or more
repetitions so if I say something star
that means that I'm willing to accept
either zero repetitions that is nothing
at all or more repetitions one or two or
three or three hundred if you see a plus
in my patterns that's going to mean one
or more repetitions that is to say
there's got to be at least one character
there one symbol and then there's
optionally more after that and then you
can say zero or one repetition you can
use a single question mark after a
symbol and that will say I want 0 of
this character or one but that's all
I'll expect and then lastly there's
going to be a way to specify a specific
number of symbols if you use these curly
braces and a number represented here
symbolically as M you can specify that
you want M repetitions be it one or two
or three or three hundred you can
specify the number of repetitions
yourself and if you want a range of
repetitions like you want this few
characters or this many characters you
can use curly braces and two numbers
inside called here M and N which would
be a range of M through n repetitions
now what does all of this mean well let
me go back to vs code here and let me
propose that we iterate on this solution
further it's not sufficient to just
check for the at sign we know that
already we minimally want something to
the left and to the right so how can I
represent that I don't really care what
the user's username is or what letters
of the alphabet are in it be it Malin or
anyone else's so what I'm going to do to
the left of this equal sign is I'm going
to use a single period the dot that
again indicates any character except for
a new line but I don't just want a
single character otherwise the person's
username could only be a at such and
such or B at such and such I want it to
be multiple such characters so I'm going
to initially use a star so dot star
means give me something to the left and
I'm going to do another one dot star
something to the right now this isn't
perfect but it's at least a step forward
because now what I'm going to go ahead
and do is this I'm going to rerun python
to validate.pi I'm going to keep testing
my own email address just to make sure I
haven't made things worse and that's now
okay I'm now going to go ahead and type
in some other input like how about just
Malin at with no domain name whatsoever
and you would think this is going to be
invalid but but but
it's still considered valid but why is
that if I go back to this chart why is
Malin at with no domain now considered
valid
what's my mistake here
by having used dot star at dot Star as
my regular expression or regex because
you're using the star instead of the
plus sign exactly the star again means
zero or more repetitions so re.search is
perfectly happy to accept nothing after
the equal after the at sign because that
would be zero repetitions so I think I
minimally need to evolve this and go
back to my code here and let me go ahead
and change this from dot star to dot
plus and let me change the ending from
dot star to dot plus so that now when I
run my code here let me go ahead and run
python validate.pi I'm going to test my
email address as always still working
now let me go ahead and type in that
same thing from before that was
accidentally considered valid now I hit
enter finally it's invalid so now we're
making some progress on being a little
more precise as to what it is we're
doing now I'll note here like with
almost everything in programming python
included there's often multiple ways to
solve the same problem and does anyone
see away in my code here that I can make
a slight tweak if I forgot that the plus
operator exists and go back to using a
star if I allowed you only to use dots
and only Stars could you recreate the
notion of plus yes
um use another Dot dot dot start yeah
because if a DOT means any character
we'll just use a DOT and then when you
want to say or more use another Dot and
then the star so equivalent to dot plus
would have been dot dot star because the
first dot means any character and the
second pair of characters dot star means
zero or more other characters and to be
clear it does not have to be the same
character just by doing Dot or dot star
does not mean your whole username needs
to be a or a A or AAA or AAA it can vary
with each symbol it just means zero or
more of any character back to back so I
could do this on both the left and the
right which one is better you know it
depends I think uh an argument could be
made that this is even more clear
because it's obvious now that there's a
DOT which means any character and then
there's the dot star but if you're in
the habit of doing this frequently one
of the reasons things like the plus
exist is just to consolidate your code
into something a little more succinct
and if you're familiar with seeing the
plus now maybe this is more readable to
you so again just like with python more
generally you're going to often see
different ways to express the same
patterns and reasonable people might
agree or disagree as to which way is
better than another well let me propose
to you that we can think about both of
these models a little more graphically
if this looks a little cryptic to you
let me go ahead and Rewind to the
previous incarnation of this regular
expression which was just a single dot
star this regular expression dot star at
dot star means what again it means zero
or more characters followed by a literal
at sign followed by zero or more other
characters now when you pass this
pattern in as an argument to re.search
it's going to read it from left to right
and then use it to try to match against
the input email in this case that the
user typed in now how is the computer
how is re.search going to keep track of
whether or not the user's email matches
this pattern well it turns out that it's
going to be using a machine of sorts
implemented in software known as a
finite State machine or more formally a
non-deterministic finite automaton and
the way it works if we depict this
graphically is as follows the re.search
function starts over here in a so-called
start State that's the sort of condition
in which it begins and then it's going
to read the user's email address from
left to right and it's going to decide
whether or not to stay in this first
state or transition to the next state so
for instance in this first state as the
user is reading my email address mailin
harvard.edu it's going to follow this
curved edge up and around to itself a
reflexive Edge and it's labeled dot
because dot again just means any
character so as the function is reading
my email address mailing at harvard.edu
from left to right it's going to follow
these transitions as follows m
a l a n and then it's hopefully going to
follow this transition to the second
state because there's a literal at sign
both in this machine as well as in my
email address then it's going to try to
read the rest of my address h a r v a r
d dot e d u and that's it and then the
computer is going to check did it end up
in a an accept state a final State
that's actually depicted here
pictorially a little differently with
double circles one inside of the other
and that just means that if the computer
finds itself in that second accept state
after having read all of the user's
input it is indeed a valid email address
if by some chance the machine somehow
ended up stuck in that first date which
does not have double circles and it is
therefore not an accept state the
computer would conclude this is an
invalid email address instead by
contrast if we go back to my other
version of the code where I instead had
dot Plus on both the left and the the
right recall that ari.search is going to
use one of these State machines in order
to decide from left to right whether or
not to accept the user's input like
Malin harvard.edu can we get from the
start state so to speak to an accept
state to decide Yep this was in fact
meeting the pattern well let's propose
that this non-deterministic finite
automaton looked like this instead we're
going to start as before in the leftmost
start State and we're going to
necessarily consume one character per
this first Edge which is labeled with
the dot to indicate that we can consume
any one character like the m in Malin
harvard.edu then we can spend some time
consuming more characters before the at
sign so the a l a n then we can consume
the at sign then we can consume at least
one more character because recall that
the regex has dot plus this time and
then we can consume even more characters
if we want so if we first consume the H
in harvard.edu that then leaves the a r
v a r d and then dot e d u and now here
too we're at the end of the story but
we're in an accept state because that
circle at the end has two circles total
which means that if the computer if this
function finds itself in that accept
state after reading the entirety of the
user's input it is to in fact a valid
email address if by contrast we had
gotten stuck in one of those other
states unable to follow a transition one
of those edges and therefore unable to
make progress in the user's input from
left to right then we would have to
conclude that that email address is in
fact invalid well how can we go upon
improving this code further let me
propose now that we check not only for
our username and also something after
the username like a domain name but
minimally required that the string ends
with DOT edu as well well I think I
could do this fairly straightforward not
only do I want there to be something
after the at sign like the domain like
Harvard I want the whole thing to end
with DOT EDU
but there's a little bit of danger here
what have I done wrong by implementing
my regular expression now in this way by
using dot Plus at dot plus dot edu what
could go wrong with this version
uh the dot is in a DOT means something
else in this context where it means
three or multiplications of a character
which is rightly interpreted differently
exactly even though I mean for it to
mean literally.edu a period and then dot
edu unfortunately in the world of
regular Expressions dot means any
character which means that this string
could technically end in a e d u or b e
d u or c e d u and so forth but that's
not in fact that I want so any instincts
now as to how I could fix this problem
and let me demonstrate the problem more
clearly let me go ahead and run this
code here let me go ahead and type in
Malin harvard.edu and as always this
does in fact work but Watch What Happens
here let me go ahead and do Malin at
Harvard and then mailing at Harvard
question mark edu enter that too is
valid so I could put any character there
and it's still going to be accepted but
I don't want question mark edu I want
dot edu literally any instinct thinks
then for how we can solve this problem
here how can I get this new function
re.search and a regular expression more
generally to literally mean a dot might
you think you can use the Escape
character the backslash indeed the
so-called Escape character which we've
seen before outside of the context of
regular Expressions when we talked about
new lines backslash n was a way of
telling the computer I want a new line
but without actually literally hitting
enter and moving the cursor yourself and
you don't want a literal n on the screen
so backslash n was a way to escape and
and convey that you want a new line it
turns out regular Expressions use a
similar technique to solve this problem
here in fact let me go into my regular
expression and before that final dot let
me put a single backslash in the world
of regular Expressions this is a
so-called special sequence and it
indicates per this backslash and a
single dot that I literally want to
match on a DOT it's not that I want to
match on any character and then edu I
want to match on a DOT or a period EDU
but we don't want python to misinterpret
this backslash is beginning a an escape
sequence something special like
backslash n which even though we as the
programmer might type two characters
backslash in it really is interpreted by
python as a single new line we don't
want any kind of misinterpretation like
that here so it turns out there's one
other thing we should do for regular
expressions like this that have a
backslash used in this way I want to
specify to python that I want this
string this regular expression and
double quotes to be treated as a raw
string literally putting an r at the
beginning of the string to indicate to
python that you should not try to
interpret any backslashes in the usual
way I want to literally pass the
backslash and the dot and the edu into
this particular function search in this
case so it's similar in spirits using
that F at the beginning of a format
string which of course tells python to
format the string in a certain way
plugging in variables that might be
between curly braces but in this case r
indicates a raw string that I want
passed in exactly as is now it's only
strictly necessary if you are in fact
using backslashes to indicate that you
want some special sequence like
backslash dot but in general it's
probably a good habit to get into to
just use raw strings for all of your
regular Expressions so that if you
eventually go back in make a change make
an addition you don't accidentally
introduce a backslash and then forget
that that might have some special or
misinterpreted meaning well let me go
ahead and try this new regular
expression I'll clear my terminal window
run python or validate
run python of validate.pi and then I'll
type in my email address correctly
mailing harvard.edu and that's
fortunately still valid Let Me Clear My
screen and run it one more time
pythonvalidate.pi and this time let's
mistype it as Malin at Harvard question
mark edu whereby there's obviously not a
DOT there but there is some other Single
Character that last time was
misinterpreted as valid but this time
now that I've improved my regular
expression it's discovered as indeed
invalid any questions now on this
technique for matching something to the
left of the at sign something to the
right and now ending with DOT edu
explicitly
um what happens
a good question and you kind of called
me out here well when in doubt let's try
let me go ahead and do
pythonvalidate.pi mailin at at
harvard.edu which also is incorrect
unfortunately my code thinks it's valid
so another problem to solve but a
shortcoming for now other questions on
these regular Expressions thus far can
you use uh curly brackets M instead of
backslash can you use curly brackets
instead of backslash not in this case if
you want a literal dot backslash dot is
the way to do it literally how about one
other question on regular expressions
is this the same thing that Google forms
uses in order to categorize data in
let's say some if you've got multiple
people sending in requests about some
feedback
do they categorize the data that they
get using this particular regular
expression things indeed if you've ever
used Google forms to not just submit it
but to create a Google form one of the
menu options is for response validation
in English at least and what that allows
you to do is specify that the user has
to input an email address or a URL or a
string of some length but there's an
even more powerful feature that some of
you may not have ever noticed and indeed
if you'd like to open up Google forms
create a new form temporarily and poke
around you will actually see in English
at least quote-unquote regular
expression mentioned as one of the
mechanisms you can use to validate your
user's input into your Google form so in
fact after today you can start avoiding
the specific drop downs of like email
address or URL or the like and you can
express your own patterns precisely as
well regular Expressions can even be
used in vs code itself if you go and
find or do a find and replace in vs code
you can of course just type in words
like you could into my Microsoft Word or
Google Docs you can also type if you
check the right box regular expressions
and start searching for patterns not
literally specific values well let me
propose that we now enhance this
implementation further by introducing a
few other symbols because right now with
my code I keep saying that I want my
email address to end with DOT edu and
start with a username but I'm being a
little too generous this does in fact
work as expected for my own email
address Malin harvard.edu but what if I
type in a sentence like my email address
is
mailenharvard.edu and suppose I've typed
that into the program or I've typed that
into a Google form is this going to be
considered valid or invalid
well let's consider it's got the at sign
so we're good there it's got one or more
characters to the left of the at sign
it's got one or more characters to the
right of the at sign it's got a
literal.edu somewhere in there to the
right of the at sign and granted there's
more stuff to the right there's
literally this period at the end of my
English sentence but that's okay because
at the moment my regular expression is
not so precise as to say the pattern
must start with the username and end
with the dot edu technically it's left
unsaid what more can be to the left and
what more can be to the right so when I
hit enter now you'll see that that whole
sentence in English is valid and that's
obviously not what you want in fact
consider the case of using Google forms
or Office 365 to collect data from users
if you don't validate your input your
users might very well type in a full
sentence or something else with a
typographical error not an actual email
so if you're just trying to copy all of
the results that have been typed into
your form so you can paste them into
Gmail or some email program it's going
to break because you're going to
accidentally pay something like a whole
English sentence into the program
instead of just an email address which
is what your mailer expects so how can I
be more precise well let me propose we
introduce a few more symbols as well it
turns out in the context of a regular
expression one of these patterns you can
use the carrot symbol the little
triangular Mark to represent that you
want this pattern to match the start of
the string specifically not anywhere but
the start of the user string by contrast
you can use a dollar sign in your
regular expression to say that you want
to match the end of the string or
technically just before the new line at
the end of the string but for all
intents and purposes think of carrot as
meaning start of the string and dollar
sign is meaning end of the string it is
a weird thing that one is a carrot and
one is a dollar sign these are not
really things that I think of as
opposites like a parenthesis or
something like that but those are the
symbols the World shows many years ago
so let me go back to vs code now and let
me add this feature to my code here let
me specify that yes I do want to search
for this pattern but I want the user's
input to start with this pattern and end
with this pattern so even though it's
going to start looking even more cryptic
I put a carrot symbol here at the
beginning and I put a dollar sign here
at the end that does not mean I want the
user to type a carrot symbol or a dollar
sign this is special symbology that
indicates to re.search that it should
only look for now an exact match against
this pattern so if I now go back to my
terminal window and I'll leave the
previous result on the screen let me
type the exact same thing my email
address is mailing harbor.edu enter
sorry a period and now I'm going to go
ahead and hit enter now that's
considered invalid but let me clear the
screen and just to make sure I didn't
break things let me type in just my
email address and that too is valid any
questions now on this version of my
regular expression which note goes
further to specify even more precisely
that I want it to match at the start and
the end
any questions on this one here
okay you have slash and Dot edu and then
the dollar sign but that is like uh one
of the regular expression right
it normally is but this backslash that I
deliberately put before this period here
is an escape character it is a way of
telling our e.search that I don't want
any character there I literally want a
period there and it's the only way you
can distinguish one from the other if I
got rid of that slash this would mean
that the email address just has to end
with any character then an e then a d
then a u i don't want that I want
literally a period Then the E then the D
then the U this is actually common
convention in programming and technology
in general if you and I decide on a
convention whereby we're using some
character on the keyboard to mean
something special invariably we create a
future problem for ourselves when we
want to literally use that same
character and so the solution in general
to that problem is to somehow escape the
character so that it's clear to the
computer that it's not that special
symbol it's literally the symbol it sees
so we don't even know that we don't need
another another slash before the dollar
sign
no uh because in this case dollar sign
means something special per this chart
here dollar sign by itself does not mean
US dollars or currency it literally
means match the end of the string if
however I wanted the user to literally
type in a dollar sign at the end of
their input the solution would be the
same I would put a backslash before the
dollar sign which means my email address
would have to be something like mailing
harvard.edu dollar sign which is
obviously not correct too so backslashes
just allow you to tell the computer to
not treat those symbols specially likes
meaning something special but to treat
them literally instead how about one
other question here on regular
expressions
to make it one plus then you said one
was to make it one with nothing sure
rewind in time I think what you're
referring to is one of our earlier
versions that initially looked like this
which just meant Zero or more characters
than an at sign then zero or more other
characters we then evolved that to be
this dot Plus on both sides which means
one or more characters on the left than
an at sign then one or more characters
on the right and if I'm interpreting
your question correctly one of the
points I made earlier was that if you
didn't use Plus or forgot that it exists
you could equivalently achieve the exact
same result with two dots and a star
because the first dot means any
character it's got to be there the
second dot star means zero or more other
characters and same on the right so it's
just another way of expressing the same
idea one or more can be represented like
this with dot dot star or you can just
use the handier syntax of dot plus which
means the same thing all right so I dare
say there's still some problems with the
regular expression in this current form
because even though now we're starting
to look for the username at the
beginning of the string from the user
and we're looking for the dot edu
literally at the end of the string from
the user those dots are a little too
encompassing right now I am allowed to
type in more than the single at sign y
because at is a character and Dot means
any character so honestly I can have as
many at signs as this thing at the
moment as I want for instance if I run
Python and validate.pi mailing at
harvard.edu still works as expected but
if I also run python to validate.pi and
incorrectly do Malin at harvard.edu to
you that should be invalid but it's
considered valid instead so I think we
need to be a little more restrictive
when it comes to that dot and we can't
just say oh any old character there is
fine we need to be more specific well it
turns out that regular Expressions also
support this syntax you can use square
brackets inside of your pattern and
inside of those square brackets
include one or more characters that you
want to look for specifically
alternatively you can inside of those
square brackets put a carrot symbol
which unfortunately in this context
means something completely different
from match the start of the string but
this would be the complement operator
inside of these square brackets which
means you cannot match any of these
characters so things are about to look
even more cryptic now but that's why
we're focusing on regular Expressions on
their own here if I don't want to allow
any character which is what a DOT is let
me go ahead and I could just say well I
only want to support a or B's or C's or
D's or E's or F's or G's I could type in
the whole alphabet here plus some
numbers to actually include all of the
letters that I do want to allow but
honestly a little simpler would be this
I could use a carrot symbol and then an
at sign which has the effect of saying
this is the set of characters that has
everything except an at sign and I can
do the same thing over here instead of a
DOT to the right of the at sign I can do
Open Bracket
carrot at sign and I admit things are
starting to escalate quickly here but
let's start from the left and go to the
right this carrot outside of the square
brackets at the very start of my string
as before means match from the start of
the string and let's Jump Ahead the
dollar sign all the way at the end of
the regular expression means match at
the end of the string so if we can
mentally take those off as
straightforward let's now focus on
everything else in the middle well to
the left here we have new syntax a
square bracket another carrot an at sign
and a closed square bracket and then a
plus the plus means the same thing as
always it means one or more of the
things to the left what is the thing to
the left well this is the new send text
inside of square brackets here I have a
carrot symbol and then an at sign that
just means any character except an at
sign it's a weird syntax but this is how
we can express that simple idea any
character on the keyboard except except
for an at sign and heck even other
characters that aren't physically on
your keyboard but that nonetheless exist
then we have a literal at sign then we
have another one of these same things
square bracket carrot at close bracket
which means any character except an at
sign then one or more of those things
followed by literally a period e d u so
now let me go ahead and do this again
let me rerun python to validate.pi and
test my own email address to make sure
I've not made things worse and we're
good now let me go ahead and clear my
screen and run Python and validate.pi
again and do Malin at at
harvard.edu crossing my fingers this
time and finally this now is invalid why
I'm allowing myself to have one at sign
in the middle of the user's input but
everything to the left per this new
syntax cannot be an at sign it can be
anything but one or more times and
everything to the right of the at sign
can be anything but in at sign one or
more time is followed by lastly a
literal.edu so again the new syntax is
quite simply this square brackets allow
you to specify a set of characters that
you literally type out at your keyboard
a b c d e f or the complement the
opposite the carrot symbol which means
not and then the one or more symbols you
want to exclude
questions now on this syntax here so
right after add sign can we use the
curly brackets M uh one so that we can
only have one repetition of the ad
symbol absolutely so we could do this
let me go ahead and pull up vs code and
let me delete the current form of a
regular expression and go back to where
we began which was just dot star at and
Dot star I could absolutely do something
like this and require that I want at
least one of any character here and then
I could do something more to have any
more as well so the curly brace syntax
which we saw on the slide earlier but
didn't yet use absolutely can be used to
specify a specific number of characters
but honestly this is more verbose than
is necessary the best solution arguably
or the simplest at least ultimately is
just to say dot plus but there too
another example of how you can solve the
same problem multiple ways let me go
back to where the regular expression
just was and take other questions as
well questions on the sets of characters
or complementing
that's set
so can you use that same syntax to say
that you don't want a certain character
throughout the whole string you could
it's going to be uh you could absolutely
use the same character to exclude
um
you could absolutely use this syntax to
exclude a certain character from the
entire string but it would be a little
harder right now because we're still
requiring.edu at the end but yes
absolutely
other questions what happens if the user
inputs.edu in the beginning of the thing
a good question what happens if the user
types in edu at the beginning of the
screen well let me go back to vs code
here and let's try to solve this in two
different ways first let's look at the
regular expression and see if we can
infer if that's going to be tolerated
well according to the current cryptic
regular expression I'm saying that you
can have any character except the at
sign so that would work I could have the
dot for the dot edu but then I have to
have an at sign so that wouldn't really
work because if I'm just typing in edu
we're not going to pass that constraint
so now let me try this in by running the
program let me type in just
literally.edu that doesn't work but but
but I could do this dot
edu.edu that too is invalid but let me
do this dot edu at
something.edu that that passes so it's
starting to get a little weird now maybe
it's valid maybe it's not but I think
we'll eventually be more precise too
about one more question on this regular
expression
and these complementing of sets can we
use uh another domain name
the string input can you use another
domain name absolutely I'm using my own
just for the sake of demonstration but
you could absolutely use any domain or
top level domain and I'm using dot edu
which is very U.S Centric but this would
absolutely work exactly the same for any
top level domain all right let me go and
head now and propose that we improve
this regular expression further because
if I pull it up again in vs code here
you'll see that I'm being a little too
tolerant still it turns out that there
are certain requirements for someone's
username and domain name in an email
address there is an official standard in
the world for what an email address can
be and what characters can be in it and
this is way too accommodating of all the
characters in the world except for the
at symbol so let's actually narrow the
definition of what we're going to
tolerate in usernames and companies like
Gmail could certainly do this as well
suppose that it's not just that I want
to exclude at science suppose that I
only want to allow for say characters
that normally appear in words like
letters of the alphabet A through Z be
it uppercase or lowercase maybe some
numbers and heck maybe even an
underscore could be allowed too well we
can use this same square bracket syntax
to specify a set of characters as
follows I could do a b c d e f g h i j
oh my God this is going to take forever
I'm gonna have to type out all 26
letters of the alphabet both lowercase
and uppercase so let me stop doing that
there's a better way already if you want
to specify Within These square brackets
a range of letters you can actually just
do a hyphen if you literally do a hyphen
Z in these square brackets the computer
is going to know you mean a through z
you do not need to type 26 letters of
the alphabet if you want to include
uppercase letters as well you just do
the same no spaces no commas you
literally just keep typing a through
capital Z so I have little a hyphen
little Z big a hyphen big Z no spaces no
commas no separators you just keep
specifying those ranges if I
additionally want numbers I could do 0 1
2 3 4 no you don't need to type in all
10 decimal digits you can just say 0
through 9 using a hyphen as well and if
you now want to support underscores as
well which is pretty common in usernames
for email addresses you can literally
just type in underscore at the at the
end notice that all of these characters
are inside of square brackets which just
again means here is a set of characters
that I want to allow I have not used a
carrot symbol at the beginning of this
whole thing because I don't want to
complement it complement it with an E
not complement it with an i I want don't
want to complement it by making it the
opposite I literally want to accept only
these characters I'm going to go ahead
and do the same thing on the right if I
want to require that the domain name
similarly come from this set of
characters which admittedly is a little
too narrow but it's familiar for now so
we'll keep it simple I'm going to go
ahead and paste that exact same set of
characters over there to the right and
so now it's much more restrictive now
I'm going to go ahead and run
pythonvalidate.pi I'm going to test my
own email address and we're still good
I'm going to clear my screen and run it
once more this time trying to break it
let me go ahead and do something like
how about David underscore Malin
harvard.edu enter but that too is going
to be valid but if I do something
completely wrong again like Malin at at
harvard.edu that's still going to be
invalid why because my regular
expression currently only allows for a
single at in the middle because
everything to the left must be alpha
numeric alphabetical or numeric or an
underscore the same thing to the right
followed by the dot edu now honestly
this is a regular expression that you
might be in the habit of typing in the
real world as in as cryptic as this
might look this is the world of reg
regular Expressions so you'll get more
comfortable with this syntax over time
but thankfully some of these patterns
are so common that there are built-in
shortcuts for representing some of the
same information that is to say you
don't have to constantly type out all of
the symbols that you want to include
because odds are some other programmer
has had the same problem so built into
regular Expressions themselves are some
additional patterns you can use and in
fact I can go ahead and get rid of this
entire set a through z lowercase A
through Z uppercase zero through nine
and an underscore and just replace it
with a single backslash W backslash W in
this case represents a word character
which is commonly known as a alpha
numeric symbol or the underscore as well
I'm going to do the same thing over here
I'm going to highlight the entire set of
square brackets delete it and replace it
with a single backslash W and now I feel
like we're making progress because even
though it's cryptic and what if it
looked way cryptic a little bit ago
um
and even though it would have looked
even more cryptic a little bit ago now
it's at least starting to read a little
more friendly this carrot on the left
means start matching at the beginning of
the string backslash w means any word
character the plus means one or more at
symbol literally then another word
character one or more then a literal dot
then literally edu and then match at the
very end of the string and that's it so
there's more of these two and we won't
use them all here but here is a partial
list of the patterns you can use within
a regular expression one you have
backslash D for any decimal digit
decimal digit meaning zero through nine
commonly done here too is if you want to
do the opposite of that the complement
so to speak you can do backslash capital
D which is anything that's not a decimal
digit so it might be letters and
punctuation and other symbols as well
meanwhile backslash s means white space
characters like a single hit of the
space or maybe hitting tab on the
keyboard that's white space backslash
capital S is the opposite or complement
of that anything that's not a white
space character backslash W we've seen a
word character as well as numbers and
the underscore and if you want the
complement or opposite of that you can
use backslash capital W to give you
everything but a word character again
these are just common patterns that so
many people were presumably using in
yesteryear that it's now baked into the
regular expression syntax so that you
can more succinctly express your same
ideas
any questions then on this approach here
where we're now using backslash w
to represent my word character
uh so I don't want to ask about uh was
the uh actually the previous approach
like the square bracket approach could
we accept like uh lists in there yes
we'll see this before long but suppose
you wanted to tolerate not just.edu but
maybe dot edu or.com you could do this
you could introduce parentheses and then
you can or those together I could say
Com or edu I could also add in something
like in the US or gov or net or anything
else or org or the like and each of the
vertical bars here means something
special it means or and the parentheses
simply group things together formally
you have this syntax here A or B A or
vertical Bar B means a has to match or B
has to match where A and B can be any
other patterns you want in parentheses
you can group those things together so
just like math you can combine ideas
into one phrase and do this thing or the
other and there's other syntax as well
that we'll soon see other questions on
these regular expressions and this
syntax here
but if we put spaces in the expression
sure so if you want spaces in there you
can't use backslash W alone because that
is only a word character which is
alphabetical numerical or the underscore
but you could do this you could go back
to this approach whereby you use square
brackets and you could say A through Z
or a through z or zero through nine or
underscore or I'm going to hit the space
bar a single space you can put a literal
space inside of the square brackets
which will allow you then to detect a
space alternatively I could still use
backslash W but I could combine it as
follows I could say give me a backslash
W or a backslash s because recall that
backslash s is white space so it's even
more than a single space it could be a
tab but by putting those things in
parentheses now you can match either the
thing on the left or the thing on the
right one or more times how about one
other question on these regular
expressions
perfect so I was going to ask um does
the backslash W
um include a DOT uh because no no it
only includes letters numbers uh and
underscore that is it
and I was wondering you gave an example
at the beginning that had uh spaces like
this is my email so and so
um I don't think our current version uh
even quite quite a long while ago
stopped accepting it was that because of
the carrot uh or
because of something no the reason I was
handling spaces in other English words
when I typed out my email address as
mailing at harvard.edu was because we
were using initially dot star or dot
plus which is any character uh and even
after that we said anything except the
at sign which includes spaces only once
I started using square brackets and a
through z and zero through nine and
underscore did we finally get to the
point where we would reject white space
and in fact I can run this here let me
go into the current version of my code
in vs code which is using again the
backslash W's for word characters let me
run pythonvalidate.pi and incorrectly
type in something like my email address
is
mailenharvard.edu period which has
spaces to the left of my username and
that is now invalid because space is not
a word character your go Notes too that
technically I'm not allowing dots and
some of you might be thinking wait a
minute my gmail address has a dot in it
that's something we're going to still
have to fix a backslash W is not the
end-all here it's just allowing us to
express our previous solution a little
more succinctly now one thing we're
still not handling quite properly is
uppercase versus lowercase the backslash
W technically does handle lowercase
letters and uppercase because it's the
exact same thing as that set from before
which had a little a through little Z
and big a through big Z but watch this
let me go ahead in my current form run
pythonvalidate.pi and just because my
caps lock key is down mailin at
harvard.edu shouting my email address
it's going to be okay in terms of the
mailing it's going to be okay in terms
of the Harvard because those are
matching the backslash W which does
include lowercase and uppercase but I'm
about to see invalid why why is mailing
at harvard.edu invalid
when it's in all caps here even though
I'm using backslash W yeah so you are
asking for the domain.edu in lowercase
and you're typing it in uppercase
exactly I'm typing in my email address
in all uppercase but I'm looking for
literally.edu and as I see you with
airpods and so many of you with
headphones I apologize for yelling into
my microphone just now to make this
point but let's see if we can't fix that
well if my pattern on line five is
expecting it to be lowercase there's
actually a few ways I can solve this one
would be something we've seen before I
could just force the user's input to all
lower case and I could put onto the end
of my first line dot lower and actually
force it all to lowercase alternatively
I could do that a little later instead
of passing an email I could pass in the
lowercase version of email because email
addresses should in fact be case
insensitive so that would work too but
there's another mechanism here which is
worth seeing it turns out that that
function before
called re.search supports recall a third
argument as well these so-called flags
and flags are configuration options
typically to a function that allow you
to configure it a little differently and
how might I go about configuring this
call to re.search a little bit
differently insofar as I'm currently
only passing into arguments well it
turns out that some of the flags you can
pass into this function are these it
turns out that the regular expression
library in Python AKA re comes with a
few built-in variables so to speak
things that you can think of as
constants that have meaning to re.search
and they do so as follows if you pass in
as a flag re.ignore case what re.search
is going to do is ignore the case of the
user's input it can be uppercase
lowercase a combination thereof the case
is going to be ignored it will be
treated case insensitively and you can
do other things too that we won't do
here but if you want to handle the
user's input that maybe spans multiple
lines maybe they didn't just type in an
email address but an entire paragraph of
text and you want to match different
lines of that text that is multiple
lines another flag is for re dot
multi-line for just that or re.all
whereby you can you can configure the
dot to rep to recognize not just any
character except new lines but any
character plus new lines as well but for
now let me go ahead and just make use of
this first one let me pass in a third
argument to re.search which is r e dot
uh ignore case let me now rerun the
program without clearing my screen
pythonvalidate.pi let me type in again
in all caps effectively shouting mailing
harvard.edu enter and now it's
considered valid because I'm telling
re.search specifically to ignore the
case of the input and that to here is
fine and why might I do this approach
rather than call Dot lower in one of
those other locations if I don't
actually want to change the user's input
for whatever reason I can still treat it
cases sensitively without actually
changing the value of that variable
itself
are any final questions now on this
validation of email addresses
so the pattern is a string right
uh can we use an F string you can you
guess you can use an F string so that
you could plug in for instance the value
of a variable and pass it into the
function other questions on this
backstage W character could we take it
as an input from the user technically
yes that's not a problem we're trying to
solve right now we want the user to
provide literal input like their email
address not necessarily a regular
expression but you could imagine
building software that asks the user
especially if they're more advanced
users to type in a regular expression
for some reason to validate something
else against that and in fact that's
what Google's doing if you play around
with Google forms and create a form with
response validation and select regular
expression Google lets you and I type in
our own regular Expressions would be a
perf which would be a perfect example of
that all right well let me propose that
we try to solve one other problem here
whereby if I go into the same version as
before which is now ignoring case but I
type in one of my other email addresses
let me go ahead and run python
validate.pi and this time let me type in
not mailing at harvard.edu which I use
primarily but another email address of
mine mailing at
cs50.harvard.edu which forwards to the
same let me go ahead and hit enter now
and huh invalid even though I'm pretty
sure that is in fact my email address
well let's put our finger on the reason
why why at the moment is malinet
cs50.harvard.edu being considered
invalid even though I'm pretty sure I
send and receive email from that address
too
why might that be because there is a DOT
that has come after the ad symbol
exactly there's a DOT after my cs50 and
I'm not expecting any dots there I'm
expecting only again word characters
which is a through z 0 through 9 and
underscore so I'm gonna have to retool
here but how could I go about doing this
well it turns out theoretically there
could be other email addresses even
though they'd be getting a little
excessively long for instance mailing at
something.cs50.harbor.edu which is not
technically exist but it could you can
have of course multiple dots in a domain
name like we see here wouldn't it be
nice if we could handle that as well
well let me propose that we modified my
regular expression as follows it turns
out that you can group ideas together
and you can not only ask whether or not
this pattern matches or this one using
syntax like a vertical Bar B which means
either A or B you can also group things
together and then apply some other
operator to them as well in fact let me
go back to vs code here and let me
propose that if I want to tolerate a
subdomain like cs50 that may or may not
be there let me go ahead and change it
as follows I could naively do this if I
want to support sub domains I could say
well let's allow for other word
characters plus and then a literal Dot
and notice I'll highlight in blue here
what I've just added everything else is
the same but I'm now adding room for
another sequence of one or more word
characters and then a literal dot so
this now I think if I rerun
pythonvalidate.pi will work for malinet
cs50.harvard.edu enter
unfortunately does anyone see where this
is going let me rerun pythonvalidate.pi
and type in as I keep doing Mainland
harvard.edu which up until now has kept
working despite all of my changes but
now oh finally I've broken my own email
address
so logically what's the solution here
well there's a bunch of ways we could
solve this I could maybe start using two
regular expressions and support your
email addresses of the form username at
domain.tld or username at
subdomain.domain.tld where TLD just
means top level domain like edu or I
could maybe just modify this one because
I'd prefer not to have like two uh
regular expressions or one that's twice
as big why don't I just specify to
re.search that part of this pattern is
optional what was the symbol we saw
earlier that allows you to specify that
the thing before it is technically
optional
we are using the Stray bar as a
optional make the option the argument
optional so we could we could use a
vertical bar and some parentheses and
say either there's something here or
there's nothing we could do that in
parentheses but I think there's actually
an even easier way way actually is a
question mark indeed question mark think
back to this summary here of our first
set of symbols whereby we had not just
Dot and star and plus but also a
question mark which means literally zero
or one repetitions which effectively
means optional it's either there one or
it's not zero now how can I translate to
that to this code here well let me go
ahead and Surround this part of my
pattern with parentheses which doesn't
mean I want literally a parenthesis in
the user's input I just want to group
these characters together and in fact
this now will still work I've only added
parentheses around the new part for the
subdomain let me run Python and
validate.pi let me run Malin at
cs50.harbor.edu enter that's still valid
but to be clear if I rerun it again for
mailing at harvard.edu that is still
invalid but not if I go in here and say
after the parentheses which now is one
logical you unit it's one big group of
ideas together I add a single question
mark there this will now tell our
e.search that that whole thing in
parentheses can either be there once or
be there not at all zero times so what
does this translate into when I run it
well let me go ahead and rerun it with
Malin at
cs50.harbor.edu so that the subdomain's
there that works as before let me clear
my screen and run it again
pythonvalidate.pi with Malin harvard.edu
which used to work then broke is are we
back in business now we are that's now
valid again
questions now on this approach where
we've used not just the question mark
But the parentheses as well okay yeah
you said he works for zero or one
repetition what if you have more
what if you have more that's okay that's
where you could do star star is zero or
more which gives you all the flexibility
in the world
yeah so I was just asking that uh with
question mark there's only one
repetition allowed it means zero or one
repetition so it's either not there or
it is there
and so that's why this pattern now if I
go back to my code even though again it
admittedly looks cryptic let me
highlight everything after the at sign
and before the dollar sign this now
represents a domain name like
harvard.edu or a sub domain within the
domain name why well this part to the
right is the same as always backslash W
plus means something like Harvard or
Yale
backslash.edu means literally.edu so the
new part is this in parentheses I have
another set of backslash W plus
backslash dot now but it's all in
parentheses I'm now having a question
mark right after that which means that
whole thing in parentheses either can be
there or it can't be there it's either
of those that are acceptable so a
question mark effectively makes
something optional it would not be
correct to remove the parentheses
because what would this mean if I remove
the parentheses that would mean that
only this dot is optional which isn't
really what we want to express I want
the sub domain like cs50 and the
additional dot to be what's there or not
there how about one other question on
regex is here can they use this for the
usernames absolutely we still have other
problems right we're not solving all of
the problems today just yet but
absolutely right now we are not letting
you have a period in your username and
again some of you with Gmail accounts or
other accounts you probably have not
just underscores numbers and letters you
might have periods too well we could fix
that not using question mark here per se
but now that we have these parentheses
at our disposal what I could do is this
I could use parentheses to surround the
backslash W to say any word character
which is the same thing again as a
letter or a number or an underscore but
I could also or in using a vertical bar
something else like a literal dot now a
literal dot needs to be escaped
otherwise it represents any character
which would be a regression a step back
but now notice what I've done in
parentheses I'm telling re.search that
those first few characters in your email
address that is your username has to be
a word character Like A through Z
uppercase or lowercase or zero through
nine or an underscore or a literal dot
we could do this differently too I could
get rid of the parentheses and the or
and I could just use a set of characters
I could again manually say a through z a
through z 0 through 9 underscore and
then I could do a literal dot with a
backslash period and now I technically
don't even need the upper case because
I'm already telling the computer to
ignore case I can just pick one or the
other which one is better is really up
to you whichever one you think is more
readable would generally be the better
design
all right let me propose that I rewind
this in time to where we left off
which was here
and let me propose that there are indeed
still limitations of this solution not
just with the username not just with the
domain name we're still being a little
too restrictive so would you like to see
the official regular expression that at
least browsers use nowadays whenever you
type in an email address to a web form
and the web form the browser tells you
yes or no your email address is
syntactically valid
ready ready
here is and this isn't even officially
the right regular expression it's a
simplified version that browsers use
because it catches most mistakes but not
all here we go
this is the regular expression for a
valid email address at least as browsers
nowadays Implement them now it's crazy
cryptic at first glance but note and
it's wrapping onto many lines but it's
just one pattern but just notice the now
familiar symbols there is the carrot
symbol at the very top there is the
dollar sign at the very end there is a
square bracket over here and then some
of these ranges plus other characters
turns out you don't normally see these
characters in email addresses it looks
like you're swearing at someone in their
username but they're valid characters
they're valid officially that doesn't
mean that Gmail is going to allow you to
put dollar signs and other punctuation
in your username but officially some
servers might allow that so if you
really want to validate a user's email
address you would actually come up with
or copy paste something like this but
honestly this looks so cryptic and if
you were to type it out manually you are
so likely to make a mistake what's the
better our solution here instead this is
where purse past week's libraries are
your friend surely someone else on the
internet a programmer more experienced
than you even has come up with code that
validates email addresses properly using
this regular expression or even
something more sophisticated than that
so generally if the problem at hand is
to validate input that is pretty
conventional an email address a URL
something where there's an official
definition that's independent of you
yourself find a popular library that
you're comfortable using and use it in
your code to validate email addresses
this is not a wheel necessarily that you
yourself should invent we've used email
addresses though to iteratively start
from something simple too simple and
build on top of that so you could
certainly imagine using regular
expression still to validate things that
aren't email addresses but there are
data that are important to you so we at
least now have these building blocks now
besides the regular Expressions
themselves it turns out there's other
functions and python re library for
regular Expressions among them is this
function here re dot match which is
actually very similar to re.search
except you don't have to specify the
carrot symbol at the very beginning of
your regex if you want to match from the
start of a string re dot match by Design
will automatically start matching from
the start of the string for you similar
in spirit is re.full match which does
the same thing but not only matches at
the start of the string but the end of
the string so that you two don't need to
type in the carrot symbol or the dollar
sign as well but let's go ahead and
transition back now to some action code
whereby we solve a different problem in
spirit rather than just validate the
user's input and make sure it looks the
way we want let's just assume that the
users are not going to type in data
exactly as we want and so we're going to
have to clean up their input this
happens so often when you're using like
a Google form or Office 365 form or
anything else to collect user input no
matter what your form question says your
users are not necessarily going to
follow those directions they might go
ahead and type in something that's a
little differently formatted than you
might like now you could certainly go
through the results and download a CSV
or open the Google spreadsheet or
equivalent in Excel and just clean up
all the data manually but if you've got
lots of submissions dozens hundreds
thousands of rows in your data set doing
things manually might not be very fun it
might be much more effective to write
code as in Python that can allow you to
clean up that data and any future data
as well so let me propose that we go
ahead here and close validate.pi and
let's go ahead and create a new program
altogether called format.pi the goal of
which is to reformat the user's input in
the format we expect I'm going to go
ahead and run code of format dot pi and
let's suppose that the data we're going
to reformat is the user's name so not
email address but name this time and
we're going to hope that they type in
their name properly like David Malin but
some users might be in the habit for
whatever reason of typing their name
backwards if you will with a comma such
as mailen comma David instead now it's
fine because both are clearly as
readable to the human but if you want to
standardize how those names are stored
in your system perhaps a database or CSV
file or something else it would be nice
to at least standardize or canonicalize
the format in which you're storing your
data so that if you print out the user's
name it's always the same format David
Malin and there's no commas or
backwardsness to it so let's go ahead
and do something familiar let's go ahead
and give myself a variable called name
and set it equal to the return value of
input asking the user as we've done many
times what's your name question mark I'm
going to go ahead and proactively at
least clean up some messiness as we keep
doing here by just stripping off any
leading or trailing white space just in
case the user accidentally hits the
space bar we don't want that ultimately
in our data set and now let me go ahead
and do this as we've done before let me
just go ahead quickly and print out just
to make sure I'm off to the right start
hello and then in curly brace's name so
making an F string to format hello comma
name now let me go ahead and clear my
screen and run python of format.pi let
me behave and type in my name as I
normally would David spacemailin enter
and I think the output looks pretty good
it looks as expected grammatically let
me now go ahead though and play this
game again but this time maybe because
I'm not thinking or I'm just in the
habit of doing last name comma first I
do Malin comma David and hit enter
alright well this now is is is weird
even though the program is just spitting
out exactly what I typed in arguably
this is not close to correct at least
grammatically it should really say hello
David Malin now maybe I could have some
if conditions and I could just reject
the user's input if they type a comma or
get their names backwards somehow but
that's going to be too little too late
if the user has already submitted a form
online and I already have the data and
now I need to go in and clean it up and
it's not going to be fun to go through
manually in Google spreadsheets or apple
numbers or Microsoft Excel and manually
fix a lot of people's names to get rid
of the commas and move the first name
before the last as is conventional in
the U.S so let's do this it could be a
little fragile but let's let's start to
express ourselves a little
programmatically here and ask this
if there is a comma in the person's name
which is pythonic I'm just asking the
question is this shorter string in this
longer string then let me go ahead and
do this let me go ahead and grab that
name in the variable
split on not just the comma but the
space after assuming the human typed
into space after their name and let me
go ahead and store the result of that
splitting of malen comma David into two
variables let's do last comma first
again unpacking the sequence of values
that comes back now let me go ahead and
reformat the name so I'm going to
forcibly change the user's name to be as
I expect so name is actually going to be
this format string first name then last
name both in curly braces but formatted
together with a single space so that I'm
overriding the user's input and updating
my name variable accordingly for the
moment to be clear this program is
interactive like the users like me are
typing their name into the program but
imagine the data already is in a CSV
file it came in from some process like a
Google form or something else online you
could imagine writing code similar to
this but that maybe goes and reads that
file into memory first maybe it's a CSV
via CSV reader or addict reader and then
iterating over each of those names but
we'll keep it simple and just do one
name at a time but now what's kind of
interesting here is if I go back to my
terminal window and clear it and run
python of format.pi and hit enter I'm
going to type in David space mailing as
before and I think we're still good but
I'm also going to go ahead and do this
python of format.pi malen comma David
with a space in between crossing my
fingers and hit enter and voila that now
has been fixed such a simple thing to be
sure but it is so commonly necessary to
clean up users input here we see at
least one way to do so pretty easily now
to be fair there's some problems here
and in fact can someone imagine a
scenario in which this code really
doesn't fix the user's input what could
still go wrong even with this fix in my
code
any thoughts if they attack the in their
name comma and then sign them oh and
then something else yeah so let me let
me try this for instance
um let me go ahead and run a program and
uh I am the only David Malin that I know
but suppose I were uh uh let's say
junior like this and it's common in
English at least to sometimes put a
comma there you don't necessarily need
the comma but I'm one of those people
who uses a comma that's now really
really broken so I've broken some
assumption there and so that could
certainly go wrong here what else well
let me go ahead and run this again and
if I did mail-in comma David no space
because I'm being a little sloppy I'm
not paying attention which is going to
happen when you have lots of users
ultimately well this really broke now
notice I have a value error an actual
exception why well because split is
supposed to be splitting the string into
two strings by looking for the comma and
a space but if there is no comma in
space it can't split it into two things
and the fact that I have two variables
on the left but I'm only getting back
one thing on the right means that I
can't do this code quite as this so it's
fragile to be sure but wouldn't it be
nice if we could at least improve it for
instance we now know some regular
expression syntax what if I at least
wanted to make this base optional well I
could use my newfound regular expression
syntax and put a question mark question
mark means zero or one of the things to
the left what's the thing to the left
it's literally a space I don't even need
parentheses if there's just one thing
there so that would be the start of a
pattern that says I must have a comma
and then I may or may not have a space
zero or one space is thereafter
unfortunately the version of split
that's built into the stir variable as
in this case doesn't support regular
Expressions if we want our regular
Expressions we need to go use that
Library here so let me go ahead and do
this let me go in and leave this code AS
is but go up to the top now and import
re to import the library for regular
expressions and now let me go ahead and
start changing my Approach here I'm
going to go ahead and do this I'm going
to use the same function called re dot
search and I'm going to search for a
pattern that I think will be la last
comma first so let me use my newfound
regular expression syntax and represent
a pattern for something like Malin comma
space David how can I do this well
inside of my quotes for re.search I'm
going to have something so dot plus
sorry I'm going to have something so dot
plus then I'm going to have a comma then
I'm going to have a space then I'm going
to have something dot plus now I'm going
to preemptively refine this a little bit
I want this whole pattern to start
matching at the beginning of the user's
input so I'm going to add the carrot
right away and I want the end of the
user's input to be matched as well so
that I'm literally expecting any
character one or more times then a comma
then a space than any other character
one or more times and then that is it
and I'm going to pass in the name
variable as before now when we've used
re.search in the past we really used it
just to answer a question does the
user's input match the following pattern
or not true or false effectively but
re.search is actually more powerful than
that you can actually get back more
information and you can do this you can
specify a variable and then an
assignment operator and get back more
precise answers to what has been found
when searched for but what is it you
want to get back well it turns out
there's this other feature of regular
Expressions which allow you to use
parentheses not just to group things
together but to capture them it turns
out when you specify parentheses in a
regular expression unbeknownst to us up
until now everything in the parentheses
will be returned to you as a return
value from the re.search function it's
going to allow you to extract specific
amounts of information from the user's
own input you can reverse this process
too by using the non-capturing version
as well you can use parentheses and then
literally a question mark and a colon
and then some other stuff and that will
say don't bother capturing this I just
want to group things but for now we're
going to use just the parentheses
themselves so how am I going to do this
well if I want to get back the user's
last name and first name I think what I
want to capture is the dot plus here
and the dot plus here
so I've deliberately surrounded in
parentheses the dot plus both to the
left and the right of the comma not
because I'm grouping them together per
se I'm not adding a question mark I'm
not adding up another Plus or Star I'm
using parentheses now for capturing
purposes why well I'm going to do this
next I'm going to still ask a Boolean
question like if there are matches then
do this so if matches is not effectively
false like none
I do expect I've gotten back some
matches and watch what I can do now I
can do last comma first equals whatever
matches in and get back all of the
groups of matches then go ahead and
update name just like before with a
format string and do first and then last
in curly braces as well and then at the
very bottom just like before print out
for instance hello
comma name so the new code now is
everything highlighted here I'm using re
search to search for whether the user
typed their name in last comma first
format but I am more powerfully using
re.search to capture some of the user's
input what's going to get captured
anything I surrounded in parentheses
will be returned to me as return values
how do you get at those return values
you ask the variable to which you assign
them for all of the groups all of the
groups of parentheses that were captured
so let me go ahead and do this let me go
ahead now and run python of format.pi
enter and I'm going to type my name as
usual in this case nothing happens with
this if condition why because I did not
type a comma and so this search does not
find a comma so there are no matches so
we immediately just print out hello name
nothing interesting or new there but if
I now go ahead and clear my screen and
run Python A format.pi and do mail-in
comma space David enter we've
reformatted my name well how did this
work let me be a little more explicit
now it turns out I don't have to just
say matches.groups I can get specific
groups back that I want so let me change
my code a little bit more let me go
ahead now
and just say this let's update name uh
well actually let's do this let's say
that the last name is going to be in the
matches but specifically group one the
first name is going to be in the matches
but specifically group two y one and two
because this is the first set of
parentheses to the left of the comma
this is the second set of parentheses to
the right of the comma and based on the
input this would be the user's last name
in this scenario Malin this would be the
user's first name David in this scenario
that's why I'm using group one for the
last name and group two for the first
name and now I'm going to go ahead and
say name equals uh fstring again first
and then last
done and let me we're finding this one
last step before we take questions I
don't really need these variables if I'm
immediately using them let's just go
ahead and tighten this up further as
we've done in the past for design sake
if I want to make the name the
concatenation of the person's first name
and last name let's just do this matches
dot group 2 first plus a space plus
matches dot group one so it's just up to
me to know from left to right this is
group one this is group two so group one
is last group two is first so if I want
to flip them around and update the value
of name I can explicitly get group two
first concatenate using plus a single
space and then concatenate on group one
all right that was a lot let me pause to
see if there are questions the key
difference here is we're still using
re.search the exact same way but now I'm
using its return value not just to
answer a question true or false but to
actually get back specific matches
anything I captured so to speak with
parentheses why is it here we're using
one and two instead of zero and one
really good question capturing the first
a good observation in almost every other
context we've started counting at zero
and one instead of one and two it turns
out there's something else in location
zero when it comes back from re.search
related to the string itself so
according to the documentation of this
function only one is the first set of
parentheses and two is the second set
and onward from there just a different
convention here other questions uh what
if we write nothing like five space
government white space how we check
um true or Foundation before I answer
directly let me just run this and make
sure I've not broken anything further
let me run python to format.pi let me
type in David spacemailin the right way
let me run it once more let me type it
mail and comma David the wrong way that
we're fixing and we're still good but I
think it will still break let me run it
a third time with Malin comma David with
no space and now it's still broken why
because I'm still looking for comma
space now how can I fix that one way I
could do that is to add a question mark
here which again is zero or more of the
thing before so if I have a space and
then a question mark literally no need
for any parentheses then I can literally
tolerate both Malin comma space David or
Malin comma David so let's try again
before this did not work let's do Malin
comma David with no space now it does
actually work so we can tolerate
different amounts of white space if I am
a little more precise with my formula
let me go ahead and try once more let me
very weirdly but possibly hit the space
bar a few too many times so now they're
really separated this again is not going
to work quite right because it's going
to consume all of that white space so
now I might want to strip left and right
any of the leading white space on the
result or what I could do here is say
this instead of zero or a one I could
use a star here so space star and now if
I run this once more with Malin comma
space space David enter now we've
cleaned up things further so you can
imagine depending on how messy the data
is that you're cleaning up your regular
Expressions might need to get more and
more sophisticated it really depends on
just how many problems we want to solve
at once well allow me to propose that we
Forge ahead further just to clean this
up even more so using a feature that's
actually relatively new to python itself
it is very common when using regular
Expressions to do exactly what I've done
here to call a function like re.search
with capturing parentheses inside such
that you get back a return value that
I'm calling matches you could call it
something else but I'm calling it by
default matches and then notice on the
next line I'm saying if matches wouldn't
it be nice if I could just tighten
things up further and do these all on
the same line well you can sort of let
me go ahead and do this let me get rid
of this if and let me just try to say
something like this if matches equals re
search and then colon so combining my if
condition into just one line instead of
those two in C or C plus plus or Java
you would actually do something like
this surrounding the whole thing with
parentheses sometimes double sets to
suppress any warnings if you want to do
two things at once if you want to not
only assign the return value of
re.search to a variable called matches
but you want to subsequently ask a
Boolean question is this effectively
true or false that's what I was doing a
moment ago let me undo this a moment ago
I was getting back the return value and
assigning it to matches and then I was
asking the question well it turns out
this need to have two lines of code
presumably rubbed people wrong for too
long in Python and so you can now
combine these two kinds of lines into
one but you need a new operator you
cannot just say if matches equals re
search and then encoding at the end you
instead need to do this you need to do
colon equals if and only if you want to
assign something from right to left and
you want to ask an if or an L if
question on the same line This is
affectionately known as you can see here
as the walrus operator and it's new to
python in recent years and it both
allows you to assign a value as I'm
doing from right to left and ask a
Boolean question about it like I'm doing
with the if or equivalently L if does
anyone know why this is called The
Walrus operator
if you kind of look at it like this
perhaps if you're familiar with walruses
it kinda sort of looks like a walrus so
a minor detail but a relatively new
feature of python that honestly you'll
probably continue to see online and in
source code and in textbooks and so
forth increasingly so now that it does
exist it does not change the logic at
all if I run python a format that's pi
and type Malin comma space David it
still fixes things but it's tightened up
my code just a bit more all right let's
go ahead and look at one final problem
to solve that of extracting information
now as well so at this point we've now
validated the user's input by checking
whether or not it meets a certain
pattern we've cleaned up the user's
input by checking against a pattern
whether it matches or not and if it does
match we kind of reorganize some of the
user's information so we can clean up
their input and standardize the format
in which we're storing or printing it in
this case let's do one final example
where we're very specifically extracting
information in order to answer some
question so let me propose this let me
go ahead and close format.pi and create
a new file called twitter.pi the goal of
which is to prompt users for the URL of
their Twitter profile and extract from
it infer from that URL what is the
user's username now why might you want
to do this well one you might want users
to be able to just very easily copy and
paste the URL from their own Twitter
profile into your form into your app so
that you can figure out what their
username is or you might have a form
that asks the user for their Twitter
username and because people aren't
necessarily paying very close attention
some people type their username some
people type their whole URL or something
else altogether it would be nice now
that you're a programmer to just be more
tolerant of different types of input and
just take on the burden of
canonicalizing standardizing the data
but being flexible with the users it's
arguably a better user experience if you
just let me copy paste or type in what I
want you clean it up you're the
programmer not me nuns for a better
experience perhaps well let me go ahead
and do this with twitter.pi let me first
go ahead and prompt the user here for a
value for a variable that I'll call URL
and just ask them to input the URL of
their Twitter profile I'm going to go
ahead and strip off any leading or
trailing white space just in case users
accidentally hit the space bar that's
like literally the least I can do quite
easily but now let's go ahead and do
this suppose that the user's address is
the following let me print out what they
type in and let me clear my screen and
run python of twitter.pi I'm going to go
ahead and type in for instance https
colon slash slash twitter.com David J
malen which happens to be my own Twitter
username for now we're just going to
print it back onto the screen just to
make sure I've not messed up yet okay so
I've printed back out the exact same URL
but the goal at hand is to extract the
username only now let me just ask
perhaps a straightforward question
logically what do I need to do to get at
the user's username well uh we just
ignore what's before the username and
then just extract the username perfect
yeah I mean it is as simple as that if
you know the usernames at the end well
let's just somehow ignore everything to
the beginning well what's at the
beginning well it's a URL so we're
probably going to need to ignore an
https a colon slash a twitter.com and a
slash so we just want to throw all of
that away why because if it's a URL We
Know by how Twitter works that the
username comes at the end so let's use
that very simple idea to get at the
information we want well I'm going to
try this a few different ways let me go
back into my program here and instead of
just printing it out which was just to
see what's going on let me do this let
me create a new variable called username
and let me call URL dot replace it turns
out that if URL is a string or a stir in
Python it again comes with multiple
methods like strip uh and split and
others as well one of which is called
replace and replace will do just that
you pass it two arguments the first of
which is what do you want to replace the
second argument is what do you want to
replace it with so if I want to get rid
of as Ivan proposed really just
everything before the username that is
the Twitter URL or the beginning thereof
let's just say this go ahead and replace
https colon slash slash twitter.com
close quote that's what I want to
replace and comma second argument what
do you want to replace it with nothing
so I'm literally going to pass in quote
unquote to effectively do a find and
replace that's what the replace method
does just like you can do it in
Microsoft Word or Google Docs this is
the programmer's way of doing find and
replace now let me go ahead and print
out just the username so I'll use an F
string like this I'll say username colon
and then in curly braces username just
to format it nicely all right let me go
ahead and clear my screen and run python
of twitter.pi enter URL here we go https
colon slash slash twitter.com
[Music]
David J Malin enter okay now we've made
some progress done for the day right
well what is sub-optimal about this can
anyone critique or find fault with my
program it is working now but it's a
little fragile I bet we could contrive
some scenarios where I think it works
but it doesn't well like it's a few
ideas actually well first of all uh if
the if we don't specify https it's all
broken secondly if we have sliced at the
end it also will be broken if we if we
have like a question mark or something
after question mark it also won't work
so let us know oh my God I mean here we
are I was pretending to think I was done
but my God like Alex gave us a whole
laundry list of like problems and just
to recap then what if it's not https
it's HTTP slightly less secure but I
should still be able to tolerate that
programmatically uh what if the protocol
is not there what if the user just type
twitter.com David J Malin it would be
nice to tolerate that rather than show
an error and make me type in the
protocol why it's not good user
experience what if it had a slash at the
end of the username or a question mark
If you think about URLs you've seen on
the web there's very commonly more
information especially if it's been
shared on social media there might be
HTTP parameters so to speak just stuff
there that we don't want there could be
a
www.twitter.com which I'm also not
expecting but does work if you go to
that URL too so there's just so many
things that can go wrong and even if I
come back to my contrived example as
earlier what if I run this program and
say this my username is https colon
slash twitter.com David J Malin enter
well that too just just didn't really
work it got rid of the you actually okay
actually that kind of worked but the
goal here is to actually get the user's
username not an English sentence
describing the user's username so I
would argue that even though I just
accidentally created perfectly correct
English grammar I did not extract the
Twitter username correctly I don't want
words like my username is as part of my
input so how can we go about improving
this and maybe chipping away at some of
those problems one by one well let me
clear my screen here let me come back up
to my code and let me not just replace
it but let me do something else instead
I'm going to go ahead and instead of
using replace I'm going to use another
function called remove prefix a prefix
is a string or a substring that comes at
the start of another so if I remove
prefix I don't need a second argument
for this function I just need one what
prefix do you want to remove so this
will at least now fix the problem I just
described of typing in like a whole
sentence where the URL is there but it's
not the beginning it's only at the end
so here this still is not correct but we
don't create this weird looking output
that just removes the URL part of the
input my username is https colon slash
twitter.com David J malen a moment ago
it did remove the URL and left only the
David J Malin this is not perfect still
but at least now it does not weirdly
remove the URL and then leave the
English it's just leaving it alone so
maybe I could handle this better but at
least it's removing it from the part of
the string I might anticipate
well what else could we do here well it
turns out that like regular Expressions
just let us express patterns much more
precisely we could spend all day using a
whole bunch of different python
functions like remove prefix or remove
and strip and others and kind of make
our way to the right solution but a
regular expression just allows you to
more succinctly if admittedly more
cryptically Express these kinds of
patterns and goals and we've seen from
parentheses which can be used not just
to group symbols together as sets but to
capture information as well we have a
very powerful tool now in our toolkit so
let me do this let me go ahead and start
fresh here and import the re Library as
before at the very top of my program I'm
still going to get the user's URL via
the same line of code but I'm now going
to use another function as well it turns
out that there's not just re.search or
rd.match or re.full match there's also
re.sub in the regular expression Library
where sub here means substitute and it
takes more arguments but they're fairly
straightforward the first argument to
re.sub is the pattern the regular
expression that you want to look for
then you have a replacement string what
do you want to replace that pattern with
and where do you want to do all that
well you pass in the string that you
want to do the substitution on then
there's some other arguments that I'll
wave my hands up for now among them are
those same flags and also account like
how many times do you want to do find
and replace do you want it to do all do
you want to do it just one or so forth
you can have further control there too
just like you would in Google Docs or
Microsoft Word well let me go back to my
code here and let me do this I'm going
to go ahead and call re not search but
re.sub for substitute I'm going to pass
in the following regular expression
https colon slash slash twitter.com
and then I'm going to close my quote and
now what do I want to replace that with
well like before with the simple stir
Place function I want to replace it with
nothing just get rid of it all together
but what string do I want to pass in to
do this to the URL from the user and now
let me go ahead and assign the return
value of re sub to a variable called
username so re Subs purpose in life is
again to substitute some value for some
regular expression some number of times
it essentially is find and replace using
regular expressions and it returns to
you the resulting string once you've
done all those substitutions so now the
very last line of my code can be the
same as before print and I'll use an F
string username colon and then in curly
braces username so I can print out
literally just that
all right let's try this and see what
happens I'll clear my terminal window
run python of twitter.pi and here we go
https colon slash slash twitter.com
David J Malin cross my fingers and hit
enter okay now we're in business but it
is still a little fragile and so let me
ask the group
what problem should I now further chip
away at they've been said before but
let's be clear what's one or more
problems that still remain the protocols
and the uh
domain prefix is Paul good the protocol
so HTTP versus https maybe the subdomain
www should it be there or not and
there's a few other mistakes here too
let me actually stay with the group what
are some other shortcomings of this
current solution
um if we use a phrase like you do before
we are going to have the same problem
because it's not taking account in the
first part of the the text example good
I might still allow for like some words
uh some English to the left of the URL
because I didn't use like my carrot
symbol so I'll fix that and any final
observations on shortcomings here
uh well it could be a HTTP or there
could be like less than two slashes okay
so it could be HTTP and I think that was
mentioned too in terms of protocol
they're
slashes that I'm not I'm not gonna worry
about if the user gives me one slash
instead of two that's really user error
and I could be tolerant of it but you
know what at that point I'm okay yelling
at them with an error message saying
please fix your input otherwise we could
be here all day long trying to handle
all possible typos for now I think in
the interest of usability or user
experience ux let's at least be tolerant
of all possible valid inputs or
reasonable inputs if you will so let me
go here and let me start chipping away
at these here what are some problems we
can solve well let me propose that we
first address the issue of matching from
the beginning of the string so let me
add the carrot to the beginning and let
me add not a dollar sign at the end
though right because I don't want to
match all the way to the end because I
want to tolerate a username there so I
think we just want the carrot symbol
there there's a subtle bug that no one
yet mentioned and let me just kind of
highlight it and see if it jumps out at
you now it's a little subtle here on my
screen I've highlighted in blue a final
bug here maybe some Smiles on the screen
yeah can we take one hand here why am I
highlighting the dot in twitter.com even
though it definitely should be there so
the dog without a backslash meaning any
character is of a new one yeah exactly
it's not it means any character so I
could type in something like Twitter uh
question mark Com or Twitter anything
com and that would actually be tolerated
it's not really that bad because why
would the user do that but if I want to
be correct and I want to be able to test
my own code properly I should really get
this detail right so that's an easy fix
too but it's a common mistake anytime
you're writing regular Expressions that
happen to involve special symbols like
dots in a URL or domain name a dollar
sign in something involving currency
remember you might indeed Need to Escape
it we with a backslash like this here
all right let me ask the group about the
protocol specifically https is a good
thing in the world it means secure there
is encryption being used so generally
you like to see https but you still see
people typing or copy pasting HTTP what
would be the simplest fix here to
tolerate as has been proposed both HTTP
and https I'm going to propose that I
could do this I could do HTTP vertical
bar or https which again Means A or B
but I think I can be smarter than that I
can keep my code a little more succinct
any recommendations here for tolerating
HTTP or https
we could try to put in question mark
behind the S perfect just use a question
mark right both of those would be viable
Solutions if you want to be super
explicit in your code fine use
parentheses and say HTTP or https so
that you the reader your boss your
teacher just know exactly what you're
doing but you know if you keep taking
the more verbose approach all the time
it might actually become less readable
certainly once your regular Expressions
get this big instead of this big so
let's save space where we can and I
would argue that this is pretty
reasonable so long as you're in the
habits of reading regular expressions
and know that question mark does not
mean a literal question mark but it
means zero or one of the thing before I
think we've effectively made the S
optional here now what else can I do
well suppose we want to tolerate the www
dot which may or may not be there but it
will work if you go to a browser I could
do this www dot uh wait I want a
backslash there so I don't repeat the
same mistake as before but this is no
good either because I want to tolerate
www being there or not being there and
now I've just required that it be there
but I think I can take the same approach
any recommendations how do I make the
www dot optional just to hammer this
home
we can like group uh make a square and
question mark perfect so question mark
is the short answer again but we have to
be a little smarter this time as Maria's
noted we need parentheses now because if
I just put a question mark after the dot
that just means the dot is optional and
that's wrong because we don't want the
user to type in
www.twitt ER we want the dot to be there
or just not at all with no www so we
need to group this whole thing together
put a parenthesis there and then a
parenthesis not after the third W after
the dot so that that whole thing is
either there or it's not there and what
else could we still do here you know
there's going to be one other thing we
should tolerate and it's been said
before and I'll pluck this one off what
about the protocol like what if the user
just doesn't type or doesn't copy paste
the HTTP colon slash or an https colon
slash slash right honestly you and I are
not in the habit generally of even
typing the protocol anymore nowadays you
just let the browser figure it out for
you and automatically add it instead so
this one's going to look like more of a
mouthful but if I want this whole thing
here in blue to be optional it's
actually the same solution as Maria
offered a moment ago I'm going to go
ahead and put a parenthesis over here
and a parenthesis after the two slashes
and then a question mark so as to make
that whole thing optional as well and
this is okay it's totally fine to make
this whole thing optional or inside of
it this little thing just the S optional
as well so long as I'm applying the same
principles again and again either on a
small scale or a bigger scale it's
totally fine to Nest one of these inside
of the other
questions now on any of these
refinements
to this parsing this analyzing of
Twitter what if we put a vertical bar
besides this www dot what if we use a
vertical bar there so we could do
something like that too we could do
something like this uh instead of the
question mark I could do www dot or
nothing and just leave that in the
parentheses that too would be fine I
personally tend not to like that because
it's a little less obvious to me wait a
minute is that deliberate or did I
forget to finish my fault by putting
something after the vertical bar but
that too would be allowed there as well
if that's what you mean other questions
on where we left things here where we
made the protocol optional too
um
inside we have another product that says
to deal with each other if you have
parentheses inside of parentheses that
too is totally fine and indeed that
should be one of the reassuring lessons
today as complicated it is each of these
regular Expressions has admittedly
gotten I'm just applying the exact same
principles in the exact same syntax
again and again so it's totally fine to
have parentheses inside of parentheses
if they're each solving different
problems and in fact the lesson I would
really emphasize the most today is that
you will not be happy if you try to
write out a whole complicated regular
expression all at once like if you're
anything like me you will fail and you
will have trouble finding the mistake
because my God look at these things they
are even to me all these years later
cryptic the better way I would argue
whether you're new to programming or as
old to it as I am is to just take these
baby steps these incremental steps where
you do something simple you make sure it
works you add one more feature make sure
it works add one more feature make sure
it works and hopefully by the end
because you've done each of those steps
one at a time the whole thing will make
sense to you but you'll also have gotten
each of those steps correct
um at each turn so please do avoid the
inclination to try to come up with long
sophisticated regular Expressions all at
once because it's just not a good use of
a time if you then stare at it trying to
find a mistake that you could have
caught if you did things more
incrementally instead all right there
Still Remains arguably at least one
problem with this solution in that even
though I'm calling re.sub to substitute
the URL with nothing quote unquote I
then on my final line of code line six
I'm just blindly assuming that it all
worked and I'm going to go ahead and
print out the username but what if the
user if I clear my screen here and run
python of twitter.pi doesn't even type a
Twitter URL what if they do something
like https colon
www.google.com like completely
unrelatedly for whatever reason enter
that is not their Twitter username so we
need to have some conditional logic I
would argue so that for this program's
sake we're only printing out or in a
back-end system we're only saving into
our database or a CSV file the use
username if we actually matched the
proper pattern so rather than use re.sub
which is useful for cleaning up data as
we've done here to get rid of something
we don't want there why don't we go back
to re.search where we began today and
use it to solve the same problem but in
a way that's conditional whereby I can
confidently say yes or no at the end of
my program here's the username or here
it is not so let me go ahead now and
I'll clear my terminal window here I'm
going to keep most of the I'm going to
keep the first two lines the same where
I import re and I get the URL from the
user but this time let's do this let's
this time search for using re.search
instead of re.sub the following I'm
going to start matching at the beginning
of the URL of the string https question
mark to make the S optional colon slash
slash then I'm going to make my www
optional by putting that in question
marks there then a Twitter com with a
literal dot there so I'll stay ahead of
that issue too then a slash and then
well this is where David J Malin is
supposed to go how do I detect this well
I think I'll just tolerate anything at
the end of the URL here all right dollar
sign at the very end close quote for the
moment I'm going to stipulate that we're
not going to worry about question marks
at the end or hashes like for fragment
IDs and URLs we're going to assume for
Simplicity now that the URL just ends
with the username alone now what am I
going to do well I want to search for
this URL specifically and I'm going to
ignore K so re.ignorecase
applying that same lesson learned from
before
re.search recall will return to you the
matches you've captured well what do I
want to capture well I want to capture
everything to the right of the
twitter.com URL here so let me surround
what should be the user's username with
parentheses not for making them optional
but to say capture this of characters
now ari.search recall returns an answer
matches will be my variable name again
but I could call it anything I want and
then I can do this if matches now I know
I can do this let's print out the format
string username colon and then uh what
do I want to print out well I think I
want to print out matches dot group one
for my matched username
all right so what am I doing just to
recap line one I'm importing the library
line two I'm getting the URL from the
user so nothing new there line five I'm
searching the user's URL as indicated
here is the second argument for this
regular expression this pattern I have
surrounded the dot plus with parentheses
so that they are captured ultimately so
I can't extract in this final scenario
the user's username if I indeed got a
match and matches is non none it is
actually containing some match then and
only then print out username in this way
let me try this now if I run python of
twitter.pi and type in HTTPS colon
www.google.com now nothing gets printed
so I've at least solved the mistake we
just saw where I was just assuming that
my code worked now I'm making sure that
I have searched for and found the
Twitter URL prefix all right well let's
run this for real now python of
twitter.pi https colon slash slash
twitter.com
davidjmalen but note I could use HTTP I
could use www I'm just going to go ahead
here and hit enter
huh none
what has gone wrong
this one's a bit more subtle
but why does matches dot group one
contain nothing wait a minute let me
maybe I maybe I did this wrong maybe
maybe do we need the www let me run it
again so here we go https colon slash
let's add it
www.twitter.com David J malen all right
enter ho ho ho ho
what is going on we have to save group I
have to say group two well wait all
right because we had the the sub domain
was optional and to make it optional I
needed to use parentheses here and so I
then said zero or one okay so that means
that actually I'm unintentionally but by
Design capturing the www dot or none of
it if it wasn't there before but I have
a second match over here because I have
a second set of parentheses so I think
yep let me change matches group one to
matches group two and lets you run this
python of twitter.pi https colon slash
www.twitter let's do this uh twitter.com
David J Malin
enter and now we've got access to the
username let me go ahead and tighten it
up a little bit further uh if you like
our new friend
it's hard not to like if we like our old
friend The Walrus uh operator let's go
ahead and add this just to tighten
things up let me go back to BS code here
and let me get rid of the unnecessary
condition there and combine it up here
if matches equals that but let's change
the single assignment operator to the
Wallace operator now I've tightened
things up further but I bet I bet I bet
there might be another solution here and
indeed it turns out that we can come
back to this final set of syntax recall
that when we introduced these
parentheses we did it so that we could
do a or b for instance with the vertical
bar though you can even combine more
than just one bar we use the group to
combine ideas like the www dot and then
there's this admittedly weird syntax at
the bottom here up until now not used
there is a non-capturing version of
parentheses if you want to use
parentheses logically because you need
to but you don't want to bother
capturing the result and this would
arguably be a better solution here
because yes if I go back to vs code I do
need to surround the www dot with
parentheses at least as I've written my
regex here because I wanted to put the
question mark after it but I don't need
the www dot coming back in fact let's
only extract the data we care about just
so there's no confusion down the road
for me or my colleagues or my teachers
so what could I do well the syntax per
this slide is to use a question mark and
a colon immediately after the open
parenthesis it looks weird admittedly
those of you who have prior programming
experience might recognize the syntax
from ternary operators doing an if else
all in one line a question mark colon at
the beginning of that parenthetical
means yes I'm using parentheses to group
these things together but no you do not
need to capture them instead so I can
change my code back now to matches.group
one I'll clear my screen here run python
of twitter.pi I'll again run here https
colon
twitter.com
davidjmalen with or without the www and
now I indeed get back that username
any questions then
on these final
techniques
so first of all could we move the carrot
right at the beginning of Twitter and
then just start reading from there and
then get rid of everything else before
that the kind of WWE
uh issues that we had and then my second
question is how would we
um use kind of I guess it either a list
or a dictionary to to sort the.com kind
of thing if because we have core UK and
that kind of sorry how would we bring
that into uh the re function a good
question but no if I move the carrot
before twitter.com and throw away the
protocol and the www then the user is
going to have to type in literally
twitter.com
username they can't even type in that
other stuff so that would be a
regression a step back as for the.com
and the dot org and Dot edu and so forth
the short answer is there's many
different solutions here if I wanted to
be stringent about.com and suppose that
Twitter probably owns multiple domain
names even though they tend to use just
this one suppose they have something
like dot org as well you could use more
parentheses here and do something like
this Com or org I'd probably want to go
and add a question mark colon to make it
non-capturing because I don't care which
it is I just want to tolerate both
alternatively we could capture that we
could do something like this where we do
dot plus so as to actually capture that
and then we could do something like this
if matches dot group one now equals
equals com then we could support this so
you could imagine factoring out the
logic just by extracting the top level
domain or TLD and then just using python
code maybe a list maybe a dictionary to
validate elsewhere outside of the regex
if it's in fact what you expect for now
though we kept things simple we focused
only on the.com in this case let's make
one final change to this program so that
we're being a little more specific with
the definition of a Twitter username it
turns out that we're being a little too
generous over here whereby we're
accepting one or more of any character I
checked the documentation for Twitter
and Twitter only supports letters of the
alphabet A through Z numbers zero
through nine or underscore so not just
dot which is literally anything so let
me go ahead and be more precise here at
the end of my string let me go ahead and
say this set of symbols in square
brackets I'm going to go ahead and say A
through Z 0 through 9 and an underscore
because again those are the only valid
symbols I don't need to bother with an
uppercase a or a lowercase C because
we're using re. ignore case over here
but I want to make sure now that I
tolerate not only one or more of these
symbols here but also maybe some other
stuff at the end of the URL I'm now
going to be okay with there being a
slash or a question mark or a hash at
the end of the URL all of which are
valid symbols in a URL but I know from
the Twitter's documentation are not part
of the username all right now I'm going
to go ahead and run python of twitter.pi
one final time typing in HTTPS colon
slash slash twitter.com David J malen
maybe with maybe without a trailing
slash but hold hopefully with my biggest
fingers crossed here I'm going to go
ahead now and hit enter and thankfully
my username is indeed David J Malin so
what more is there in the world of
regular expressions and this own Library
not just re.search and also re.sub
there's other functions too there's
re.split via which you can split a
string not using a specific character or
characters like a comma and a space but
multiple characters as well and there's
even functions like re.find all which
can allow you to search for multiple
copies of the same pattern in different
places in a string so you can perhaps
and manipulate more than just one so at
the end of the day now you've really
learned a whole other language like that
of regular expressions and we've used
them in Python but these regular
Expressions actually exist in so many
languages too among them JavaScript and
Java and Ruby and more so with this new
language even though it's admittedly
cryptic when you use it for the first
time you have this newfound ability to
express these patterns that again you
can use to validate data to clean up
data or even extract data and from any
data set you might have in mind that's
it for this week we will see you next
time
[Music]
foreign
this is cs50's Introduction to
programming with python my name is David
Malin and this is our week on object
oriented programming or oop it turns out
that in the world of programming there's
different paradigms of programming
languages there's different ways of
solving problems with code and it's a
little hard to see this at first if
you've only learned one language but
over time if and when you learn other
languages besides python you'll start to
notice certain patterns and certain
capabilities of some languages but not
another thus far within the world of
python you and I have largely been
writing code that's procedural in nature
whereby we're writing procedures we're
writing functions and we're sort of
doing things top to bottom everything is
step by step by step as you would expect
in general from an algorithm but along
the way we've actually dabbled in
another Paradigm known as functional
programming with python whereby we've
been able to pass functions around we
even had an anonymous function some
weeks ago and that's evidence of
features of a functional programming
language even though we've just
scratched this surface thereof today we
focus on another Paradigm and this one
in more detail namely object oriented
programming and now while some of you
might have prior programming experience
and have learned languages like Java
which are by Design fundamentally object
oriented python indeed allows you a bit
of flexibility when it comes to how you
solve problems with code but it turns
out oop object-oriented programming is a
pretty compelling solution to problems
that you invariably encounter as your
programs get longer larger and more
complicated so indeed oop for our
purposes is going to be a solution to a
problem that builds on so many of the
lessons passed so let's go ahead and do
this let's start by writing a program
very procedurally by opening up vs code
here I'm going to go ahead and create a
program called student.pi and in this
program I want to do something
relatively simple initially as we might
have done some weeks ago now where I
just ask a user for their name and maybe
in the context of the Harry Potter
Universe their house and just print out
where that student is from and let's
gradually enhance this program by adding
more and more features to it and see if
we don't stumble upon problems that up
until now we might not have had very
elegant well-designed solutions to but
if we introduce explicitly
object-oriented programming as a
programming technique I bet we can clean
up our code and set the stage for
writing even more sophisticated programs
longer programs down the line so in
student.pi let me go ahead and do a name
variable setting it equal to the return
value of input and just prompt the user
for their name like this and then let me
go ahead and do the same for a house
variable and prompt the user for their
house using input like this and let's do
something super simple now let's just go
ahead and print out an F string that
says something like name from house just
so that I can confirm that the contents
of these variables are indeed as I
expect I'm not going to do any error
checking or trimming or anything like
that for now I'm really just going to
spit back out whatever the user just
typed in all right let me go ahead and
run python of student and Dot Pi let's
use our go to like Harry as in Harry
Potter from Gryffindor and when I hit
enter now let's see if I see that Harry
from Gryffindor is indeed the case all
right so I think we have a working
program at this point but let's now
introduce some of those Lessons Learned
way back from week zero where we started
writing our own functions not
necessarily because it solves the
problem more correctly I dare say this
is correct as is but it begins to give
us building blocks that we can extend so
as to solve more complicated programs so
let me go back up to student.pi and
let's go ahead now and do this let's put
the entire logic I just wrote inside of
our typical method called Main and let
me indent those three lines so that at
least they're now combined into one main
method but instead of using input on
line two and input on line three why
don't we go ahead and assume for the
moment that we've got some function
called get name in the world and let's
go ahead and assume we've got another
function like get house in the world
that don't take parameters but their
purpose in life is by by their names
going to be to get the user's name and
to get their users house respectively
and then I'm going to print out the
exact same F string as before I of
course need to implement these functions
now so let me go lower in my file and
Define a function called get underscore
name nothing in these parentheses
because it's not going to take a
parameter and I'm going to go ahead and
do something like name equals input
quote unquote name just like before and
then I'm going to go ahead and return
name so it's a super simple function but
it's a an abstraction I now have a
function called get name whose
implementation details I don't have to
care about anymore I just know that the
function exists and I can tighten this
up in fact I don't really need a name
variable on line eight if I'm
immediately going to return that same
name variable on line 9. so let me just
tighten this up a little bit even though
it doesn't change the functionality and
just immediately return the return value
of the inputs function call here let's
do something very similar now for get
house which will similarly take no
arguments I'm going to go ahead and
return the return value of input this
time prompting the user for their house
and they need one final detail at the
very bottom let's continue our habit of
doing if the name of this file equals
equals quote unquote main then let's go
ahead and actually call Main and recall
that we have that in place so that if
this eventually becomes part of a module
a library of sorts I don't accidentally
call Main blindly I only do it if I mean
to run main from the command line on
this file all right so if I didn't make
any mistakes here let me go ahead and in
my terminal window again run python of
student.pi enter let's type in Harry
enter let's type in Gryffindor enter and
we're set Harry from Gryffindor seems to
still be working so we haven't really
solved the problem anymore correctly but
I've laid the foundation to maybe now do
some more interesting things because
I've had these building blocks in place
all right but let me propose that we
could be doing this a little bit
differently get name get house is fine
but at the end of the day I'm really
trying to get a student from the user I
want their name and their house not just
one or the other so maybe it would be a
little cleaner still to define a
function called get student and let get
student do all of this work for us now
theoretically get student could call get
name and could call get house but
because these functions are so short I
think I'm okay with justifying one
function called get student that
similarly won't take any arguments but
it's going to do two things it's going
to get this Student's name by prompting
them with input as before and it's going
to get the student's house by also
prompting them as before and then
now hmm I want to return the student but
I think I might have painted myself into
a corner here because I now have two
variables name and house and yet up
until now we've pretty much returned one
or the other we've returned one value so
any suggestions for how we can perhaps
solve this problem that I just created
for myself whereby I want to return
really a student but I currently have a
name variable and a house variable I
minimally like to return both of those I
believe that we can return a dictionary
include the name and the house yeah so
we absolutely could return a dictionary
addict object in Python whereby maybe
one key is name one key is house and the
values thereof are exactly the values of
these variables so we could totally do
that uh I worry that that might be
getting a little complicated I wonder if
there's a simpler way instead any other
instincts even if you're not sure it
would work written both name and house
return both name and house I I like the
sound of that it sounds simple I don't
have to figure around what a dictionary
is going to look like and in fact this
too would be a valid approach even if
you've not seen this before it turns out
in Python that you can kind of return
multiple values but that's a bit of a
white lie or we could take Muhammad's
approach of actually returning a
dictionary and putting multiple Keys
therein so here again we have yet
another example of how you can solve the
same problem in at least two ways and I
dare say we're about to see even more so
one way you could solve this problem
whereby you want to return multiple
values would be to do something like
this I could go ahead and literally
return not just name but I could put a
comma and also return house this is not
necessarily something you can do in
other languages if you have programs in
other languages before it depends on the
language but it looks like thanks to
this comma maybe I can in fact return
two values is actually proposed well if
I'm returning two values in this way on
line 10 how do I get both values at the
same time well there's a couple of ways
let me go up to my main function I know
minimally I'm going to have to change
the get name and get house to get
student but what am I going to store the
return value in I think I could actually
do this and we have seen this technique
before where you can unpack so to speak
sequences of values that are coming back
and indeed consider this to be exactly
that name comma house is some kind of
sequence that I'm returning of values
name comma house so if I want to unpack
those and store the return values in two
separate variables I can in fact use the
commas on the left hand side of my
assignment operator the equal sign to do
just that now to be clear I don't need
to call these variables name and house
here I could simplify this and use just
n here and H here and then I could
return just n and H but I would argue
that's not very clear to the reader as
to what's going on so I think in this
case even though it's a coincidence that
I've used the same variable names in get
student and get Main and in Maine it's a
little more readable to someone like me
so I'm going to leave it as is
well let's go ahead and see now if this
works let me clear my screen down here
and run python of student.pi enter let's
again type in Harry let's again type in
Gryffindor enter and voila we still see
that Harry is from Gryffindor but what
are we actually doing here what are we
actually doing by returning this value
well it turns out that what we've just
done is used a tuple a tuple is another
type of data in Python that's a
collection of values X comma y or X
comma y comma Z it's similar in spirit
to a list in that sense but it's
immutable it's not mutable now what does
that mean a list as we've seen it before
is a data structure in Python that you
can change the values of you can go into
bracket zero for the first location and
change the value there you can go to
bracket one bracket two bracket three
and actually change the values in lists
but if you have no intention of changing
the values of variables and you want to
return effectively multiple values you
don't have to even return it as a list
you can return it as a tuple and instead
just by using a comma and it turns out
we can make explicit that here's the
white lie I'm not actually returning two
values per se whenever you use a comma
in this way on line 9 you're actually
returning one value which is a tuple
inside of that Tuple now are two values
so it's similar in spirit to returning
one list with two things here I'm
returning one Tuple with two things and
the mere fact that I've used a comma and
nothing else tells python that I indeed
want to return a tuple but there's more
explicit syntax that we can use instead
I can actually more verbosely put
explicit parentheses around the values
of this Tuple just to make more clear to
me to the reader that this isn't two
values per se this is one value with two
things inside of it and what I can
actually do then too is I don't have to
unpack this up here so to speak I can
actually go up here and maybe give a
more apt name like student and I can
name the value or rather name the
variable in which I'm storing the return
value of get student as quote unquote
student so maybe this is a little better
design now because I'm sort of
abstracting away what a student is it's
implemented at the moment as a tuple
with two values but at least now I have
a variable called what I mean a student
but there's going to be a catch on line
three I still want to print out that
Student's name and their house but I
don't have a name variable anymore and I
don't have a house and I also don't have
a dictionary as was proposed earlier so
I can't even go at those keys by name
but what a tuple is it's very similar in
spirit to a list but it is indeed just
immutable and what I mean by that is I
can still index into it numerically by
saying student square bracket zero for
the item in the first location in that
Tuple and then over here instead of
house I can say student bracket one
student bracket one is going to give me
the second location in that Tuple let me
go ahead and clear my terminal window
again run python of student.pi let's
type in Harry let's type in Gryffindor
enter and we still have some working
code let me pause here now and see if
there are any questions on this
technique of returning a tuple and
indexing into it in this way I guess
that's like a actual use case where you
would use a tuple versus you know a list
or something else that's similar it's a
really good question when would you use
a tuple versus a list when you want to
program defensively or in general when
you know that the values in this
variable shouldn't change so why would
you use a data type that allows them to
be changed it just invites mistakes bugs
down the line either by you or
colleagues who are interacting with your
code so Tuple is just another way where
you can increase the probability of
correctness by just not letting anyone
yourself included change the contents
they're in so it's just another tool in
your toolkit but let's make clear then
what I mean by immutable again I claim
that immutable means that you cannot
change the value well let's go ahead and
try to do this let me go ahead ahead and
run this program once more as is
pythonofstudent.pi let me go ahead and
type in for instance how about padma's
name and I'm going to go ahead and say
that Padma is in Gryffindor as in the
movies and we see Padma from Gryffindor
but technically I went down this rabbit
hole and looking at Harry Potter more
closely technically in the books Padma I
believe was from Ravenclaw so this is
actually a mistake or an inconsistency
between the movies and the books let's
see if we can't fix this inconsistency
in our code so how about we do this if
the student's name that's inputted
equals Padma why don't we override
whatever the uh whatever the house is
and change it to be properly Gryffindor
let me go ahead and do if students now
if I want to get at padma's name I'm
going to have to do student bracket zero
I have to know what location the name is
in in this Tuple but if that in value
equals equals Padma let's go ahead with
this if statement and make a change
let's change the students for uh at one
value so the second value if we're zero
indexing let's change it to be another
house in the World of Harry Potter
called Ravenclaw so I'm just fixing
maybe the user's input they watch the
movie so they type in Padma Gryffindor
but in the books it was Padma from
Ravenclaw all right let me go ahead and
go down to my terminal window clear my
terminal and do python of student.pi
enter I'm going to do Harry as well as
Gryffindor just to demonstrate that that
is still working as intended Let Me
Clear My screen again though and run
python of student.pi on Padma and I'll
put her2 in Gryffindor as in the movies
and hit enter and now I just see a big
mess of errors on the screen some kind
of exception has been thrown and indeed
a type error has happened I'm using a
data type wherein there's an error and
what is that error well Tuple object
does not support item assignment it's a
little arcanely Express that is that's
not really very user friendly but if you
think about what those words mean Tuple
object does not support item assign so
assignment is copying from right to left
so somehow that's invalid and here is a
manifestation of the immutability of
tuples you cannot change location 0 or 1
or anything inside that is a feature
that is the design of a tuple so if I
want to override that I think I'm going
to have to use a different type of data
that we've used before namely a list and
that's fine if you want to enable
yourself and colleagues using your code
to change the contents of that container
well we can go ahead and return not a
tuple using explicit parentheses or no
parentheses just the comma but I can use
square brackets and if I'm using square
brackets on the left and the right this
is indeed explicitly a list same idea
but it's mutable that is to say you can
change the contents of a list so making
no other changes just returning a list
with square brackets instead of a tuple
with parentheses or just the comma let
me go ahead now and run python of
student.pi enter let me type in Harry
and Gryffindor again that's still
working good to see let me run this once
more and type in Padma and Gryffindor as
in the movies but no now we've corrected
it to be Padma from Ravenclaw as in the
books instead
any questions now on tuples versus lists
or this idea of immutability versus
mutability
it can be used a nested tackle in Python
like a nested list
absolutely you can have not only nested
lists in Python where one of the
elements in a list could be another list
so you have some square brackets out
here you might have some other square
brackets inside you can absolutely do
the same with a tuple as well there's no
constraint on the types of values you
can put in there we've not had occasion
to do that in this case I'm just
returning a simple uh simple Tuple with
two elements but yes you could
absolutely do that too other questions
on tuples versus lists okay for example
um when I see this websocket um is it
many use for the list oh a really good
question uh sort of so when you create a
value like a list you use square
brackets and that would indeed be a
visual indicator that this is definitely
a list uh if you instead see parentheses
that's a visual indicator when creating
a value that it's definitely a tuple
however somewhat confusingly both lists
and tuples use square brackets when you
access the contents of them when you
index into them at location zero or
location one you always use square
brackets so that's the distinction there
good question allow me to propose now if
I made that we solve this problem yet
another way and let's see if we're
either making things better or for worse
than us recall that dictionaries or dict
objects also exist in python and a
dictionary is this collection of keys
and values and the upside in particular
of a dictionary is that they have better
semantics right you don't just have to
assume that a name is always going to be
at location zero house is always going
to be at location one I mean that's the
kind of thing especially if you had
three four or more values eventually you
or someone is going to get confused and
forget what the order is and you're
going to write buggy code so a
dictionary is a little more powerful in
that you can semantically associate Keys
like little descriptions with the values
those keys and those values respectively
so let me go ahead and do this and we
can do this in a few different ways but
let me propose that we focus on get
student here and let's go ahead and do
this let me go ahead and delete the
implementation of get student as is let
me create a student variable and
initialize it to an empty dictionary and
I can do that with just two curly braces
here and then let me go ahead and set
two keys inside of that dictionary
inside of the student there will be
quote unquote a name key and the value
of that is going to be whatever the
return value of input is when I prompt
the user for their name and then the
house key inside of that same student
dictionary is going to be the return
value of whatever the user types in for
their house and lastly I'm going to go
ahead and in return students so now I am
literally returning one thing still but
this time it's a dict rather than a
tuple rather than a list but there's
still two things in it technically four
things if you count the keys and the
values but there's two key value pairs
now my code up here is going to have to
change a little bit and let's simplify
this and remove for instance now the the
Padma if statement just to focus on
what's changing at hand and let me go
ahead now and leave line two alone I'm
still going to have a student variable
that gets assigned the return value of
get student but what I want to do here
now is actually access the keys inside
of that dictionary not by numeric index
which was for tuples and lists zero and
one but by way of the keys now normally
I might be in the habit as I personally
am of using double quotes quote unquote
name inside of there and quote unquote
house instead of there but before I even
run this code and show you a mistake see
an error on the screen does anyone want
to call out what I have done wrong here
this is just an F string I just want to
print out the value of the name key the
value of the house key in this
dictionary
button
your your audio is a little garbled for
us but I think I heard double quotes and
single quotes so I'm going to assume
that indeed you've identified precisely
the issue I'm just going to confuse
python right now even though this is an
F string inside of Double quotes
prefixed with an F I can't actually use
my double quotes inside my double quotes
because that's going to potentially
confuse python indeed if I run this
program now python of student.pi and hit
enter I get a syntax error so the
program didn't even run fully it just
couldn't be understood because it got
confused by those double quotes So the
simplest fix here would indeed just be
to use not double quotes but single
quotes around the keys or conversely
flip the double quotes on the outside to
single quotes then use double quotes on
the inside you just want to be
consistent so it's subtle detail but
again this is now specific to dictionary
syntax this isn't fundamental to how
we're solving this current problem at
hand all right well let's go ahead and
try this let me go ahead now and run
python of student.pi let's go ahead and
type in Harry let's type in Gryffindor
and hopefully Harry is back from
Gryffindor no syntax errors no other
errors I think I'm back in business here
and what I do like to be clear about
using a dictionary is that it's allowing
me just better semantics again I don't
have to remember memorize document that
zero is name one is house instead name
is name and house is house it's just a
little clear a little more expressive so
that's generally a good thing especially
if we stored more data about students
than just their name in their house if
you had three Fields four five ten
different fields no one's going to want
to remember or be able to remember
forever which is zero which is one which
is two and so forth better to introduce
names like name and house in this case
but but let me tighten this up further
and indeed I'm typically in the habit of
not introducing variables unnecessarily
unless they make the code more readable
and an alternative way to format the
same code would be this strictly
speaking I don't need to create an empty
dictionary then add one key to it then
add a second key to it and then return
that dictionary I can actually
consolidate this all into one statement
if you will let me go ahead and do this
let me go ahead and say name equals
inputs return value house equals inputs
return value and then instead of
returning any variable name student
which I'm going to propose doesn't need
to exist anymore let me just create and
return the dictionary all at once let me
do quote unquote name in lowercase here
and then the variable it's storing the
user's name then quote unquote house as
my second key the value of which is
going to be house the variable now is
this better maybe maybe not maybe the
first way was a little more readable and
that's totally fine to create variables
if they improve the readability of of
your code but just know that you can
also create and return a dictionary on
the fly like this so to speak all in one
line and I think it's arguably pretty
reasonable in this case why it's just
pretty short I probably wouldn't do this
if it got longer and longer and longer I
might minimally then start moving my key
value pairs to separate lines but this
would just be a slightly more compact
way of doing this as well but let me
propose we do one more change let's go
ahead and introduce that same special
casing of Padma to fix her house from
Gryffindor for instance to Ravenclaw how
do we do this with dictionaries well
dictionaries like lists are mutable you
can change what is in them just like you
can lists how do you do that it's just a
little different syntactically so let's
go back into Main and do this fix if the
student variable has a name key that
equals equals Padma then indented go
ahead and change the value of the house
key inside of that student dictionary to
be quote unquote Ravenclaw instead so
very similar in spirit to what we did
with a list but instead of using
location 0 and 1 we're much more clearly
explicitly semantically using quote
unquote name and quote unquote house
because you index into lists and topples
using numbers but you index into
dictionaries using strings as I've done
here all right let me go ahead and run
python of student dot Pi we'll again do
Harry from Gryffindor and I think all is
well let me run it one more time this
time with Padma who in the movies is
from Gryffindor but should really be
from Ravenclaw
are any questions then on this
progression from tuples to lists to
dictionaries we haven't necessarily
introduced anything new other than those
tuples which have been available to us
all this time but the goal at the moment
is just to demonstrate this distinction
among these different data types and how
they each work a little bit differently
so what if a combination of lists is
there in a tuple so is the list like we
can change the list because Tuple are
immutable but listen correct you can
change the contents of lists and you can
put most anything you want in them other
lists or strings as I've done integers
or anything else tuples you can do the
exact same thing but you cannot change
them once you've created them a
dictionary is more like a list in that
it is mutable you can change it but the
way you index into a dictionary is by
way of these Keys these strings as we
keep saying rather than by numbers those
numeric indices
all right well let me propose that there
is yet another way of solving this
problem and indeed I would argue that
there's now an opportunity to hand even
though this program isn't particularly
complicated all I'm doing is collecting
a name from the user and a house from
the user you could imagine wanting
longer term to collect even more
information like the students Patronus
or magical spell or a whole bunch of
other information that might belong in a
student and right now we're just kind of
using these very general purpose data
types in Python a tuple to combine some
values together a list to do the same
but let us change it later a dictionary
which is more powerful because it's a
little more structured it does have keys
and it has values not just values but
you know what this we wouldn't have to
be having this conversation if the
authors of python had just given us a
data type called student right wouldn't
it have been nice if there were just a
type of variable I could create in my
code called student then we wouldn't
have to figure out well do we use a
tuple or list or a dictionary but that's
pretty reasonable right you can imagine
just us how slippery of a slope that is
so to speak if the creators of a
language had to anticipate all the
possible types of data that programmers
like you and me want to store in your
programs so they just gave us these
general purpose tools but they gave us
another general purpose tool that's
going to allow us to create our own data
types as well and actually give them
names and that terminology is a class A
Class is kind of like a blueprint for
pieces of data object so to speak a
class is kind of like a mold that you
can define and give a name and when you
use that mold or you use that blueprint
you get types of data that are designed
exactly as you want so in short classes
allow you to invent your own data types
in Python and give them a name and this
is a primary feature of object oriented
programming to be able to create your
own objects in this way and in the case
of python in classes even give them some
custom names so what does this mean in
real terms well let me go ahead and come
back to vs code here and let me propose
that we introduce a little bit of new
syntax I'm going to go ahead and clear
my terminal window first I'm going to go
to the top of my file and I'm just going
to start a thought but not finish it yet
I'm going to use this new keyword for
classes called literally class so indeed
the new keyword we're going to have here
and if I go back to our slides here this
would be the official URL where you can
read up more on this particular feature
of python in the official tutorial class
is a new keyword we can use now this is
coincidentally related to students
because students take classes but it has
nothing to do with the fact that we're
dealing with students class is a general
purpose term in a lot of languages
python among them that allow you to
Define these custom containers with
custom names for pieces of data so let's
go back to vs code let's use this new
keyword and let me propose that we
create a class called students and by
convention I'm going to use a capital S
here and I'm going to go ahead and with
a colon get to later the implementation
of this class so I'm just going to use
dot dot dot which is a valid placeholder
for now that just indicates to me that
I'm going to come back to implementing
this later but as of now it does in fact
exist I now have a student class defined
for me that I can now use in my code
here how am I going to use it well first
of all let me go down to get student and
let me change this code to no longer use
a dictionary but to use this class I'm
going to do this I'm going to give
myself a variable called student as I've
done before but I'm going to set it
equal to Capital student open
parenthesis close parenthesis so I'm
going to do what appears to be calling a
function and that function student with
a capital S notice matches the name that
I gave this class at the top of my file
all right what do I next want to do I'm
going to go ahead and give this student
a name now if I were still using a
dictionary I would say student quote
unquote name using square brackets but
this is not a dictionary it turns out
classes have what for now we'll call
attributes properties of sorts that
allow you to specify values inside of
them in the Syntax for that happens to
be a DOT we've seen dots before we've
used it in the context of modules and
libraries more generally this is another
similar in spirit use of a DOT that
allows you to get at something inside of
something else so student dot name is
going to be the syntax I use for giving
this student a name and that name is
going to be whatever the return value of
name is and then I'm going to go ahead
and say student dot house to give
another attribute called house and give
that the return value of input here
prompting the user for house and then as
before I'm just going to return student
but now what's really powerful about
class and object-oriented programming
more generally is that I've created this
custom data type called literally
student capital S I've stored one such
student in a variable like I can always
do in a variable called student
lowercase s but I could call it anything
I want it just makes sense to call it
student as well but lowercase for
clarity and then I'm returning that
variable and because of my syntax in
lines 14 and 15 that has the result of
putting inside of that class a name
attribute and a house attribute I just
need to make one more change up here I'm
going to go ahead and remove our Padma
code just so we can focus only on what's
new rather than fixing her house and I'm
going to go in here and change the
syntax that previously was for
dictionaries again dictionaries use
square brackets and then strings in
quotes either single quotes or double
quotes depending on the context here
though I'm going to change this to be
student dot name and over here I'm going
to change it to be student dot house and
that's just going to be my new syntax
for getting the contents of what appears
to be a class called student let me go
ahead and rerun python of student.i
enter let's type in Harry's name as
before let's put him in Gryffindor
crossing our fingers as we often do and
Harry is indeed from Gryffindor
what though have I done let's introduce
one other bit of terminology here it
turns out that I can create a class
using that class keyword but anytime you
use a class you're creating what are
called objects and here is the word
objects as in object oriented
programming or oop let me go back to my
code here and even though I haven't
really implemented much of it at all I
literally just left it with a dot dot
dot that's enough code lines one and two
to just invent a new data type called
student capital s that may or may not
have some future functionality as well
that's enough to create a class what
though am I doing on line 11 on line 11
what I'm technically doing is creating
an object of that class so this too is
another term of R you create objects
from classes so if we go back to that
metaphor that a class is like a
blueprint for a house or a class is like
a mold an object is when you use that
blueprint to build a specific house or
something that comes out of plaster the
mold when you actually use that mole to
create such an object so a class is
again the definition of a new data type
the object is the Incarnation of or
technically instantiation of and another
term for objects would actually be an
instance you have instances of classes
as well so that's a lot of vocabulary
but at the end of the day it just boils
down to this you can Define your own
class which is really your own data type
you can then store attributes inside of
it using this dot notation here and then
you can access those same attributes
using Code like this here and now I have
a proper student data type and I don't
have to kind of hack something together
using a tuple or a list or even a
dictionary I now have a proper data type
called student that the authors of
python didn't give me I gave myself
any questions now on classes this new
keyword class or this idea of these
objects or instances thereof is the
class object mutable or immutable a good
question and we've clearly laid the
stage for having that conversation about
every data type now we will see that
they are mutable but you can make them
immutable so you can get the best of
both worlds Now by writing some actual
code and we'll write more code than the
dot dot dot in just a bit other
questions on classes or these objects
thereof then what would be the
properties of those classes uh so at the
moment the properties of or the
attributes of as I've been calling them
thus far would just be name and house it
turns out that there may very well be
other attributes built into classes that
we may see before long but for now the
only two attributes that I care about
are the ones that I myself created
namely name and house or again what I
would call attributes and in a little
bit we're going to start calling those
same attributes more technically
instance variables name and house as I
presented them here in vs code are
really just variables called name and
called house inside of an object whose
type is student all right so what more
can we do with these classes well again
on line 11 is where we're instantiating
an object of the student class and
assigning it to a student variable we're
then adding attributes name and house
respectively on lines 12 and 13
currently both of those have values that
are technically strings or stirs because
that's what the return value of input is
but those attributes values could
actually be any data type we're just
keeping things simple and focusing on
defining students in terms of two
strings name and house and then on line
14 we're returning that variable we're
returning that object to main so that we
can actually print out who is from what
house well let's go ahead and add a bit
more functionality here because right
now on lines 12 and 13 this is a little
manual and it's a little reckless of me
to just be putting anything I want
inside of this student object it turns
out with classes unlike with
dictionaries we can actually standardize
all the more what those attributes can
be and how what kinds of values you can
set them to so let me go ahead and do
this let me propose that it would
actually be really nice if instead of
doing this here let me go ahead and
simplify my code as follows let me go
ahead and give myself a local variable
called name and set it equal to the
return value of input like we've done
many times now already let me give
myself one other variable for now called
house and set it equal to the return
value of input as well prompting the
user for their house and now instead of
creating a student object from my
student class and then manually putting
the name attribute inside of it and the
house attribute inside of it let me
actually do something more powerful let
me do this let me call that student
function which is identical to the class
name just by finding a class you get a
function whose name is identical to the
class name with the capital letter
included but instead of just doing open
parenthesis close parenthesis let me
pass in the name that I want to fill
this this object with and the house that
I want to put in that object as well and
now let me set the return value as
before to be student equals like this so
what have I done that's different
fundamentally I'm still getting user
input in the same way I'm using input on
line 11 and input on line 12 and I just
so happen to be storing those return
values in local variables but now now
we're setting the stage for the more
powerful features of classes and object
oriented programming more generally
notice that I'm deliberately passing to
this capital S student function name
comma house I'm passing in arguments to
the function now the student class is
not going to know what to do with those
yet but now I'm sort of standardizing
how I'm passing data into this student
class and ultimately it's going to give
me an opportunity to error check those
inputs to make sure that the name is
valid that it has a value and it's not
just the user hitting enter it's going
to allow me to ensure that it's a valid
house that it's Gryffindor or Hufflepuff
or Ravenclaw or Slytherin or not just
hitting enter or some random value that
the user types in because I'm passing
name and house to the student class this
particular function I'm going to have
more control over the correctness of my
data so let's now go up to the student
class which up until now I left is just
dot dot dot it turns out that in the
context of classes there are a number of
not just uh attributes or instance
variables that you can put inside but
also methods classes come with certain
methods or functions inside of them that
you can Define and they just behave in a
special way by nature of how python
works these functions allow you to
determine behavior in a standard way
they are indeed special methods in that
sense now what do I mean by this well
let me go back to vs code here and let
me propose that I start to define a
standard function called underscore
underscore or Dunder as it's abbreviated
in it underscore underscore and then I'm
going to go ahead and do open
parenthesis and then I'm going to put in
here literally the word self more on
that in just a moment but now inside of
this function I'm going to have an
opportunity Unity to customize this
classes objects that is to say this
underscore underscore init method or
Dunder init method is specifically known
as an instance method and it's called
exactly this this is designed by the
authors of python and if you want to
initialize the contents of an object
from a class you define this method and
we'll see what it's about to do here let
me go back to vs code and let me do
something like this
self.name equals name and self.house
equals house but I don't want to just
init this object very generically I want
this method called init to take in not
just self but name comma house as well
now what in the world is going on
because there's a lot of weird syntax
here there's this Dunder init method a
double underscore init double underscore
there's all of a sudden this parameter
called self and then there's this new
syntax self.name and self.house now
you're seeing really a manifestation of
object oriented programming it's not all
that different fundamentally from what
we've been doing for weeks with
dictionaries by adding keys to
dictionaries but in this case we're
adding variables to objects AKA instance
variables to objects now what's going on
let's do this in Reverse let's go back
to the line of code we wrote earlier on
line 15 I am treating the name of this
class student with a capital S as a
function and I am passing in two values
name and house what I've highlighted
here on the screen on line 15 is
generally known as a Constructor call
this is a line of code that is going to
construct a student object for me using
synonyms it is going to instantiate a
student object for me and again how is
it going to create that object it's
going to use the student class as a
template as a mold of sorts so that
every student is structured the same
every student is going to have a name
every student's going to have a house
but because I can pass in arguments to
this student function capital S I'm
going to be able to customize the
contents of that object so if you think
about the real world if you've ever been
on a street or a neighborhood where all
of the houses kind of look the same but
there might be painted differently they
might be decorated a little bit
differently on the outside all of those
houses might have been built using the
exact same blueprint sort of a mold if
you will but then you can specialize
exactly the finer points of those houses
by painting the outside a different
color or planting different trees you
can style them differently similar in
spirit here we have a student blueprint
that's always going to have now a name
and a house but it's up to you and me to
pass in any name in any house that we
want now where is this function the fact
that I'm calling student capital S and
then a parenthesis and a closed
parenthesis with arguments inside side
suggests that there's a function
somewhere in the world that has been
defined with death that's going to be
called well as you might have guessed by
now the function that will always be
called by definition of how python
classes work is a function called double
underscore init double underscore why
it's a crazy name but it's what the
authors of python chose to just
implement the initialization of an
object in Python now the only weird
thing especially weird thing I will
admit is this it would be way clear to
me too if the only two parameters for in
it were just name comma house right
that's how we've defined every function
thus far in the class you just specify
the parameters that you want the
function to accept and indeed that lines
up with what I'm doing on line 15. I am
only passing in two things to the
student function but it turns out that
the authors of python need to give us a
little bit of help here because suppose
that you pass in name and house to this
init method and a method is just a
function inside of a class what are you
going to do with the name and the house
like literally where are you going to
put them if you want to remember the
name in the house for this student
you've got to be able to store those
values somewhere and how do you store
them in the current object that has just
been instantiated well the authors of
python decided that the convention is
going to be that this init method also
semi-secretely takes a third argument
that has to come first by convention
it's called self but you could call it
technically anything you want but the
convention is to always call itself and
self as its name implies gives you
access to the current object that was
just created what does that mean again
now on line 14 now that it's moved down
a little bit this line here is a
Constructor it constructs a student
object but there's nothing in that
object initially there's no name there's
no house but the object is exists in the
computer's memory it's up to now you to
store the name and the house inside of
that object how do you do that well
python will just automatically call this
init method for you and it's going to
automatically pass in a reference to a
an argument that represents the current
object that it just constructed in
memory for you and it's up to you to
populate it with values and what this
means is that inside of your init method
you can literally do self.name to create
a new attribute AKA an instance variable
inside of that otherwise empty object
and put this name inside of it it allows
you to do self.house and store that
value of house now you could call these
things anything you want they could be n
they could be H as before but that's
really not very self uh explanatory much
better to do this kind of convention
self.name equals name self.house equals
house and this is like installing into
the otherwise empty object the value
name and house and storing them in
really identically named instance
variables in the object and again an
object is just an instance of a class
now I know that was a lot of vocabulary
that's a lot of weird syntax so any
questions on this init method whose
purpose in life again is to initialize
an otherwise empty object when you first
create it and what is the difference
between the init method and default
Constructor a good question so in other
languages if you program before for
instance Java there are expunctions that
are explicitly called Constructors that
indeed construct an object they
initialize it with values python
technically calls this init method the
initialization method it initializes the
value it's on line 14 line 15 now of my
code if I scroll back down that I'm
technically constructing the object it
turns out there's another special method
in Python that we won't talk about in
detail today called underscore
underscore new underscore underscore
that actually handles the process of
creating an empty object in memory for
us but generally speaking you the
programmer don't need to manipulate the
new function it just works for you
instead you define your own init method
here an init function inside of your
class and that method initializes the
contents of the object so there's
technically a distinction between
constructing the object with new and
initializing it within it but in the
world of python you pretty much only
worry about the init method python
generally does the other part for you a
good question others uh what about if
you want to store more than one name or
more than one house a good question if
more than one house you can do this in
different ways you could create other
attributes technically called instance
variables like self.name one self dot
name two but we've seen in the past that
that is not a very good design just to
have multiple variables to store
multiple things maybe instead you have
an instance variable called
self.names plural and you set it equal
to a list of names or a list of houses
now in this case I don't think that
really solves a problem because I'm
trying to implement a student sing
regular so it doesn't really make sense
to have multiple first names maybe a
nickname maybe a last name so we could
add those two but I don't think we need
multiple names per se and in this case
multiple houses but absolutely you could
do that using some of our familiar
building blocks like lists other
questions how are classes or objects
represented in memory how are classes
and objects represented in memory so the
class is technically just code it is the
code on the top of my file lines one
through four that defines that blueprint
that template if you will objects are
stored in the computer's memory by
taking up some number of bytes so you're
probably familiar with bytes or
kilobytes or megabytes there's some
chunk of bytes probably all in the same
location in the computer's memory or Ram
where those Vari where those objects are
stored but that's what python the
program handles for you python The
Interpreter figures out where in the
computer's memory to put it you and I
the programmers get to think and solve
problems at this level python The
Interpreter handles those lower level
details for you how about one final
question on classes and objects now my
question is if we can see do the same
thing with the dictionary so I have to
use classes good question if you can do
the same things as you can with
dictionaries why should you use classes
because we are just scratching the
surface now of what you can do with
classes allow me to go back now to my
keyboard and show you more of what you
can do with classes but in short you can
do much more with classes you can ensure
the correctness of your data much more
with classes you can error check things
and generally you can design more
complicated software more effectively
and we'll continue to see today features
of python and object-oriented
programming more generally that allows
us to do just that so let me propose in
fact that first let's just tighten up
this current implementation which again
has us with an init method that just
declares two instance variables
self.name and self.house which again
just creates those variables inside of
the otherwise empty object and assigns
them values name and house respectively
let me go ahead and just do one little
thing here I don't really need the
student variable let me just tighten
this up so that each time we improve or
change the code we're focusing really on
just the minimal changes alone so I've
not fundamentally done anything
different I just got rid of the variable
name and I'm just returning the return
value of this student function that's
constructing my new object for me so I'm
just tightening things up as we've done
many times in the past well what if
something goes wrong when in creating
this student for instance what if the
user does not give us a name and they
just hit enter when prompted for name
like I don't want to put in my
computer's memory a sort of bogus
student object that has no name right
I'd ideally like to check for errors
before I even create it so I don't
create a nameless student it would just
be weird and probably a bug to have an
object that has no name similarly I
don't want the user to be able to type
in something random as their house at
least in the World of Harry Potter
there's really only four houses at
Hogwarts at least or there's again
Gryffindor and Hufflepuff and Ravenclaw
and Slytherin a list of four valid
houses it would be nice if I somehow
validated that the user's input is
indeed in that list now I could do all
of that validation in my get student
function I could check is the name empty
if so don't create the student object is
the house one of those four houses if
not don't create the student object but
that would be rather decoupled from the
student itself right get student
currently exists as just my own function
in my student.pi file but classes and
really object-oriented programming more
generally encourages you to encapsulate
inside of a class all functionality
related to that class so if you want to
validate that a name exists if you want
to validate that a house is correct that
belongs just fundamentally in the class
called student itself not in some random
function that you wrote elsewhere again
this is just methodology because again
if we think about writing code that gets
longer and longer more and more
complicated it should make just
intuitive sense that if you keep all the
house and all the Stu all of the name
and all of the house related code in the
student it's just better organization
right keep all of the related code
together and that's probably going to
set you up for more success and indeed
that's part of this methodology of
object oriented programming let me go
ahead now and change my students classes
init method to do this
if the name is blank so if not name and
we've seen this kind of syntax before if
you say in Python pythonically if not
name that's like doing something like
this if name equals equals quote unquote
but I can do this a little more
elegantly just say if not name would be
the more pythonic way to do it well I
want to return an error like I might
want to do something like this print
missing name but this is not good enough
it does not suffice to just print out
missing name and then let the rest of
the code go through all right well what
could I do instead in the past we've
seen another technique I could do
sys.exit and I could say something like
missing name and I could go up here and
I could import CIS but this is a really
obnoxious solution to the problem just
because you or maybe a colleague messed
up and called a function with an invalid
name you're going to quit my whole
program like that's really really
extreme of a response and you probably
don't want to do that if your program's
in the middle of running you might want
to clean clean some stuff up you might
want to save files you don't want to
just exit a program sometimes in some
arbitrary line just because input was
invalid so I don't think we want to do
that either but we do now have a
mechanism
for signaling errors unfortunately I
can't do something like this I could try
returning none and say uh-uh this
student does not exist I'm going to hand
you back none instead but it's too late
if we scroll back down to where I'm
creating the student it's on line 17 now
where I've highlighted this code the
student has already been created there
is an object somewhere in the computer's
memory that's structured as a student it
just doesn't have any values inside of
it but it's too late therefore to return
none that ship has sailed the object
exists you can't just suddenly say no no
there is no object there is an object
it's up to you to Signal an error and
how do you signal an error well we've
actually seen this before but we haven't
had occasion to create our own errors it
turns out in Python there's another
keyword related to exceptions that
python itself uses to raise all of those
exceptions we've talked about in the
past when you've caught things like
value errors or other such exceptions
that come with python well it turns out
you the programmer can raise that is
create your own exceptions when
something just really goes wrong not
wrong enough that you want to quit and
exit the whole program but enough that
you need to somehow alert the programmer
that there has been an error something
exceptional in a very bad way something
exceptional has happened and let them
try to catch that exception as needed so
let me go back to vs code here and
propose that if the user passes in an
invalid name it's just empty so there's
not a name well what I really want to do
is this I want to raise a value error
and we've seen the value errors before
we've created value errors accidentally
before and generally you and I have
tried to catch them if they happen well
the flip side of this feature of
exceptions in a language like python is
that you the programmer can also raise
exceptions when something exceptional
happens and you can even be more precise
you don't have to raise a generic value
error and let the programmer figure out
what went wrong long you can treat value
error and all exceptions in Python like
functions and actually pass to them an
explanatory message like quote unquote
missing name so that at least the
programmer when they encounter this
error knows oh I messed up I didn't make
sure that the user has a name and now
what do you want to do instead well now
if you're the programmer you could do
something like this you could try to
create a student except if there's a
value error then you could handle it in
some way and I'm going to wave my hand
with a dot dot dot at how you would
handle it but you would handle it using
try and accept just like we have in the
past and that would allow you the
programmer to try to create the student
but if something goes wrong okay okay
I'll handle it nonetheless so what's new
here again is this raise keyword that
just lets you and I actually raise our
own exceptions to Signal these errors
well let me go back to my code here and
I'm just going to go ahead and not
bother trying or catching the this error
for now we'll just focus on raising it
and assume that from our week on
exceptions you could add try and accept
as needed in places let me go back to
the code here and propose that something
else could go wrong with house right if
there is a name we're good but if we're
given a house but it's invalid we should
probably raise an exception for that too
so what if we do this if house is not in
the list containing Gryffindor quote
unquote uh Hufflepuff quote unquote uh
let's see Ravenclaw quote unquote or
Slytherin quote unquote then with my
colon let's raise another type of value
error but rather than raise a generic
value error let's pass in an argument
quote unquote invalid house
and so here we now see a capability that
we can do with classes that we can't
with dictionaries if you add an
attribute to a dictionary a key to a
dictionary it's going in no matter what
even if the name is empty even if the
house is a completely random string of
text that's not one of these four houses
it's going into that dictionary but with
the class and by way of this init method
you and I can now control exactly what's
going to be installed if you will inside
of this object you have a little more
control now over correctness and so now
let me go ahead and scroll back down to
my terminal window and clear it let me
run python of student.pi let me type in
something like Harry let me type in
Gryffindor enter and we see that indeed
Harry is from Gryffindor what if I made
a mistake though what if I ran python of
student.pi and type Terry as the name
but I this time typed in number four
privet Drive which is where he grew up
instead of his proper Hogwarts house let
me hit enter now and now you see a value
error but this isn't one that python
generated for us per se I raise this
error and therefore if I went in and
wrote more code in my get student
function I could also catch this error
with our usual try except syntax so all
we have now is not just classes in our
toolkit but even more Powers when it
comes to exceptions and not just
catching them ourselves but raising them
ourselves too
any questions now on
this use of classes and in it and now
this ability to raise exceptions when
something goes wrong inside of the
initialization so what if
the user has a middle name
name middle name and last name how would
you fix that a good question if you
wanted the user to if you wanted the
student to have a first name middle name
and last name we could do this in a
bunch of different ways the simplest
though if Let Me Clear My screen here
and let me just temporarily do this let
me propose that the init method taking a
first argument a middle argument and a
last argument and then what I think I
would do down here is ultimately have
first equals first and then I would do
the same thing for middle and last so
middle and middle and then last and last
and then what I would have to do here
is when I actually ask the user for
their name I might need to really go all
out I might need to ask them first for
their first name and store that in a
variable called First and therefore pass
in first I might similarly need to ask
them for their middle name and store
that in a variable and then pass in a
second argument middle and then lastly
if you will let me go ahead and create a
third variable called last get the input
for their last name and pass that in as
well I could instead just use one input
and just ask him for their whole name so
type in David Malin enter or David J
Malin all three of them and maybe I
could use Python split function maybe a
regular expression to tease it apart
that's probably going to be messy
because there's going to be people who
don't have just two or three names they
might have four or five so maybe
sometimes it's better to have multiple
prompts but that's not a problem because
with a class we have the expressiveness
to take in more arguments if we want we
could even take a list if we wanted but
I think we'd probably want to have even
more error checking then not just for
name but for first and then maybe for
middle and then maybe for last so it
just is more and more code though there
would be ways to perhaps consolidate
that too let me undo all of that and see
if there are other questions now on
classes
I assume this is classes or something I
might do at the beginning of a project
can I just put them in a different file
and import them into my project or or my
main code as needed absolutely a really
good question you could imagine wanting
to use this student class not just in
student.pi but in other files or other
projects of yours and absolutely you can
create your own library of classes by
putting the student class in your own
module or package per our discussion in
the past about libraries more generally
and absolutely you can do that and later
today what we see that we've actually
been using classes you and I before in
third party libraries so you too can
absolutely do the same how about one
more question on classes
can you have optional variables in
classes and two can you have your own
error names like let's be egotistical
and say I want to raise Eric error short
answer yes so you can uh these init
functions are just like python functions
more generally even though they're
special and that they're going to get
called automatically by python for you
but if you wanted to make house optional
you could do something like this you
could give it a default value in the
init functions uh signature so to speak
and that first line of code on line two
and that would allow me to not have to
pass in-house in this case I'm going to
continue to always pass a name and house
but you could make things optional and
yes your second question if you wanted
to have your own error message like an
Eric error you could actually create
your own Eric error exception and we'll
see in a little bit that there's
actually a whole Suite of exceptions
that exist and you too can invent those
as well
let me propose though that we now
introduce one other aspect of this
whereby we try printing out what a
student looks like at the moment if I
scroll back down to my main function I'm
still printing the student's name and
house very manually I'm going inside of
the object doing student.name and I'm
going inside of the object again and
getting student.house just to see where
the student is from but wouldn't it be
nice if I could just print the student
like I've been printing for weeks any
int or float or stir or any other data
type well let's see what happens if I
just try printing the student instead of
manually going inside and trying to
create that sentence myself well in my
terminal window let me go ahead and run
python of student.pi again let me type
in Harry let me type in Gryffindor and
voila Harry whoa okay main student
object at ox102
733e80 well what is going on well if you
were to run the same code you might
actually see something different on your
computer in terms of that number but
what you're really really seeing is the
underlying representation as a string of
this specific object in particular
you're seeing where in the computer's
memory it is this number ox102 733 e80
refers to essentially a specific
location in the computer's memory or Ram
that's not really that interesting for
me or you or generally speaking
programmers but it's just the default
way of describing via print what this
thing is but I can override this as well
it turns out that there are other
special methods in Python when it comes
to classes not just underscore
underscore init underscore underscore
But continuing that same pattern
underscore underscore stir underscore
underscore so this too is a special
method that if you define it inside of
your class python will just
automatically call this function for you
anytime some other function wants to see
your object as a string print wants to
see your your object as a string but by
default if you don't have this method
defined in your class it's going to
print out that very ugly esoteric
Incarnation thereof where it says
main.student object at Ox dot dot dot
well how can I then Define my own stir
function well here back in vs code let
me propose that I go in and Define not
just underscore underscore in it but let
me Define a second function in this
class here as follows def underscore
underscore stir underscore underscore
they're r d two even though the font in
vs code is putting the two underscores
so close it just looks like a longer
underscore there are indeed two there on
the left and the right just like for
init this one only takes one argument
that by convention is always called self
so that you have access to it and then
indented below that after a colon I'm
going to go ahead and create a format
string and return it so let me go ahead
and return how about something generic
first like a student so I'm not going to
bother even trying to figure out what
this Student's name or house is I'm just
going to always return a student let me
go back now to my earlier code which has
print student on line 16. Let Me Clear
My terminal window and rerun python of
student.pi enter type in Harry type in
Gryffindor last time I saw that very
cryptic output this time I see more
generically a student you know more
readable but not very enlightening which
student is this well notice that the uh
double underscore stir method takes in
this self-argument by default it's just
the way the python authors designed this
method it will always be passed a
reference to the current student object
what do I mean by that when this line of
code on line six is called print because
it's hoping it's going to get a string
is going to trigger the underscore
underscore stir underscore underscore
method to be called and python for you
automatically is going to pass into that
method a reference to the object that's
trying to be printed so that you the
programmer can do something like this
here's an F string with double quotes as
usual I'm going to use some curly braces
and say print out self.name from
self.house so there's nothing new in
what I've just done it's just an F
string and F on the beginning two double
quotes a couple of pairs of curly braces
but because automatically this stir
method gets passed self so to speak a
reference to the current object I can go
inside of that object and grab the name
I can go inside that object again and
grab the house so now when I go back to
my terminal window previously it just
printed out a student but now if I run
python of student.pi enter type in Harry
type in Gryffindor and one more time hit
enter Harry is again from Gryffindor but
if I run this yet again let's for
instance do Draco is from Slytherin
enter dracos from Slytherin now it's
customized to the specific object that
we're trying to print
questions on this function here
this Dunder stir method is there
anything else that the under underscore
underscore stir method can do
um the other question is what's the
difference between stir and wrapper a
good question so there are many other
methods that come with python classes
that start with underscore underscore
we're just scratching the surface and
we'll pretty much Focus primarily on
these but yes there are many others and
we'll see at least one other in just a
little bit there is an among the others
is indeed one called uh repper which is
a representation of the Python object
generally speaking the underscore
underscore repr underscore underscore
method is meant for developers eyes it
typically has more information than
Harry from Gryffindor it would also say
what type of object it is like a student
capital S whereas underscore underscore
stir underscore underscore is generally
meant for users uh the users of the
program and it's meant to be even more
user friendly but both of those can be
overridden as you see fit well let me
propose now that we pick up where we've
left off on student and just add even
more functionality but not just these
special methods like double underscore
in it and double underscore stir like
let's create our own methods because
therein lies the real power and
flexibility of classes if you and I as
the programmers can invent new
functionality that's specific to
students for instance uh students at
Hogwarts over the time in in school
learn how to cast a certain type of
spell so when they say expecto patronum
something comes out of their wand that
typically resembles an animal or
something like that it's a special spell
that they have to practice and practice
so let's see if we can't store not just
a student's name and their house but
also their Patronus what actually they
conjure when using this spell well let
me go ahead and clear my terminal window
and in the top of my code here in the
init method of student let me go ahead
and start expecting a third argument in
addition to self which automatically
gets passed in called Patronus and I'm
not going to worry uh for now on
validating the Patronus from an official
list of valid patronuses or patroni I'm
instead going to go ahead and just
blindly assign it to self.patronus
equals Patronus and we're going to let
the user type whatever they want for now
but I could certainly add more error
checking if I wanted to limit the
patronuses to a specific list of them
here let me go ahead now and prompt the
user for this Patronus as by in my get
student method get student function
defining a variable called Patronus or
anything else prompting the user for
input for their Patronus and now I'm
going to go ahead and pass in that third
variable here so again similar in spirit
to just adding more and more attributes
to the class I'm going to pass in all
three of these values instead of just
two I'm not going to do anything
interesting with that value yet but just
to make sure I haven't made things worse
by breaking my code let me run python of
student.pi I'll type in Harry I'll type
in Gryffindor and it turns out his
Patronus was a stag and hit enter I
haven't seen what his Patronus is in my
output because I didn't change my stir
method yet but at least I don't have any
syntax error so at least I've not made
anything worse but suppose now I want to
have functionality not just for
initializing a student and printing out
a student if my class is really meant to
be a student what I can do is not just
remember information about data about
students what's powerful about classes
unlike dictionaries alone is that
classes can have not just variables or
instance variables so to speak those
attributes we keep creating they can
also have functions built in AKA methods
when a function is inside of a class
it's called a method but it's still just
a function at this point we've seen two
functions already two methods called a
double underscore in it and double
underscore stir but those are special
methods in that they just work if you
define them python calls them
automatically for you but what if you
wanted to create more functionality for
a student so that your class really
represents this real world or maybe
fantasy world notion of a student where
students not only have names and houses
and patronuses they also have
functionality they have actions they can
perform like casting a charm a spell
magically could we Implement therefore a
function called charm that actually uses
their magical knowledge well let's go
ahead and Define our very own function
as follows Let Me Clear My terminal
window scroll back up to my student
class and instead of creating yet
another function that's special with
double underscores I'm going to invent
my own function or method inside of this
class I want to give Harry and Hermione
and all of the other students the
ability to cast charms so I'm going to
define a function that I can completely
on my own called Charmed I could call
this function anything I want but
because it's a method inside of a class
the convention is that it's always going
to take at least one argument called
self by convention so that you you have
access to the current object even if you
don't plan to use it per se all right
let me go ahead and propose that we
Implement charm in such a way that the
method returns an emoji that's
appropriate for each student's Patronus
all right how to implement this well
inside of the charm method let's go
ahead and match on
self.patronus which is the instance
variable containing a string that
represents each student's Patronus and
in the case that it matches a stag for
instance for Harry let's go ahead and
return maybe the closest Emoji this
horse here
how about in the case of an otter well
in that case let's go ahead and return
oh maybe the closest match to the otter
which might be this Emoji here and let's
see in the case of a for for Ron rather
than Hermione a Jack Russell Terrier
let's go ahead and return how about
don't have as many options here why
don't we go ahead and return the cutest
available dog in that case and in the
case of
no Patronus recognized as my cover
someone like Draco let's go ahead and
use a default case using the underscores
as in the past and let's go ahead and
return for this oh what should happen if
someone doesn't have a Patronus why
don't we just see a magical wand that
seems to fizzle out as in this case all
right well now rather than just print
the student let's go about printing
their actual Patronus so I'm going to go
down to my main function here I'm going
to still get a student using the get
student function but rather than print
student let's go ahead and declare
expecto patronum printing out just that
as pure text and now let's go ahead and
print out not the student but rather the
return value of their own charm Method
All right so let me go back down to my
terminal window and run python of
student.pi and enter name let's start
with Harry he lives in Gryffindor
Patronus is a stag and let's see expecto
patronum and of course we see the Stag
Emoji what about someone Mike Draco who
at least in the books doesn't have a
known Patronus well let's go ahead and
clear my terminal window rerun python of
student.pi and this time let's type in
Draco for name Slytherin for house and
Patronus is unknown so I'm just going to
go ahead and hit enter and now expecto
patronum and just kind of sizzles
instead questions now on what I've done
by implementing this charm method
can be like call a method outside the
function absolutely and we're seeing
that already if I scroll back down to my
main function which is outside of the
class because it's all the way down in
the file it's all left aligned just like
the class notice on line 28 I'm calling
student.charm and I'm accessing a method
that's inside of the student object even
though my main function is outside of
the class
and what's different between our init
function or method and our stir method
that we've seen before those are called
automatically when you try to create a
student or when you try to print a
student for the first time we're now
seeing a method that I invented inside
of the student class that I can call
anywhere I want and if I'm calling it
outside of the class like I am here I
just use the name of the variable
containing that student object and I
just dot charm just like I could access
the individual attributes or in instance
variables inside of that object as well
other questions on classes and this new
method charm you know parentheses you uh
you put yourself supposed to be like a
initializer but like in the top part you
didn't you didn't um Define it the same
way would you have to put the class on
why you didn't put the class right there
so notice the indentation here so on
line one I've of course said class
student colon and then everything below
that is indented at the moment that
means that my init method my stir method
and this new Char method are all inside
of part of that class
by convention then each of these methods
inside of a class should expect that
python will automatically pass in at
least one argument to every method in a
class and that argument will always be a
reference to the current object the
hairy object or the Draco object that is
currently trying to cast a charm or be
printed so whenever you create a method
inside of a class you should always have
it take at least one argument called
self and then zero or more other
arguments that are entirely up to you in
it for instance takes three more name
house Patronus stir takes zero more
charm takes zero more but the convention
is to always call that default argument
self and python just automatically gives
you access to the current object
other questions how about one more on
classes and charms so I just wanted to
ask that you have put the emojis in
double quotes So does it take the Emojis
as the form of strings or something else
yes if uh unfamiliar an emoji is just a
character it's part of a mapping of
numbers to letters known as Unicode and
so whenever you see these emoji on the
screen like the horse or the otter or
the dog here specifically that's really
just like a key from your keyboard you
and I on Max and PCs can't typically
type it because you see English
characters or some other human language
but Emoji are increasingly available uh
via menus and drop down and in my case
copy paste on Macs and PCs and Android
devices and iPhones they are just
characters even though they look like
pictures you can think of it like a
graphical font almost so they're just
text and indeed if you put them between
double quotes or single quotes you can
print Emoji just like you can any other
human character as well
well let me propose now that we remove
this Patronus code just to simplify our
world and focus on some of the other
core capabilities of classes so at the
risk of disappointing I'm going to get
rid of all of these beautiful emoji and
charms and I'm going to go ahead and
stop asking the user now for their
Patronus and I'm going to stop passing
it into in it here and I'm going to stop
uh doing this here and I'm going to
instead just go ahead and restore our
use of print student here and I'm going
to go ahead and get rid of Patronus down
here so it's essentially undo all of the
fun charms we just created so we're now
back at the point in the story where we
have a student class with only two
methods in it and stir the first of
those takes of course self as the first
argument as it always will plus two more
now name and house no more Patronus
we're validating name up here we're
validating house down here and then
we're assigning name and house
respectively to two in distance
variables called name and house also but
we used self to get access to the
current object to store those values
they're in we then still have our stir
method here which takes one argument by
default self and that's it and that
function is going to be called
automatically anytime you want to
convert a student object to a string
just like print might want to do here so
let me go ahead and just make sure I
haven't broken anything let me run
python of student.pi I'll type in Harry
I'll type in Gryffindor enter okay we're
back in business gone are the charms and
patronuses but at least I'm back to a
situation where I have names and houses
but it turns out at the moment our use
of classes is not very robust even
though we have this mechanism very
cleverly if I may in our init method of
making sure that we're validating name
and house making sure that name is not
blank and making sure that house is a
valid house among those four Hogwarts
houses
it turns out that classes will still let
me get at those attributes those
so-called instance variables using dot
notation anyway let me scroll down then
and try to do this a little
adversarially suppose that on line 16 I
go ahead and call get students which
exists as before and then I store the
return value in a student variable again
on line 16. that will ensure that get
student gets called which calls input
and input and then it calls the student
Constructor which invokes automatically
this init method so by way of how we've
laid out my code we're going to ensure
that name is not blank and house is
definitely one of those four values my
error correction or error checking is in
place
but if I'm a little adversarial I can
still circumvent it suppose that fine
I'm gonna you're gonna require me to
type in Harry and Gryffindor I'm going
to go ahead and type in student dot
house equals quote unquote number four
privet drive and you're not going to be
able to stop me why well it turns out
with classes and objects thereof you and
I can still access those instance
variables using this familiar dot
notation that's how we began the story
of classes just setting these attributes
ourselves but you can also read these
attributes themselves and change them
later if you want and this will
effectively circumvent the if condition
and the other if condition in our init
method because that is only called when
you first create the student object
there's nothing stopping me at the
moment from just changing the house or
the name after so if I now clear my
terminal window and run python of
student.pi I'll still type in Harry and
Gryffindor to meet my requirements that
the house be one of those four but when
it's printed notice I've still
overridden it so it seems that while
classes do allow us a little more
control over the data we're storing it
doesn't necessarily prevent the user be
it rather the programmer be it myself or
maybe a colleague from still kind of
messing things up so here too in the
spirit of programming a little more
defensively allow me to introduce
another feature of python as well namely
properties
so a property is really just an
attribute that has even more defense
mechanisms put into place a little more
functionality implemented by you to
prevent programmers like me and you for
messing things up like these attributes
so again a property is going to be an
attribute that you and I just have more
control over how we just write a little
more code using some python conventions
and how we're going to do that is going
to use in just a moment a feature a
keyword known as app property which is
technically a function property is a
function in Python but we're about to
see some new at syntax that allows you
to decorate functions and this too is a
term of Art in the world of python you
can have decorators which are functions
that modify the behavior of other
functions if you will and we'll leave it
at that without going too much into the
weeds and we'll see by example how you
can use these decorators specifically to
define properties so let me go back to
vs code here and let me propose that I
do this I'm going to go ahead and create
how about a property called house as
follows inside of my student class I'm
going to go ahead and below my init
method and below my stir method I'm
going to go ahead and Define a function
called house that takes as it always
must one argument at least called self
and what I'm going to do now is return
self dot house so I'm just going to
define a method called House whose sole
purpose in life is to return the value
of house but I'm going to Define one
other method curiously also call it
house but that's going to take into as
arguments two values self as always and
also a value called house and I'm going
to now do this I'm going to say sell uh
rather I'm going to do self dot house
equals house now what have I done well
let me just temporarily add some
comments here in a moment we're going to
start referring to this generally as a
getter and down here I'm going to refer
to this as a Setter and this is
terminology you frequently see in the
world of java if some of you have
programmed in Java before but as the
names imply a getter is a function for a
class that gets some attribute a Setter
is a function in some class that sets
some value and now even though we're not
done and there's a bit of a mistake in
the code I've already written
intuitively what we're going to do is
this we're trying to prevent programmers
myself included from circumventing my
error checking that I put into place for
name and house how can I do that well we
don't have that many building blocks in
programming we've had things like
variables for data and we have functions
for actions well why don't we do this
why don't we somehow require that in
order to access an attribute you go
through some function and let's require
that in order to set some attribute you
go through some function and
conventionally those functions are
called a getter function and a Setter
function and why are we using functions
or in this case methods inside of a
class well once you have functions those
are just actions or verbs that you and I
can create ourselves we can put any
error correction I want in these
functions because it's code that's going
to get executed top to bottom so how can
I now prevent the user from setting the
house to an invalid value let me borrow
some logic from before rather than
blindly do this just set self.house
equal to the house value that's passed
in let's add our error checking there so
if house is not in the following list of
Gryffindor or Hufflepuff
or Slither or
Ravenclaw or Slytherin just as before
let's go ahead and raise a value error
just to signify that uh something has
gone wrong I'll be more explicit I'll
include a message like invalid house
quote unquote otherwise I'm going to
proceed on now line 21 to set self.house
to house so I've just copied if you will
or retyped my error checking inside of
this so-called Setter function now why
have I done that well to be clear
whenever the user or the programmer
writes code like this student dot house
equals what's about to happen magically
is python will not just let the
programmer access student.house directly
that attribute that instance variable
AKA self.house it's instead going to
magically automatically call this Setter
function for me how does python know to
do that well if it sees that on the left
hand side there is self.house where
house is the name of the getter or
Setter and then it sees an equal sign
indicating assignment that's just enough
of a visual clue to say wait a minute
I'm not going to let you access that
attribute directly I'm going to use the
setter instead why because the equal
sign means I'm trying to set I'm trying
to assign a value from right to left
into that attribute so what python is
going to do automatically is call this
function for me and that's amazing
because now I can execute code an
algorithm to check do I want to let the
user the programmer set that attribute
to that value if not I'm going to raise
a value error and you're just not going
to be able to do it if so fine I'll go
ahead and set it for you but in order to
do this we need a little more syntax and
I'm going to get rid of my comment and
I'm going to use that decorator I need
to tell python to treat this method as a
getter and then the Syntax for the
setter is a little different you now say
house dot Setter I wish one was getter
and the other was Setter that's not the
way they designed it when you want to
define a getter you just say at property
above the function and you name the
function exactly like you would like the
property to be called quote unquote
house
once you do that you can now use a new
decorator that sort of automatically
created for you called at house because
I called it house and then you literally
say at house.setter and this whole line
on line 17 is a clue to python that here
comes a function whose name is identical
but notice that it takes two arguments
both self so you have access to the
contents of the object and house which
is just going to be a stir that comes
from the programmer from like the human
input return value so that you can set
that value as well
but there's one fix I need to make now
here everything else I think is still
good however watch this I no longer need
this error check here why because if I
scroll back down to my code here I
claimed a moment ago that code like this
with
uh student.house equals is going to
automatically get python to call my
Setter for me guess what even up here in
my init method calling self.house equals
is also going to call my Setter method
which is amazing because now I can keep
all of my error checking in one place in
the setter and it will now get called
either when I create the object for the
first time because of init or even if
the you the programmer tries to
circumvent that init method and change
the value of this attribute my Setter
will also get called my Setter will get
called anytime I access dot house
but there's one fix I need to make
unfortunately I have collided names
right now if we go up here on line five
this is an instance variable it's a
string inside of myself inside of the
current student object called name and
this is another instance variable
called House unfortunately if I have an
instance variable called name and house
I cannot also have functions called
house they're going to collide you got
to decide do you want the variable to be
called house or do you want the function
to be called House unfortunately you
can't have both because now Python's
going to confuse one for the other so
the conventional fix for this is to do
this to have the setter not store the
value that's passed in in self.house but
to use an almost identical name but to
use a little indicator that you means
you know you're doing this correctly you
typically by convention put an
underscore in front of the instance
variable's name and when you return it
up here you similarly put an underscore
so now technically my instance variable
is called underscore house but my
property which is a fancier attribute if
you will is called house alone
huge amount of syntax I know but it's a
very powerful feature and again this is
why you can graduate from dictionaries
alone and have so much more
functionality at your disposal let me go
ahead and clear my terminal window and
run python of student.pi enter name all
right let's go ahead and type in Harry
let's go ahead and type in Gryffindor
crossing my fingers as always and now
look invalid house this is a good thing
why because notice in my main function
I'm still trying maliciously if you will
to change Harry's house to not be one of
the four valid ones I'm trying to change
it to his childhood home of number four
privet drive but because python knows
that wait a minute you're trying to
assign that is set of value and that
value AKA house is now defined as a
property you're going to have to go
through the setter function instead to
even let you change that value and
because I have this raise value error if
the house is not as intended you're not
going to be allowed to change it to an
invalid value so I'm protecting the data
on the way in through the init method
and I'm even defending the data if you
try to override it there so I think the
only solution for me the programmer is
don't try to break my own code let me
remove that line because it's just not
going to work let me run python of
student.pi and again type in Harry type
in Gryffindor enter and Harry is indeed
from Gryffindor if I did something
incorrect like Harry from number four
privet Drive enter we're again going to
see the value error because my code just
doesn't let that value in Via manual
input now or via that adversarial change
all right that was a lot but any
question on
properties
uh while we are using Getters and
Setters it's just for the purpose so
that we can find our
um that function that method that
function in in our code the reason that
I'm going through the trouble of
defining this getter or Setter is
because I want to make sure that
programmers cannot do things like this
if I'm going through the trouble of
validating the attributes for these
student objects I don't want you to be
able to go in there and just change them
at will I want to have some control over
that object so that you can just trust
that it's going to be correct as
designed so using a getter and Setter
really just enables python to
automatically detect when you're trying
to manually set a value the equal sign
and the dot as I've highlighted here is
enough of a clue to python to realize
wait a minute you're trying to set a
value let me see if this class has a
Setter defined and if so I'm going to
call that and I'm not just going to
blindly assign the value from right to
left so it's just giving me more control
other questions on properties when we
use a Getters we just have just one
argument and if we use Setters is always
going to be two arguments it's not
normal
correct it's always going to be one
argument self for the getter two
arguments for the setter self and
something else and the intuition for
that is if you're getting a value you
don't need to pass anything else in
because you already know the object it's
called student in this case so you're
just going to get the value of that
property but if you want to set the
property to something else you got to
pass in that argument you've got to pass
in the value to which you want to set it
so it's always zero or one however you
see it as one or two because again any
function inside of a class AKA a method
is going to be automatically passed self
so that you have access to that current
object in memory how about one other
question on properties why didn't we use
the same underscore house in init method
a good question so even though I'm using
the underscore house here in my Setter
and the underscore house here in my
getter I deliberately did not use it up
here the reason for that is that by
using self.house and this equal sign
that's the same pattern that I want
python to recognize I want python to
automatically call the setter even when
I'm passing in the house via the init
method if I were to change this to do
this that would circumvent the setter
and now there's no error checking in in
it whatsoever so it's such a fine line
the only thing standing between us and
error checking or no error checking is
the presence or absence of this
underscore but that's typically the
convention by not using the underscore
there make sure that even that
assignment goes through the setter so
that honestly I don't have to copy paste
the same error checking in two places I
can put it just in this Setter so it's
better design and that's why I manually
retyped it at first but then I deleted
it from init well allow me to propose
that we make one other change to this
file might as well go ahead and Define a
property for name as well and let me go
ahead and do this maybe above the house
property just to keep things in the same
order as I defined them earlier let me
give myself another property this one's
going to be called name it's going to
take one argument called self as always
and this one very similarly is just
going to return self dot underscore name
so I'm going to anticipate that I'm
going to have to rename name also so
that I don't have that same Collision as
before but now let me go ahead and
Define another setter this one for name
so the convention is at name dot Setter
y name because the property I just
created is called name so the getter and
Setter sort of work in conjunction in
that in this way if you will let me go
down under at name Setter and Define
another function also called name but
the key thing here is that it's not not
identical it's not the exact same
function name and the exact same number
of arguments the setter again takes a
second argument and I can call it
anything I want but I'm going to call it
name because that's what's being passed
in and I'm going to air put my error
checking here if not name just like we
used to do let's go ahead and raise a
value error and let's put an explanatory
message like uh Missing name quote
unquote otherwise let's go ahead and
update self dot underscore name to equal
name and I don't have to change in it
except to get rid of this duplicate
error checking now because again if I
use self.name equals here and self.house
equals here with no underscore both of
those assignments are going to go
through my two Setter functions now
before we run this let me go ahead and
remove this adversarial code which we
know won't work because we're catching
it let me go back down to my terminal
window and run python of student.pi
enter let's type in Harry let's type in
Gryffindor and that seems to work let's
try though again to run python of
student.pi with Harry from number four
privet drive this will not work a value
error with invalid house because that's
not one of the four Hogwarts houses and
now for good measure let's run it one
more time and let's not even give it a
name let's just hit enter when prompted
I can type anything for the house I'll
go ahead and still give it Gryffindor
enter now we get another value error but
this one is for missing name
so we seem now to have all the more of a
defense mechanism in place to ensure
that name is as we expect it's got to
have some value that's not blank and
houses as we expect it's got to have one
of those four values
but at the risk of bursting everyone's
bubble and making you wonder why did we
just go through all of that
unfortunately python really focuses on
conventions not hard constraints and by
that I mean this if I go back into my
main function after I've gotten a
student on line 30 and I try to
adversarially do something like this
student.house equals quote unquote
number four privet drive we know this
won't work because my Setter for house
is going to catch this watch again
python of student.pi uh let's type in
Harry let's type in Gryffindor which
will at least pass our check that's
induced by init but line 31 is going to
trigger the same Setter to be called and
we're going to raise a value error
saying invalid house
unfortunately and if some of you are
already thinking a little adversarily
tragically look what you can do you can
change dot house to be dot underscore
house why will the instance variable is
now called underscore house the property
is called house no underscore but the
underlying attribute implemented as an
instance variable is still called
underscore house and tragically python
of student.pi let's type in Harry let's
type in Gryffindor which is correct but
Watch What Happens now oh my God we
slipped through
so what was the point of all of this
emphasis from me on doing things the
right way the pythonic way by having
this getter and Setter well unlike
languages like Java that just prevent
you from doing things like this python
itself allows you to specify that
certain instance variables can be public
and accessible to anyone's code or
protected or private which means that no
one else should be able to change these
values in the world of python it's just
the honor System it's not baked into the
language itself that there's a notion of
visibility public or private or even
somewhere in between protected instead
you're on the honor System and the
convention generally is if a instance
variable starts with an underscore
please don't touch it like just don't
like that's on you if you touch that
variable and break things the underscore
is meant to signify a convention that
this is meant to be private but it
really just means please don't touch
this sometimes if there's two
underscores which you can use too that's
an even greater effort by programmers to
say really don't touch this but but
technically speaking there's nothing
stopping you or me from circumventing
all of these mechanisms these properties
these Getters and Setters were
ultimately just on the honor System not
to do so when we see instance variables
prefixed with one or perhaps even two
underscores all right so this is a lot
all at once this introduction to object
oriented programming but it might come
as quite a surprise that even though we
might have identified oop by name in
weeks past we've all been using classes
and objects for weeks now in this class
in fact if you think back on one of the
very first things we did in this class
we used integers and just got integers
from the user but if you haven't already
if you go and dig into the documentation
for integers which again lives at this
URL here you would actually find that
int itself is and has been for weeks a
class and in fact this is the signature
of the Constructor call for an INT
whereby you pass in X like a number
quote unquote 50 or quote unquote
something else you pass in optionally
the base 10 for decimal 2 for binary or
anything else and that int function will
actually return to you all this time an
object of type int that is to say int is
a class it is a template a blueprint for
creating integers in memory and anytime
you and I have converted a string for
instance to an INT you and I have been
creating an object of type int that was
calling apparently the underscore
underscore in it underscore underscore
method that someone else the authors of
python wrote to give us back that proper
integer besides that if you can believe
it stirs strings in Python have been
classes since the first week of this
class as well if you look up the
documentation for a stir which lives at
a similar URL there you will find that
when you instantiate that is create a
stirrer it takes optionally a parameter
called object here the default value of
which is just quote unquote which allows
you to create an effect an empty string
a blank string if you will but any time
you and I have created stirs or even
used explicitly this stir function you
are getting back an object of type stir
anytime you and I have forced a string
to lowercase per the documentation using
syntax like this you and I have been
taking an object of type stir and
forcing it all to lower case by calling
a method called Lower a method that the
authors of pyekathon built into the stir
class but it's been there from the
get-go so this notion of methods is not
even new today you and I've been doing
it for this long if you've ever called
strip to remove the leading in the
trailing white space from a string in
Python you are calling another method
that came with python written by the
authors of python and even though we
didn't call it a class at the time a
stir all this time has been a class and
instances of strings are themselves
objects and those objects come therefore
with these functions built in AKA
methods that allow us to do things like
force to lower case and strip white
space from the beginning and end let's
do another list anytime you've created a
list either either syntactically with
square brackets or literally with list
open parenthesis close parenthesis which
is also possible you have been using a
class if you go to the documentation for
list at this similar URL here or more
specifically the tutorial on lists here
in Python you will see that a list is
and has been since the early weeks of
this class A Class itself and that clist
class takes as part of its uh
initialization and optional iterable
something that can be iterated over like
one comma two comma three or some list
of values and you can then get back a
list containing those same iterable
values if you've ever appended something
to a list in this class as I have myself
in the past you've been using a method
call depend that comes with the list
class that per the X here takes an
argument that allows you to append
something to the current list AKA self
in the context of that method we can do
this all day long if you've used a
dictionary or a dict in Python I've
actually all this time been calling them
objects and that's for a reason
dict itself is a class in Python if you
pull up its official documentation here
and you'll see that it is defined indeed
as itself a class and that class comes
with methods as well and so anytime
we've manipulated dictionaries we've
been in underneath the hood using all of
those same methods and in fact we can
see this if we're really curious let me
go back over here to vs code and let me
go ahead and create a new file that very
simply does something like play around
with data types and let me go ahead and
create a new file for instance called
say type dot Pi just so that I can poke
around inside of some values and type
dot Pi I'm just going to go ahead and do
this I'm going to print out whatever the
type is of say the number 50. and this
is a function you've not necessarily
seen me use already and it's not one you
would frequently use in your own code
there are other ways to detect if you
need to what the type is of a variable
but in this case type of 50 is just
going to tell me and then print out what
the data type is of that value now
hopefully all of us could guess that 50
is indeed going to be an integer that is
an INT but we can see it in this way and
this too is what's powerful about
knowing a bit of programming if you want
to know the answer to a question just
try it out like I am here so let me go
ahead and run python of type.pi enter
and there it is when you print out the
type of the number 50 you'll see on the
screen in this cryptic syntax class
quote unquote int this is not something
that you probably want to show to the
user but if you yourself just want to
poke around and see what's going on or
maybe use that information somehow it's
certainly at your disposal to use with
this type function for that let's change
it around a little bit instead of
passing is the argument to type 50 as an
INT let's type something also familiar
like hello comma World in double or
single quotes let me go back to my
terminal window clear the screen and run
python of type.pi again and now voila
there it is all this time a stir is also
a class we can do this a few more times
for instance let's go ahead and change
hello world to just an empty list open
square bracket close square bracket and
this is starting to look a little
cryptic but again notice what I'm doing
in square brackets is an empty list
we've done that before that is the sole
argument to this new type function and
that's just being passed to the print
function so that the return value of
type is the argument to print so if I
now run this code python of type.pi
there it is a list is a class 2. you
might recall that I said that you can
also create an empty list by literally
doing list open parenthesis close
parenthesis this is a bit of an
inconsistency as we can now identify
that int and stir and Now list they're
technically all lower case and I went to
Great Lengths of creating my student
class to have that capital S and that's
a convention because int and stir and
list and others come with python they
decided to make their built-in data
types even though their classes all
lowercase but the convention the
recommendation in the python Community
when creating your classes is D2
capitalize the first letter as I did in
something like student capital S but
list open parenthesis close parenthesis
is identical to really just two empty
square brackets if I clear my screen and
run type.pi again you see the exact same
thing the class is called list let's do
one more let me change the list to B
naught square brackets but curly braces
we've done this before anytime I've done
two curly braces with nothing in between
this of course is an empty dictionary or
a dict object in Python well we can see
that now let me clear my screen run
python of type.pi enter and there it is
class dict it's been there this whole
time we just didn't call it a class
until today I can similarly do this one
explicitly instead of two curly braces
let's write out with two
parentheses now we have a lot of
parentheses again like with list but
this is just making even more clear that
the type of addict object is indeed the
class dict itself
so this is to say that is new as a lot
of today's idea and syntax might be
you've actually been using it perhaps
unbeknownst to you for weeks now we now
just have terminology to describe what
it is we've been doing all this time and
you now have the expressiveness with
some practice to create your own classes
inside of which are your own instance
variables perhaps wrapped with those
properties and your own instance methods
but it turns out there's other types of
methods in the world thus far I've been
deliberate in calling all of our
variables instance variables and all of
our methods instance methods it turns
out there's other types of variables and
methods out there and one of those is
called class methods it turns out that
sometimes it's not really necessary or
sensible to associate a function with
objects of a class but rather with the
class itself
an instance or an object of a class is a
very specific Incarnation thereof again
on that neighborhood that has a lot of
identical looking buildings but they're
all a little bit different because of
different paints and such sometimes you
might have functionality related to each
of those houses that isn't distinct or
unique for any of the houses it's
functionality that's going to be exactly
the same no matter the house in question
same in the world of object-oriented
programming sometimes you want some
functionality some action to be
associated with the class itself no
matter what the specific objects own
values or instance variables are and for
that we have a keyword called at class
method this is another decorator really
another function that you can use to
specify that this method is not by
default implicitly an instance method
that has access to self the object
itself this is a class method that's not
going to have access to self but it does
know what class it's inside so what do I
mean mean by this well let me go back to
vs code here and let me propose that we
create a new file this time implementing
the notion of a the Sorting Hat from the
World of Harry Potter as well to stay on
theme I'm going to go ahead and run code
of hat.pi and in hat.pi let's implement
the notion of this Sorting Hat if
unfamiliar in the books and in the films
there is literally a pointy hat that
when a student put it on their head that
Sorting Hat so to speak decides what
house the student is in whether it's
Gryffindor or something else so let's
Implement encode this notion of a
Sorting Hat such that when we pass to
the Sorting Hat the name of a student
like quote unquote Harry this Sorting
Hat implemented in code will tell us
what house that student should be in all
right well let's go ahead and do this in
hat.pi first let's go ahead and define a
class called hat and then let's get back
to implementing it itself and I find
this to be a helpful technique not just
with teaching but when writing code like
I know I want a hack class I don't
necessarily know what I want it to do
yet so I'm going to create this sort of
placeholder dot dot dot so I'll come
back to that let's now try to use this
class as though it existed and from
there I perhaps can realize exactly what
functionality that class needs to have
to support my use case let me go ahead
and create a variable called hat in all
lower case and instantiate a hat object
so no matter what the Hat class ends up
looking like this is the common syntax
for instantiating an object of a certain
class in the past we saw student all
lower case equals Capital student open
parenthesis close parenthesis and then
eventually we added in things like name
and house for now let's assume that the
hat is much simpler than a student and
it only has sorting capabilities so I'm
not going to even pass any arguments
there too indeed let me assume that the
Sorting Hat has one Function One method
inside of it called sort and so if I do
hat dot sort quote unquote Harry let's
propose that that prints out what house
that student should be in so that's it
I'm going to encapsulate that is tuck
away inside of a hat class all of this
requisite functionality and I'm going to
print out onto the screen what hat uh
what house Harry belongs in all right
now I think I need to get into the weeds
of actually initializing this class well
let me go ahead and do this if I don't
care to parameterize hat I just want to
for instance sort values let's go ahead
and Define this function sort first so
let's define sort as taking a first
argument self which is always going to
be the case when defining an instance
method as before but the source method
clearly takes one argument from the
programmer me namely the student's name
and again we've seen this dichotomy
before even though I'm trying to pass in
one argument when I Define the method
it's got to take that many arguments
plus one more self which is always going
to be automatically passed in by python
first all right what do I want to do
well let's go ahead and do something
like this print quote unquote or rather
print this name how about quote unquote
is in quote unquote some house I'm going
to again use some placeholder code for
myself because I'm not quite sure how to
finish implementing this Sorting Hat but
I think that's enough to just test where
my code is at now let me go ahead and
run python of hat.pi and hit enter and
it looks like indeed Harry is in some
house we're not done yet because it's
clearly not doing anything interesting
but it at least is running correctly
with no errors
well let's go ahead now and decide where
uh what house Harry should actually be
in by introducing a bit of Randomness
and choosing a house randomly well I can
do this in a few ways let me go ahead
and do this I need to have a list of
houses somewhere so where can I put that
I could solve this problem in different
ways let me propose that I do this let
me Define a method called init as I've
done before that takes in self but no
other arguments and whenever the Sorting
Hat is instantiated let's do this let's
create a houses instance variable plural
that equals this list Gryffindor comma
Hufflepuff comma Ravenclaw comma
Slytherin so the exact same list that
we've used before and I'm storing it in
an instance variable inside of this
class I'm not taking any arguments
Beyond self to in it but I just need
this list of values somewhere for
instance so what can I do here well let
me go ahead and replace some house with
the actual house well what could I do
here well I want to put a house there
well let's go ahead and create a
variable called house and if you think
back to our discussion of libraries in
the random module there is a function
called choice that if you pass in a list
of choices like self.houses that will
pick a random house out of those four
and then on line seven I can pass it in
if I want to tighten this up let me just
go ahead and highlight that code get rid
of the variable it's technically
unnecessary and because the line of code
is still pretty short I'm okay with just
putting it all in one line but I could
certainly use the variable like I did a
moment ago so what have I done in my
init function I have defined a
initialization of the object that stores
in self.houses the list of four houses
and then in sort I'm accessing that same
list but I'm randomly choosing the set
of houses there now why have I done it
in this way this too is General
convention anytime you have a list of
things that who knows maybe will change
over time places like Harvard have
constructed new houses over the years so
you might have to change the list of
available houses it didn't happen in
seven books or eight films of Harry
Potter but you could imagine maybe
Hogwarts eventually has a fifth house so
there's generally some value in putting
list of constants toward the top of your
file toward the top of the class so it's
just obvious what the list of values is
you don't want to necessarily tuck it
away in some function like sort
especially if you might want to use that
function in sorry especially if you want
to use that list in multiple functions
not just sort but if I kept adding to
this class you might want to use that
same list of houses in multiple
functions so let's keep it in the object
Itself by storing it in self.houses all
right well we're about to change the
course of history here perhaps let me do
python of hat.pi and I think we're about
to assign Harry to one of those four
houses randomly
huh name error name random is not
defined well wait a minute where did I
go wrong here
thinking back to our class on libraries
why did my code break and not tell me
where Harry is to be you do not import
the random Library exactly if the random
library or module is something I want to
use I need to tell python that at the
top of my file so let me go up here and
do import random and then below that let
me go ahead and clear my terminal window
and try again python of hat.pi crossing
my fingers seeing where Harry is going
to end up and okay Harry as of now is
officially in Hufflepuff despite
everything you've read or seen well
let's run this again let me clear my
window and run python of hat.pi and now
he's in Ravenclaw that's consistent with
using random let's clear that and run it
again he's still in Ravenclaw but that
could happen even though there's four
choices let's do it again Hufflepuff
back in Hufflepuff we can't seem to get
the right answer so to speak now he's in
Gryffindor albeit randomly so we seem to
have a program that based on these
limited tests seems to indeed be
assigning Harry to a house randomly now
I'm somewhat lazily just letting sort
print out this value I could do
something else like return a string and
then let me on line 13 do the printing
for me but for now I think we have an
example of a class called hat that
nonetheless applies some of our lessons
learned thus far today where I've
created a class because a Sorting Hat is
frankly well I was about to say real
world entity but really a fantasy world
entity and indeed that's a perhaps
common heuristic or mental model to have
when should you use a class to represent
something in your code very often when
you're trying to represent some real
world entity or fantasy world entity
like a student which is something in the
real world like a Sorting Hat which okay
doesn't exist but hats certainly do so
quite reasonable to have a class for hat
and that's not always the case that
classes represent real world entities
but indeed we've seen thus far that int
and stir and list and dict these are all
structures that you might have in the
real world we have integers and strings
of text and other things so it rather
makes sense to represent even those
things more technically using a class as
well you could use just a dictionary to
represent a student or a hat but again
with classes come all this and even more
functionality
but I honestly am not using classes in
really the the right way here why well
in the World of Harry Potter there
really is only to my knowledge one
Sorting Hat and yet here I have gone and
implemented a class called hat and again
a class is like a blueprint a template a
mold that allows you to create one or
more objects thereof now most of my
programs thus far have been pretty
simple and I've just created one student
but certainly if I spent more time and
wrote more code you could imagine
writing one program that has a list of
students many more students than just
the one we keep demonstrating yet it
would be a little weird it's a little
inconsistent with the real or the
Fantasy World of Harry Potter to
instantiate one two three or more
sorting hats there really is just one
really one Singleton if you will which
is a term of Art in a lot of context of
programming so let me propose that we
actually improve the design of the
Sorting Hat so that we don't have to
instantiate a sorting hat because right
now this is kind of allowing me to do
something like hat one equals hat hat
two equals hat hat three equals and so
forth I don't really need that
capability I really just need to
represent the Sorting Hat with a class
but I don't really need to instantiate
it why because it already exists I need
just one so it turns out in Python that
up until now we've been using as I keep
calling them instance methods writing
functions inside of classes that are
automatically passed a reference to self
the current object but sometimes you
just don't need that sometimes it
suffices you just know what the class is
and assume that there might not even be
any objects of that class so in this
sense you can use a class really as a
container for data and or functionality
that is just somehow conceptually
related things related to a Sorting Hat
and there's this other decorator or
function called class method that allows
us to do just this so let me go back to
my code here and let me propose that if
I'm not going to instantiate multiple
houses I don't really need this init
method because that's really meant to
initialize specific objects from that
blueprint that template that mold so let
me get rid of this but if I get rid of
this I no longer have access to self but
that's okay because it turns out in
addition to their existing class methods
there are also what we might call class
variables and class variables exist
within the class itself and there's just
one copy of that variable for all of the
objects thereof they all share if you
will the same variable be it an INT or
stir or in this case a list so what I've
done here is Define inside of my hat
class in a class variable called houses
I don't say self because self is no
longer relevant self refers to specific
objects I want a variable inside of this
class AKA a class variable that equals
that list because because it's inside of
this hat now class I can use that list
in any of my functions I've only got one
now called sort but if I had more it
would be accessible to all of those
methods as well and with sort it also
doesn't really make sense to sort within
a specific sorting hack because again
there's I only want there to be one so I
can actually specify that this is a
class method by saying at class method
and I don't pass in self anymore I
actually by convention pass in the a
reference to the class itself it's
typically written as clsy well if you
wrote
c-l-a-s-s that would actually conflict
with the keyword class that we keep
using up here so the world realized that
oops we can't reuse that same phrase
here so let's just call this class this
is useful in some contexts including
this one why well notice what I can now
do I can now change self to be just
class why because houses now not an
instance variable accessible via
self-dot houses it is now a class
variable accessible by a class dot
houses or technically
cls.houses in this case but now the
final flourish is this now I don't have
to instantiate any hat objects as I used
to on here line 13. I can just use
functionality that comes with this class
so I'm going to delete that line
altogether I'm going to capitalize the
Hat on this new line 13 and just say hat
dot sort quote unquote Harry
so what have I done I've not bothered
instantiating an object of type hat I am
just accessing a class method inside of
the Hat class that you know what is just
gonna work this is how class methods
work you use the name of the class
capital letter and all dot method name
passing in any arguments you want python
is going to automatically pass in some
variable via which you can refer to that
class in that function that you've
implemented inside of that class so that
I can do something like this it's not
that I want a variable called houses
locally in this function I want the
variable called houses that's associated
with this current class
so I can still access this same list
that I defined on line six and now if I
go back down here to my terminal and run
python of hat.pi enter
Harry is still in Hufflepuff once more
Harry is back in Gryffindor at least
randomly
questions now on these class variables
or these class methods which are in
contrast with instance variables and
instance methods and the one thing at
least that's a little strange here is
that even though there's a decorator
called at class method there is not one
called at instance method a method is
just automatically a so-called instant
method when you define it without any
decorator can you have a class he said
another class
you can you can Define one class inside
of another generally speaking this isn't
done but there are cases where it can be
helpful especially for larger more
sophisticated programs so yes it is
possible good other questions the
question was about the cell dot houses
when you when we remove it we uh and we
pass the data the variable is created
itself why we remove the salt
so in the previous examples both of the
Hat demonstration and also all of the
student demonstrations we were uh
creating a student object by calling
student capital S open parenthesis close
parenthesis with eventually name and a
house passed in and then we were using
the done uh the Double underscore init
method to initialize the self.name and
the self.house instance variables
therein to those respective values in
this latest version of the Sorting Hat I
haven't bothered with self anywhere only
because conceptually I don't need or
want there to be multiple hats in the
world I'm just using the class as kind
of a container to bundle up this list of
houses this sorting functionality maybe
eventually I'll add more functionality
to it but that's it and so sometimes you
can use object-oriented programming in
this somewhat different way when you
want there to be functionality but it's
not specific to any one specific hat
it's specific to the Sorting Hat itself
how about one other question now on
these class variables or methods just
another way of using object-oriented
programming but to solve somewhat
different problem well what's the
difference between the class hat and I
don't know like a function of head a
good question so why are we using a
class at all and not just having a file
called hat.pi with a variable called
houses and a function called sort like
why are we adding this complexity in
this particular case we don't
necessarily need to I could absolutely
go in here I could get rid of the class
I could undo this indentation I could
get rid of this decorator and I could
get rid of hat Dot and I could just do
this and additionally let's see let's
get rid of class here let's get rid of
class Here and Now run python of hat.pi
enter and it still works put Harry in
the wrong house but that's what we have
what happens randomly that's fine too
what we're introducing today by way of
object oriented programming is just a
different way of modeling the world it's
not really compelling with an example
like this frankly that's relatively
simple it's not very complex there's not
much functionality honestly the version
that we just typed up these 10 lines
this is fine this solves this problem
but as our code gets longer as we start
collaborating with other people as the
problems we're trying to solve with
could get more sophisticated you're
going to find that your code gets messy
quickly and you're going to find that
you have a huge number of functions for
instance in one file and some of them
are related to each other but some of
them are not well at that point wouldn't
it be nice to just organize them a
little differently and in the World of
Harry Potter let's have a class for
student let's have a class for Professor
let's have a class for the Sorting Hat
let's have a class for something else
and so once your world gets much more
complicated than some of the
demonstrations we do here in class when
we want to focus on individual ideas
object oriented programming is just a
way of encapsulating related data that
is variables related functionality that
is methods inside of things that have
names these things are called classes so
it's just another way to solve problems
and when we focused on libraries a
couple of weeks back that too was
another solution to the same problem you
could Define your own modules or
packages put some of your data and or
functionality in there and that's fine
too and sometimes which one you should
use overlaps if you're familiar with
Venn diagrams the overlapping region
might mean that you could use a class
you could use a module or a package you
could just use a single local file over
time you'll develop an instinct and
maybe even a personal preference for
which tool to use
all right let me propose now that we
apply this same idea of a class method
to clean up one other thing as well let
me close hat.pi and reopen student.pi as
we left it earlier and let me go ahead
and simplify it just a little bit I'm
going to go ahead and get rid of the
properties on up because there's
anything wrong with them but just
because I want us to focus on some of
the key ideas when we began with this
program so I'm going to go ahead and
keep main as well I'm not going to
adversarially try to change Harry's
address there I'm going to instead go
ahead though and just print the student
but this is the thing I want to focus on
here
this in our previous student examples
was kind of a missed opportunity to
clean up my code well what do I mean by
that well up here at the top of this
file even though I've simplified it by
getting rid of the properties and all of
that error checking because I want to
focus on the essence of this class now
just the student's name and the house
and the printing thereof this is by
nature of classes and object oriented
programming theoretically all of my
student specific functionality that is
to say if I have functionality and data
related to a student you the programmer
my colleague would assume that it's all
bundled up encapsulated so to speak
inside of the student class and yet if
you scroll down further what is this
like there's a function called get
student that just exists elsewhere in
this file that prompts the user for a
name prompts the user for a house
creates the student object and then
returns it like that's not wrong like it
works and we saw many many times it kept
working but this is a little weird right
because why well if this is a function
that helps you get a student helps you
get the name of a student and the house
of a student why isn't that
functionality in the class itself after
all as my code gets more and more
complicated and does more things I'm
going to be looking at the student class
for all student related functionality
I'm not going to be scrolling down
expecting that oh maybe there's some
other student functionality just kind of
randomly later in this file so it's not
wrong but this is again evidence of
maybe bad design not so much with this
small program but this is an example
again of code smell like something
smells a little off here like this is
probably going to get us in trouble by
separating related functionality so
again it's a design principle not a
correctness concern but class methods
allow us to address this too let me go
ahead and do this I'm going to delete
get student altogether leaving only main
as my other function here and inside of
my student class I'm going to do this
I'm going to define a function even more
simply called get and by nature of how
class methods work it's going to take in
the name of the class itself or a
reference there too as an argument and
I'm going to move the functionality from
get student into the student class and
I'm going to do this name equals input
quote unquote name house equals input
quote unquote house and then what this
function is going to do is return a new
student object by calling class which
again is just an automatically passed in
reference to the class itself passing in
name and house and I will admit this
syntax seems a little strange that now
I'm calling CLS and I'm passing in these
arguments but let me do one final fix
here let me go to the top of this
function and more explicitly say this is
a class method this solves a potential
chicken in the egg problem so to speak
whereby one needs to come before the
other potentially so what am I doing
here inside of my student class I now
have a function called get it is I shall
claim a class method what does that mean
it just means I can call this method
without instantiating a student object
first therein lies the potential Chicken
and the Egg problem and if unfamiliar
that's an expression meaning well did
the world have chickens first that laid
eggs or was there an egg that then
yielded the chickens but how did the egg
get there it's this sort of weird
circular problem and that's what we're
facing here it would be weird if you had
to create a student object in order to
call get in order to get another student
object like that sounds messy let's just
get a student via a class method that by
definition does not require you to
create a student object first just like
the Hat in its final form we use the Hat
class to just say hat Capital H dot sort
we didn't need to create a hat first we
just used the class itself
so what am I going to do here now let me
go down to Main and instead of saying
get student notice what I can now do
student dot get and everything else can
stay the same all I've done now is I've
migrated all of my logic from get
student which was this own Standalone
function but clearly related to students
by name I've moved the same code really
to inside of the student class in a more
simply named function called get but I
could still call it get student if I
want it just sees a little redundant to
call it get student in a student class
so I'm simplifying so I have a method
called get but I'm calling it a class
method to avoid that chicken in the egg
problem I want to be able to call get
without having a student object in my
universe already and the Syntax for that
is at class method the convention is to
give this method at least one argument
by convention called CLS for class which
is just going to be a reference to the
class itself mines 11 and 12 are
identical to what they've always been
and get student the only new syntax here
is this but this again is one of the
features of object oriented programming
you can now instantiate
a student object by just using CLS
that's passed in I technically could use
student capital S but it turns out I'm
doing what's more conventional because
this will both solve and avoid problems
down the line with more complicated code
this line here on line 13 just means
create an object of the current class
what class is that well whatever CLS is
well that by definition of how it all
works is going to be student and I want
you to initialize it as always with name
and house so now scrolling down my code
is this and this is just nice to read
you did perhaps have to acquire a taste
for this and I sound a little odd saying
this is nice to read but indeed
student.get just tells me what's going
on I'm gonna get a student I don't need
a separate function written by me called
get student in the file itself the get
functionality is built into the class
all my student related code now is
together so let me go down to my
terminal window and run python of
student.pi enter let's type in Harry
let's type in Gryffindor and we're back
to where we began but but but
everything related to students now is in
this here class the only other thing in
the file is Main and this conditional
that we always use to avoid accidentally
executing main when we're making a
module or a package or the like so again
a solution to a problem not a big one in
the case of a relatively small program
but one that you will eventually
encounter as your programs get longer
and longer with more and more entities
to represent
questions now on this use of a class
method does the does the class have to
be defined before the main function in
terms of the order of the of the program
a really good question so when in doubt
let's try this so let's try to change
the order let's move main to the top
which I've often encouraged so let's go
ahead and above the class do this and
notice now that technically line two is
mentioning student which does not exist
until line six and Below let me go ahead
and clear my terminal run python of
student.pi so far so good Harry
Gryffindor okay uh and indeed Harry's
from Gryffindor the reason Michael it
does not matter in this case is because
we're not actually calling main until
the very end and just as in the past
that means that python has a chance to
read everything top to bottom left to
right so everything exists I would say
generally classes are defined at the top
of the file however it would be even
maybe cleaner to move the classes
definition to its own file and then
import it so essentially to make
reusable code by putting it into your
own module or package so that not just
this program but many others can use
that definition of student as well other
questions now
on classes class methods or the like I
wanted to ask is there a way to like
declare all the all the possible all the
possible attributes of the class because
it looks so inconsistent
um well so my takeaway there is this is
Python's approach to these principles
different languages like Java just take
a different approach but have very
similar features the syntax just tends
to vary and this is how the python
Community chose to implement this idea
the right mental model ultimately is
that these instance variables instant
methods belong to or operate on specific
objects a specific student a specific
hat class variables and class methods
operate on the entire class itself or in
turn all objects of that class which
we've not seen in a demonstration of but
it's sort of a higher level concept so
it turns out besides these class methods
which are distinct from those instance
methods which to be fair do not have
their own decorator they just are by
default instance method there's yet
other types of methods you can have in
classes in Python they tend to be called
Static methods and they too come with
another decorator called at static
method which is a rabbit hole we won't
go down but realize that there is yet
other functionality that you can
leverage with an object-oriented
programming but what we thought we'd do
is focus really on some final core
features that you see not just in Python
but other languages as well and perhaps
one of the most compelling features of
object-oriented programming that we
haven't yet used explicitly though it
turns out we've seen implicitly over the
past weeks is this notion of inheritance
it turns out via object-oriented
programming there's actually an
opportunity to design your classes in a
hierarchical fashion whereby you can
have one class inherit from or borrow
attributes that is methods or variables
from another class if they all have
those in common so what do I mean by
this here what let me propose that we
Implement over in vs code here a brand
new file called wizard.pi let me go
ahead and run code of wizard.pi
and then let's start as before defining
a class called student and let's go
ahead and first Define the underscore
underscore init method which of course
is minimally going to take an argument
traditionally called self and in this
case let's also have it take as before a
name and a house and then in this init
method let's go ahead and assign the
instance variables self.name equals name
and self.house equals house let's assume
that there's some other functionality in
this class as well dot dot dot but let's
move on now to implementing the notion
of a professor in The Wizarding World as
well so for this class let's call it
professor
and a professor let's say is also going
to have its own initialization method so
underscore underscore in it it's going
to take self as always as the first
argument a professor also has a name so
we'll pass that in second two and even
though some professors are heads of
houses let's assume that a professor is
really identified by their name and
their subject area the class that they
teach so we'll call this third argument
subject now as before let's go ahead and
assign self.name equals name and let's
assign self.subject equals subject here
and as before let's assume that there's
some more functionality associated with
professors as well well what do you
notice already here in my definitions of
students and professors
typically we're a bit reluctant to allow
for any redundancy in our code and here
I feel like my init method is taking a
name for students my init method is also
taking a name for a professor and I have
these identical lines of code like
self.name equals name and this is only
going to get exacerbated if I now go and
add some error checking so for instance
How about if uh if not name we should
probably be in the habit of raising
something like a value error in an
explanatory message like missing name
and you know what if a professor is
missing their name I should probably
copy paste that code down here and
that's where the red flag should be
going off whereby as soon as you start
copy pasting code there's probably a
better way so that we can write the code
once and perhaps reuse it in some way
and here too object oriented programming
offers a solution it turns out that
object-oriented programming in Python
also supports inheritance whereby you
can Define multiple classes that somehow
relate to one another they don't need to
exist sort of in parallel in this way
there could actually be some hierarchy
between them so for instance in The
Wizarding World we could argue that both
a student and a professor are at the end
of the day Wizards so maybe what we
should really Define is a third class
for instance called wizard that has any
of the common attributes for students
and professors alike and for now we've
kept it relatively simple the only thing
they have in common is a name and a name
in student and Professor respectively so
why don't we minimally factor that out
first all right so let me go ahead here
and just to keep things organized at the
top of my file let's define a third
class called Wizard and a wizard will
have its own initialization method So
Def underscore underscore init
underscore underscore and self as always
and a wizard let's say for now is only
going to be initialized with their name
in this way and now I'm going to go
ahead and do some of that error checking
so if not name we'll raise a value error
in the Wizard class otherwise we'll go
ahead and do self.name equals name and
heck Dot got maybe some other
functionality as well but not a subject
which is specific to professors and not
a house which I've claimed is specific
to students now I think we can begin to
maybe remove some of the redundancies in
our other classes here so for instance
down with student why don't I go ahead
and remove this error checking here and
remove this error this assignment of
self.name equals name because I'm
already doing that in Wizard and
similarly down here at Professor why
don't I do the same let's get rid of the
error checking let's get rid of
self.name equals name because again I'm
doing that already up there for Wizard
as well but at the moment even though
they're all in the same file I haven't
told python that a student is a wizard
and a professor is a wizard so I really
need to link these two together and the
way you can prescribe inheritance
whereby one class should inherit from
another or conversely one class should
descend for another from another we can
do this I can say class student but
before the colon I can go in and say in
parentheses a student inherits from or
is a subclass of wizard which conversely
is the superclass of the student class
so this just means that when I Define a
student class go ahead and inherit all
of the characteristics of a wizard as
well and I'm going to do the same thing
for her for a professor so parenthesis
wizard after the class name professor
and that's going to give me access to
some of that same functionality but
because my student class and my
professor class still have their same
init methods those are the methods that
are going to get called whenever I
create a student in code or I create a
professor in code I need to somehow
explicitly say that I also want to use
the functionality in the Wizard classes
init method and the way to do this in
Python is is as follows let me go into
my init method for student and let me
call Super with no arguments which is a
reference to the super class of this
class so if this class is student the
super class that is the parent class is
is Wizard so super open paren close
paren will have the effect of accessing
the super class and then I'm going to go
ahead and explicitly call its init
method and I'm going to pass to the
Wizards init method the name that the
students init method was passed and I'm
going to go ahead and do the same down
here in Wizard this is one line of copy
paste but I think I'm okay with it here
because it's still allowing me to do all
of the name assignment and the error
checking up in the Wizard class instead
I think we're okay now by just calling
super dot init for both student and
Professor alike now admittedly this
syntax is definitely out there the fact
that we're calling super in parentheses
and dots and underscore underscore on
the left and the right of in it here but
it's just a combination of these two
ideas super open parenthesis close
parenthesis is a way of programmatically
accessing a current classes parent class
or super class and underscore underscore
in it of course is just referring to now
that class is owned in this
specialization method now per the dot
dots there could be a lot more going on
in these classes but what's nice now is
that wizard as a class is taking care of
all of the assignment of a Wizard's name
whether that wizard is a student or a
professor and it's even doing some error
checking to make sure they're in the
name was actually passed in meanwhile
student is inheriting all of that
functionality and using it by calling
the super class's own init method but
it's additionally taking the house
that's presumably passed into the
student Constructor function and
assigning it to its own instance
variable self.house and similarly
Professor are restoring in self.subject
the subject that was passed into there
that one as well now how might we use
these classes well we'll continue to
wave our hands with a little bit of
detail here but if at the bottom of this
file or any other file that Imports this
one I could now write code like this I
could create a student variable and
assign it the return value of the
student Constructor call and maybe that
student is named Harry and that students
house for instance might be Gryffindor
and meanwhile I might do something like
this professor equals professor over
here and notice the lowercase s on the
left capital S on the right same for
Professor on the left lower case and
uppercase on the right respectively
Professor quote unquote Severus and how
about defense against the dark arts will
be his subject and meanwhile if we want
more generically just a wizard who at
the moment is neither student nor
Professor teaching classes actively we
could even do that we could do wizard
equals Wizard and capital W on the right
hand side of the equal sign because it's
the name of the class and someone like
Albus passing in only albus's name not a
house not a subject because in this case
he's known only as a wizard meanwhile
with each of these calls this line of
code here will ensure that the init
method for the wizard class is called
this line of code here will ensure that
the init method of the student class and
in turn the in method of the superclass
wizard is called and then lastly on this
final line of code will this syntax
ensure that the init method of the
professor class is called which in turn
calls the init method of the superclass
as well any questions now on this idea
of inheritance which is a key feature of
a lot of object oriented programming
languages
um so is there any situation where
because uh from what I've seen so far A
lot of times there's like a lot of
nesting if you do super does it go one
up is there any situation where you know
it's nested in another class as well
um above wizard let's say a really good
question if you were to have a super
super class so your hierarchy is even
taller than the two levels of uh
hierarchy that we currently have
absolutely but what's nice about object
oriented Pro what's nice about
inheritance as the name implies is just
as you might have inherited certain
traits as a human from your grandfather
and grandmother or your great
grandfather or great-grandmother some of
those properties can actually trickle
down to you so to speak in the context
of code as well so when you descend from
another class that is when you subclass
a super class or a super super class you
actually do inherit all of the
functionality not just from one level
above you but from two or three so you
can indeed access some of that
functionality as well and you can even
override it if you want some of these
classes to behave a little bit
differently than others other questions
on inheritance so it's kind of similar
to the last one but can you have like
two parents on the same level a really
good question so there are ways to
implement uh um descendants from
multiple parents and there's different
ways to do this not just in Python but
other languages we've kept things simple
here though by having a single
inheritance path a good question how
about one more question on inheritance
can we have multiple arguments in super
dot double underscore in it yes but in
this case I'm only passing a name on
line 18 and I'm only passing in name on
line 10 why because on line two when I
defined the init method for the wizard
class I only expect a single argument
but I could absolutely have under common
functionality like I could add in a
Patronus if both students and professors
have patronuses that can come out of
their wands I could have two arguments
instead we've been using this feature of
object-oriented programming now for
quite some time in the form of
exceptions indeed if you look at the
official documentation for exceptions in
Python you'll see that there's not even
the ones we've seen in class like value
error and others there's any number of
others as well but they are all
themselves hierarchical in nature this
is just a subset of the available
exceptions that come built into Python
and you can actually as a programmer
create your own exceptions as well but
as this chart here captures
hierarchically all exceptions we've seen
thus far actually descend from or
inherit from
um super classes already so for instance
at the bottom of this list here is value
error which we've seen quite a bit and
if you follow the line straight up on
this ASCII rendition of this chart
you'll see that value error has a parent
class or super class called exception
and the exception class meanwhile has a
parent class called base exception why
did the authors of python do this well
it turns out that whether you have a
value error or a key error or an
assertion error or any number of others
there's a lot of functionality common to
all of those types of errors that you
want all that you want a programmer to
be able to use and so it turns out that
the authors of python decided you know
what let's not have a dozen or more
different classes that all just have
copy pasted similar functionality let's
create this hierarchy so that even
though the exceptions toward the bottom
of this list are very precise they at
least inherit that is borrow some very
common functionality up above so it
turns out that when you use the try and
the accept keyword in Python generally
speaking we've tried to catch very
specific exceptions like value error but
technically you could capture the parent
or even the grandparent exception for a
given exception especially if you're not
necessarily sure which one is going to
get raised or better yet there could be
many exceptions that get raised but you
want to handle them all the same and you
don't want to necessarily enumerate them
in parentheses separated by commas you
want to say you want to handle all
exceptions of a certain super class in
much the same way so this has been
latent this whole time anytime we've
seen or used or caught or now raised
exceptions and built into python is this
hierarchy and if you were to invent your
own exception generally you wouldn't
want to start from scratch you would
want to descend from that is subclass
one of these existing exceptions and add
your own twist on it your own
functionality as well
well there's one final feature of
object-oriented programming that we'd
like to share with you today and that it
will perhaps be quite the eye opener is
what you can really do now that you have
classes at your disposal and this too
surprise has been a feature you and I
have been taking for granted for weeks
now this has just worked but it's been
implemented in a way that you can now
leverage yourself it turns out that
python in some other languages too
support this notion of operator
overloading whereby you can take very
common symbols like plus or minus or
other such syntax on the on the keyboard
and you can Implement your own
interpretation thereof plus does not
have to equal addition and minus does
not have to equal subtraction in fact
you and I have already seen another
context in which plus means something
else
plus has not always in Python meant
addition per se what else has python
used Plus for concatenation for
concatenation for joining two strings
for adding to a list can you use plus as
well so plus has actually been funny
enough overloaded by the authors of
python for us and so we can use the same
symbol in much the same way as addition
but with different data types to solve
slightly different problems well let me
propose that we go back over to vs code
here and let me go ahead and create a
new Final file called Vault dot Pi so
code of vault.pi and let me propose that
we implement the idea of a vault at
Gringotts keeping on theme wherein
there's a bank in the World of Harry
Potter and within this Bank families and
individuals have vaults containing all
sorts of money in The Wizarding World
and the type of money that exists in the
World of Harry Potter are coins called
galleons and sickles and Canucks and
those are in descending order of value
and so inside of a vault might be a
whole bunch of coins gold silver and
bronze essentially each in those
denominations tucked away so how can I
go about implementing first of all the
idea of a vault so that I can store for
instance for Harry Potter how much uh
coinage is in his family's Vault or for
one reason the same let me go ahead and
vault.pi and first create a class called
Vault essentially meant to represent a
bank vault perfect another real world or
fantasy world entity that I want to
represent with code I could use a tuple
or a list or a dictionary but again I'm
going to get a lot more functionality
with classes and we'll see one final
flourish with operators inside of this
Vault class let's go ahead and do this
let me Define my init method taking its
first argument of self and let me Define
three arguments to this when you create
a vault in my code here I want to be
able to initialize it with some number
of galleons some number of sickles and
some number of Canucks I want the user
the programmer to be able to pass in one
or more of those values ideally but they
can be optional so I'll give them
defaults so let's go ahead and Define a
parameter called galleons whose default
value will be zero sickles whose default
value will also be zero and Canucks
whose default value will be zero as well
so the programmer can pass in one or two
or three or heck even none of those and
they'll all have some implied defaults
how do I want to remember those values
that are passed in well let me do this
self.gallians equals galleons and
self.sicles equals sickles and self dot
canuts equals Canucks and so I could add
some error checking especially if you
don't pass in a number I could turn
these into properties to do even more
validation but let's keep it simple and
as always Focus only on the new ideas so
I'm just going to trust that these
values were passed in and I'm going to
immediately assign them to these
instance variables what now do I want to
do well let's come up with a way of
printing out what is in someone's vaults
ultimately but first let's do this let's
create a vault for The Potters by
creating by assignment a new Vault and
let's say that the Potters have 100
galleons 50 sickles and 24 Canucks all
right and that's in that Vault and let's
print out for instance Potter all right
let's run this code and see how it works
now let me go ahead and run python a
vault.pi enter
okay seems to work no syntax errors or
anything else but this is not very
enlightening how do I fix this thinking
back to what we've done before you have
to use the underscore underscore stir
exactly I need to use one of those
special methods that comes with classes
and Define for myself how I want a vault
to be printed as a string so let me go
ahead and do that let me Define the stir
method taking in self as its sole
arguments here and let's just return a
very simple string that just reveals
what's in the vault so I'm going to
return a formatted F string inside of
which is self.gallians and then the word
Galleon so I know which those are then
let's do self.sicles and let's output
the word sickles and then lastly let's
output self.nuts and then Canucks here
so I know in this string just how many
of each of those coins I have in this
particular family's Vault all right let
me go ahead and run python of vault.pi
changing nothing else except the stir
method and now we see indeed that Harry
has 100 galleons 50 sickles and 25
Canucks all right well let's do one
thing more here below that let's go
ahead and Define a Weasley variable and
Ron never seemed to have quite as much
money in the vault as did Harry so let's
say that the Weasley Vault will have 25
50 and 100 so I'll just reverse the
order of those denominations rather than
Harry's hundred 5025 and now let me go
ahead and print Weasley like this
and let's go ahead and clear my terminal
window run python of vault.pi this time
that stir method will be invoked twice
once for each of those Vault objects and
we'll see indeed that the first one for
Harry's got 150 and 25 respectively
versus runs 25 50 and 100 respectively
but now let's do something interesting
suppose that you wanted to combine the
contents of two vaults be it Harry's and
rods or any other two people how would
you go about doing this in code well if
I wanted to combine the vaults for
someone I could do this well I could do
galleons equals let's do Potter dot
galleons plus Weasley dot galleons that
gives me a variable called galleons that
has the sum of Harry and Ron's galleons
let's next do sickles equals Potter dot
sickles plus Weasley dot sickles
and then lastly let's do Canucks equals
Potter dot canutz plus Weasley dot
Canucks I've got three variables what
can I now do with these values well
let's create a third a new Vault uh
total will be the name of this variable
equals a new Vault capital V notice and
now let's pass in those three new
variables galleons sickles and canuts
and that's it and let's print out this
total Vault so we should now see three
vaults one for Harry for Ron and the
combination the addition of the two let
me go ahead and rerun python of vault.pi
and there we have it uh what was 150 25
and 25 50 and 100 combined through
addition now is 125 100
125. so pretty straightforward using
techniques from weeks ago where we're
just declaring a few new variables and
doing some addition
but wouldn't it be cool if I could do
something like this wouldn't it be cool
if I could just somehow not manually
create my own Vault and do all of this
annoying math up here what if I could
just do Potter plus Weasley and get rid
of all of this logic here like wouldn't
it be nice if I overload the operator no
we know as plus just like stir does just
like list does to allow me to add two
volts together on the left and the right
well it turns out in Python and through
operator overlading there is a way to do
just this if you consult the
documentation there are there's this and
so many other special methods that come
with classes the third one we'll see
here is this one here underscore
underscore add underscore underscore and
you'll see that it very generically is
described in the documentation is
working for any object be it a vault or
stir or a list or something else by
convention it's going to take a first
argument called self and then it's going
to take some other argument by
convention called other
self in effect is going to be referring
to whatever object is on the left of a
plus sign other is going to be referring
to whatever's on the right hand side of
a plus sign thereby giving us a way of
describing encode the operand on the
left and the operand on the right of the
operator Plus in between that is to say
if I go back to vs code here what I'm
trying to do is Implement support for
this well let me try without writing any
other code just yet python a vault.pi
enter type error unsupported operand
types for Vault and Vault that is to say
python at this moment does not know what
it means to add two vaults together
right you and I might have an instinct
probably want to combine the galleons
and the sickles and the Canucks
respectively python doesn't know that it
just knows that you have a new class
called Vault but let's teach python to
do this let me clear my terminal window
let me scroll back up to the class
itself where at the moment I only have
two special methods in knit and stir but
let's add this third all right let me go
into the class here and Define
underscore underscore add underscore
underscore and then specify its first
parameter as self as before and then a
second parameter for this particular
method called by convention other now as
always I could name those parameters
anything I want but I'm going to stick
with convention Here and Now inside of
this method am I going to have to now
add together the contents of two vaults
well what two volts well if we scroll
down to our goal at hand the goal of
course is to add this Vault plus this
other Vault Potter plus Weasley
respectively well it turns out in Python
that when you do overload an operator
like Plus what's going to happen
automatically as soon as python sees
that is it's going to call that
underscore underscore ad underscore
underscore method and it's going to pass
into it two arguments whatever the
operand is on the left Potter in this
case and whatever the operand is on the
right Weasley in this case and those
values are going to get passed in as
self and other respectively what that
means is that we can access their are
contents up here in our implementation
of that as follows let me go ahead and
Define a local variable called galleons
and set that equal to for instance the
sum of self.gallians whatever's in
Potter's vault in this case plus
whatever is in Weasley's vault in this
case which would be other dot galleons
let me do the same for sickles self dot
sickles plus other dot sickles and let
me lastly do that for canutz so
self.canuts plus other dot canuts but at
the end of the day I'm going to need to
return a brand new bigger Vault that
contains all of those contents together
and if we ultimately want to assign that
bigger Vault to a variable like total
here on the left we'd better indeed
return a value from this add method so
I'm going to go ahead and give myself a
brand new vault as by returning Capital
vault which of course is going to call
My Vault function into which I can now
pass some of those initialization
arguments well how many Galleon signals
and Canucks do I want this brand new
Vault to contain well I want it to
contain this many galleons this many
sickles and this many knots so
ultimately what we're doing in this
implementation of add is adding together
those Galleon sickles and Canucks
passing them to the Vault function so
that we get a brand new bigger Vault and
return that all together
so now I've defined this new special
method called add that should now just
make Plus work for two vaults all right
let's see let me run down to my terminal
window python of vault.pi and hit enter
and voila and now we've implemented an
overloaded operator plus to do what you
and I as humans would hope would be the
case when you add two vaults together
but I've now written the code more
specifically to teach python what it
means concretely to add two vaults
together and it's with very similar
coding effect underneath the hood that
python is doing this for two strings to
concatenate them together to joining two
lists into a new list with lists and so
many other classes as well
any questions now on operator
overloading or this example here how
would you go about creating a function
for adding a student and a vault for two
two separate classes how would that be
possible
let me see what happens here I don't
know offhand let's do this let's create
a stir and see what happens if I add
Potter plus a stirrer
stir up yeah okay so it would work I'm
just figuring this out as I go here Eric
so just to be clear what I did was I
just changed Weasley to stir just to see
what would happen when I add a vault
plus a stir and it will work
theoretically why because so long as the
type of value on the left has an add
method implemented other can be any type
that you want you just have to decide in
code what it's going to mean
conceptually to add a vault plus a
string which in this case probably
doesn't make any sense at all but it's
possible it's going to be the operand on
the left and I'm inferring that I did
not know the answer a moment ago I'm
inferring that because what I got was an
attribute error here on line 11 because
python did not like this other dot
galleons didn't work but I could make it
work by figuring something out really
good question didn't know that one
myself other questions on operator
overloading can you define new operators
in Python I don't think so there is a
very long but precise list of operators
that you can overload I do not believe
you can assign arbitrary characters to
be operators in Python uh let me defer
to Carter in the chat to revoke okay I'm
seeing two of my colleagues are saying
no not possible so I'm gonna go with my
first instinct no otherwise that'd be
kind of cool you could make Emoji do
whatever you want to how about one final
question on operator overloading is that
the only operation you can do uh is this
as far as like can you do a subtraction
as well you can you can do so many
others let me um if Carter you don't
mind pulling up this URL here so this
link here special method names in
today's slides you'll see a long list of
all of The Operators that you can
overload you can do less than equals
then plus equals minus equals pretty
much any symbol you've seen me type on
the screen can be overloaded in the
context of classes
so even though today we focused entirely
on object-oriented programming this is a
technique that we've been using really
since the first week of the class
because indeed those ins those stirs
those floats those lists those
dictionaries and so much more were
already underneath the hood this whole
time classes and objects thereof but you
now as a programmer have the ability to
create your own classes with your own
instance or class variables with your
own instance or class methods with your
own properties and even with your own
custom behavior for operators so
ultimately you can absolutely continue
using those simple tuples or lists or
those dictionaries or other structures
as well but object-oriented programming
and with it classes and now these
objects is just another tool in your
toolkit and dare say as your code gets
more sophisticated and your problems get
bigger you'll find that being able to
model these real world or even fantasy
world entities with classes and related
data and functionality will ultimately
just allow you to Define code that's not
just correct but ever well designed as
well this one was cs50
[Music]
foreign
this is cs50's Introduction to
programming with python my name is David
Malin and over these past many weeks
have we focused on functions and
variables early on then conditionals and
loops and exceptions a bit of libraries
unit tests file Lao regular Expressions
object oriented programming and really
Etc and indeed that's where we focus
today is on all the more that you can do
with python and programming more
generally Beyond some of those
fundamental concepts as well in fact if
you start to flip through the
documentation for python in all of its
form all of which is as always
accessible at docs.python.org you'll see
additional documentation on Python's own
tutorial in library it's reference it's
how to and among all of those various
documents as well as others more online
you'll see that there's some tidbits
that we didn't quite touch on and indeed
even though we themed these past several
weeks of round fairly broad topics that
are rather essential for doing typical
types of problems in Python it turns out
there's quite a number of other feature
as well that we didn't necessarily touch
on that didn't necessarily fit within
any of those overarching Concepts or
might have been a little too much too
soon if we did them too early on in the
course and so in today our final lecture
will be Focus really on all the more
that you can do with python and
hopefully wet your appetite for teaching
yourself all the more too for instance
among Python's various data types
there's this other one that we haven't
had occasion to yet use namely a set in
mathematics a set is typically a
collection of values wherein there are
no duplicates so it's not quite a list
it's a bit more special than that in
that somehow any duplicates are
eliminated for you well it turns out
within python this is an actual data
type that you yourself can use in your
code and via the documentation here
might you be able to glean that it's a
useful problem if you want to somehow
automatically filter out duplicates so
let me go ahead and go over to vs code
here and let me go ahead and show you a
file that I created a bit of in advance
whereby we have a file here called
houses dot pi and then how Moses dot Pi
I already went ahead and whipped up a
big uh list of students inside of which
is a number of dictionaries Each of
which represents a student's name and
house respectively now this is a pretty
sizable dictionary and so it lends
itself to iteration over the same and
suppose that the goal here was quite
simply to figure out well what are the
unique houses at Hogwarts in the World
of Harry Potter it would be nice perhaps
to not have to know these kinds of
details or look them up online here we
have a set of students albeit not
exhaustive with all of the houses but
among these students here what are the
unique houses in which they live well I
could certainly as a human just eyeball
this and tell you that it's well
Gryffindor Slytherin Ravenclaw but how
could we go about doing it
programmatically for these students as
well well let's take one approach first
here let me go into houses.pi and let me
propose that we first how about create
an empty list called houses in which I'm
going to accumulate each of the houses
uniquely so every time I iterate through
this list of of dictionaries I'm only
going to add a house to this list if I
haven't seen it before so how do I
express that well let me iterate over
all of the students with for students in
students as we've done in the past and
let me ask you a question now so if the
current students house and notice that
I'm indexing into the current student
because I know they are a dictionary or
dict object and if that student's house
is not in my House's list then indented
am I going to say houses dot append
because again houses is a list and I'm
going to append that particular house to
the list then at the very bottom here
let me go ahead and do something
somewhat interesting here and say for
each of the houses that I've accumulated
in I could just say houses but if I just
say houses what was the point of
accumulating them all all at once I
could just do this whole thing in a loop
let's at least go about and sort those
houses with sorted which is going to
sort the strings alphabetically and
let's go ahead there in and print each
of the houses let me go ahead now in my
terminal window and run python of
houses.pi and hit enter and there we
have it Gryffindor Ravenclaw Slytherin
in alphabetical order even though in the
list of dictionaries up here technically
the order in which we saw these with was
Gryffindor Gryffindor Gryffindor
Slytherin Ravenclaw so indeed my code
seems to have sorted them properly so
this is perfectly fine and it's one way
of solving this problem but it turns out
we could use more that's built into the
language python to solve this problem
ourselves here I'm rather Reinventing a
wheel really the notion of a set wherein
duplicates are eliminated for me so let
me go ahead and clear my terminal window
and perhaps change the type of object
I'm using here instead of a list which
could also be written like this to
create an empty list let me go ahead and
create an empty set whereby I call a
function called set that's going to
return to me some object in Python that
represents this notion of a set wherein
duplicates are automatically eliminated
and now I can type tighten up my code
because I don't have to use this if
condition myself I think I can just do
something like this inside of my Loop
let me do houses dot add so it's not
append for a set it's a pen for a list
but it's add to a set per the
documentation then let me go ahead and
add this current student's house and now
I think the rest of my code can be the
same I'm just now trusting per the
documentation for set in Python that
it's going to filter out duplicates for
me and I can just blindly add add add
all of these houses to the set and any
duplicates already there will be gone
python of houses dot pi and enter and
voila we're back in business with just
those three there as well let me pause
here to see if there's any questions now
on this use of set which is just another
data type that's available to you in
other class in the world of python that
you can reach for when solving some
problem like this how can we locate an
item in a set for example find Griffin
door in that set how do you find an item
in in a set you can use very similar
syntax as we've done for a list before
you can use syntax like if Gryffindor in
houses then and you can answer a
question along those lines so you can
use in and not in and similar functions
as well other questions on set okay what
happens if you have a similar house name
let's say instead of Slytherin it is
maybe an O instead of an eye will the
for Loop look throughout each of those
um letters in the house name uh it would
compare the strings so if Slytherin
appears more than once but is slightly
misspelled or miscapitalized if I heard
you right those would appear to be
distinct string so you would get both
versions of Slytherin in the result
however we've seen in the past how we
can clean up users data if indeed it
might be messy we could force everything
to uppercase or everything to lower case
or we could use capitalize the function
built into stirs or title case that
would handle some of the cleanup for us
in this case because the data is not
coming from humans using the input
function I wrote the code in advance
it's safer to assume that I got the
houses right but that's absolutely a
risk if it's coming from users allow me
to turn our attention back to some of
the other features here that we can
leverage in Python if we dig further
into the documentation and read up more
on its features well in some language
there's this notion of global variables
whereby you can define a variable that's
either local to a function as we've seen
many times or if you put a variable
outside of all of your functions perhaps
near the top of your file that would
generally be considered a global
variable or in the world of python it
might be specific to the module but for
all intents and purposes it's going to
behave for a given program as though it
is global however it turns out that if
you do this when solving some problem
down the line whereby you have multiple
functions and you do have one or more
variables that are outside of those
functions you might not be able to
change those variables as easily as you
might think so indeed let me go back to
vs code here and in just a moment I'm
going to go ahead and create a new file
how about called Bank dot Pi let's go
ahead and implement the notion of a bank
wherein we can store things like money
in various forms and let me go ahead and
do this let me go ahead and Implement a
very simple bank that simply keeps track
of my total balance the number of
dollars or cents or whatever I might be
storing in this bank and I'm going to
give myself a variable called balance at
the top which is an integer a set to
zero now let me go ahead and Define a
main function as we often do and inside
of my main function let me go ahead and
print out quote unquote balance and then
print out the value of balance itself
passing to print as we've often done
more than one argument so that they get
separated by a single white space And
now since I have a main function really
setting the stage for doing more
interesting things soon let me go ahead
and do our usual if the name of this
file equals equals underscore underscore
main then go ahead and call Main so this
is a terribly short program but it's
perhaps representative of how you might
solve some future problem in Python
whereby you have a main function that's
going to eventually do some interesting
stuff and at the top of your file you
have one or more variables that are just
useful to keep there because then you
know where they are and perhaps not just
main but other functions can access them
as well so let's see when I run this
program python of bank.pi I would hope
based on my own intuition thus far then
I'm going to see that my current balance
is zero that is to say even though the
balance variable is defined on line one
hopefully I can still print it on line
five inside of main even though balance
was not defined in my main function here
we go hitting enter and voila balance
zero so it does seem to work even if you
declare a variable in Python outside of
your functions it appears that you can
access it you can read the value of that
variable even inside of a function like
main well let's get a little more
adventurous now because this program
really isn't solving anyone's problems
let's go ahead and Implement more of a
bank like the ability to deposit money
into the bank and to withdraw money
money from the bank thereby giving me
some more functions that might very well
need to access that same variable Let Me
Clear My terminal window here and let me
go ahead and pretend for the moment that
I have the ability to deposit say 100 or
100 coins whatever the unit of currency
is here and then maybe I want to
withdraw straight away 50 of those same
dollars or coins and now let me go ahead
and just print out at the bottom of main
what my new balance should be so that in
an Ideal World once I've deposited 100
then withdrawn 50 after starting at zero
I'd like to think that my new balance on
line 8 should indeed be 50. all right
but I haven't implemented these
functions yet so let's do that as we've
done in the past down here I'm going to
go ahead and Define another function
deposit I'm going to say that it takes
an argument called n for a number of
coins or dollars or the like and I'm
just going to do this I'm going to go
ahead and say balance plus equals n
thereby changing the value of N I could
do it more verbally balance equals
balance plus n but I'm going to use the
shorter hand notation here instead and
now let's Implement withdraw so Define a
function called withdraw it too is going
to take a variable in argument n for
number of dollars or coins and now I'm
going to go ahead and subtract from
balance using minus equals n as well and
I'm still going to call Main if the name
of this file is main so what have I done
I've just added not just one but three
functions total all of which apparently
need to access balance by printing it
incrementing it or decrementing it as
we've seen here all right let me go
ahead and focus on these three functions
here let me go back to my terminal
window and run python of bank.pi and hit
enter
and wow seems like we've introduced some
number of problems here and what are
these problems well Unbound local error
is perhaps the first time we've seen
this one here local variable balance
referenced before assignment and that's
a bit misleading definitely confusing
right because I absolutely assigned
balance of value on the top of my code
and indeed if I scroll back up nothing
has changed or been lost up there it's
definitely been assigned to value and
now online uh 12 it would seem that when
deposit is called I'm just trying to
access that variable again so
intuitively what might explain this
error message Unbound local error what
is python telling us there that python
can or can't do when it comes to these
so-called Global variables that are at
the top of my file so if you want to
change this variable you should write an
Insight Dev function name in and the
global variable unchangeable yeah so if
you want to change the value it might
need to be local to the function if you
are trying to change a global variable
though in a function it clearly does not
work so it's okay to read a global
variable read meaning access it and
print it and so forth but apparently you
can't write to a global variable in the
same way from within one of these
functions all right well maybe the fixes
to do this let me clear my terminal
window in that error and maybe I could
just do this let's get rid of the global
variable and let's go ahead and put it
for instance inside of main might this
now work well let me try this now python
of bank.pi enter
that alone did not solve it I still have
an Unbound local error this time though
it's for a different reason it turns out
now that balance on line
two is by definition a local variable a
local variable is one that exists in the
context of a function at least in this
case a global variable is the opposite
one that does not for instance at the
top of my file so here is another
distinction in Python if you declare a
variable in a function like main just as
I've done on line two with balance it is
indeed local to that function deposit
and withdraw do not have access to that
same variable why because it's local to
Main and so you would think now we're
kind of stuck in this vicious cycle well
maybe the solution then is to move
balance globally so all three functions
can access it but clearly where we began
as Elena noted we can't therefore change
it so it turns out the solution to this
problem in Python is ironically exactly
this keyword here it's a little
different as you might have seen if
you've programmed before in other
languages but there's indeed a keyword
in Python called Global that allows you
to tell a function that hey this is not
a variable that's local to you I mean it
to be a global variable that I want you
to edit so if I go back to vs code here
clearing my terminal window to get rid
of that error let me go ahead and undo
the change I just made and put balance
back at the top of my file but this time
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
inform my two functions that need to
change the value of balance that it is
indeed Global by typing Global balance
again here as well as here Global
balance I still leave the same lines of
code now on lines 13 and 18 that
increment and decrement balance but this
now use of keyword Global is a little
bit of a clue to python that oh okay
it's not a local variable this is not a
bug that you've introduced you mean for
me to edit this variable up above so now
let me go ahead in my terminal window
and run python of bank.pi I'm hoping to
see that my balance is zero plus a
hundred minus 50 is
50. and indeed it now is it starts off
at zero per my first print statement on
line five but it ends up at 50 total at
below that on line eight let me pause
here to see if now there's any questions
on these Global or local variables what
happens when you declare a variable
globally and as in the same variable
globally and in a function a good
question you're always thinking about
the so-called Corner cases so if you
declare a variable both globally like at
the top of your file and then an
identically named variable inside of a
function
same name the latter Will Shadow so to
speak the former that is you'll be able
to use the latter that is the local
variable but it will have no effect on
the global variable temporarily python
will only know that the local variable
exists so in general the rule of thumb
is just don't do that not only might it
create bugs in your code because you
don't quite change what you intend to
change it's also perhaps uh non-obvious
to other readers as well other questions
on globals or locals okay what if we
decide some unbalanced as an argument
inside the main function yeah another
good Instinct but in this case that also
is not going to solve the problem
because if you pass in a variable like
balance to each of the functions and
then change it within that function it's
only going to be changing in effect a
local copy thereof it's not going to be
changing what's outside of those
functions so I think we actually need a
better way altogether and in fact allow
me to transition to perhaps a
modification of this same program
program recall that we looked most
recently at this notion of
object-oriented programming whereby you
can model real world entities for
instance a bank and you can model and
encapsulate information about that real
world entity for instance like someone's
account balance so let me propose that
we actually do this let me start from
scratch with bank.pi get rid of the
global variable altogether and actually
use some object-oriented code let me
define a class called account to
represent someone's bank account and
then let me go ahead and initialize with
my init method which again takes by
convention at least one argument called
self let me go ahead and initialize the
every person's bank account to some
value like zero now how can I do that
well I'm going to go ahead and do
self.balance equals zero thereby giving
me an instance variable called balance
initialized for this account to zero but
I'm going to proactively remember how we
also introduce this notion of properties
which might otherwise collide with the
names of my instance variables so just
by convention I'm going to do this I'm
going to rename this instance variable
proactively to underscore balance to
effectively indicate that it's private
even though that's not enforced by
python it's just a visual clue to myself
that this is something that really I
should not or other code should not
touch just functions in this class now
let me go ahead and do this let me go
ahead and Define an actual function
called balance that really is going to
be a property whose purpose in life is
just to return self dot balance and I'm
going to go explicitly and say this is
indeed a property of this class now let
me go ahead and re-implement those other
two functions deposit and withdraw but
in the confines of this class so I'm
going to say Define
deposit it's going to take in an
argument self as always but an
additional One n a number of dollars or
coins to deposit and how do I now
manipulate this well I'm going to do
self dot underscore balance plus equals
n and now down here I'm going to do def
withdraw self and just like for deposit
but here I'm going to do self.balance
minus equals n and now if I go down
below this class I'm going to go ahead
and Define myself a main function just
so I can try this now out I'm going to
go ahead and create an account object by
calling the account Constructor that is
the name of the class with two
parentheses if I'm not passing in any
arguments to init I'm going to go ahead
now and print out as before the balance
of my account but to do that I'm going
to access the property of that account
like this and I'm going to go ahead now
and say deposit another hundred dollars
or coins with deposit 100 and I'm going
to go ahead like before and also now
immediately withdraw for whatever reason
50 of the same and now I'm going to
print One Last Time balance followed by
account.balance again accessing that
property and for this whole thing to
work of course I need one of these if
name equals equals underscore main then
go ahead and call Main now before I run
this you'll see that it rather escalated
quickly I had a very simple goal at hand
to implement the notion of a bank and I
was able to implement that perfectly
fine ultimately by declaring balance to
be Global but then to tell each of my
functions that it is indeed Global but
that's not really the best form of
encapsulation we have at our disposal
now right per our focus on
object-oriented programming if we're
trying to implement some real world
entity like an account at a bank that's
what classes allow us to do and it
allows us to solve that same problem
perhaps a little more cleanly certainly
if we're going to accumulate more and
more functions or methods over time so
if I didn't make any mistakes here if I
run python of bank.pi and hit enter now
you'll see that it just works just fine
because in the world of classes in
Python the so-called instance variables
are by definition accessible to all of
the methods in that class because we're
accessing them all by way of that
special per diameter self
so which way to do it for a reasonably
small script wherein you are simply
trying to implement a script that has
some Global uh information like an
account balance that you then need to
manipulate elsewhere the global keyword
is a solution to that problem but
generally speaking in many languages
python to some extent among them using
Global variables tends to be frowned
upon only because things can get messy
quickly and it can become less obvious
quickly exactly where your information
is stored if some of it's up here some
of it's in your function so generally
the rule of thumb is to use Global
variables sparingly though technically
speaking in Python these Global
variables are technically local to our
module if we were indeed implementing a
library and not just a program so in
short try to use Global variables
sparingly but when you do there is a
solution to these same problems
questions now on globals or our
re-implementation of the same idea but
using
full-fledged object oriented programming
uh I just would like to ask uh what this
property does what this property does so
if I go back to vs code here you'll see
that this was a Technique we looked at
in our lecture on object-oriented
programming whereby a property is a
instance variable that's somehow
protected it allows me to control how it
can be read and written so in this case
I only have what's called generally a
Setter and sorry in this case I only
have what's generally called a getter
and there's no mention of the word
getter here this is just what app
property means that function balance
will allow me recall to use syntax like
this where I can pretend as though
balance is indeed with no underscore an
instance variable but I can now prevent
code like mine in main from trying to
change balance because I do not have a
Setter I would not be able to do
something like account balance equals a
thousand to just give myself a thousand
dollars or coins because I have not
defined a Setter so again per our focus
on object oriented programming these
properties just allow me some finer
grain can control some languages allow
you to Define variables that are so to
speak constant that is once you have set
a value to them you cannot change the
value of that variable and that tends to
be a good thing because it allows you to
program defensively just in case you
accidentally or someone else
accidentally tries to modify the value
of that variable if you have declared it
in some language as a constant it cannot
be changed or usually cannot be changed
without great effort unfortunately in
Python we're again on the sort of honor
System here where we have conventions to
indicate that something should be
treated as though it's constant but
that's not actually enforced by the
language so for instance let me go back
here to vs code and let me create a new
file for instance called meows.pi and
let's see if we can't implement the
notion of a cat meowing on the screen so
I'll do code of meows dot pi and in
meows.pi let me go ahead for instance
and Implement a very simple program that
just has a cat meowing three times so
how about this for I in the range of 3
go go ahead and print out quote unquote
meow all right well we've seen in the
past how we can clean this up a little
bit for instance if I'm not actually
using I I might as well pythonically
just change the name of that variable to
underscore even though that has no
functional effect here but here we have
this three sort of randomly hard-coded
that is typed explicitly into my code
and it's totally not a big deal when
your code is only two lines but imagine
that this is a much bigger program with
dozens or even hundreds of lines and
imagine that one of those lines just as
a three in there somewhere like you're
never going to find that three very
easily and it's going to be very easily
overlooked by you or colleagues or
others that you've hard-coded some magic
value like a three right there in your
code so it tends to be best practice not
just in Python but other languages as
well anytime you have what is
essentially a constant like a number
three that shouldn't ever change is to
at least let it Bubble Up surface it to
the top of your code so that it's just
obvious what your code's constant values
are and so by that I mean this at the
top of this file it would probably be a
little clearer to colleagues and frankly
me tomorrow after I've forgotten what I
did today to Define a variable like
meows and set it equal to three and then
instead of hard coding three here or
even lower in a much bigger program let
me just go ahead and pass in that
variable's value to my Loop so that now
it's just kind of obvious to me that
meows is apparently the number of times
to meow and if I ever want to change it
the only code I have to change is at the
very top of my file I don't need to go
fishing around or figure out what's
going to break what do I need to change
I just know that I can change these
constants up at the top the problem
though with python is that python
doesn't actually make variables constant
it's indeed a convention in Python and
some other languages to at least
capitalize your variables when you want
to indicate to the world that you should
not touch this it is constant but there
is literally nothing in my code
preventing me from saying you know what
today I feel like four meows instead
like that would work work in other
languages though there's typically a
keyword or some other mechanism
syntactically that would allow you to
prevent line three currently from
executing so that when you try to run
your code you would actually get an
error message explicitly saying you
cannot do that so python again is a bit
more on the honor System when it comes
to these conventions instead now it
turns out there's other types of
constants quote unquote that python
typically manifests and in fact let me
go ahead and change this around a little
bit let me delete this version of meows
and let me introduce again a class from
our discussion of object oriented
programming like a class representing a
cat another real world entity recall
that within classes you can have not
just instance variables but class
variables that is variables inside of
the class that aren't inside of self per
se but they're accessible to all the
methods inside of that class here too
there's a convention but not enforced by
python of having class constants whereby
inside of the class you might want to
have a variable people that should
should not be changed but you just want
to indicate that visually by
capitalizing its name so for instance if
the default number of meows for a cat is
meant to be three I can literally inside
of my class but outside of any of my
defined methods just create a class
variable all capitalized with that same
value and then if I want to create a
method like meow for instance which as
an instance method might take in self as
we know and then I might have my Loop
here for underscore in the range of and
now I need to access this the convention
would be to say cat dot meows to make
clear that I want the meows variable
that's associated with the class called
cat then I'm going to go ahead and print
out one of these meows and now at the
bottom of my code outside of the class
let me go ahead and do something like
this let me instantiate a cat using the
cat Constructor notice this is important
per our discussion of oop the class is
capitalized by convention but the
variable over here is is lower case and
I could call it just C or anything else
but I kind of like the symmetry of
calling it little cat here and big cat
so to speak over here and now if I want
this particular cat to meow that default
number of three times I can just do cat
dot meow like this and that method meow
is going to per line five access that
class constant but again it's constant
only in the fact and only in the sense
that you should not touch that not that
it's actually going to be enforced by
the language
all right let me go ahead then and run
this with python of meows.pi and there
it is three of our meows meow meow it
turns out that python is a dynamically
typed language that is to say it's not
strongly typed whereby when you want an
INT you have to tell the program that
you are using an INT you don't have to
tell the program that you are using a
stir or a float or a set or anything
else generally speaking to date you and
I when we're creating variables we just
give a variable a name we frequently
assign it using an equal sign some other
value and honestly python just kind of
dynamically figures out what type of
variable it is if it's quote unquote
hello world the variable is going to be
a stir if it's 50 the integer the
variable is going to be an INT now in
other languages including C and C plus
plus and Java and others it's sometimes
necessary for the programmer to specify
what types of variables you want
something to be the upside of that is
that it helps you detect bugs more
readily because if you did intend for a
variable to store a string or an integer
but you accidentally store an integer or
a string the opposite or something else
altogether your language can detect that
kind of mistake for you when you go for
instance to run the program it can say
no you've made a mistake and you can fix
that before your actual users detect as
much in Python 2 here it's again more of
a friendly environment where you can
provide hints to python itself as to
what type a variable should be but the
language itself does not strongly
enforce these rather you can use a tool
that will tell you whether or not you're
using a variable correctly but it's
typically a tool you would run as the
programmer before you actually release
your code to the world or if you have
some kind of automated process you can
run this kind of tool just like you
could reformat or link your code with
some other program before you actually
release it to the world so how might we
go about using these so-called typins
well they're documented in the usual
place in Python's own documentation and
it turns out there's a program that's
pretty popular for checking whether or
not your code is adhering to your own
type pins and that program here is
called My Pie and it's just one of
several but this one's particularly
popular and can be easily installed in
the usual way with Pip install my pie
and its own documentation is that this
URL here but we'll use it quite simply
to check whether or not our variables
are indeed using the right types so how
can we go about doing this all right let
me go back here to vs code clear my
terminal window and in fact erase
meows.pi as it currently was and let's
Implement a different version of meows
that quite simply has a function called
meow that does the actual meowing on the
screen and then I'm just going to go
ahead and call that function down toward
the bottom I'm not going to bother with
a main function just for Simplicity so
that we can focus as always only on
what's new so here we are defining a
function called meow it's going to take
a number of times to meow for instance n
for number and inside of this function
I'm going to to do my usual for
underscore in the range of n Go ahead
and print quote unquote meow So based on
our earlier code I think this is correct
I've not bothered defining the variable
as I am instead using the underscore
because I'm not using it anywhere but I
think I now have a working function
whose purpose in life is to meow zero or
one or two or three or more times well
let's use this function again not
bothering with main I'm just going to
keep my function at the very top because
there's only one and I'm going to write
my code here on line six so I'm going to
give myself I'm going to ask the user
for a number and I'm going to go ahead
and prompt them in the usual way for
that number of times to meow and now I'm
going to go ahead and call meow on that
number now some of you might see what
I've already done wrong but perhaps I
myself don't so let me go into my
terminal window and run python of
meows.pi the goal being to prompt me
this seems to be working I'm going to
type in three and I would expect now the
meow function to print out meow three
times and to sure
but no there's some kind of type error
here stir object cannot be interpreted
as an integer why might that be
why might that be
because the input function retains a
string instead of an integer exactly the
input function returns a string or a
stir not an end so in the past of course
our solution to this problem has just
been to convert the string to an INT by
using the int function but now let me
start programming more defensively so
that honestly I don't even find myself
in this situation at all let me go ahead
and do this let me add what's called a
type hint to my function that explicitly
specifies for meow what type of variable
should be passed in I'm going to go
ahead now and change the very first line
of my code and my function to specify
that n colon should be an INT and this
is a type hint the fact that I've added
a colon of space and the word int is not
creating another int or anything like
that it's just a hint an annotation so
to speak to python that this variable on
the left called n should be an INT now
unfortunately a python itself doesn't
care because again these type hints are
not enforced by the language and that's
by Design the language itself in the
community prefers that python B
dynamically typed not so strongly typed
as to require these things to be true
but if I run meows.pi type in three
again the same error is there but let me
go about trying this my Pi program an
example of a program that understands
type hints and if I run it proactively
myself can find bugs like this in my
code before I or worse a user actually
runs and encounter something cryptic
like this type error here let me clear
my terminal window and this time run my
Pi space meows dot Pi so I'm going to
run my Pi on my program but I'm not
running python itself when I hit enter
we'll see this
all right we see now that my pie found
apparently an error on line seven error
argument one to meow has incompatible
type stir expected end so it's still an
error message but my Pi is not a program
that my users would use this is a
program that you and I as programmers
would use and because we have run this
code now before we for instance released
this program to the world I can now see
even before the code is called or run oh
I seem to be mu using my argument to
meow wrong I had better fix this somehow
well I can actually go about in hint
adding type hints even to my own
variables here so as to catch this
another way too if I know on line six
that I'm creating already a variable
called number and I know already that
I'm assigned it equal to the return
value of input I could give my Pi in
tools like it another hint and say you
know what this variable called number
should also be an INT that is to say if
I now start getting into the habit of
annotating all of my variables and
arguments to functions maybe my pie can
actually help me find things quite
quickly as well before I get to the
point of running python itself let's go
ahead and try this again mypie of
meows.pi and hit enter and this time
notice that my pie actually found the
mistake a little more quickly notice
this time it found on line six that
error incompatible types and assignment
expression has Type stir variable has
Type int so before I even got to the
point of calling meow line six via this
type in when used and analyzed by my Pi
has helped me find a wait a minute I
shouldn't be assigning the return value
of input to my variable called number in
the first place why my Pie has just
pointed out to me that one returns a
stirrer I'm expecting an INT let me fix
this now instead alright so let me clear
my terminal window and now let me do
what most of you were probably thinking
I should have done in the first place
after all of these weeks but now let me
go ahead and convert the return value of
input to an integer for today's purposes
I'm not going to try to catch any
exceptions or the like we're just going
to assume that the user types this in
properly and now let me go ahead and run
my Pi of meows.pi having not only added
two types to my argument to my function
to my variable down here on line six and
I've also now fixed the problem itself
let me go ahead and run my pi and
success no issues found in one source
file now it's more reasonable for me to
go and run something like python of
meows and just trust that when I type in
3 at least I'm not going to get a type
error that is I didn't mess up as a
programmer with respect to the types of
my variables why because when I wrote
the code in the first place I provided
these annotations these hints that
inform tools like my Pi that my
intention had better line up with what
the actual code does let me pause here
and see if there's now any questions on
tight pins or my pie is is it common or
how common is it for those to be used or
is it just that it's more used in more
complex code
um where it's more difficult to ensure
that you're actually using the correct
type in the way that you're using
variables it's a good question and it's
rather a matter of opinion python was
designed to be a little more versatile
and flexible when it comes to some of
these details partly for writability to
make it easier and faster to write code
partly for performance so that the
program like python doesn't have to
bother checking these kinds of details
we can just get right into the code the
reality though is that uh strong type
checks do tend to be a good thing for
the correctness of your code why because
programs like my Pi can find before your
code is even run if there's already
known to be an error and it tends to be
good for defensive programming so the
the situation essentially is that within
the python ecosystem you can annotate
your types in this way you can use tools
tools to use those tight pins but today
to python itself does not enforce or
expect to enforce these conventions and
larger code bases and professional code
bases Commercial Code bases probably
depending on the product project manager
or depending on the engineering team
they may very well want themselves to be
using type hints why if it just
decreases the probability of bugs in
fact let me propose now that I imagine a
situation where instead of expecting
that meow prints meow meow meow some
number of times suppose that I
accidentally assumed that the meow
function just returns meow some number
of times we saw for instance when
focusing on unit tests that it tends to
be a good thing to have functions that
return values be it an INT or a string
rather than just having some side effect
like printing things out themselves so
perhaps I'm still in that mindset and
I've just assumed mistakenly for the
moment that meow returns a value like
meow or meow meow or meow meow meow a
big string of some number of meows
rather than just printing it itself as
it clearly does at the moment on line
three and therefore suppose that I
accidentally did something like this
rather than just getting the number and
passing it to meow suppose I did this
suppose I declared a number of of a new
variable called meows the type of which
I think should be stir and suppose again
I assume accidentally that meow returns
to me a string of those meows so that I
myself can then print them later this
would be a little more conducive
arguably to testing my meow function why
because I could expect that it's
returning meow or meow meow or meow meow
meow separated by new lines returning a
stir that I could then assert equals
what I expect it to be in something like
a unit test I'm not going to bother
writing any unit tests now but let's
just suppose that's the mindset I'm now
in and so on line seven I'm assuming
that I want to assign the return value
of meow to a new variable called meows
which I've annotated with this type hint
as being a stir just so we can see
another variable this one's not an INT
but a stir instead well let me go ahead
and run this code now python of meows.pi
enter typing in three and you'll see a
curious bug meow meow meow none
but why is that well it turns out at the
moment my meow function only has a side
effect it just prints out meow some
number of times it doesn't explicitly
return a value as it would if there were
literally the return keyword there by
default then when a function in Python
does not explicitly return a value it's
implicit return value is effect none and
so what we're seeing here is this on
line eight because I'm assigning the
return value of meow which is none to my
meows variable line three is what's
still printing meow meow meow and line
eight is what's now incorrectly printing
none because I accidentally thought that
meow returns a value but it doesn't so
it's about return value is effectively
none so I'm printing very weirdly the
word none at the bottom so how could I
go about catching this kind of mistake
too like I might make this mistake but
maybe with less frequency if I'm in the
habit of annotating my code we with this
new feature called type hints what you
can do here is this let me clear my
terminal window to get rid of that
artifact and up here let me additionally
specify with some funny looking syntax
that my meow function actually by Design
returns none so you literally use this
arrow notation in Python when hinting
what the return value of a function is
you would do this after the parentheses
a space a hyphen a greater than symbol
like an arrow and then another space and
then the type of the return value for
now it's indeed gonna excuse me return
none but now at least I can catch it
like this if I now run not python but my
Pi on my code which would be a habit I'm
now getting into if using type hints
check that I'm using all of my types
correctly before I even run my program
we'll see that now my Pi has found on
line seven that meow quote unquote does
not return a value and my pie knows that
because I have proactively annotated my
meow function as having none as its
return value so now my Pi can detect
that I should now realize oh wait a
minute I'm being foolish here my meow
clearly does not return a value I should
not be treating it like it does on line
seven let me go about actually fixing
this now so how do I go about fixing
this well let's practice what we
preached in our focus on unit test
having a function like meow not have
side effects like printing itself but
let's have it return the actual string
and I can actually do this kind of
cleanly let me uh clear my error message
in my terminal window here let me get
rid of the loop here let me say this
time that okay fine meow is going to
return a value an actual stir or string
so I've changed none to stir and now I
can implement this in any number of ways
maybe even using a loop but recall that
we have this syntax in Python which will
I think solve this problem for us if I
want to return a string of n meows what
I can actually do recall is this return
quote unquote meow backslash n times
that number n so it's kind of a clever
one-liner avoids the need for a for Loop
or something more involved than that to
just say multiply meow backslash n
against itself three times essential or
end times in this case in general so
that I get back a big string of zero
meows One Two Three or many more Mouse
instead I think now my code on line six
is actually correct now I've changed
meow to behave the way I was pretending
to assume it always worked so I'm
storing in meows plural of variable
that's of type stir because now meow
does have a return value of typester
itself per this type hint as well all
right let me go ahead now and print
meows but because each of my meows comes
with a trailing new line the backslash
and I'm going to proactively fix what
would be a minor aesthetic bug and I'm
just going to avoid outputting an extra
new line at the end of those three so if
I run python of meows.pi now type in
three there's my meow meow meow and now
no mention of none
questions now on type hints and these
annotations in my pie and using them to
defensively write code that just
decreases hopefully the probability of
your own bugs
[Music]
while the program don't take it as a
strange why does the program not take it
as a as strange
so so recall that um early on in the
class we looked at plus as a
concatenation operator that allows you
to join a string on the left and the
right multiplication is also an
overloaded operator for Strings whereby
if you have a string on the left and an
INT on the right it will multiply the
string so to speak by concatenating or
joining that many meows all together so
this is a feature of object oriented
programming an OB an operator
overloading as we saw it uh in the past
other questions on tight Pence or my pie
can we not Typecast this data type uh
the you know of this variable number no
you still and let me correct the
terminology it wouldn't be called type
casting in this context because it's not
like C or C plus plus where there's an
equivalence between these types you're
technically converting on line five a
stir to an INT you do still have to do
this because my Pi for instance would
yell at you if you were trying to assign
a stir on the right to an INT on the
left you must still use the int function
int itself is still a function it's not
a type hint but the word int is being
used in another way now in these type
pins so this imp is still a function
call as it always has been this syntax
on the left is another use of the
keyword int but in the form of these
type hints so you still have to do the
conversion yourself
all right let me propose that we
transition to another feature of python
that's worth knowing especially since
it's one that you'll see in the wild
when you see code or libraries that
other folks have written namely
something known as a doc string or
document strings it turns out in the
world of python there is a standardized
way per another pep python enhancement
proposal this one 257 that essentially
standardizes how you should document
your functions among other aspects of
your code and so for instance let me go
back to my meows.pi file here and let me
propose that we now start documenting
this code too so that I know what the
meow function does and in fact the
standard way of doing this using doc
string notation would be as follows to
comment this function not above it as
you might be in the habit of doing with
code in general but actually inside of
it but instead of commenting it like
this with the usual hash comment sign
like meow n times it turns out that when
you're formally docking when you're
formally documenting a function like
meow in this case you don't use regular
inline comments so to speak you use this
syntax instead you use triple quotation
marks either double or single then you
write out your comment meow and times
and then you write the same again at the
end so either three double quotes at the
start in the end or three single quotes
at the start in the end and python has
built into it certain tools and certain
assumptions that if it detects that
there is a comment using this doc string
format triple quotes on the left and the
right it will assume that that's indeed
the documentation for that function and
it turns out in the python python
ecosystem there's a lot of tools that
you can then use to analyze your code
automatically extract all of these
document strings for you and even
generate web pages or PDFs of
documentation for your own functions so
there's these conventions via which if
you adhere to them you can start
documenting your code as for other
people by generating automatically the
documentation from your own code without
writing something up from scratch
manually now it turns out if your
function does take arguments and perhaps
does a bit more there are multiple
conventions for how you can document for
the human programmers that might be
using your function whether it's you or
a colleague or someone else on the
internet to actually use these doc
strings to standardize the information
they're in so you might see this instead
using the same triple quotes above and
below now you might see your one
sentence one sentence explanation of the
function meows meow end times sometimes
depending on the style and use it might
actually still be on the first line but
with a blank line below it but I'll keep
everything uniformly indented and this
is a convention used by some popular
python documentation tools as well you
would say syntax like this param n colon
and then adjust description of what n is
number of times to meow then colon Type
n colon int which just indicates that
the type of n is an integer then if this
function could actually raise an
exception you can document that too and
actually it's not really well it's
arguably my mistake here if n comes in
as an argument and is not in fact an INT
maybe it's a float or a string or
something else the multiplication sign
here is not going to work it's not going
to multiply the string it's going to
trigger what I know from experience to
be a type error so I'm going to go ahead
and proactively say in my own
documentation that this function
technically if you use it wrong could
raise a type error even though I'm
hinting up here with this annotation
that you should pass in an INT again
python doesn't enforce that so if you
pass in a float this might in fact raise
this function a type error and so that
might happen if n is not an INT and then
lastly I might say for clarity's sake
for other programmers this function
returns a string of n meows one per line
and the return type of that value our
type is going to be stir now all of this
syntax here as I've used it is not
python per se this is a convention known
as restructured text which is a form of
markdown like language that's used for
documentation for websites for blogs and
even more but it's one of the popular
conventions within the world of python
to document your own functions so this
does not have anything to do
fundamentally with type hints type hints
are a feature of python what I'm doing
here is just adhering to a third-party
Convention of putting in between a
Python doc string from the start to the
end a certain standard format so that
these third-party tools can analyze my
code for me top to bottom left to right
and ideally generate documentation for
me it can generate a PDF a web page or
something else so that I or my
colleagues don't need to not just only
write code but also manually create
documentation for our code we can keep
everything together and use tools to
generate the same for us
any questions now on these doc strings
which again are a Convention of
documenting your own code often
following some standard syntax yeah so
when you say like you would document it
and put it in a PDF is the purpose of
doing this to kind of like publish it
and share your function so other users
can use it absolutely in the past when
we have installed some third-party
libraries for instance cow say a few
weeks back recall that I showed you what
functions it had but if you read the
documentation you might actually see
that it was documented for us by the
author of that program now I don't
believe they were using this particular
syntax but it was definitely useful for
you and me to be able to read some web
page or PDF telling us how to use the
library rather than wasting time reading
through someone else's code and trying
to infer what functions exist and how to
use them it just tends to be much more
developer friendly to have proper
documentation for our own code or
libraries as well other questions yeah
um when with Doc strings when you when
it's used to generate like a PDF or
whatever does it does it include uh any
of the code so if you're referencing in
the in your in your comment uh if you're
referencing the code in the comment
itself might not make sense without
seeing the code because it does do these
include include it short answer you can
do that not in the convention I'm using
here but there's actually a clever way
to write in your doc strings sample
inputs to your functions and Sample
outputs for your functions and if you
use a different tool that we've not
discussed that tool will run your code
using those sample inputs it will check
that your outputs match your sample
outputs and if not the program will yell
at you saying you've got a bug somewhere
so this is just another way where you
can use doc strings to not only document
but even catch errors in your code
this has been a lot and there's a bit
more to go why don't we go ahead here
and take a five minute break and when we
resume we'll take a look at yet another
feature of python yet another library to
write code faster all right suppose we
want to modify this meows program to
actually take its input not from the
input function in the blinking prompt
but from the command line recall in our
discussion of libraries that you could
use something like sys.org V to get at
command line arguments that a human has
provided when you're running your
program so why don't we whip up a
version of meow that uses command line
arguments instead of again input so I'm
going to go ahead and delete what we've
done here thus far and let me propose
that we import CIS as we've done in the
past and let's do this how about if the
user does not type any command line
arguments then my program will just meow
once just so that it does something
visually interesting otherwise let's
also give the user an option to specify
how many times I want the cat to meow so
let's start simple let's first of all go
ahead and do this if the length of
sis.org V equals equals one that is the
user only typed the name of the program
and nothing else after the uh in their
command then let's go ahead and just
print out one meow like this uh else for
now let's go ahead and print out
something like this else go ahead and
print out let's say usage for the
program which will be usage of meows dot
Pi just so that the user knows that the
program itself is called meows.pi all
right now let me go down to my terminal
window and start to type python of
meows.pi and at this point notice that
the length of sys.org V Should indeed be
one why well python the name doesn't end
up in sys.rv at all ever but meows.pi
the name of the file does and it's going
to go in sys.org v0 but that's only one
element so the length of this thing is
one there's nothing more to the right so
when I hit enter now we should see
indeed one meow if I don't cooperate
suppose I do something like meows three
enter then I'm going to they see a
reminder that this is how you use the
program and this is a common convention
to literally print out the word usage a
colon then the name of the program and
maybe some explanation of how to use it
so I'm keeping it very simple but let's
be a little fancier what if I really
wanted the user to type in maybe not
three but something more sophisticated
and in fact when controlling programs
from the command line it's very common
to provide what are often called
switches or Flags whereby you pass in
something like dash n which semantically
means this number of times then often a
space and then something like the number
three this still allows me to do other
things at the command line if I want but
the fact that I've standardized on how
I'm providing command line arguments to
this program with Dash N3 is just a more
reliable way now of my program knowing
what does the three mean it's a little
less obvious if I just do meows.pi Space
3 well what does the three mean at least
with syntax like Dash N3 especially if
you've read the documentation for this
program ultimately oh Dash N means
number of times got it it's a way of
passing in two additional arguments but
that have some relationship between them
so how do I modify my program to
understand Dash N3 well if I'm using CIS
like this I could do this L if the
length of cis.org V equals this time 3
because notice there's one two three
things at my prompt so sys.org V 0 1 and
2 three things total separated by spaces
if it equals three and let's be safe and
sis.org V bracket one equals equals dash
n then let's go ahead and do this let's
go ahead and convert uh sis dot org V of
to an integer and assign it to a
variable for instance called n and then
let's go ahead and do this for
underscore in the range of n let's go
ahead and print out some of these meows
now there's still an opportunity maybe
to consolidate my print lines with meow
but for now I'm going to keep these
ideas separate so I'm going to handle
the default case with no arguments up
here as before and now more
interestingly I'm going to do this to be
clear I'm going to check if the user
gave me three command line arguments the
name of the program dash n and a number
if indeed the second thing they gave me
in sys.org V of 1 equals equals dash n
then I'm going to assume that the next
thing sys.org V of 2 is going to be an
integer and I'll convert it to such and
store it in this variable n and now just
using a loop I'm going to print out meow
that many times alright so it's kind of
a combination of our earlier focus on
Loops our earlier focus on command line
arguments just creating a program that
allow me to claim is representative of
how a lot of command line programs work
even though we've typically not used
many like this but it's very common to
configure a program one you're about to
run into the command line with something
like these command line arguments like
dash n or Dash something else now I'm
going to go ahead and hit enter
and I think I should see indeed three
meows by contrast if I do two at the end
I should see two meows if I do one I
should see one meow and frankly if I
just omit this all together I should see
one meow as well because that was my
default case earlier
and now let me allow us to uh assume
that this program eventually gets more
complicated right let's imagine a world
where I don't want to support just dash
n maybe I want to support Dash a and
dash B and dash C and Dash D and a whole
lot of others or heck at that point I
should maybe give them words so maybe
it's a dash dash number it's indeed a
convention uh in Computing typically to
use single dashes with a single letter
like n but use double dashes if you're
actually using a whole word like number
so the command line argument might be
dash n or maybe it's dash dash number
but you can imagine just how complicated
the code gets if now you want to support
Dash N Dash a dash b c and so forth
you're gonna have to be checking all
over the place and what if they come in
a different order you're going to have
to check is dash n first or is it second
or is it third or is its fourth I mean
this just becomes very painful very
quickly just to do something relatively
simple like allow the user to pass
command line arguments into your program
well this this is why as always there
exists libraries and another library
that comes with python that's probably
worth knowing something about is this
one here called ARG parse in fact with a
lot of the tools I myself or cs50s team
writes in Python we very frequently use
ARG parse whenever they are more
complicated than a lot of our class
demos and a little more similar to this
one where we want to allow the user to
pass in configuration options at the
command line and by supporting things
like dash n or Dash a or Dash b or Dash
C ARG parse is a library that per its
documentation just handles all of this
parsing so to speak this analysis of
command line Arguments for you
automatically so you can focus on
writing the interesting parts of your
program not the command line arguments
part so how might we use this well let
me go back to vs code here let me clear
my terminal window and let me propose
that I rewrite this using not CIS but
actually using ARG parse and I'm going
to start a little simple and then build
back up so let me throw all of this away
for now now and instead import ARG parse
ARG parse stands for argument parser to
parse something means to read it kind of
pick it apart to analyze it so this is
indeed going to do just that for me now
let me go ahead and do this and for this
Library it's helpful to know a little
object oriented programming like we all
now do I'm going to create a variable
called parser that could call it
anything I want I'm going to set it
equal to the return value of ARG parse
dot
argument parser with a capital A and a
capital P A Constructor for a class
called argument parser that comes with
python itself within this Library here
now I'm going to configure this argument
parser to know about the specific
command line arguments that I myself
want to support in my program so I'm
going to do this
parser.add underscore argument so that's
apparently a method in the parser object
I'm going to add an argument of dash n
Easy enough now I'm going to go ahead
and actually parse the command line
arguments I'm going to do args or I
could call the variable anything I want
parser dot parse args and by default
parse arcs is going to automatically
look at sys.org V for me I don't need to
import sys myself I can leave the
argument parser its code to import sys
look at sys.orgv and figure out where
dash n or anything else actually is and
what's nice now because this line of
code here results in the parser having
parsed all of the command line arguments
I now have this object in this variable
called args inside of which are all of
the values of those command line
arguments no matter what order they
appeared in not such a big deal when
I've only got one because it's only
going to go in one place at the end but
if I've got dash n a dash b c you could
imagine them being in all different
orders they definitely don't have to be
alphabetical the user should be able to
type them in any order they want that's
better for usability ARG parser is going
to figure all of that out for me and all
I have to do now is this if I want to
iterate over that many numbers of
arguments and that many mouths rather I
can do this for underscore in the range
of the int conversion of args.n so dot
is the syntax we kept using to access
things like properties inside of an
object and that's what args is it's the
object returned by the parse arcs
function for me I'm going to go ahead
now and print out quote unquote meow
this many times so it's not super simple
like these are three new lines of code I
need to write and rather understand but
it's already a little simpler and more
compact than my if and my L if and my
ORS and my ands and all of that Boolean
logic it's handling a lot of this for me
so if I didn't make any mistakes let me
run python now of meows.pi enter and I
did make a mistake here I did make a
mistake what's what's wrong here now
what's wrong well I definitely didn't
run it the way I intend so dash n three
enter so it does work but if I don't
cooperate this actually seems to be a
worst version if I don't pass in dash n
in a number it just errors with a type
error it must be a string none is what
came back so there's clearly an error
here but the library is more flexible I
can actually provide some documentation
on how to use this thing so how do I
know how to use this well typically it's
conventional in Python and in a lot of
programming environments to run a
program with a special argument Dash H
or dash dash help and almost always I
will claim you'll then see some kind of
usage information indeed that's what I'm
looking at now I just ran python of
meows.pi space Dash H I'll do it again
let me clear my screen and this time do
dash dash help in English enter and I
see the same thing it's not very useful
at the moment it just shows me what the
usage is up here and this is kind of
interesting this is a standard syntax
and Community Computing and we've kind
of seen it in Python's documentation
before this just means that the
program's name is of course meows.pi
square brackets as almost always in
documentation means it's optional so I
don't have to type Dash H but I can I
don't have to type dash n and another
value but I can and then down here is
some explanation of these options and
more reversely showing me that I can
also do dash dash help and not just Dash
H but this is so generic this has
nothing to do with my program this is
not going to help my users when I
actually release this software for the
world so let me go ahead and improve it
let me add a description to my argument
parser that the humans will see meow
like a cat quote unquote is going to be
the value of this named parameter called
description and let me also add a help
parameter to my dash n argument that
just explains what Dash N means number
of times to meow quote unquote I'm not
going to change anything else but I am
going to go back to my terminal window
and run python of meow I'm going to run
python of meows.pi Dash H or
equivalently dash dash help and now
notice that this is a little more user
friendly if I scroll up we still see the
same usage but there's a quick sentence
in English of explanation that this
program meows like a cat and if I look
at the options now oh that's what N
means it's the number of times to meow
and this Capital end a metal variable if
you will is just indicating to me that I
need to type a number by convention
after the lowercase dash n
so it would be nice though all that said
if my program still didn't just break
when I run it without any command line
arguments right ideally my program would
handle this just like my manual version
did when I used sys.orgv myself so we
just need to add a little more
functionality to this library and if I
read the documentation I'll see that add
argument takes yet another named
argument if you want you can specify a
default value for dash n for instance
one and I'll do that there and you can
further specify that it's got to be an
INT and what this will additionally
allow me to do is if I tell Arc parser
to make sure that the value of dash n is
an INT I don't need to do the conversion
manually I can just trust down on line
seven that when I access the property
called n inside of my args object it's
going to be automatically an INT for me
and again this is the value of a library
it let it do all of the work for you so
you can get back to focusing on the
interesting project at hand whatever
problem it is you're trying to solve
like in this case granted not that
interesting but meowing like a cat let
me go ahead now and run python of
meows.pi and hit enter this time
no arguments and now it meows why
because I specified that if I don't as a
user specify dash n it's going to have a
default value of 1 apparently and I
don't have to convert that value from a
stir to an end because I told our parser
please just make this an INT for me
any questions now on artparse or really
this principle of just Outsourcing the
commodity stuff the stuff that
everyone's program eventually needs to
do so that you can focus on the juicy
part yourself what does that and contain
what does args.n contain it contains the
integer that the human typed after a
space after dash n
a good question other questions
yeah did uh uh the the when you specify
the type
um for the argument
uh what happens if does that basically
handle the exception if if the user
inputs a string in this case a really
good question suppose that the human
does not type a number and therefore not
an in well let's see what happens so
python of meows.pi dash n dog it's where
dog is obviously not a number enter and
voila we see an automatically generated
error message little cryptic admittedly
but I'm seeing a reminder of what the
usage is and a minor explanation of what
is invalid about this and again this is
what allows you this is what allows me
to like focus on writing the actual code
we care about and just letting the
library automate some of this stuff for
us all right well allow me to propose
now that we take a look at one other
feature of python that we've seen before
but it turns out we can use it even more
powerfully as our programs become more
sophisticated and the problems we're
trying to solve themselves become more
involved let me go ahead and re turn to
vs code closing out meows.pi and
creating a new file for instance called
unpack dot Pi so code of unpack dot pi
and let me just remind us like what we
mean by unpacking because this is
actually a feature of python that we've
seen before for instance suppose that I
write a program that prompts the user
for their name like David space Malin
wouldn't it be nice if we could record a
sort of split the user's name into two
separate variables and when we've done
this in the past we've done it in a few
different ways but one of them involved
unpacking a single value uh that comes
back from that like a list or some other
data structure and putting it
immediately into two variables so let's
do this here let me go ahead and call
the input function asking someone what's
your name question mark then let me go
ahead and just split a little naively on
a single space so I'm assuming that the
only users at the moment are people like
me David space Malin no middle names no
multiple names it's just one and two
which itself could be buggy for other
users but for now I'm keeping it simple
just to remind us that I can now unpack
that return value with something like
first underscore last equals the return
value of input and now I can go ahead
and do something like this like printing
out with an F string hello comma and
then curly braces first if I just want
to greet myself or any other user is
hello David without the last name and
frankly if I'm not using the last name
recall that a python convention is just
to name it underscore to make clear that
you know you're not using that value but
it does need to be there because you're
unpacking two values at once so if I run
this it won't be all that unfamiliar I'm
just going to run now python of
unpack.pi I'll type in David Malin which
has a single space and there we have it
hello comma David well it turns out that
there's other ways to unpack values and
there's other features that python
offers especially when it comes to
defining and using functions and this is
slightly more intermediate functionality
if you will that's useful because you
can start to write even more elegant and
Powerful code once you get comfortable
with syntax like this so let me go ahead
and propose that we not just play with
Hello uh uh hello names anymore but
instead do something maybe involving
some coinage again so maybe not dollars
and cents but maybe again as in the past
some galleons and sickles and Canucks
with among which there's a mathematical
relationship as to how many of those in
the Wizarding World equal each other and
let me go ahead and do this let me
Define a simple function called total
that just tells me the total value of
someone's vault in Gringotts The
Wizarding Bank based on how many
galleons sickles and Canucks that they
have which again are currencies from The
Wizarding World as opposed to our actual
human world so this total function might
take a variable like galleons and
sickles and Canucks like this and then
it's going to return the formula which I
admittedly had to look up myself and it
turns out that the formula for
converting galleons and sickles to
canuts would be this galleons times 17
plus sickles then times all of that by
29 and then add in the individual
Canucks not sure in what detail this
came up in the books or movies but here
we have it the official formula all
right now let's go ahead and do this let
me go ahead and call the total function
with just some sample inputs suppose
that someone like Harry has a hundred
galleons 50 sickles and 25 canuts let me
go ahead and print that out on the
screen all right well if total returns
an integer which I think this arithmetic
expression will do let me go ahead and
store rather pass the return value of
total to print and then just for clarity
let me write Canucks at the end so I
know that the unit of measure here is
indeed canutz in total all right now let
me go ahead in my terminal window and
run python of unpack.pi and hit enter
and it turns out mathematically that if
I got my math correct a hundred galleons
plus 50 sickles plus uh 25 cannuts
equals in total 50
775 Canucks just avoiding having to use
our own human currency here but I'm not
doing anything along the lines of
unpacking at least just yet let me
propose now that I do this just for the
sake of discussion let me propose that I
leave the total function as is but let
me go ahead and just store all of my
coins in a list so coins in order from
left to right
150 25 it just because for whatever
purposes in this story I have all of my
coinage in a list in this order kind of
a purse or wallet of sorts well how can
I pass this in well I'm not going to
hard code the same values twice just for
the sake of discussion how could I pass
in the individual elements of a list to
my total function well of course I could
treat this list as I always do using
numeric indices by doing coins bracket
zero coins bracket one coins bracket two
so this is old school stuff with lists
if I've got a list called coins and
there's three elements the indices or
indexes of those elements are 0 1 and 2
respectively from left to right so all
I'm doing here now is passing in the
first element from that list as galleons
the second element of that list as
sickles and the third element of this
list as Mike nuts and that lines up with
of course the signature of this function
which as total expects that I've passed
in those three things in that order left
to right all right let me go ahead and
run just make sure I haven't broken
anything unpack.pi and hit enter and the
math still checks out
but this is getting a little verbose a
little verbose and wouldn't it be nice
if I could just pass the list of coins
to this total function wouldn't it be
nice if I could just say something like
this coins
but let me pause and ask the group why
would this not actually work as is
it technically is passing in all three
but why would I get some kind of error
when I run this Eric uh because you are
passing a list to galleons yeah I'm
passing a list to galleons and nothing
for sickles and Canucks and notice those
don't have default values there's no
equal signs on that first line of code
which means Python's not going to know
what value should be assumed there so it
just seems like it's not going to work
plus it's the wrong type as Eric notes
it's a list and it's not an integer as
it was before so let's actually run this
incorrect version python of unpacked.pi
enter type error and that is probably
what you might expect like I'm messing
up with the types here and I re I'm
required to pass in two positional
arguments sickles and Canucks that were
not even passed so I've definitely aired
here but it certainly seems unfortunate
if the only solution to this is to do
what I previously did which is index
into the first element index into the
second element index into the third like
you can imagine with bigger fancier
functions that take even more argument
it's this is going to get very verbose
and honestly very vulnerable potentially
to just mistakes typos on my part but
here too is where you can do what's
known again as unpacking a value in
Python right now a list is kind of
packed with multiple values my current
list has these three values 150 and 25
respectively but they're all packed up
in this one list wouldn't it be nice if
I could unpack that list just like I
previously unpacked the return value of
the stir classes split function into
multiple things too and indeed I can do
just that python actually allows me to
pass in not coins but
Star Coins so if you use a single
asterisk at the beginning of your
variable that will unpack it and it will
take one sequence in this case coins of
size 3 and explode it if you will unpack
it into three individual arguments no
commas are needed python just handles
this for you but the effect of passing
in Star Coins is to pass in the
individual members of that list which in
this case are going to be 150 and 25
respectively which is perfect because
now it's going to line up with galleons
sickles Canucks respectively so now when
I run python of unpack.pi we're back in
business and the math checks out but
I've kind of cleaned up my code by just
introducing this new symbol which we've
used of course in other contexts for
multiplication and the like but now it's
also used for unpacking in this way
questions on what we've just done it's a
single operator but it's already quite
powerful because it allows us to take a
data structure and unpack it and pass it
in individually
does that work for um uh
tuples sets dicks dictionaries
as well tuples yes
sets I don't know wrong Shin I don't
know if order is preserved
no oh is that no it does not or you know
you're checking
order's not preserved so it wouldn't
work with set
does not work with set does not work
with set
sorry I'm verbally Googling here just to
save us some keystrokes so it would work
for
enumerations that where order is indeed
preserved and we'll see another example
in a moment where it actually can be
used in a different way for dictionaries
which nowadays do preserve order
other questions on unpacking in this way
yes hi hello how can you use unpacking
to get the value uh for example 10 plus
50 plus 25 uh instead of a for Loop and
then result plus short answer no if you
want the individual values you should be
just indexing in this case into those
specific locations
um this is returning multiple values the
equivalent of a comma separated list so
you would use the earlier approach if
you cared about the individual locations
how about one other question on
unpacking what if we have declared we we
declare some default values and if you
use these asterisk points will it work
right or will it
skip it good question if I heard you
right what if for instance the list has
four values like this here and you're
still unpacking it when it's only three
that's expected well let's try it python
of unpack dot Pi enter another type
error this time it takes three
positional arguments before we're given
so the onus is on us as the programmer
not to do that in this case so
potentially fragile but avoidable if I'm
controlling the contents of this list in
fact let me propose now that we take a
look at another variant of this whereby
we use not just positional uh arguments
whereby we trust that the first is
galleons the second is sickles the third
is knuts suppose that we actually passed
in the names as we're allowed to do in
Python and then technically we could
pass them in in any order and python
would figure it out using named
parameters instead well how might I do
this well it's going to be a bit of a
regression at first so let me get rid of
this list here
let me change this now to just manually
pass in the values I care about galleons
I want to still equal 100 sickles I want
to equal 50 and Canucks I want to equal
25. so this is old school parameter
pressing it's no longer positional I'm
explicitly specifying the names of these
arguments but that's just going to work
because that's exactly what the names of
these parameters are in my total
function as before let's make sure I
nonetheless did not break anything let's
run python of uh of unpack.pi enter and
there we have it still 50 775 Canucks
well once you start giving things names
and values names and values that
probably should bring to mind one of our
most versatile data structures in Python
and even other languages that of a
dictionary remember that a dictionary is
just a collection of key value pairs
names and their respective values so
this kind of opens up an opportunity
what if if I did this what if I actually
had for some reason in my program on a
variable as before called coins but
instead of making it a list of three
values like before what if it's a proper
dictionary so what if it's galleons
quote unquote colon 100 for 100 of those
sickles quote unquote and 50 of those
and knuts quote unquote 25 of those each
of those separated by uh colons and let
me fix my square brackets to this time
be curly braces which recall is the
symbol we use for dictionaries or dict
objects in Python so now I have a
dictionary called coins not a list it's
a collection of keys and values three
keys galleons sickles canuts and three
values 150 25 respectively if I were to
now pass these individual values into my
total function I could do it as always
with my dictionary so I'm doing it old
school now coins is the name of my
dictionary I index into it not with
numbers like with lists but with words
so galleons strings like this coins
quote unquote sickles in square brackets
there and then lastly coins square
brackets quote unquote Canucks so it's
getting it's verbose again like this is
not maybe the best road to go down but
we'll backpedal in a moment this is just
how if you happen to have all of your
coins stored in a dictionary you could
pass the Galleon sickles and canuts into
your function respectively let's make
sure I didn't break anything let's rerun
python of unpack.pi and we're still good
now how could we get to a situation like
this well as always imagine this
program's a little longer than this one
here and somehow you're using a
dictionary maybe just to keep track of
someone's purse or wallet like how many
coins of each type that they have and as
such it's perfectly reasonable to use a
dictionary but then you want to print
out the total and darn it if that total
function does not expect a dictionary so
you cannot just do something nice and
simple like pass in coin for reasons we
saw earlier that would be a type error
total expects three arguments three
integers you can't just pass in a
dictionary but if that's the data
structure you're using to store the
person's purse or wallet well it's kind
of unfortunate that we have this clash
between these data types well here's
what we can do we can't pass in coins
because watch if I try doing that and
run python of unpack.pi we're getting
another type error missing two required
positional arguments sickles and Canucks
I have to pass in three things but
wonderfully python allows you to unpack
dictionaries as well for a dictionary
you don't use a single asterisk you use
two and what this syntax has the effect
of doing is passing in three values with
names it has the effect of passing in
galleons equals 100 comma sickles equals
50 comma Canucks equals 25 and so it has
the similar effect to the list unpacking
but that just passed in the values 150
25 separated by commas in effect when
unpacking a dictionary it passes in the
keys and the values separated
conceptually with equal signs just like
our function expects so if I now run
python of unpack.pi again we're still
good but we've tightened our code up
again and now I'm giving myself yet
another option I can either store a
Wizard's Purser or uh wallets in there
in a list as we did earlier or I can
store it a little more versus with even
more specificity using a dictionary
instead and so to be clear let me rewind
star star coins is the same thing if I
rewind a little bit to our first example
of named arguments is equivalent to what
I've highlighted here when you unpack a
dictionary it passes in all of the keys
and all of the values much like the
syntax here but let me tighten it up and
go to where we left off questions now on
unpacking can we have a in this
dictionary can we have instead of having
a constant name value pair can we have a
variable number of you know name value
pairs short answer yes you can have more
than three key value pairs as I have
here but it's not going to work
unpacking it if the total function is
expecting only three so if I were to add
something here like let me introduce
pennies to The Wizarding World and
suppose I have one penny for instance
and now I run this same code python of
uh unpack.pi we're back to a type error
again whereby I got an unexpected
keyword argument pennies because that is
not expected by the total function we
will see in just a moment wonderfully a
solution though to that but for now it
does not work
other questions on unpacking with
dictionaries or lists in list English
values we get the same number of
arguments and we declared a default
value in the function now if you use
this as trick will it overwrite that
value or will it skip it skip the
default value a good question if you if
we did have default values up here for
instance equals zero equals zero equals
zero the upside of that recall from our
discussion of arguments to functions a
while back is that now you don't have to
pass in all of those values they will
default to those zeros therefore you
could pass in fewer than three values
either using a list or a dictionary
that's unpacked in this scenario I
deliberately did not do that because I
wanted us to encounter this specific
error in this case but you could
absolutely go back and add those
defaults
so it turns out that this single
asterisk or this double asterisk is not
only used in the context of unpacking
that same syntax is actually used as a
visual indicator in Python when a
function itself might very well take a
variable number of arguments that is to
say a function can be very attic which
means that it doesn't necessarily have
to take say three arguments specifically
even if they do or don't have default
values it can take maybe zero or one or
two or three and it turns out the Syntax
for implementing the same idea is quite
similar in spirit in fact let me go back
to vs code here and let me propose that
we start over with this code and get rid
of our notion of galleons and sickles
and Canucks and do something just a
little more generic just so that we've
seen the Syntax for this suppose that I
Define a function as follows Define a
function let's call it f and that
function is not going to take a specific
number of arguments but a variable one
and so I'm going to go ahead and use
this syntax here star args which
indicates that that this function is
indeed very attic it takes some variable
number of positional arguments
positional in the sense that they go
typically from left to right but I don't
know how many just yet I want to support
suppose that I additionally want to
support some number of keyword arguments
that is named parameters that can be
called optionally and individually by
their own name well the convention
syntactically here would be to use two
stars and then kwrs I could call args or
KW args anything else that I want but a
convention you'll frequently see in
Python's own documentation is that when
you have placeholders like this for some
number of arguments and some number of
keyword arguments the world tends to use
args and Key kwrgs Well inside of this
function let's do something super simple
just for now let me go ahead and print
out literally quote unquote positional
just to indicate to myself while
wrapping my mind around what's going on
here what the positional arguments are
and let me quite simply print out those
args this is not something you would
typically do you you don't typically
just take in these arguments and print
them no matter how many there are I'm
just doing this diagnostically for now
to show you how this syntax works now
let me go ahead at the bottom of my file
and I won't bother with a main function
this time so we can focus only on this
function f let me go ahead and just call
F with three arguments I'll use the same
arguments as before but I didn't bother
giving them names just yet like galleons
and sickles and Canucks and the like so
what do I have
a program that no matter what calls this
function f but it first defines F at the
top of the file is taking some number of
positional arguments some number of
named arguments and for the moment I'm
just printing out the positional ones
let me go ahead and in my terminal
window run python of unpack.pi and hit
enter and you'll see that the positional
arguments passed in are apparently this
a sequence
150 25 but notice this if I clear my
terminal window there and pass in
something else like five a fourth
argument previously if I try to change
the number of arguments I'm passing in
to my total function which was only
defined as taking three I would have
gotten a type error some visual
indication that no you can't pass in
more or fewer arguments than is actually
in the function's definition but now
watch if I run python of unpack.pi this
time passing in 150 25 and 5 a fourth
argument all four of those went through
just fine I can get rid of all of those
but one for instance now rerun my
program after clearing my screen and now
I'll see just one argument here and even
though there's a comma and nothing after
it this is actually the syntax when
seeing a tuple in effect whereby The
Comma just indicates this is indeed a
list but there's only one element
therein well let's get a little more
curious too let me go ahead and Rewind
here to where we started with just those
three values and this time let me go
ahead and print out my named argument so
to speak which is an args but KW args
again the positional arcs in this syntax
come first the named arguments KW arcs
come second that's what python
prescribes so now let me go ahead and
not pass in just these numbers let me go
ahead and pass in actually named
arguments so let me do something now
more specifically like galleons equals
100 and sickles equals 50 and nuts
equals 25. I'm not going to bother doing
any math with total I just want to poke
around right now at this functionality
of having a variable number of arguments
and what's neat now is if I run python
of unpack.pi and hit enter no problem
what kwrx is is automatically a
dictionary that contains all of the
named arguments that were passed to my
function which is to say when designing
your own functions if you want to
support more than one argument maybe
more than two or three or four maybe a
variable number of arguments indeed you
can support both a variable number of
positional arguments that are just value
comma value comma value or any number of
named arguments where you actually put
the name of the parameter equals the
value and then maybe a comma and some
more of the same
so now it turns out we have seen this
before in some of the functions we've
used to date we didn't necessarily see
it called args or necessarily see it
called KW args but we have seen at least
one example of this in the wild recall
our old friend print which we've been
using now for weeks and when we first
looked at the documentation for print
way back when it looked a little
something like this the first argument
to print was objects and I waved my hand
at the time at the asterisk that was at
the start of that variable name but then
we had sep for separator the default
value of which was a space we had n the
default value of which was a new line
and then some other named arguments that
we waved our hands at then and I'll
again do now but what you can now
perhaps infer from our emphasis on these
asterisks today the single stars or the
double stars is the you know what this
is the convention in Python's
documentation to indicate that print
takes a variable number of arguments so
if we were to look at the actual
implementation of the print function
implemented by Python's own authors it
might very well look something like this
def print and then the first argument
would be star objects thereby indicating
that print takes a variable number of
arguments the next one of which might be
sep equals quote unquote either using
double quotes or as in the documentation
single quotes two the next one of which
might be n the default value of which is
a new line and then some of those other
named arguments that we've not looked at
as well and then maybe inside of the
print function implemented by the
authors of python maybe there's a for
Loop like for object in objects that
allows them to iterate over each of
those variable number of objects and
print each of them and this is why apply
in programs past you and I have been
able to do just print open parenthesis
close parenthesis with nothing inside or
you and I have been able to print out
something like Hello World a single
string inside of those parentheses or
you and I have been able to do a single
string hello and then another string
quote unquote World thereby passing in
two arguments or even more so we've long
had this ability to use variatic ARC
functions whereby you can pass in a
variable number of arguments what you
now have via this args and KW Arc syntax
but again they do not need to be called
that is the ability using that star or
two stars to implement those kinds of
functions yourself
my own F function a moment ago did not
do anything all that interesting but it
hints at how you could if in the future
you have a use case for taking zero or
one or more of either type of arguments
any questions now
on these types of arguments
what will happen if you print quarks and
the argument is
like a lift
ah so what would happen if you print the
argument like it's a list so I think we
saw that if I roll back in my history
here
to when I had that F function which I
called f just to be very generic just so
we could play around with the syntax
this is what I had here so this is a um
I passed in 100 comma 50 comma 25 that
gets automatically stored in args and
when I run it you can actually see that
sequence of values by running python of
unpack.pi there is that sequence all in
the form of one single variable I'm
printing it just for Diagnostic purposes
this is not really a useful or pretty
program but it hints at how we can
access that whole sequence of values
other questions
on this approach here can we pass KW
args from one function to another
function absolutely you can pass either
of those to another function which you
might want to do if you want to wrap
another function provide some additional
functionality but still pass in all of
the supported arguments to the
underlying function as well
[Music]
how about this next it turns out that a
few other tools we can add to your tool
kit relate to the types of programming
models that python supports we started
out quite some time ago focusing really
on procedural programming in Python
whereby we wrote code top to bottom left
to right defining some functions or if
you will procedures along the way
defining variables and having side
effects and assigning values as needed
but we then eventually introduced or
really revealed that python is also very
much object oriented and a lot of those
variables a lot of those types that
we're using all that time were in fact
objects objects that were came from
certain classes and those classes were
templates of sorts blueprints via which
you could encapsulate both data and
functionality therein what we also saw
along the way some hints of a third
Paradigm of programming that python also
to some extended supports which is known
as functional programming whereby
functions are ever more powerful in that
they tend not to have side effects no
printing or changing of State globally
but rather they're completely
self-contained and might take as inputs
and return values and that's generally a
paradigm we saw when we started sorting
things particularly with functions like
our sort function or Lambda function
when we passed in the function we wanted
to use to sort a list way back when well
it turns out python has other
functionality that is reminiscent of
functional programming and indeed is a
powerful way to solve problems a little
more differently still let me propose
this let me propose that I whip up a new
program here in vs code by closing our
unpacked up high and this time creating
another program called yell suppose the
goal at hand is to implement some
program that allows the user to pass in
input and then it yells the response by
forcing everything to uppercase my
apologies to those with with headphones
there I'll I'll modulate so let me go
ahead and run code of yell dot pi and
within yell.pi let's go ahead and
Implement a program that really does
just that let's go ahead and Define a
main function up here and let's assume
for the moment that this yell function
already exists and yells something like
this is cs50 properly capitalized not in
all caps now let's go ahead and
implement this yell function with def
yell that's going to take for now a
single uh word or phrase and let's go
ahead and I'll call it phrase here and
I'm going to go ahead and just print out
the phrase Dot Upper so phrase Dot Upper
is going to force the whole thing to
uppercase and as usual down here if the
name of this file equals equals quote
unquote main then let's go ahead as
always and call Main so let's just run
this but for the most part it should be
fairly straightforward when I run python
of yell dot Pi this is cs50 is yelled on
the screen all right that's nice but
it's not great that yell only expects a
single uh is expects a single phrase
wouldn't it be nice like print if I
could pass in one phrase or two or three
or really multiple words more generally
but as individual words themselves so
let me retool this a little bit and
change yell to take in not a phrase but
how about something like a list of words
so that ultimately I can call Yell like
this uh quotes unquote this inside of a
list quote unquote this inside of a list
and quote unquote cs50 inside of a list
I'm not going to bother with type hints
or annotations for now but I'll just
assume that Yale has been defined now as
taking a list of words as defined here
but now I want to force them all to
lowercase so I don't quite want to do
something as simple as this like for
word in words I could for instance print
that given word and maybe end the line
with nothing right now but I think if I
do this python of yell dot Pi no that's
that's not right I haven't forced
anything to uppercase so let's fix this
well let's go ahead and do the following
let me go ahead and accumulate the
uppercase words as follows let me create
a variable called uppercased and
initialize it to an empty list using
square brackets or or more verbose list
syntax and now let me go ahead and
iterate over each of those words in
Words
and for each of them let's go into our
upper cased list a pen to it the current
words uppercase version so this is a way
of creating a new list called uppercased
that is just appending appending
appending to that list each of the
current words in the loop but uppercased
instead and now just let me go ahead and
print out the uppercase list this isn't
quite right let's see what happens here
python of yell dot Pi okay it's not
quite right because I don't think I want
those quotes or those square brackets
what am I seeing I'm actually printing a
list but but but here's where some of
our unpacking syntax now can be useful I
don't have to change my approach to this
problem I can just unpack uppercase by
adding a single star and now let me go
ahead and rerun python of yell dot pi
and now it's actually just English
there's no remnants of python syntax
like the quotes and the commas and the
square brackets I've now unpacked this
is C ps50 as three separate arguments to
print so already now this unpacking
technique would seem to be useful well
it's a little unfortunate that I now
need to call Yell though with a list of
values in this way this is just not the
norm or at least it's not nearly as user
friendly as something like the print
function where I can pass in zero or one
or two or three or any number of
arguments why are you making me for your
yell function pass in only a list well
we can do better let's adopt some of the
new conventions we've learned and let's
go ahead and get rid of the list by
removing the square brackets and let's
just pass Yale three arguments now I
don't want to do something like change
the definition of words to take in like
word one word two or like that's not
going to scale and it's not going to
handle different number of words but we
have a technique now we can say star
args which will allow the yell function
to accept any number of arguments and
just for specificity let's not call it
generically arcs let's name it something
a little more self-explanatory like star
words this just means I have a variable
number of words being passed in now I
think I've made a marginal Improvement
let me run this again python of yell dot
Pi this is cs50 is in all caps but it's
just a little better right because now I
can treat yell just like I've long
treated print pass in as many things as
you want and print will deal with it now
my yell function is just as powerful it
would seem and better still it also
forces everything to uppercase well it
turns out python comes with this
function called map whose purpose in
life is to allow you to map that is
apply some function to every element of
some sequence like a list so for
instance if we want to force to
uppercase each of the words this is cs50
in the list of words that's been passed
in well we essentially want to map the
uppercase function to each of those
values so using map and python can I do
just that let me go back here to vs code
vote and let me propose now that I
re-implement this as follows I get rid
of all three of these lines here getting
rid of that Loop in particular let me
still declare a variable called
uppercased but let me set it equal to
the return value of this new function
called map map takes two arguments here
in this case the name of a function that
I want to map onto a sequence of values
well what function do I want to apply to
every word that's been passed in well it
turns out thanks to my knowledge now of
object oriented programming I know that
in the stir class there is a function
called upper we've usually called it by
using the name of a string variable Dot
Upper open paren close paren but if you
read the documentation for the stir
class you'll see that the function is
described indeed as stir Dot Upper I'm
not using parentheses open and close at
the end of stir Dot Upper because I
don't want to call it now well I want to
pass this function to the map function
so that map can somehow add those
parentheses so to speak and call it on
every one of these words
and this is what map does quite
powerfully and is an instance indeed of
functional programming whereby I'm
passing to this map function another
function not calling it I'm just passing
it in by a reference of sorts and what
map is going to do for me is iterate
over each of those words call stir Dot
Upper on each of those words and return
to me a brand new list containing all of
those results together in one list it
completely obviates the need for me to
do this more manually using that list
I'm still going to print the whole thing
using star uppercase so that if I get
back a three a list of three uppercase
words I'm gonna unpack them and print
them all out so let's run this again
python of yell dot Pi enter and voila
it's still working but the code now is
even more tight even tighter than before
so it turns out there's another way we
can solve this problem in a way that's
even more pythonic or at least quite
common and that that's using a feature
known as a list comprehension and it's a
big phrase if you will but it refers to
the ability in Python for you to very
easily construct a list on the fly
without using a loop without calling a
pen and a pen but to do everything in
one dare say elegant one-liner so how
can I go about using this notion of a of
a list comprehension well let me go
ahead and do this in yell.pi and vs code
here let me go ahead and change my
Approach as follows instead of using map
which is perfectly fine and correct in
this way let me just show you this other
way as well a list comprehension is the
opportunity to create a list like this
using square brackets like this but
inside of those square brackets to write
a python expression that in effect is
going to dynamically generate a brand
new list for you using some logic you've
written and the approach I might take
here is this if I want to store in this
list the uppercase version of every word
in that words list I can do this word
Dot Upper
for word in words now this is a mouthful
but I dare say python programmers love
this capability of being able to Define
on the fly a list inside of which is any
number of values that you would
ordinarily at least as we've done it
construct with a loop and again calling
append and a pen and append but that
usually takes two three four or more
lines this list comprehension that I've
highlighted here is now an alternative
way to create the exact same thing a
list inside of which are a whole bunch
of uppercased words which words for each
word in the words list that was passed
into yell is what ends up in this list
questions on this syntax here it
definitely takes a little bit of getting
used to because you've got like this
value on the left this function call
here you've got this Loop inside of the
square brackets but if you become
accustomed to reading the code in this
way from left to right this means give
me the uppercase version of the word for
each word in my words list
questions here on list comprehensions uh
can you do conditionals also like if
else or uh combine if L if else indeed
you can and let me come back to that
where we'll see an opportunity to do
things conditionally but for now I'm
just uppercasing every word in the list
a good question other questions yeah
um is this is this functional
programming or I mean this particular
thing
you're using words Dot Upper for word in
words not necessarily this is more of a
feature of python I would say yeah map
was uh one uh very specific incarnation
of there of our use of Lambda and
passing it in as a key attribute to the
sort function sorted function a while
back was an example and we're about to
see uh one other so we can even use
these list comprehensions to filter
values in or out of our resulting list
so in fact in vs code here let me close
l.pi and close my terminal window and
let me create a new program here whose
purpose in life maybe is to take a a
same list of students as before with a
shorter version thereof and just filter
out all of the students in Gryffindor so
let me go ahead and create a file called
gryffindors.pi I'm going to go ahead and
copy paste from before really my list of
students at least Hermione Harry Ron and
Draco from the start here just so that I
can focus on uh one student who happens
not to be from Slytherin and what I'm
going to do here now if I want to filter
out only the Gryffindor students let me
go ahead and do this let me create
another variable called gryffindors
which is going to equal the following
lists and this is going to be a bit of a
longer line so I'm going to proactively
move my square brackets onto two
separate lines and I'm going to create
now a list comprehension I want to do
this I want this new list called
gryffindors to contain every student's
name for each student in the students
list but but but if the student's house
equals equals quote unquote Gryffindor
so this is nearly identical in spirit to
what I just did earlier to create a list
comprehension out of each of the words
passed to my yell function but here I'm
doing so conditionally and so I'm
borrowing inspiration from our focus on
Loops borrowing some information
inspiration from our focus on uh
conditionals combining that into this
same square bracket notation so that
what gryffindors ultimately is is zero
or more students names and the names
that are included are the result of
iterating over each of those students
and only including in the final result
the students whose house happens to be
Gryffindor so when I go ahead and run
this with python of gryffindors.pi and
hit enter you'll see huh nothing
actually happened here well that's
because I didn't finish the program let
me go ahead and actually finish the
program with this how about for each
Gryffindor in gryffindor's plural and
better yet so that it's sensible that I
did all of this work in advance let me
go ahead and sort all of those names
with our familiar sorted function let's
go ahead now and print out each of these
gryffindors so now notice if familiar
with the books in the movies you'll know
that only three of these four students
are actually in Gryffindor and if I run
python of gryffindor.pi there we see
Harry Hermione and Ron butt now in
sorted order as well so that's just one
way we can solve this same problem using
not just a list comprehension but a list
comprehension that has this conditional
therein but there's yet other ways to
solve this same problem too and we come
back to some functional features of
python in addition to functions like Map
There's also this one called filter that
can be used to achieve the same effect
but with a more functional approach if
you will let me go back to vs code here
and with the same example let me do this
let me leave the original list up above
as before including Draco who's not in
fact from Gryffindor and let me
temporarily Define a function called is
Gryffindor that takes in as uh value
something like a student s and then
let's do this let's go ahead and say if
s quote unquote house equals equals
Gryffindor then go ahead and return true
otherwise go ahead and return false now
we've seen before conditionals like this
that are a bit unnecessarily verbose I
don't need to have a conditional if I'm
already asking a Boolean question up
here so I can actually tighten this up
as we've done in the past and just
return does the student's house equal
equal Gryffindor either it does and it's
true or it doesn't and it's false I
don't need to explicitly return true or
false I can just return the value of
that Boolean let's go ahead now and do
this I'm going to create as before a
variable called gryffindors a list for
all of my Gryffindor students that
equals to this time the result of
calling filter filter takes at least two
arguments here one of which is the name
of a function to call is Gryffindor and
I'm going to apply that function to each
of the elements of this sequence here so
similar in spirit to map I'm passing in
a function that's going to be applied to
each of the elements in the sequence but
map which turns one value for each
element in the sequence that's how we
forced all of the words to uppercase but
if I want to conditionally include a
student in my resulting gryffindor's
list I can use filter instead filter
expects its first function to be not
something like stir Dot Upper but a
function that returns true or false tell
me whether or not I should include or
not include the current student from the
final list and the question being asked
is do they live in Gryffindor we're
checking the dictionary's house key for
that answer and so ultimately I think
we'll be left with something quite
similar for Gryffindor
in the sorted ver let's do for
Gryffindor in gryffindors let's go ahead
then and print out the current students
Gryffindor name it's not going to be
sorted just yet but when I run this
version here python of gryffindors.pi
and hit enter we're back in business
it's unsorted but we have Hermione Harry
and Ron but not Draco and if you recall
from a few weeks back if we want to sort
even a list of dictionaries we can still
do that too I can call sorted on
gryffindors plural and I can pass in a
key and that key can have a Anonymous
function AKA a Lambda function that
takes in a student as input call it s
and then Returns the value s quote
unquote name if my goal is to sort by
indeed uh students own names if I go
ahead now and run
pythonofgriffendors.pi I see the same
list of students but this time it's
sorted so here we've seen two approaches
to this particular problem of Gryffindor
students whereby we can either use
something like a list comprehension and
in inside of that list comprehension do
a bit of filtration including an if
conditional as I did or we can take a
more functional approach by just using
this filter function passing into it the
function that I want to make these
decisions for me and then include only
those for whom true is returned any
questions on either of these two
approaches uh yeah I just had a question
that if we write the code like in the
previous version where everything is
stuffed into one like once the if we
check for the style of the code then
want it
don't have a problem with it because
it's less readable so with a formatter
like black have a problem with the style
of some of this code the previous one
where the everything was stopped into
one line oh a good question would
something like black have a problem with
this code well let me rewind to that
version which was using the somewhat
longer uh list comprehension which looks
like if we go far enough back
give me a few more undo's which looked
like this ultimately let me go ahead and
run black on gryffindors.pi and you'll
see that I actually it reformatted ever
so slightly but I proactively fix this
myself had I done this and done it on
just one line but I knew that black
might not like that it would have fixed
it for me so I just proactively fixed it
before writing the code myself how about
time for one other question on
gryffindors.pi and this approach of
using a list comprehension or filter
yeah when when using filter instead of
calling the function is Griffin there
can you use it right there inside filter
can you use the function is Gryffindor
so you don't want to call it like this
because you don't want to call it then
you want filter to call the function for
you if that's what you mean so I pass it
in only by its name instead
no I mean if you can write the return as
is SQL script in the inside yes indeed
in fact so recall that we indeed use
these Lambda functions way back when
when we wanted to pass in a quick and
dirty function anonymously to allow
sorted to filter by a different key of a
dictionary we can do that here I can
actually take the essence of this is
Gryffindor function I can change the
name of this function in my filter call
to be another Lambda function passing in
an argument like s and returning exactly
that I can now delete my is Gryffindor
function all together and now when I run
python of gryffindors.pi I still get the
same answer and I've not bothered
defining a function only to then use it
in one and only one place
well let me propose too that we equip
you with one other tool for your toolkit
namely dictionary comprehensions as well
and admittedly the syntax is starting to
get even weirder but as you get more
comfortable with all of these Primitives
and others these are just tools that you
can optionally but perhaps powerfully
use to solve future problems down the
road and with a dictionary comprehension
we have the ability to create on the fly
a dictionary with keys and some values
without having to do it sort of old
school by come creating an empty
dictionary and creating a for Loop and
iterating over that Loop and inserting
more and more keys and values into the
dictionary we can rather do it all at
once so in fact let me go back to vs
code here and let me propose now that I
do this let me go ahead and initially do
it the old-fashioned way here as follows
let me go ahead and simplify and get rid
of the houses all together so that we
can focus for now just on a list of
students names I'm going to go ahead and
run students I'm going to go ahead and
write students e equals quote unquote
terminal quote unquote Harry and we'll
keep it even shorter this time quote
unquote Ron only those three students in
Gryffindor I'm going to now proactively
as we've done in the past give myself an
empty list so that I have something to
accumulate some answers to this problem
in and now I'm going to do something
like this for student and students so I
can iterate over each of them let's go
ahead and with the gryffindors list
append to it the name of the student so
quote unquote name and then student
which is indeed their name from that
list and now let's go ahead and just put
these students all in Gryffindor I know
these three students are in Gryffindor
so suppose that the problem at hand is
that I want to build up a list of
dictionaries that only contains the
Gryffindor students so it's sort of a
step back from the previous version
where I already had the names and the
houses for now just assume that the
problem is I have all of their names but
I don't yet have the student
dictionaries themselves so I'm
rebuilding that same structure that I
previously took for granted now now
let's go ahead and just for the sake of
discussion just print out these
gryffindors so we can see what we've
built if I run python of gryffindors.pi
in my prompt I see a bit of a cryptic
syntax but again look for our little
hints I've got a square bracket at the
end and a square bracket at the
beginning and that indicates as always
this is a list I then I have a whole
bunch of curly braces with a whole bunch
of quoted keys they happen to be single
quotes by convention when using print on
a dictionary but that's just a visual
indicator that that is my key and the
first value thereof is Hermione second
key is a house this value thereof is
Gryffindor then there's a comma which
separates one object from the
next and if we look past Harry and
Gryffindor there's a second comma which
separates Harry and Gryffindor from Ron
and Gryffindor as well so in short here
is some code whereby I fairly manually
built up with a for Loop in an otherwise
initially empty list the same data
structure as before minus Draco just for
Gryffindor students but here's where
again with dictionary comprehensions or
really list comprehensions first can we
do this a little more succinctly Let Me
Clear My terminal window let's get rid
of this initially empty list and this
for Loop that appends appends appends to
it and let's just do this a gryffindor's
variable will equal the following list
comprehension inside of that list I want
a dictionary structured with someone's
name and their name so someone's house
and only for now Gryffindor and that's
it but I want one of these
objects here in these curly braces for
each student in students
so here too inside of my list
comprehension with my square brackets I
want an object as indicate I want a
dictionary as indicated by the curly
braces I want each of those dictionaries
to have two keys name and house
respectively the values thereof are the
student's name from earlier here and
Gryffindor only which students do I want
to create those dict objects from well
for student and students so again on the
left I have what I want in the final
list and on the right I have a loop and
this time no conditional I want all of
these students in Gryffindor as their
house now let's print this again python
of gryffindors.pi and hit enter and now
we have the exact same output so instead
of three lines it's just one it's a
little more cryptic to read at first
glance but once familiar with list
comprehensions and this sort of syntax
it's just another way of solving that
same problem what if I want to change
this and simplify what if I don't want a
list of dictionaries which I now have
again per the square brackets I have a
list of three objects here what
if I just want one bigger dictionary
inside of which is a key like Hermione
colon Gryffindor Harry colon Gryffindor
Ron colon Gryffindor I don't need a list
I don't need separate objects per
student I just want instead one big
dictionary where the keys are the
students names and the values of their
house and I'm assuming for now no one's
going to have the same first name in
this world well I can do this let me get
rid of this here and not create a list
comprehension but again this thing known
as a dictionary comprehension and the
visual indicator or difference here is
that instead of being square brackets on
the very outside this time it's going to
be curly braces instead so inside of
these curly braces what do I want every
key to be I want every key to be the
student's name I want every value for
now to be Gryffindor and I want to do
this for each student in students and
now things are getting really
interesting and this is another
manifestation of python in some views
being very readable from left to right
absolutely takes practice and comfort
but this is creating a variable called
Gryffindor which is going to be a
dictionary per these curly braces every
key is going to be the name of some
student every value is going to be
Gryffindor what names of what students
well this dictionary comprehension will
be constructed from the list of students
one at a time so when I print this now
the syntax will look a little different
because it's not a list of dictionary
objects it's just one bigger dictionary
object itself but now printing
gryffindors gives me Hermione colon
Gryffindor Harry colon Gryffindor and
Ron colon Gryffindor as well
any questions now on what we've called
dictionary comprehensions as well
[Music]
any questions on here
no well let's introduce one other
function from Python's toolkit followed
by one final feature and flourish and
then you're off on your way well let's
go ahead and think back to this recall
some time ago that we had just a simple
list of students as we have here
Hermione Harry and Ron and for instance
way back when we wanted to print out for
instance their ranking from one to two
to three unfortunately when you do
something like this for student and
students you can print out the student's
name quite easily of course if I do
python of gryffindors.pi I get Hermione
Harry Ron in that same order but I don't
see any numerical rank I see no number
one two or three so I could maybe do
this with maybe a different type of for
Loop instead of this why don't I try
this so maybe I could do 4 I in the
range of the length of the students list
and we've done something like this
before and then I could print out I and
I could print out the student's name by
indexing into that list at location I
well what does this look like if I run
python of gryffindors.pi it's close but
you know these aren't programmers they
don't necessarily think of themselves as
zero index Termini probably wants to be
first not zero so how can we fix this
well just a little bit of arithmetic I
could print out I plus 1 of course and
then the student's name so if I clear my
terminal window and run python of
gryffindors.pi once more now we have
this enumeration one two three of each
of these students but it turns out that
python actually has had all this time
another built-in function that you might
Now find useful that is namely enumerate
and enumerate allows you to solve this
kind of problem much more simply by
iterating over some sequence but finding
out not each value one at a time but
both the value one at a time and the
index thereof it gives you back two
answers at once so if I go back to vs
code here now and take this approach I
don't need to do this this complicated
range and length and then I all over the
place I can more succinctly do this I
can say for I comma student in the
enumerate
return value passing in students so this
gives me back an enumeration if you will
and now I can go about printing I plus 1
as before and I can print out the
student so I don't need to index into
the list with bracket I notation I don't
need to call range I don't need to call
length again enumerate takes a sequence
of values like these students and it
allows me to get back the current index
0 1 2 and the current value Hermione
Harry Ron respectively so now just
tighten things up further and indeed
that's been our theme here can we solve
the same problems as we've been solving
for weeks but tighten things up using
just more of this toolkit
allow us to equip you with one final
tool for your toolkit namely this
ability to generate values in Python
from functions this is not a problem
that we've necessarily encountered
before but it turns out if you're
writing a function that reads or
generates lots of data your function
your program your computer might very
well run out of memory and your program
might not be able to run any further but
it turns out there's a solution to this
problem that's something you might have
in your back pocket particularly if
after this course you start crunching
quite a few numbers and analyzing all
the more data in fact let's go back to
vs code here and let's go ahead and
create a program that's perhaps timely
at this time of day particularly
depending on your time zone you might be
feeling all the more sleepy but here in
the US it's quite common to be lull to
sleep when you're struggling otherwise
by counting sheep in your head and
typically as depicted in cartoons you
might see in your mind's eye one sheep
jumping over a fence and then two and
then three sheep and then four and then
eventually you presumably get so bored
counting these sheep you actually do
fall asleep so in vs code here let's
create a a program called sleep.pi that
allows me to print out some number of
sheep as though I'm counting them in my
mind's eye and Via this program let's do
this let's prompt the user for a
variable n setting it equal to the
integer conversion of the return value
of input asking the user what's n for
how many sheep do they want to try
counting and then let's do a familiar
for Loop here and we'll start counting
from zero as always so we'll first have
zero sheep then one sheep then two sheep
and so on for I in the range of that
value n Go ahead and print out and I'll
paste here an emoji representing a sheep
times I so the first iteration I'll see
Zero sheep the second iteration I'll see
one and then two and then however many
specified by n ultimately minus one all
right let's go down into my terminal
window here and run python of sleep.pi
and I should see indeed after typing in
say 3 for my value of n zero sheep then
one sheep then two sheep and so forth
and if I make my terminal window even
bigger here we can of course do many
more than this typing in for instance 10
and you'll see that we get more and more
sheep as time passes presumably becoming
all the more tedious to Envision in my
mind's eye so let's now go ahead and
practice what we've been preaching when
it comes to the design of this program
and see if and when we actually run into
a problem let me go ahead here now and
put all of this in a main function by
defining main up here as always let me
go ahead and indent all of this code
here and then let me just do this
conditionally as always if the name of
this file equals equals quote unquote
main let's go ahead and call Main let's
make sure I didn't break anything just
yet even though functionally this should
be nearly the same and if I type in
three I still have zero then one then
two sheep on the screen but we've been
in the habit of course of creating
helper functions for ourselves that is
factoring our code in a way that allows
us to abstract away certain
functionality like generating some
number of sheep into separate functions
so that one they're indeed abstracted
and we no longer have to think about how
they're implemented and we can even
reuse them in projects as in libraries
but we've also been in the habit too of
now testing those functions as with unit
tests so I probably shouldn't keep all
of my logic anyway in man and let's
Factor some of this out wouldn't it be
nice if I could for instance just call a
sheep function as by taking this line of
code here and instead of just printing
it here let's print out the return value
of a new function called Sheep that
tells the function how many sheep to
print I in this case let's go down as
always and create another function here
called Sheep the Sheep function now will
take a parameter n that specifies how
many sheep do you want to return and so
that we can test this as with a unit
test so we won't do that here let me go
ahead and not print the number of sheep
as via a side effect but let me go ahead
and return one of those sheep times n so
that the user gets back a whole string
of sheep that's the appropriate number
to print so here too functionally I
don't think we've changed anything too
fundamentally python of sleep.pi typing
three still gives us zero then one and
then two sheep but now we at least have
a framework for focusing on the
implementation of this sheep function
but it's a little inelegant now that
it's still up to the main function to do
this iteration we've seen in the past
way back in week zero wouldn't it be
nice to define a function that actually
handles the process of returning the
entire string that we want rather than
just one row of sheep at a time well I
think we can do this why don't I go
ahead and change sheep as follows let me
go ahead here and first create a flock
of sheep that's initially empty using an
empty list then for I in the range of n
let's go ahead and append that flock for
instance one sheep times I so that I
keep adding to this list zero sheep then
one sheep then two sheep then three and
so forth and then ultimately I'm going
to return the whole flock of sheep at
once so this is going to return the
equivalent of all of those strings of
sheep so that eh main can handle the
printing thereof so back up here in
Maine let's do this how about for each
sheep I'll call it s since sheep is both
singular and plural for s in sheep of n
which again returns to me a list of all
of the sheep the whole flock let's just
print out each sheep S one at a time all
right so so far so good here I think let
me go ahead and run python of sleep.pi
and hit enter what's N3 and that still
seems to work just fine but let me get a
little uh creative here and see not just
three sheep on my screen but maybe 10
rows of sheep and that too seems to work
fine let me get a little more
adventurous and type in maybe a hundred
sheep and it's starting to look ugly to
be fair but they're all printing out
pretty fast let me go ahead and try
again with maybe 1 000 sheep on the
screen and they flew by pretty fast it's
still pretty messy but they're all there
we could count them all up how about not
just a thousand but ten thousand sheep
well that too seems okay it's taking
like 10 times as long and that's why you
see this flickering on the screen all of
the sheep are still printing but but but
it's a lot of data being printed if I
hang in there a little longer
hopefully we'll see all 10 000 sheep
coming to pass
this is here in the video where we'll we
will speed up time
a real online oh my God this is a lot of
sheep
there we go okay and now all of my sheep
have been printed so it seems to be
working just fine well let me just be
even more adventurous and okay let me
try my luck let me try like uh how about
one million sheep this time and hit
enter
huh
something's no longer working
while we wait for a spoiler here does
anyone have any intuition for why my
program suddenly stopped printing sheep
what is going wrong in this version
wherein I'm generating this really big
flock of sheep we might have run out of
memory or computation power yeah so
maybe we're actually pushing the limits
of my Mac my PCS my cloud servers memory
or CPU the brains of the computer's
capabilities because it's just trying to
generate massive massive massive lists
of sheep one million of those rows of
sheep Each of which has a huge number of
sheep and it seems that my computer here
is honestly just really struggling and
this is really unfortunate now because
it would seem that even though this
program clearly works pretty well for a
thousand sheep 10 000 sheep once you
cross some threshold it just stops
working all together or it just takes
way too long for the program to be
useful anymore but this seems a little
silly right because theoretically I
should absolutely be able to print all
of these same sheep if I just printed
one right away then print two right away
then print three then four then five it
seems that the essence of this problem
if I go back to my code is that per my
best practices that I'm trying to
practice what I'm preaching it seems
that the fundamental problem is that
I've modularized my code by creating
this helper function called Sheep whose
purpose in life is to do all of the
generation of sheep and then return all
of them at once
wouldn't it be better and I can actually
hear my fan turning on now even just
trying to generate these sheep wouldn't
it be better then to just print the
Sheep one two three four at a time well
we could do that but that's really a
step backwards that rather contradicts
all of the Lessons Learned of the past
few weeks where generally not putting
everything in Maine is a good thing
generally having an additional function
that you can then test separately with
unit tests is a good thing do we really
need to give up all of those best
practices just to print out some sheep
and and here fall asleep well it turns
out there's a solution to this problem
and namely in the form of these
generators in Python you can define a
function as a generator whereby it can
still generate a massive amount of data
for your users but you can have it
return just a little bit of that data at
a time and you yourself can implement
the code in almost the same way but you
don't have to worry about too much
getting returned all at once these two
like all features of a python are
documented in the official documentation
they're in but what you'll find
ultimately that it all boils down to
this keyword here yield up until now
when we've been banking functions we
have been defining functions that return
values if at all using the keyword
return and indeed if we go back to our
code here that's exactly what I've been
waiting for I've been waiting to return
the whole flock at once unfortunately if
you wait too long and here we have it my
program was quote unquote killed that is
to say my computer got so fed up with
how much memory and CPU it was trying to
use it just said nope you're not going
to run it all and that's unfortunate now
my program no longer works for large
numbers of sleeps sheeps which is not
good if I'm really having trouble
falling asleep some night so how can I
use yield to solve this problem instead
well let me do this instead of building
up this massive list of sheep in this
big list called flock let's just do this
instead let me go ahead and simplify
this whole function as follows whereby I
iterate for I in the range of N and then
on each iteration in the past I might
have been inclined to use return and
return something like one sheep times I
but this won't work here right because
if you want a million sheep and you
start a for Loop saying for I in the
range of a million you're going to
return accidentally zero sheep right
away and then this function is
essentially useless you shouldn't return
a value in the middle of a loop like
this because you're not going to get to
any of these subsequent iterations of
the loop it's going to iterate once and
boom you return but thanks to this other
keyword in Python called yield you can
tell python to effectively return just
one value at a time from this Loop so if
I go back to the this version of my code
here and I say not return but yield this
is like saying return one value at a
time return one value at a time return
one value at a time the for Loop will
keep working and I will keep counting
from zero to one to two all the way up
toward one million but each time the
function is just going to hand you back
a little piece of data it's going to
generate so to speak just a little bit
of that data not all of the data at once
and that's good because my computer has
a decent amount of ram certainly enough
to fit one row of sheep it just doesn't
have enough memory to fit Apparently one
million rows of so many sheep so now if
I go to my terminal window and run
python of sleep.pi and hit enter what's
in 3 would still work zero then one and
then two let me go ahead and increase
the size of this here and run python of
sleep.pi let's try one million as before
and hit enter and now I immediately see
results I don't think we'll wait for all
of these sheep to be printed because
then we will literally all be asleep but
what you'll notice happening now is the
program is not hanging so to speak it's
not waiting and waiting and thinking and
thinking and trying to generate the
entire flock at once it's just
generating one row of sheep at a time
and it's flickering on the screen
because there's so many of them and
that's all thanks to yield it's
generating a little bit of data at a
time not all at once
any questions now on this feature called
generators
any questions at all to add one more
piece of terminology to the mix just so
you've heard it this same feature of the
same feature here is returning what will
technically Now call an iterator yield
is returning an iterator that allows
your own code your own for Loop in main
to iterate over these generated values
one at a time how how does this yield
actually works under under the hood I
mean is it is it using
multi-trading you can think of the
implementation as being asynchronous in
this sense whereby the function is uh
returning a value immediately and then
subsequently giving you back another one
as well underneath the hood what's
really happening is the generator is
just retaining state for you it does not
going to run the entire loop from top to
bottom and then return a value it's
going to do one iteration and yield a
result and the python for you is going
to suspect spend the function if you
will but remember on what iteration it
was so the next time you iterate over it
as it's going to happen again and again
in this for Loop in main you get back
another value again and again so yield
returns indeed this thing called an
iterator and that iterator can be
stepped over as in a loop one element at
a time but the language python handles
all of that for you so that you don't
need to do all of the underlying uh
Plumbing yourself
how about time for one other question on
these generators and iterators as our
sheep continue to fly by pulling in
every iteration the program will return
the memory to the system
so the program will not crack correct on
each iteration it's only returning the
one string of sheep that's appropriate
for the current value of I it is not
trying to return all million rows of the
same and therefore it uses really one
millionth the amount of memory although
that's a bit of an oversimplification
all right as these sheep continue to fly
across the screen let me now uh go ahead
and interrupt this as you might have had
to in the past with infinite Loops in
your own code even though this is an
infinite it's just really long Ctrl c
will interrupt with your keyboard that
program giving me back control of my
computer well here we are at the end of
cs50's introduction to programming with
python and if today in particular of all
days felt like a real escalation real
quickly realize that these are really
these are just additional perhaps
optional Tools in your toolkit that you
can add to all of the past Lessons
Learned so that as you exit from this
course and Tackle other courses or
projects of your own you have all the
more of a mental model and all the more
of a toolbox with which to solve those
same problems if we think back now just
a few weeks ago it was probably in our
focus on functions and variables that
you first started struggling but now in
retrospect if you look back at those
problems and those same problem sets
odds are those same problems would come
all too easily to you now can
additionals was the next step in the
class wherein we gave you the ability to
ask questions and get answers and
therefore do things conditionally in
your code we came full circle today and
you can see that you can now use those
same kinds of conditionals now to do
fancier things with list comprehensions
and dictionary comprehensions and the
like Loops of course have been
omnipresent now for weeks including
today as we built up those same
structures and of course something can
go wrong and exceptions and exception
handling was our mechanism for not only
catching errors in code but also raising
your own exception so that if you're
laying the foundation to write code for
other people as in the form of libraries
you can do that too libraries of course
are things you can not only use but now
write on your own be it a small module
or whole package of code that you want
to share with others around the world
and even better can you write tests for
your own code for your libraries for
others code as well so that ultimately
you can be all the more confident that
not only your code is correct today but
if you make a change to your code
tomorrow you haven't broken anything at
least according to your tests if they
continue to to pass file i o though
meanwhile was a way of now storing data
not just in the computer's memory like
all of these sheep but actually storing
things persistently longer term to disk
being in a CSV or something more like a
binary file like an image with regular
Expressions you then had the ability to
express patterns and actually validate
data or extract data from information
all the more of a useful technique
nowadays when so much of the world is
trying to analyze and process data at
scale some of which might in fact be
quite messy from the get-go and then of
course most recently object oriented
programming an opportunity to solve the
same kinds of problems but with a
slightly different perspective a way to
encapsulate and to represent real world
entities this time in code and today of
course Etc with so many other tools that
you can add that didn't necessarily fall
under any of those earlier umbrellas but
are useful functions and data types and
techniques just to have again in your
back pocket as yet other mechanisms for
solving problems as well not just
putting everyone to sleep but I thought
another way to end might be a little
more vocally to try writing one final
program together this one using a
library we've seen in the past as well
as one other I've taken the liberty of
installing a text to speech library on
my computer here and I'm going to go
ahead perhaps and open a new file here
called uh say dot Pi in vs code and I'm
going to go ahead here and first import
our own friend import cow say I'm going
to import this new library here import
Pi ttsx3 the python text-to-speech
library and now per its documentation
which I read in advance I'm going to go
ahead and create a variable for myself
here engine equals
pyttsx3. init to initialize that library
for text to speech I'm going to then ask
the user well what do I want to hear
spoken and I might do something like
this a variable called this equals the
return value of input what's this shall
be my simple question and I'm going to
keep it this time as a string we've seen
how to use cow say we can do cow say dot
Cal of this turns out this new library
can allow me to use its own engine to
say this as well but then ultimately I'm
going to have to run the engine dot run
and wait just in case it's a long phrase
or sentence to be said but that's it in
just eight lines of code not only am I
apparently going to have a cal appear on
the screen to close us out now but also
some synthesized text ultimately then we
hope with this course that you not only
Learn Python that you've not only
learned programming but you've really
learned how to solve problems and
ultimately how to teach yourself new
languages funny enough I myself only
learned python just a few years ago and
even though I certainly went through
some formal documentation and resources
online I mostly learned what I know now
and even what I had to learn again for
today by just asking lots of questions
be it a Google or friends who are more
versed in this language than I and so
having that instinct having that
vocabulary Vari which to ask questions
of others to search for answers to
questions you absolutely now have enough
of a foundation in Python and
programming to go off and stand on your
own so you can certainly and you're
welcome and encouraged to go on and take
other courses in Python and programming
specifically but better still as quickly
as you can is to find some project
that's personally of interest that uses
python or some other language because at
least from my own experience I tend to
learn best and I hope you might too by
actually applying these skills not to
problems in the classroom but really
truly to problems in the real world
allow me with all that said to look at
my full screen terminal window here run
pythonofsay.pi
crossing my fingers one final time in
hopes that I've not made any mistakes or
bugs and here we go python of say.pi
prompting me what's this how about we
end on this note here
[Music]
this was cs50